Scholastic audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 10, Darkness of Dragons, by 2ET
Sutherland.
Read by Shannon McManus.
The Jade Mountain Prophecy.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jane Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice. unless the lost city of night
can be found.
Prologue.
Almost 21 years ago.
A dragon was fleeing across the dunes.
She didn't dare fly.
The sun had just risen into the cloudless
blue expands overhead.
Up there.
She'd be as easy to spot as one of the
dark circling buzzards that seemed to be
waiting for her to die.
But I'm not going to die.
She thought fiercely.
Not today.
She ran with her sand colored wings
outstretched, hoping to catch any
stirrings of wind, but the air was still
and hot down on the desert floor.
Her scales were baking.
Her back had never been so hot.
Her body was a sack of fire heated
stones.
She had to drag along behind her Her
earrings felt like twin pieces of the sun
blazing against her skull.
Brief, dazed visions of roasted lizards
drifted in and out of her head.
Sometimes she was the one on the spit
turning above the fire.
Sometimes she had fallen in, and was
staring up at them, as they rotated
slowly overhead, and the flames licked
around her.
Was that the sound of wing beats in the
distance?
She threw herself down and burrowed until
she was hidden.
A few layers below the surface.
She found a cooler swath of sand, and she
drove her scalded talons into it.
I left the dates out to dry for too
long.
They've all shriveled up.
Quicksand will be so disappointed in me.
She blinked and blinked again, trying to
shake off the hallucination without
moving.
Her old boss had been dead for years.
She wasn't in the kitchens anymore.
She was running for her life.
She couldn't let the desert consume her
mind right now.
The flickering shadows of 2 dragons swept
past.
She stayed still, buried. until the wing
beats were long gone.
And then she was up and running again.
It can't be much farther, she thought
desperately.
Of course, the journey never seemed this
long when she flew, but she'd been
running for half the night, and surely
the sun had risen hours ago.
What if I'm lost?
Or what if she moved without telling me?
It had been almost a year since her last
visit.
Something wavered on the blurry horizon.
A hut, a tree?
The dragon shifted course to aim for it
but as she got closer, it disappeared
again.
A mirage.
I'm losing it, but I can't.
There's too much at stake.
She stopped.
Closed her eyes and concentrated
fiercely.
Sand wings were naturally adapted to
desert conditions.
Better at handling heat and a lack of
water than other dragon tribes, but even
sand wings weren't supposed to spend
hours on the desert floor, running along
the sand in the baking sun.
They were supposed to get up and fly, to
sweep from oasis to oasis on swift
wings.
An oasis.
She lives near that pool with the 5 palms
maybe.
She strained her ears.
There.
The faintest far away sound of
splashing.
Of a bucket plunging into water and
coming out dripping.
She opened her eyes and ran toward it
determination in every muscle of her
heavy body.
And finally, there it was.
The small hut by the pool, shaded by the
5 palm trees.
She let out a cry of relief and stumbled
half sliding down the last dune and
collapsing entirely into the water.
The door of the hut opened, and a sharp
eyed dragon emerged, wiping her claws on
a small, sandy dark green towel.
Don't drink too much, she said
acerbically.
If you're sick in my oasis, you're
cleaning it up yourself.
I know, said the fugitive, taking one
more swallow and stopping reluctantly, she
sat up, water streaming off her wings, and
burst into tears.
Prickle, I'm in so much trouble.
Oh, by the circle of snakes, her sister
snapped, throwing the towel at her.
I told you to stay away from that
Prince.
You should have left the palace with me
when he 1st started mooning around the
kitchens.
I knew he'd get you killed sooner or
later.
And probably me too, if I didn't clear
out.
Please, help me, Palm begged.
You were right.
Of course you were right.
I'm sorry, I didn't listen.
Are the queen's guards chasing you right
now?
Prickle said sharply.
Did you lead them to me?
I will not be murdered for your
mistakes.
She glanced up at the sky and took a step
back toward her door.
No, wait.
Palm floundered out of the pool and threw
herself at her sister's feet.
I was careful, I promise.
I just need a place to hide for a few
even one day, just one day.
Then I'll keep running and you'll never
have to see me again.
I swear.
Prickles stared down her nose at Palm.
Flicking her wing tips crossly.
Side by side, the 2 dragons were clearly
sisters from the same hatching, with
similar patterns of light brown scales
freckled across their paler yellow
scales.
But palm was rounder, softer.
A creature with access to the bread and
date sugar cookies of the palace
kitchens.
While Prickle had the lean weathered look
of a dragon, who'd been living on her own
in the desert for 2 years.
Please, Palm begged.
Can you help me?
Prickles surveyed her coldly.
Palm remembered the fight they'd had, the
1st day smolder stopped by the kitchen to
compliment the camel's stew.
Prickle had seen the spark between them
long before Palm realized that it was
mutual.
She thought it was innocent enough, having
a crush on the handsome sandwing prints
and that Prickle was overreacting. until
he came back.
And then came back again.
And then he invited her for a walk around
the courtyards.
And then they started meeting after dark
and whispering about the future.
Soon after that, Prickle moved out of the
palace overnight, warning Palm to stay
away from the royal family if she wanted
to live.
Fine.
Prickles said abruptly.
You can stay for one night.
If you give me your earrings.
What?
Palm reached out to touch the glowing
fire opals in her ears.
These?
But they were a gift from, I know, said
her sister.
They're much too expensive for you to
afford on your wages.
I'll get a whole lot of gold for them in
the scorpion den.
My last connection to smolder, Palm
thought sadly.
Hand them over, said Prickle, or keep
flying right now.
Paul knew her wings and talons could make
it another foot.
Her claws were shaking as she reached up
unclasped the earrings, and dropped them
into Prickle's palm.
It's not my last connection.
She reminded herself.
I have something more important now.
Pretty, said her sister, examining the
opals.
Maybe I'll keep them instead of selling
them.
She fastened them into her own ears, where
they glittered, smug little, I told you
so, faces a palm.
Now stop blubbering and tell me what
happened.
We tried to elope.
Palm admitted.
She wiped her eyes with a towel, leaving
trails of sticky wet sand across her
face.
Prickle let out a frustrated growl, you
have the brains of a sun addled camel.
I know, Palm sniffled.
But we had to.
Prickle's gaze flashed over Palm's
figure.
I take it back.
Sun addled camels at least still have a
survival instinct.
She turned and swept into the hut, and
Palm hurried after her.
It was blissfully cool inside, compared
to the scorching heat Palm had been
running through for so long.
A red curtain covered the only window
casting the room in shades of blood and
rubies.
Prickles stepped over to a low table
picked up a small mirror, and tilted her
head to admire the earrings.
You brought this on yourself.
She pointed out self righteously.
But it isn't fair, Palm burst out.
Why can't he fall in love?
Why does his whole life have to be wasted
just so his mother won't feel
threatened?
Other royal families aren't like this.
She rubbed her eyes angrily.
Besides, she muttered, it could be male
and then no one would even care about
it.
Prickle rolled her eyes.
Finish your stupid story.
We were supposed to meet by the caravan
gate before midnight, Palm said.
We were going to go west, or maybe south
and find a small oasis where we could
live in peace, just like you did.
I didn't bring a prince or a secret
potential heir to the throne into my
hideout.
Her sister observed.
She took down 2 bowls from a shelf. and
began rummaging in a sack.
For food, Palm hoped, Well, the guards
showed up before he did.
Palm said, her wings drooping.
I don't know how they knew about me or
our plans.
She sat down in the corner, twisting the
green towel between her claws.
I have 3 guesses, Prickle growled, and
they all begin with B. She was probably
right.
Poem had always felt the eyes of the 3
sandwing princesses on her, burns
ferocious glare, blisters malevolent
scrutiny.
Even gossipy blazes watchful curiosity.
Smolder tried to meet Paul in secret, but
perhaps there was no such thing as a true
secret in the palace.
Well, maybe one, she thought, touching
her stomach.
I was able to escape, she said.
They heard him coming and got distracted
and I bolted.
But I know they're looking for me.
Oasis won't let them stop until they find
me.
Smolder's probably already dead, Prickle
said heartlessly.
You'll never be able to go back to the
palace.
If Oasis doesn't get you, one of her
daughters will.
I know.
Palm said, her eyes filling with tears
again.
Oh, smolder, I'll miss you so much.
Prickle's head shot up.
Her ears flicked toward the door of the
hut.
Her venomous tail lifted slowly
menacingly over her head.
The 2 sisters waited in petrified silence
for several long heartbeats.
Are you sure you weren't followed?
Prickle whispered harshly.
I'm sure, Palm whispered back.
Then what was Prickle started.
But her question was interrupted by the
unmistakable thump, thump, of talons
landing heavily on the sand outside.
Oh, moons.
Palm whispered in terror.
She shrank back against the wall as the
door was flung open, and 2 sand winged
soldiers burst into the room.
I knew it, crowed the male soldier.
I told you I heard her sister had a place
out here.
The other soldier winced. and her eyes
locked with palms.
She knew this dragon, Akave.
She's the little one who was so scared
the 1st few days in the wingery.
Palm was only a year older, but she'd
worried about the frightened dragonette.
She'd shared her snacks and convinced
Agave to play dragons and vipers until
she calmed down.
But that was a long time ago.
Agave was a full grown soldier now.
Big shouldered and long clawed.
She flicked her tail up and frowned at
Palm.
Yeah, you were right, torch.
She said.
Good thinking.
All right, you prince loving traitor.
Time to come with us.
She stepped forward, and snapped a pair
of shackles around Prickle's wrists.
Palm's gasp was drowned out by the snarl
of outrage from her sister.
I'm not Palm?
Prickle roared.
She is.
I'm not stupid enough to sneak around
with a sand snorter like smolder.
Take these off.
Nice try.
Agave said, seizing Prickle's neck and
slamming her back into the wall.
The 2 bowls wobbled and one fell, spilling
coconut milk into the sand.
I'm not pickle wheezed.
She clawed the agave's talons.
Palm, tell them.
Palm couldn't find her voice.
She couldn't breathe.
Did agave really think?
Are you sure about this?
Asked the other soldier nervously.
They do look alike.
But I would have guessed that the other
one was Palm.
I mean, it's hard to tell, but, This one
is Palm, said Agave calmly.
I knew her in the wingery.
Besides, look at her earrings.
She turned Prickle's head, so the jewels
glowed in the dim red light.
Those came from the prince.
No doubt about it.
I hear she's been wearing them around the
palace.
Oh, yes.
The other guard exhaled with relief.
I heard that too.
Asking for trouble, flaunting a gift like
that.
You're right, that must be her.
No, Prickles shrieked, trying to throw
agave off her.
They're not mine.
She gave them to me.
I'm not Palm.
The male soldier leaped forward and
locked a heavy collar around Prickle's
neck, attached to a chain, which he held
while agave shackled Prickle's back legs
as well.
Palm!
Prickle screamed.
Don't let them do this to me.
I should stop them, Palm thought in a
panic.
She's my sister.
I have to save her.
But, I also have to save my dragonette.
If she admitted the truth, and they took
her back to the palace, the queen would
find out quickly that she was with Egg
and she would never let Smolders
dragonette live.
What can I do?
How can I choose between my sister and my
egg?
Palm stumbled to her feet as the soldiers
began to drag Prickle to the door.
Well, what's going to happen to her?
Palm asked.
Queen Oasis wants her locked in the
deepest dungeon, said the male soldier
where no one will ever find her.
As for you, Agave said. meeting her eyes
at last.
You might be accused of helping her.
I'd suggest you run.
Her gaze flickered slightly, down to the
small scar on palms left wing, the one
she got, falling off the wingery roof.
She does know I'm me.
She's trying to save me.
Palm.
Prickle growled.
Tell them the truth, or so help me, I'll
set the moon's on fire and drop them on
your head.
It's not just my life that needs saving
though.
I have to save my egg.
I'm the only one who can.
I'm sorry, Palm.
She lifted her head and tilted it in
exactly her sister's usual condescending
way.
You brought this upon yourself.
What?
Prickle roared a blast of fire, the palm
barely managed to duck.
Flames caught, and flared all around the
hut.
The small bed, the box beside it, the
shelf, the bowls, the curtain blazed into
a curling flag of red, white, gold.
The soldiers yanked Prickle out the door
and palm rushed out after them, coughing
and blinking the smoke away.
As her sight cleared, she saw them
clamping iron around prickles' snout.
She wouldn't be breathing any more fire
today. or shouting about her innocence.
She'd have to fly back to the palace in
livid silence.
And then someone there will recognize her
Palm thought.
They'll set her free.
They'll think it was all a mistake.
I hope.
I hope Agave doesn't get in trouble.
She stood beside the oasis pool.
Watching the 3 dragons fly away, feeling
the heat of the burning hut as it
collapsed inward.
Prickle will never forgive me for this.
But once the queen sees her, she'll know
she's not me and let her go.
And by then, I'll be long gone.
Me and my dragonette.
This is the head start I needed.
She whirled to plunge herself into the
pool, washing off the sand and taking
huge gulps.
She found 2 camel skin pouches hanging
from one of the trees, filled them with
water, and slung them across her chest.
Barely a minute later she was flying, up
in the sky this time, south and east
toward the mountains.
She'd hide in the forests and hills, maybe
in the rainforest for a while, somewhere
sheltered, where she could have her egg
in safety.
Then she'd keep moving.
She'd keep her dragonette alive, and one
day, she'd tell her the truth about her
heritage, and if it was a girl, it felt
like a girl.
She'd teach her that the throne wasn't
worth it, that it was better to hide and
live, that she didn't need power or
treasure, how to survive.
That was all she needed to know.
Far below.
Sand world around something small, moving
fast.
Palm's heart gave a little nervous jump
and she squinted down at it.
Scavengers, 3 of them, on horseback
riding into the desert, toward the
Queen's palace.
That's odd, she thought.
Don't they know there are dragons out
here?
A moment later?
She'd forgotten them again.
Her mind was full of dreams of her
dragonette.
I'm sorry you never got to meet her
smolder.
She thought sorrowfully.
But I remember the names we talked
about.
Don't worry.
If it is a girl, it feels like a girl.
Then I shall give her the name you chose
and hide her away somewhere secret and
safe.
She'll get the chance to be ordinary that
you never had.
By the moon's Epeirae.
I swear she will never have anything to
do with thrones, or queens, or battles, or
crowns, for as long as we both shall
live.
Part one.
Storm of sands.
Chapter one.
Kibli stood on one of the peaks of Jade
Mountain, watching a group of 7 dragons
fly away to the west.
Although there were 4 small black night
wings flying in the group, he knew
exactly which one was moon.
He'd flown with her all the way through
the sky kingdom, to possibility and
back.
He knew the way she held her wings to
catch the changing winds.
He recognized the way she tipped her head
up to breathe in the sunlight.
If it were up to him.
He'd spend every day of the rest of his
life flying with her.
He certainly wouldn't watch her soar away
with a dragon who might have evil plans
and definitely had superpowers.
They all fall in line behind Dark Stalker
letting him take the lead, he noticed.
Even though Dark Stalker doesn't actually
know the way to the Nightwing village in
the rainforest.
They act like he's their leader, because
he acts like he's their leader.
Maybe I should go after them.
His wings twitched.
He knew he shouldn't.
It would make Dark Stalkers suspicious of
him.
And Turtle would have a better chance of
spying safely without Kibley there.
But he couldn't bear this feeling.
Watching Moon fly away from him. knowing
that soon they'd be kingdoms apart.
He looked down at the small slate in his
talons.
He wished he could will a message into
existence, although he knew Turtle was
still flying, and there was nothing to
report yet.
He wished the slates worked both ways, so
he could send questions to Turtle.
He'd already thought of 5 more things he
wanted to ask.
The 2 sea wings stood out among the black
knight wings.
Near the back, the green, struggling form
of Prince Turtle, and farther up, close
behind Dark Stalker, Princess Anemone
small, and whitish pinkish blue gray
doing flips in the sky.
Trying to show off her dark stalker.
She wants him to see that nothing
frightens her.
But I think she's really a bit nervous
about leaving school against her mother's
wishes, nervous, and thrilled.
She's the sort who enjoys disobeying
orders, because she's never had much
chance to.
Which made it ironic and rather sad that
she was so eager to follow Dark Stalker.
I wonder what sort of spell he has on
her.
Is it the same as the one he has on
everyone else?
Or is it special to her?
The sun flashed off turtles green scales
as the dragons banked south.
Kibley was worried for him too.
The sea wing prince had cast his spell to
make himself invisible to dark stalker
but Kibley could think of a 1000000 ways
for that to go wrong.
But I should stay out of the way.
Turtle is the one with magic powers.
He's the one who can save the day, if it
needs saving.
That's what special powers are for, making
heroes.
If only they'd let me have dark stalkers
scroll.
If only peril hadn't burned it.
Then I'd have magic too.
Then I could change the world.
I could fix so many things.
If only I had anything special or magic
about me.
But he wasn't special, and he certainly
didn't have magic.
In fact, he was a useless, spotted waste
of scales, as his mother, brother, and
sister had spent the 1st 3 years of his
life reminding him.
He still heard them all the time, their
voices in his head, telling him how
wretched he was.
He tried to drown them out by
concentrating on his life as an outlaw.
But the smallest thing could bring them
crashing back in.
Just the thought of how he'd lost the
scroll, how he'd held infinite power for
a moment, and then lost it forever.
Brought on a wave of memories of desert
heat and scornful laughter.
The Scorpion Den, where Kibley grew up
was a cutthroat world of thieves, con
artists, mercenaries, fences, thugs for
hire, and assassins.
But for really top notch underhanded work
of any kind, everyone knew there was one
dragon in the city who outshone them all
Kibli's mother.
Her name was Cobra, daughter of a
powerful crime lord.
Her skills were legendary among certain
circles.
The 3 guests who died at Queen Scarlet's
wedding years ago, everyone suspected one
of Cobra's nefarious poisons, but no one
could ever prove it.
The 2 sisters of Queen Oasis who had
vanished into the night.
Sure.
It might have been the queen herself, but
why get her talons dirty when she could
afford someone like Cobra.
Rumor even had it, that all 3 sandwing
princesses had tried to commission her to
kill the others during the war of
sandwing succession.
According to the rumor, she'd refused
them all, on the grounds that an ongoing
war was much more profitable for her.
Kibli had heard all the rumors about his
mother.
He knew that the biggest mystery in the
Scorpion Den was why Cobra had bothered
to have her 3 dragonettes and why she
allowed them to live.
He'd heard the whispers as he stole
pouches of gold coins from under the
tables in the tavern down the street.
She hates Dragonette.
How does she put up with 3 of them making
noise and taking up space in her house
all day?
Bah.
She'll get sick of them sooner or later.
They'll be lucky if they get a chance to
make a run for it.
Especially that scrawny one.
The gossipers would say with incredulous
chuckles.
The one with the freckled scales on his
nose, the one who talks too much, and
notices too much, and sneaks around
behind her like a little trail of
footprints, the one with the odd name.
That was Kibley.
Everyone said Cobra hated her
dragonettes.
And him most of all, but he didn't
believe it.
Even when she said it, he didn't really
Not until the day she sold him.
Kibli remembered those first three years
of his life with much more clarity than
most young dragons.
He remembered the hot, musty smell of the
carpets that hung from their walls and
cover the floors, mingling with a scent
of roasting coriander in the kitchen.
He remembered the time he found a bowl
with a few drops of goat's milk left in
it and licked it clean.
He remembered the 1st time he stole
something to feed himself.
A runty spotted persimmon, that had
fallen under a food cart, and how he hid
in a fortune teller's tent to eat it
knowing rattlesnake or sirocco would
snatch it away if they saw it.
He remembered the roars of dragons coming
to blows on the street outside.
And how everyone would fly up to the
courtyard walls to watch, and the buckets
of sand that hung from every wall, so
that they could be poured over any fires
the fighting dragons might set.
Most of all, he remembered lying awake
night after night.
Beside his snoring siblings, watching his
mother on the other side of the room, lit
by a single lamp, she would sharpen her
blades, mix poisons, study maps and
blueprints, or dismember scorpions to
study and extract their venom.
Kibli would feel the tensions shivering
through his wings as he waited.
Night after night for her to look his
way.
One glance in his direction, one moment
where her face would soften, where her
love would slip through when she thought
no one was looking.
That was all he wanted.
Just a tiny hint of that secret inner
love that he was sure she felt.
But Cobra never looked up at her
dragonettes.
Not once, in all the nights he watched
her.
She never looked over during the day
either, while Sarocco and Rattlesnake
threw him into walls, trapped his tail
indoors, or buried him in sand.
His brother and sister realized a lot
sooner than Kibley, that Cobra didn't
care at all what they did.
But Kibli kept trying.
He got smarter and faster, hoping she
would notice.
He turned their traps back on them
learned to dodge and faint, and trick
them almost every time.
Brute strength wouldn't work against 2
dragonettes that were much bigger than
him.
So his cleverness was the only weapon he
had to ensure that he got his fair share
to eat.
He was convinced that eventually, his
mother would have to notice that he was
good enough to be worth loving.
Kibley was 3.5 years old when his
salvation finally walked in.
It was an otherwise ordinary day.
Hot as blazes, and Cobra had ordered them
out into the streets because she was
expecting a client.
Her exact words were, get your ugly
snouts out of here and don't come back
until dark.
If you must come back at all.
Kimley was choosing to find it hopeful
that she'd been looking at Sirocco when
she'd said, Ugly snouts, and did him when
she said, come back, like maybe she was
subliminally revealing her true
feelings?
He came up with a lot of stories like
this in his head.
Other dragonettes were always racing
around the narrow alleyways that
surrounded their house, scrapping and
shouting, and tussling over trinkets or
prey.
On that day, however, they weren't
fighting.
Instead, a crowd of grubby dragonettes
were gathered in a circle down one of the
dead ends, jostling and shouting wagers
at one another.
As Rattlesnake muscled her way to the
front.
Kibley caught a glimpse of fur, and a
small, quivering whiskered nose between
the talons and tails that blocked his
view.
Kibley took a few steps back, then
launched himself up to the window ledge
on the 2nd floor of a nearby lamp store.
From there, he could see down into the
cleared patch of space, where all the
dragonettes were focusing their
attention.
A large scrap of orangish fur was
circling a much smaller gray bit of fur
with a long tail.
What's going on?
Rattlesnake demanded.
Taking bets on how long this gritter
lasts?
One of the wiry orphans answered her
flicking a wing at the gray fur ball.
Care to wager?
He was so covered in dirt and ashes that
he looked half mud wing, which he easily
might be.
There were several hybrids in the
Scorpion Den.
Since blister wouldn't tolerate cross
contamination in her army, and burn hated
them as well.
Kibley squinted, and realized the little
creature was a spiny mouse, slightly
bigger than average.
Its ears trembled with terror as it
darted around, blocked in on all sides by
enormous talons and sun baked scales and
fiery breath.
The larger animals stalking it was a cat
which meant it must be the pet of someone
important, or else it would have been
eaten by now.
Stupid game, rattlesnake pronounced
tossing a scornful look at the 2
mammals.
I'd rather eat them than bet on them.
Yeah, but those scritters are prickly on
your tongue.
The other dragon observed.
Besides, check out what the winner
snags.
He jerked his head at 5 coconuts, arranged
in a small pyramid next to the wall.
Five coconuts.
Kibley would have been tempted to place a
bed himself, if he'd had anything to
wager.
He looked back along the alley toward his
house.
His mother loved coconut.
It was one of the things she never shared
with the dragonettes.
On the rare occasions when she managed to
get one.
I may have nothing to wager, Kibley
thought.
But maybe I can get one a different way.
A few moments later, the cat had this
spiny mouse cornered.
It prowled a step closer.
Another step.
The mouse was petrified with fear.
The cat reached out one paw.
And a bucketful of sand cascaded over the
cat's head, instantly burying it with a
yowl of fury.
Slasher, ward, one of the watching
dragons.
She surged forward, and began digging
frantically in the sand for her cat.
Who did that?
Everyone was looking up now.
But Kibley was already standing
innocently in the crowd, casting
bewildered looks at the sky.
He took a sideways step, accidentally
treading on the toes of a dragon he knew
was prone to hysterics, and as he'd hoped
his mark started screaming
melodramatically.
Enough dragons jumped and surged around
in the confusion that a gap opened up and
the mouse darted out of the circle.
At the same time, Slasher the cat burst
out of the sand, hissing and spitting
furiously.
Where'd it go?
shouted one of the dragons.
Who won?
shouted another.
Don't let the scrooter escape, bellowed a
third.
It went that way, Kibley yelled, pointing
out of the alley.
Dragons stampeded past him, and in the
swift, roaring chaos, he managed to
snatch one of the coconuts, tuck it under
his wing, and hustle out along with a
thundering crowd.
At the corner, everyone scattered
searching for the little creature.
Kibley made his way casually toward his
own house.
An adult sandwing was lingering outside
watching the gang of dragonettes descend
into finger pointing and fighting.
She gave him a speculative look as he
approached.
Morning, Kibley said, tipping his head
toward her.
He darted inside and scampered through
into the back room, where his mother
always met with clients.
He was in luck.
Whoever she was waiting for hadn't
arrived yet.
She crouched, alone, behind her table
studying a document with a scrawled
sketch of a dragon's face on it.
He was also not in luck, because she was
evidently in a terrible mood.
Her head snapped up, and she gave him an
evil glare.
Get out, she snarled.
I brought you something, Kibley said
quickly.
He produced the coconut and held it out
in his trembling talons.
I stole it for you.
Cobra rose to her feet, spreading her
wings until she seemed to fill the entire
room.
You stole a coconut?
She hissed.
And you brought it to me?
She took a step toward him.
Yes, he said proudly.
I know you like them, so, have I taught
you nothing about survival?
She snarled.
She smashed the coconut out of his talons
and threw him into the wall.
Kibley's head collided painfully with a
torch sconce.
You survive, Cobra bellowed.
That's all you have to do.
Nobody is ever going to take care of
you.
A dragon looks out for herself, and no
one else.
You weak little worm.
If you steal a coconut, you keep it for
yourself.
She reached out to grab him again.
But just then, someone cleared their
throat from the doorway.
Cobra whirled around, almost nicking
Kibley with her venomous tail. through
his tears.
Kibley recognized the dragon who'd been
watching the fray outside.
She angled her head to study him sideways
for a moment.
Am I interrupting something?
She asked.
Just trying to teach my idiot son a
lesson.
Cobra hissed.
About what, exactly?
asked the stranger.
Cobra folded her wings back?
He thinks about other dragons too much.
It's going to get him killed one day.
Interesting, said the other dragon.
Her eyes flicked from Kibley to the
coconut to Cobra, as if she were reading
the story of what had just happened.
I happen to be looking for dragons who
work well with others, let's say.
I'd like to take them off your talons.
He is not for sale, said Cobra.
Kibley glanced up at her.
That sounded like she cared enough to
want to keep him, except that she'd said
it in her opening negotiations voice, not
her, and that final voice.
As though she was only bartering to get a
better offer.
Give him to me, said the other dragon, and
my outlaws will stay out of your
business.
Cobra's eyebrows arched.
Should I care what your little gang of
ruffians does?
Yes, we will have full control of this
city by the new year.
If we're willing to leave you alone
that's an offer you should jump at.
The dragon stepped past Cobra and
beckoned to Kibley.
Come along, dragon who cares too much.
I didn't say you could take him, Thorn.
Cobra snapped.
But I am taking him.
Thorn answered calmly.
Why would you want him?
Cobra tried.
He's useless.
He's completely ordinary.
He'll never do anything important.
Ordinary dragons do important things all
the time, said Thorn.
Or perhaps I just want him to steal me
some coconuts.
You don't need to worry about it.
Because you won't be seeing him again.
Huh.
Cobra snorted.
That would be an upside.
Kibley looked from one to the other in
disbelief.
His mother was about to back down, and
he'd never seen her give in to anyone
except his terrifying grandfather.
Who was this strange dragon who wanted to
steal him?
Was Cobra afraid of her?
What about our business?
Cobra demanded.
Flicking one wing out to block Kibley's
path?
Have you found any of them?
Thorn asked, nodding at the sketch on
Cobra's desk.
No, Cobra answered.
Not a trace anywhere.
Thorn frowned.
Then keep looking.
Same rate until you find them.
She dropped a small jangling sack into
Cobra's claws and turned to Kibley
again.
Time to go.
But, Kibley tried to protest, my mother
doesn't want you here, finished Cobra.
She was greedily digging about inside the
sack.
Kibley blanked hard, trying to hold back
his tears.
His mother definitely wouldn't want to
keep him if he cried.
The strange dragon crouched in front of
him.
And he realized for the 1st time how kind
her eyes were.
You will be safe with me.
She said softly, and wanted, and cared
for.
But, but, Kibley choked out.
I won't want my mother to, to want you
and care for you, Thorn said, even more
softly.
I know.
I'm sorry she doesn't.
But your life doesn't have to be like
this.
Come with me. you'll see.
She brushed his wing with hers and turned
toward the door.
Kibley took 2 steps after her, then
looked back at his mother.
Cobra was piling coins in careful stacks
on her desk, but she felt his eyes on her
and glanced up.
Hoping for some last words of wisdom.
Cobra said scornfully.
Take care of yourself, Lizard.
You'll never amount to much, so don't go
trying to be a hero, or you'll just get
killed, and don't come crawling back
here.
How's that?
Thorn put a wing around Kibley, and
steered him toward the door.
Her jaw was tense, as if she was holding
back a lot of things she wanted to say.
Kibley's home passed by him in a blur, and
by the time he looked up, they were in
unfamiliar streets, heading toward the
other side of the city.
There were palm trees here, staggered
along the walls of the alleys, or poking
out of courtyards like curious snouts.
Can I ask you something?
Thorn said.
He nodded.
What did you do with a spiny mouse?
He reached into the small pouch slung
around his chest and drew out the small
trembling creature.
Thorn stopped, and watched him release it
into a hole in one of the outer city
walls.
I figured you'd rescued it. she said.
They're not really worth eating.
He said, worried now.
Should he have offered it to her?
What did she want him to do?
If he was going to belong to her now, he
should start figuring out how to make her
like him.
Maybe he'd already failed.
I agree, she said, thumping his shoulder
in a friendly way.
I'd have let it go too.
It was clever, what you did.
I was impressed with how you tricked
everyone.
Just the kind of smarts I'm looking for
in my organization.
Kibli's heart was threatening to swell
and burst right out of his chest.
No one had ever praised him for
anything.
No one had ever noticed anything he'd
ever done right.
She didn't do it intentionally.
But in that moment, Thorn won Kibley's
undying loyalty forever.
He thought she was the only dragon he'd
ever care about that much, that he would
spend his life fighting and dying for her
and be happy doing so.
Until she sent him off to school, and he
met a dragon named Moon Watcher.
And now everything felt different.
He'd had a live plan.
Prove his loyalty, serve Thorn, be the
best out claw possible.
That live plan did not include thinking
about a fascinating night wing all the
time.
Moon took up so much of his headspace.
He caught himself watching her, the way
he used to watch Cobra, hoping for a
glance that would hint she might love him
back.
He wanted to bring her new scrolls that
would make her face light up.
He wanted to make her soup when her
visions gave her headaches, and sing her
silly songs to help her stop worrying.
He wanted to fly beside her while she
saved the world.
He most definitely did not want to watch
her fly away, with no idea when she would
ever come back.
Kibley saw a glimmer of silver father
down the mountain.
It was winter, gazing after the departing
dragons, with a soulfully tragic face.
Did I look like that too?
Watching her leave?
Probably not.
Winter has a much better snout for
soulful tragedy than I do.
Whenever Kibli tried to make heroic
dashing faces like Winters in the mirror
it mostly looked like he was trying to
suck bits of scorpion out of his teeth.
Hey, he said, landing beside his friend.
He decided to fly with a label friend
although parts of him could acknowledge
that it was a little optimistic.
Winter jumped and gave him a sideways
scowl.
Humph he said, clearing his throat.
Just uh, admiring the sunrise.
Oh yeah, me too. said Kibley.
Absolutely nothing else interesting
happening out here.
Nope.
Excellent sunrise.
That's it.
Winter transferred his scowl to the wings
that were getting smaller and smaller in
the distance.
Well, he said, at least Dark Stalker will
take care of, ah, of them.
Moon can take care of herself.
Kibley pointed out.
He'll get settled in the rainforest, make
some friends, and then she'll come right
back, Winter said, ignoring Kibley.
And we can all go back to normal.
Except now we have a giant magic friend
who can tell us the future.
That'll be useful.
Kibli couldn't keep the worry office face
as he regarded winter.
He just didn't sound like the haughty
sharp-minded ice wing prince that Kibley
had come to know.
Everyone else under Dark Stalker's
spell.
If I'm right, and there is a spell, still
sounds like themselves.
They're less suspicious of him than they
probably should be, but still normal
ish.
Winter is acting like someone's wrapped
his brain in walrus blubber.
How can everything go back to normal?
Kibley asked.
Aren't you supposed to be dead?
What happens when your queen finds out
you've popped up back at school?
Or your parents?
Won't that be a little awkward for your
brother who supposedly killed you?
Winter hesitated.
I...
I'm not sure, he said.
My name must be gone from the rankings
wall by now.
I think if I choose to stay in exile.
It shouldn't make any difference to my
queen or my family.
I'm as good as dead to them anyway.
He paused again, then added in a lower
voice, I do worry about Hillstorm.
I wasn't going to come back to school, but
He trailed off.
But Moon was here.
Kibley finished in his head, feeling
imaginary claws sink into his heart.
And he'd risk anything to be with her.
Kimble thought he would do the same, but
he'd never been tested like winter, sent
through the cold darkness of betrayal and
certain death.
How could he ever think he'd be worthy of
Moon, when she could choose someone like
Winter?
Or at least the real winter?
The one underneath a weird spell.
I have to get him back.
For his sake and for hers.
Once he's thinking for himself again, we
can figure out what to do about Moon and
Dark Stalker.
I have to break Dark Stalker's spell on
him.
But how?
Chapter 2.
Winter found Kibley in the prey center
shortly after midday and poked him with
his tail.
Enough moping, he said.
We have class.
I'm not moping, said Kibley. sitting up
and throwing away the banana.
He'd been staring at for 20 minutes.
You're moping.
I most certainly am not said Winter.
I swing princes never mope.
Oh, I'm sorry, Kibley said.
I got the word wrong.
You're brooding.
Well, that would be preferable.
Winter drew back his wings and snorted a
tiny cloud of ice particles, but I'm not
doing either.
I'm going to history class, and so should
you.
History?
Kibli protested.
How can we possibly sit in a dark cave
listening to webs drone on about the
ancient past?
This is history happening right now.
We're in the middle of it, or we should
be.
Oh, really?
What sort of history were you planning to
make today?
Winter scoffed.
All the excitement has gone off to the
rainforest.
We are just the footnotes.
He poked Kibley with his tail again.
Come on, or tsunami will yell at us.
Khibli trailed through the tunnels after
him.
Try not to look as glum as he felt about
the idea of being a footnote in someone
else's heroic saga.
They found their way to the new history
cave.
Several winding corridors away from the
one that had been firebombed.
This one had a skylight, but it was still
too dark, damp, and chilly for Kibley.
He missed the wide open sunshine of the
desert.
He also wasn't a big fan of the fact that
the cave only had one exit, or the way
scrolls were piled in corners like
inevitable kindling.
Even though Sora was gone now, he
couldn't help thinking of the last attack
and what might have happened without
Moon's prophetic warnings.
Tameron, the injured rain wing, was
already there when they arrived.
She was circling the cave cautiously
tapping the walls with their talons and
sniffing the air.
Anything we should worry about?
Kibley asked her.
She shook her head.
Unless, do you smell smoke?
she asked.
I don't, he said, inhaling deeply.
And sand wings have a pretty good sense
of smell.
So do I, normally, she said.
But I haven't been able to get the smell
of smoke out of my nose since the
explosion.
Her wings twitched back, and she reached
out to touch the cave wall as if
reassuring herself it was still there.
Kibley mentally flipped through what he
knew about rain wing scales.
When they weren't deliberately changed
for camouflage or adornment, they
reflected the dragon's emotions.
Tamarinds today were a muted blue gray
with ripples of white, in between the
bandages and scorch marks.
A little sad, Kibley guessed, and Kinkaju
turned white when she was attacked and
knocked unconscious.
So maybe that indicates pain?
Are you all right?
He asked.
Do the burns hurt a lot?
Today they do, she said, wincing.
Mostly, I'm worried about Kinkaju
though.
Me too.
Kibley admitted.
He'd last seen their rain wing friend
lying in a bed in the town of
possibility.
Far across the continent, unable to wake
up.
That's one thing I could have done with
Dark Stalker's scroll.
I would have healed her.
I would have healed Tamron too, and all
the soldiers who were hurt by the war.
Oh, why hadn't his friends just let him
have it?
Then Dark Stalker would still be under
the mountain.
Kibley would be fixing everyone's
problems.
Kinkaju would be awake.
Tamron would be able to see, and Moon
would still be here, where he could talk
to her every day.
A sea wing burst into the room, flapping
his wings and staring around
frantically.
Where is she?
He demanded.
Has anyone seen Princess Anemone?
Pike.
Kibley plucked the name from his memory
of the winglet lists.
Clawmates with Big Tail, now dead, and
Flame, now accused of trying to murder
Stone Mover.
Pike is the sea wing who's always
defending anemone, and may be working for
her mother, Queen Coral.
Um, yes, Winter answered him.
He peered down his snout at Pike.
Anemone left for the rainforest with all
the night wings, and their glorious
leader early this morning.
Did you literally just say glorious
leader?
Kibli asked.
Do you literally not recognize sarcasm
when you hear it?
Winter retorted.
Nearly everything winter ever said
sounded sarcastic.
But Kibli thought he was developing a
fairly good sense of when the ice wing
was actually being sincere.
And the intonation just then had been
troubling, to say the least.
She left?
Pike cried.
Left the school?
He clutched his head.
You couldn't have stopped her, Kibley
said.
Don't blame yourself.
I have to go after her, Pike said. turning
in a circle, but I don't know anything
about the rainforest.
Oh, Queen Coral is going to feed me to
the sharks.
The princess on her own with no one to
guard her?
Prince Turtle was with her, Winter
pointed out.
I don't find that reassuring.
Pike snapped.
I'm inclined to agree with you, Winter
said, poking his nose back into his
scroll.
Turtle is great, Kibley argued.
He'll watch out for her.
He didn't dare tell them that Turtle was
invisible to Dark Stalker.
But surely that meant turtle would be
useful protection for his sister.
Didn't it?
Besides, Tamarin added, anemones and
animus.
She can guard herself better than anyone
else could.
Perhaps, Kibley thought, but it depends
on what spells Dark Stalker is cast on
her.
I have to go after her, Pike said again.
He spun toward the entrance and ran
straight into their history teacher.
Sit down, young dragon.
Web said, pleasantly, but firmly.
It is time for our lesson.
I have to go rescue the princess.
Pike cried.
Fiddle squids, Webb said, ushering him
back into the cave.
You are a student.
What you have to do is fill your mind
with knowledge and wisdom.
Khibli sympathized completely with a
frustrated look on Pike's face.
He wanted to rip off the roof of the
cavern with his claws and go flying after
the other dragons too.
Since you're 2 wingluds. are rather low
on numbers at the moment.
Silver Wiglet will be joining us today.
Webbs went on.
He flicked a beckoning wing at the
hallway, and 4 dragonettes filed in.
Rather low on numbers is a generous way
to describe us.
Kibley thought ruefully.
He and Winter were the only ones from
Jade Winglet still at school, and
Tamarin's Gold Winglet had been equally
decimated by the explosion, and Saurus
attempted assassination of Icicle.
But wait.
Kibley perked up.
This meant he'd get to see ostrich, the
sandwing and silver winglet.
She was the daughter of Queen Thorn's
most trusted general, 6 Claws, and Kibley
had promised to look out for her while
they were at school.
He hadn't seen her yet since his return
to Jade Mountain, although he'd gone
looking the night before.
Princess Anemone had been the only one in
the cave they shared.
When he poked his snout in.
She was scattering jewelry around, clearly
in such a bad temper, that he hadn't
dared stay to wait for ostrich.
But the curious little sandwing wasn't
among the dragonettes settling into the
classroom.
Kibley checked his mental list.
There was a big shouldered mud wing named
Seepia, a placid looking rain wing named
Bodo, who settled himself next to Tamarin
a haughty ice wing called Chiang Bai, who
did not sit next to Winter, and a small
boned, dusky orange sky wing named Thrush
who took one of the front row seats and
gazed intently at the teacher.
Where is ostrich?
Kibley wondered.
She's usually so excited for her classes
no matter how boring they are.
How did she escape this torture?
Now, where were we?
Web said, in his maddeningly slow voice.
Ah, yes.
The 500 years of transformation and
resettling that followed the scorching.
Thrush raised one of his talents, and
spoke without waiting to be called on.
Can you teach us about dark stalker today
please?
Yes.
Cheng Bai agreed.
He doesn't seem anything like the dragon
from our old stories, in that he did not
immediately start murdering all of us.
Three moons, said Bodo, his claws turning
lime green, is uh, is he likely to do
that?
Dog stalker.
Webbs grumbled.
Wrecking my lesson plans.
That's over 3000 years after the
scorching.
We're not scheduled to get to that era
for months.
But we need to know about him now, Tamarin
insisted.
Because of the maybe murdering, Boto
said.
I think I agree, yes.
I would like to hear about that.
Or more specifically about how not
happening that is?
We can see with our eyes what kind of
dragon dark stalker is.
Winter said scornfully.
I trust my own judgment better than any
old history scroll.
Says the dragon whose sister turned out
to be a murderer.
Sepia suddenly interjected.
Winter leaped to his feet and whirled
toward her.
His teeth bared.
Kibley darted in between them, wings
outstretched, ready to hold winter back
or help him fight, whichever turned out
to be necessary.
It was a mud wing who blew up the other
cave, not my sister, Winter flared.
But she did it because of what your
sister did.
Sepia said stoutly.
Winter, let's be fair.
Kibley pointed out.
We just stopped Icicle from trying to
murder Starfight and then glory.
So technically.
You're not helping Kibley, Winter growled
at him.
Now, now, now, now, now.
Webb fretted, flapping his wings.
The war is behind us.
That's the whole point of this place.
No fighting allowed.
Behind him, Kibley saw Sonny poke her
head into the classroom.
She scanned the dragonettes and frowned
slightly, then disappeared again.
That was worrying.
All right.
We can talk about Dark Stalker. website.
If you'll all sit down and shut up.
I'll tell you what I know about him.
He rolled up the scroll on his desk
muttering something like, and I thought
tsunami was bad.
Winter subsided back into his seat
looking baleful.
Dark Stalker is the son of a night wing
named Foe Slayer, and an ice wing prince
named Arctic.
Webbs rattled off.
He lived over 2000 years ago in the
ancient night wing kingdom, and he was
the first animus dragon to hatch in the
night wing tribe.
A gift he inherited from his father.
But he rapidly became too dangerous to
control, and he was plotting to
assassinate the queen and steal her power
when his friend Fathom, and Clearsight
conspired to stop him.
Stuffing him under a mountain and putting
him to sleep forever.
Clearly not forever, Cheng Bai
interrupted.
Right, said Webbs, a little flustered.
Until now, but he has emerged a changed
dragon, humbled and unambitious, who only
wants to use his powers for good.
So, nothing to worry about.
Can we get back to our actual lesson?
Um, said Kibley, wait.
How exactly do we know he's humbled and
unambitious now?
Because it's obvious, Winter said, rolling
his eyes.
It's not like he immediately demanded to
be made king of the night wings or
anything.
With impeccable comic timing, the slate
in Kibley's pouch gave a little jump.
He waited until no one was looking at him
anymore, then pulled it out and hid it
under his desk.
He could see a message from Turtle
appearing on the surface, agonizingly
slowly.
Dark Stalker wants to be Nightwing King.
Nightwings deciding what they want.
Kibli nearly laughed, but he didn't want
to draw attention to the slate, and also
it was too terrifying to be funny.
Tell me more, Turtle, he pleaded
silently.
What's happening?
How are the night wings reacting?
What about glory?
And moon?
Does Moon want him to be king?
Is she still acting like herself?
But nothing else appeared on the slate
and after a few minutes, Kibli had to
accept that was Turtle's entire message.
He sighed.
Dark stalker is king.
I can see the logic.
It's a choice between 2 difficult, unusual
alternatives, to have a king, or to be
ruled by a rain wing.
He knew several of the night wings
intensely disliked the idea of being
ruled by Queen Glory.
He'd seen it on their faces in the
rainforest.
Even before Moon confirmed that she'd
heard such grumblings in their minds.
No matter what glory did, how hard she
worked, how intelligently she solved
their problems, or how fairly and kindly
she treated them.
Some night wings would never accept her
simply because she was a rain wing.
But what kind of king would dark stalker
be?
Would he be content with ruling his
tribe?
Did his ambitions stop there?
Kibli would have liked to believe they
did.
But the last words of Moon's prophecy
kept repeating on a loop in his head.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
That was definitely dark stalker, rising
from his prison.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
He was pretty sure this was Dark Stalker
2.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice.
Why?
When?
How soon?
Unless the lost city of night can be
found.
He brooded on that last line for a
moment.
Dark Stalker knew where the lost city
was.
Was there something there that could stop
him?
Something fathom and clear sight left
behind, perhaps, in case their old friend
slash enemy ever emerged?
That's what Kibley would have done if he
were them, left some kind of backup
plan.
But how would anyone know what it was, or
how to use it?
Sonny appeared in the doorway again.
Webbs, she whispered.
I need to borrow Kipley.
Webb flicked his tail impatiently, and
Kibley leaped to his feet, just barely
managing to keep the joy off his face.
Thank you, he whispered to Sonny, as he
bounded out into the hallway.
Can you do that every time I have
history?
I mean, didn't you go through this exact
same suffering when you were younger?
How can you inflict it on other innocent
souls?
Lessons with webs were awesome.
Sonny said sternly, or at least, Kibli
guessed that was her attempt at a stern
face.
You be grateful you don't have to do
battle training with Kestrel.
Her expression shifted.
Worry lines creeping across her
forehead.
Kibley?
Have you seen ostrich today?
No, he said, instantly alert.
I haven't seen her since I got back to
Jade Mountain.
I had breakfast with her yesterday
morning.
Sonny said.
But when everything happened with my
father and flame, I forgot to check on
her last night.
And then today, I haven't been able to
find her anywhere.
Kibley's heart sank as Sonny rubbed her
temples anxiously.
I'm terribly afraid, she said.
That ostrich is missing.
Chapter 3.
Kibli helped Sonny search the entire
mountain again.
He studied the whole map in his mind.
Everything that was part of the school
and everything that wasn't.
All the corners where a small dragonette
might hide or get lost or get stuck.
He checked her favorite places, the music
room, the library, and her least favorite
places, the underground lakes, the slopes
below stone movers cave that were
littered with prey bones.
He even poked his head into Stone Mover's
cave itself, where he saw flame, trapped
by the shackles Dark Stalker had made
furiously struggling to get loose.
Kibley had heard the story from Turtle
but he was still startled by Flame's
smooth, perfectly healed snout, and by
the flashing hatred in Flame's eyes.
Against the wall.
Stone Mover was lying with his head
averted and eyes closed.
Kibley couldn't help thinking that
trapping flame in the same cave as the
dragon he'd tried to murder was a worse
punishment for the victim than it was for
the attempted murderer.
But he didn't linger to dwell on that
problem.
He had to find ostrich.
Her parents, 6 Claws and Kindle, trusted
Kibley.
Queen Thorn trusted him.
She'd basically told him that the sand
wings at the academy were his
responsibility, and then he'd flown off
and abandoned them.
True, he'd been on a quest to help moon
in winter, and of course, he'd expected
the students to be safe with Sunny.
But still, he hadn't even stopped to
worry about them at all.
Have I been thinking about Moon?
About my new friends?
Too much, and not enough about Thorn and
the rest of my tribe.
He'd beaten himself into a state of
surging guilt by the time he met Sonny
again.
Back at the cave where ostrich and
anemone had been assigned to live
together.
It was hard to tell the young sandwing
had ever been here.
Like most dragons raised with the
outlaws.
She was used to living sparely and
compactly, in case they had to relocate
suddenly, or face a sandstorm or fend off
a street gang invasion.
The sea wing princess, on the other talon
clearly lived a very different life.
The cave was covered in her mess.
From piles of damp blankets to trails of
wet moss to little fish bones scattered
around, but more than all of that, there
were the jewels, and trinkets, and
treasures.
Kibley guessed, there was more wealth
scattered casually around this cave than
he'd ever personally have in his entire
life.
He could see why it wouldn't make sense
to take it all with her to the
rainforest.
But couldn't she have at least put it
away in one of her giant wooden chests, or
found a better place to hide it all?
The glittering pink and gold tiaras
sticking out from under one of the
blankets?
That was just begging to be stolen.
A single one of those black pearl cluster
earrings would fetch a price that could
feed 10 orphans for a month.
And anemone would probably just assume
she'd lost it and not even care.
Dragons who treated treasure like this
didn't deserve treasure like this.
Kibley sat down and wrapped his wings
around himself, fighting back all his
outclaw instincts.
He was very glad Moon wasn't there to
read his mind and discover all the
unworthy thoughts he was having.
Thorn had given her outlaws strict
instructions once she became queen.
We are not outside the law anymore, she'd
said.
We are the law, which means it's up to us
to show how fair and just and righteous
those in power can be.
We won't be like the regimes that came
before us.
I know it'll be hard, but from now on, no
more stealing, no more cheating, no more
striking 1st, or solving problems with
our claws and venom.
We all have to be better dragons now.
Argh.
But wouldn't a good dragon just take one
emerald necklace, if it could pay for a
real library for the Scorpion Den
orphanages?
No, no, no.
Kibley closed his eyes and took a deep
breath.
Winter wouldn't have this problem.
He wouldn't even be tempted by any of
this.
That's why he deserves a moon, and I
don't.
Three moons?
What a disaster, Sonny said, stepping
around him and surveying the room
critically.
It looks like Princess Anemone hasn't
quite gotten used to living without
servants yet.
The good news is, she hasn't managed to
make ostrich do her cleaning up for her
Kibley pointed out.
He grinned.
It would be funny to see her try, though.
Ostrich was one of the kinder, gentler
souls among the outlaws, but she had a
streak of ferocity from her father, and
an iron core from her mother that made
her impossible to push around.
Kibli knew she would never bow to any
royal, except Queen Thorn, of course.
They circled the room, looking for any
clues that might hit at ostrich's
whereabouts.
Her small corner of the room held almost
nothing personal.
Other than a small sketch of her parents
that was pinned to the wall beside her
hammock.
Kibley was studying 6 Clauses' face when
he felt the slight twitch lightly again.
He tugged it quickly out of the pouch, and
watched the new message appear.
The night wings are getting a king.
Turtle wrote.
Kibley stared at the slate, and stared at
it some more.
But nothing else appeared.
Turtle, he growled softly.
Is that seriously all the information you
think is worth reporting?
What happened?
The Slade stared placidly and blankly
back at him.
What about Queen Glory?
What about Moon?
Are they all going to live in the
rainforest together?
Has he killed anyone?
Or done anything dangerous or
suspicious?
Or is this the most peaceful transfer of
power in Pyrean history?
What's going on with the superpowers Dark
Stalker was handing out yesterday?
Are you safe?
How does Moon feel about this new king?
Turtle?
Tell me anything.
What's that?
Sonny interrupted his careening thoughts
coming up behind him and looking
curiously at the little object in his
talons.
Nothing, he answered.
Tucking the obstinately uninformative
slate back in his pouch.
He wished he could tell Sonny the news
about Dark Stalker.
But then he'd have to reveal Turtles
animus magic, which seemed not only
unfair, but rather unsafe.
He had to focus on ostrich.
That was the only thing he could do
anything about right now.
His gaze fell on a pair of rippling
beaten copper armbands, tossed carelessly
on a pile of half rolled scrolls.
Aren't those the armbands, anemone
enchanted to control the weather?
He asked Sonny.
She frowned slightly.
I think so.
I can't believe she just left them here.
Such powerful magic, lying around
abandoned.
Anyone could get their claws on those and
do all kinds of damage.
Maybe you should take them, he suggested
to Sonny, so no one else does.
I feel guilty about it, but I think
you're right.
She said.
With a sigh, she gathered the armbands
and slid them into her bag.
Kibli watched them disappear with a small
sting of envy.
Last night.
He'd asked Turtle to make him an animus
dragon.
He'd taken his most secret wish and laid
it at turtle's feet, and then turtle had
stomped on it.
Kibli understood why.
Another animus in the world meant more
threats to the animus dragons who
existed.
But it still made him ache to think how
close he was to all that power, and yet
he would never have it.
Instead, he'd have to watch other dragons
like turtle and anemone, use their power
on frivolous things they didn't even care
about. weather controlling wristbands, and
slates that only communicated in one
direction.
And he'd never get to do all the good he
could have done with that power in his
own talents.
With animus magic, I could find ostrich
easily.
Let's ask the other sand wings when they
last saw ostrich, he suggested.
And then, for the 1st time, he realized
that Onyx, Tamarin's clawmate, should
have been in history class as well, but
she hadn't been.
I'm such an idiot.
How could I miss that?
Where is the gold winglet supposed to be
right now?
He asked Sonny.
Herbs and healing, with the copper
winglet, I think.
She said.
Herbs and healing?
he echoed.
Following her as she set off through the
tunnels.
I don't think we ever had that class.
We just added it a few days ago.
Sonny said.
A couple of students asked for something
like it.
Tamarin and Peregrine especially.
Peregrine, Kibley thought.
Flicking through the information in his
head, Sky Wing, Copper Winglet.
Claw mates with Pronghorn.
He's the one who's deaf in one ear.
From an explosion near his home during
the war.
Queen Ruby has devoted a lot of energy to
taking care of those wounded in the war.
I bet Peregrine is hoping to become a
doctor, so he can help.
The class was gathered in the healing
center watching clay as he laid out
bandages.
A large blue and red drawing of a dragon
was pinned to the wall behind him
illustrating where all the muscles were.
Which muscle did you get all venomed and
burned?
asked Pronghorn, poking at the drawing?
This one here, Clay said.
Point into the drawing and then to the
scar on his right thigh.
That's why I limp.
Because it was damaged where all these
parts connect.
But remember, peril saved my life by
burning me here.
Otherwise, the venom would have spread
and killed me pretty quickly.
He traced his claw along the paths, the
viper venom would have gone throughout
the figure in the drawing.
Ooh. said a few of the dragonettes.
Kibley studied the group of students.
Onyx was not here either.
The only members of the gold winglet in
the class were Tamarin and Pike.
Clay, can we borrow Pronghorn and
Tamarin?
Sunny asked.
Of course, Clay said, smiling down at
her.
Kibley offered his wing to Tamarin, but
she shook her head and found her own way
into the hall.
Pronghorn stood beside her, bouncing
eagerly on his toes as he looked from
Kibley to Sonny.
Pronghorn's family had been on Blaze's
side during the war, hiding with her in a
fortress in the cold tundra near the ice
kingdom.
So Kibley didn't know him all that well.
But he liked Pronghorn's energy.
Queen Thorn had chosen him for the
academy because he'd sent her 8 letters
begging to be included, expressing his
curiosity about the other tribes
enlisting all the things he was excited
to learn about.
What is it?
he asked.
Can I help with something?
We're looking for ostrich and onyx, Kibley
told him.
Have you seen them in the last couple of
days?
Chronghorn wrinkled his nose
thoughtfully?
The last time I saw ostrich was yesterday
before lunch.
She and Aaron and I took some instruments
to one of the upper caves to play with a
sound of rain in the background.
We invited Onyx, but she doesn't really
like music.
Doesn't like music?
Kibley echoed, startled.
Is she missing a soul?
What else does she dislike?
Sunshine?
Me, Tamarin offered, and most other
dragons.
Really?
Sonny said anxiously.
Oh, no.
I had no idea.
Is she hard to live with?
Is she mean to you?
No, she's always nice to my face, said
Tamaron.
In the rose and purple lights of the
hallway.
It was hard to tell what color her scales
were.
Most dragons don't realize how much I can
figure out, from their tone of voice, or
the little huffs they make between
sentences.
She thinks because I can't see her, I
won't be able to tell when she's rolling
her eyes, or making fun of someone.
Sometimes, she'll sneak in and out of our
cave because she doesn't want to have to
talk to me.
And she thinks I don't notice.
She shrugged.
It's not personal though.
I think she doesn't particularly care
about any dragons unless they can help
her get what she wants.
What does she want?
Kibley asked.
Tamaron shrugged again.
I don't know, but maybe she's gone to get
it, because she didn't come back to our
cave last night.
Khibli and Sonny both pricked up their
ears.
She didn't?
Sonny asked.
Whoa.
Do you think ostrich and onyx left
together?
Pronghorn asked.
Maybe to go back to the kingdom of sand?
Ostrich woodenly without telling someone
Kibley said.
She wouldn't leave without telling me.
Unless she was forced to.
Sonny said, trailing off.
She twisted her front talons together
looking ill.
You think someone took them?
Pronghorn asked keenly.
But why would someone kidnap onyx and
ostrich?
Kibley had no idea?
He kept seeing ostrich's face.
The trusting look she always gave him.
I convinced her to stay at school.
I told her I'd protect her.
And then I left her here. whatever's
happened to her.
This is my fault.
Chapter 4.
Why can't we go 2 days without a crisis?
Tsunami demanded when they told her?
Why is this school a magnet for
disaster?
Maybe it was a terrible idea all along
Sonny said.
Sinking into a pile of leaves in the
corner of the library.
She buried her face in her front talons.
Just like Blaise said it would be.
Starflight felt his way over to put one
wing around her.
Blaze is literally the least intelligent
royal dragon in the world, he said.
She can't be right, by definition.
If she thinks this school is doomed, then
it is definitely going to be wonderful.
Sunny gave him a rueful look.
Not if we keep losing all our students
it's not.
I mean, tsunami sputtered.
All we ask is that they sit in their
classrooms and learn stuff.
Is that so hard?
Well, Clay said, it is a bit...
I mean, sometimes...
It was for me.
He mumbled quickly at her quelling look.
And not go gallivanting off on lunatic
expeditions?
She pointed significantly at Kibley.
I am talking about you, to be clear, and
your whole troublemaking winglet.
We were helping winter, Kibli protested
and there's a prophecy.
No, tsunami shouted.
She stuck her claws in her ears.
No prophecies.
La la la fate is stupid.
Well, at least we're all being adults
about this.
Starflight said.
What?
Tsunami demanded, removing her claws.
Nothing, he said innocently.
I don't think ostrich went gallivanting
anywhere.
Kibley said, pacing around the central
desk.
She would have told me or Sonny if she
needed to leave.
Is there any chance ostrich and onyx went
with Dark Stalker and the others?
Starflight asked.
Maybe they were curious, like turtle and
anemone?
No, Sonny said.
It sounds like they disappeared last
night before the night wings left.
She stood up decisively.
I'm going to try dream visiting them.
She touched Kibley's shoulder with her
wing and made him meet her eyes.
Don't you dare leave this mountain until
I figure out where they are.
He nodded reluctantly.
Until tsunami cried, as Sonny hurried out
of the library.
What happened to ever?
Never leave this mountain?
That's what the rules should be?
Maybe we should send a message to Dark
Stalker, Clay suggested.
He could use his magic to help us find
them.
The others agreed eagerly, while Kibley
stared down at his feet.
It didn't feel right to him that Dark
Stalker was already the 1st answer they
were all reaching for.
That Dark Stalker seemed like the
solution to all problems.
He reached out to touch his earring.
This was his protection.
This was the only thing that ensured, his
mind was his own.
Turtle had enchanted it for him, using
the words Kibley had planned out.
The Dark Stalker had sensed Turtle
casting the spell.
That's how they'd learned that Dark
Stalker would know anytime an animus
dragon used his or her magic.
So Turtle can safely make any more
protection spells, and if there was only
going to be one, maybe someone else
should have it.
Maybe he should put the earring on
tsunami, or Sunny, or Starflight, on
someone who could make a difference if
only they were seeing clearly.
Wait.
There's someone who needs it even more
than they do.
I'll be back soon, he said.
Turning and hurrying out of the library.
He ran down the tunnel to the sleeping
caves and skidded into his room.
Winter sat up on his ledge, looking
irritated, but he always looked
irritated.
Must you tear about like a pack of
elephant seals sliding downhill?
Winter demanded.
Some of us are trying to read, like
civilized dragons.
That doesn't look like reading, Kibley
said.
Pointing to the square of paper, winter
was clearly drawing on.
Winter hit it quickly under his blanket
but not before Kibli glimpsed an outline
of a dark face, with silver scales beside
her eyes.
Keep your scruffy, sand covered nose out
of my business, Winter said haughtily.
Sure, but 1st you have to put on my
earring, Kibley said, advancing toward
him.
I beg your pardon, said Winter, with a
look of startled alarm.
No, thank you.
Absolutely not.
Shoo.
Just for a minute?
Kibley wheedled.
He reached out to his ear.
I said no.
Winter snapped.
You'll probably give me some weird
sandwing disease.
And besides, it would clash horribly with
my scales.
I'm trying to help you, Kibley said.
Stop being a beetle brain and just put it
on.
He pounced on winter and tried to pin him
down.
But winter was a bit bigger and
shockingly cold, and it was impossible to
wrestle him and maneuver out his earring
at the same time.
Winter thwacked Kibley's head several
times, hard with his wings, threw the
sand wing off his ledge and bolted into
the corridor.
I'm getting my own cave for real this
time, he shouted.
I will not be forced to cohabitate with a
deranged dragon.
Winter tore off of the tunnel before
Kibley could stop him.
Kibley paused in the doorway. catching
his breath.
Curious faces poked out of other sleeping
caves, goggling at him.
So, that went well.
He probably should have predicted that
winter would be a stubborn donkey for no
reason.
He wondered what would happen to him if
he did give the earring to someone else.
It was unnerving to imagine willingly
giving up his mind.
If only he'd had Turtle make 2 earrings
at the same time.
If only I were smarter, unless selfish
one for me, one for winter, double the
earrings.
He froze.
Struck by a sizzling lightning bolt of an
idea, could it possibly work?
He darted down the tunnel to turtle's
nearly empty cave.
Turtle's sleeping mat was on the floor of
Kibley's room from the night before, but
Umbers was still here.
Under Umber's mat was the satchel Turtle
had left behind.
And inside that satchel were 3 pieces of
curved wood that slotted together to make
a bowl.
Kibley slid them into place, his talons
trembling.
He put the bowl gently on the floor, and
reached up to remove his earring.
If this works, will dark stalkers sense
it, like he sensed the original spell?
Kibli thought for a moment.
No.
He can sense a new spell being cast by
ananimous.
This is an animus touched object being
used, pretty much the way it always is.
If Dark Stalker's spell included an
alert.
Every time an animus touched object is
used.
He'd be constantly barraged by dragons
using dream visitors, turtles message
slates, the palace, and the tree of light
and all the other spells in the ice
kingdom.
It would be too much to keep track of.
So if we think it's safe to use the
message slates.
It should be safe to use this bowl.
If it works at all.
Do it, quick.
Don't think about it too much.
Don't think yourself out of it.
Blinking rapidly, he dropped the earring
with a clatter into the smooth wooden
curves.
Nothing happened.
The earring lay there, warm and golden.
Kibley's wings drooped.
It must only work with food, he sighed.
Of course it does.
Turtles' spells are all like this.
Very specific.
He reached for the earring.
And then remembered something.
There was a phrase.
Something turtle said you had to say to
make the bowl work.
He drew back his claws, thinking
furiously.
Do your magic, he said to the bull.
Be magic.
Do a magical magic thing.
Come on, Kibley.
Use that brain of yours.
Double the stuff, he tried.
Make yourself two.
Twice the thing.
Oh, that's it.
Twice as much, twice as much.
He leaned forward excitedly.
Nothing happened.
The bowl still contained one solitary
earring.
Oh, come on.
That had to work.
Be more useful, he shouted at the bull.
Are you yelling at dishwear?
Carol asked, poking her head into the
room.
Just this one bowl, Kibley said
grumpily.
Because it's the stupidest bowl in
Pyria.
Peril edged a little closer and peered at
it.
Huh, she said.
Looks like a norm.
Nope, she interrupted herself, seeing the
look on his face.
You're right.
Stupidest bull I've ever seen.
Can I join in?
Hey, Bull, your shape is inane.
Food probably falls out of you all the
time.
I bet you don't even stack well in
cabinets.
Yeah, that's right.
You're the worst.
Ooh, this is great.
Let's do it every day.
I feel much better.
I don't, said Kibley.
Although, honestly, he did, a little
bit.
Uh, would it help if I set it on fire?
Peril offered sympathetically.
No, no, Kibley said.
I mean, thank you, but I'm trying to make
it do something.
Turtle animus touched it, but it's not
working.
Oh.
Aha.
Pearl said thoughtfully.
I know.
Maybe if I set it on fire a little bit
that'll scare it into doing what you
want.
Peril.
It's a bowl.
You can't scare it.
It doesn't have feelings.
As far as you know, she said, I say it's
looking awfully smug right now.
I guess I'll have to think of something
else, Kibley said with a sigh.
Did you try asking it nicely?
Parel asked.
Turtle would say try asking it nicely.
He's got a whole thing about how I'm
terrible at that or something, as if
setting things on fire isn't always the
most efficient way to get things done.
Asking it nicely.
Kibli picked up the bowl and realized
that his talons were trembling again.
He took a deep breath, gazing down at the
earring.
Twice as much, he whispered.
Please.
There was a small popping sound in the
air, and then, all at once, there were 2
identical earrings lying in the bowl.
It worked!
Kibley yelled.
It worked.
It actually worked.
Peril peeked into the bowl, keeping her
fiery scales as far away from it as she
could.
Oh, she said, in her polite voice.
Another earring.
I see.
Now your ears will match.
That is important.
I always thought you looked very silly
with only one.
It's not for me, Kibley said, and I do
not.
One earring is how all the outclaws wear
them.
Does Moon think only one earring looks
silly?
Kibli, focus.
He took out one of the earrings and
hooked it back into his ear.
Then he clasped the bowl and said firmly
Twice as much, please.
Another earring appeared.
Twice as much, please, he said again, and
then there were four.
Twice as much, please, twice as much
please, twice as much, please.
Four became eight, became 16, became 32.
Enough for all the dragons in the
school.
The bowl was nearly overflowing with
enchanted earrings now, heavy as thorns
crown, and his claws.
Harold tipped her head to the side.
Watching the multiplying jewelry
curiously.
Okay, I can figure this out, she said.
Backups in case you lose your
unfashionable ornament?
That's a lot of backups, though.
You must have the attention span of a
scavenger if you lose it that often.
Maybe a Kibli fan club and they all want
one?
Kibli was startled into a laugh.
I could never be that popular, he said.
Now, a winter fan club, that I can
imagine.
What?
Why?
Carol said loudly.
He's handsome, tortured, and heroic
Kibley supplied.
Everyone loves dragons like that.
I don't, said Pearl, shaking her head.
I prefer dragons are handsome, baffled
kind, and accidentally heroic.
I mean, hypothetically, just supposing
there was someone like that.
I would maybe think they were pretty cool
is all I'm saying.
Not that I'm thinking of anyone
specific.
Here, put one of these on.
Kibley rolled an earring across the floor
to her.
She poked at it gingerly.
This'll melt in a heartbeat on my ear.
My thought so, but try it anyway.
Kibley asked.
Actually, I have this new no thanks
policy about strange jewelry, Peril
said.
Bad run in with a necklace, but this
wouldn't survive long enough to do
anything to me anyway.
She picked up the earring, and as soon as
it touched her fire scales, the earring
melted into a blobby lump of gold around
the amber teardrop.
There was no way for her to wear it.
I'm sorry, peril, Kibley said.
He could use the earrings to protect
everyone else at Jade Mountain Academy
but not her.
Well...
She said, in a fairly delightful
pretending very hard to be sad voice.
It is disappointing because boy.
Wow, so pretty, but I will just have to
survive somehow anyway.
It's enchanted, Kibley said.
Turtle put a spell on my earring to
protect me from any spells dark stalker
might cast.
Peril did not react with a wild
excitement he'd hoped for.
Oh, she said.
Dark stalker?
Huh?
Well, I'm sure that won't be necessary.
There's nothing I can do to convince her
as long as she's under his spell.
I'm going to take these to Sonny, Kibley
said.
Coming?
Harold made a complicated face.
All right, she said.
It took Hibli a while to find the caves
of the school founders.
He'd never sought them out in their own
rooms before.
Sonny's was part sleeping cave, part
office, with a bundle of blankets neatly
tied away in the back corner.
Three low tables arranged in a semicircle
took up most of the room, scattered with
paper, ink, small slates for
announcements, and maps.
There were 2 openings in the walls where
the late afternoon sunlight spilled in
and across the room, and the rest of the
walls were covered in blue, white, gold
sand wing tapestries, drawings of thorn
and to do lists, with half the items
crossed off.
Sunny was sitting in one of the shafts of
sunshine, clasping a large blue sapphire
in her front talons, with her eyes closed
and her tail coiled around her feet.
Kibley hesitated in the doorway.
What's she doing?
Harold asked in a whisper that just
barely counted as a whisper.
Looking for ostrich and onyx.
He murmured back.
Sand wings?
Pearl said.
Like the pair who flew off west
yesterday?
What?
Kibley cried, whirling toward her.
You saw them leave?
Well, sure, peril said.
I figured they were spooked by Dark
Stalker.
I'm sure they'll be back once everyone
calms the heck down.
They were by themselves, Kibley asked.
Just the 2 of them, flying away.
Yep.
Carol squinted at Sonny, who still hadn't
opened her eyes.
But then, Kibli tried to puzzle this
out.
Ostrich had left willingly without
telling anyone.
Unless it's not what it looks like.
We thought someone must have snuck in to
kidnap them.
But maybe there wasn't an outside
kidnapper.
Maybe the kidnapper, was right here at
Jade Mountain.
Onyx could have said anything to make
ostrich go with her.
Kibble could think of 8 different threats
off the top of his head that would have
worked.
The question was why?
What could onyx possibly want with a
dragonette like ostrich?
A path to her father?
He guessed immediately.
Thorn's most trusted general.
Whatever onyx wants?
She's hoping to use 6 claws to get it.
Which meant they must be on their way to
Thorn's palace, and they had a day's lead
on Kibley.
He had to go after them.
His queen was in danger.
He had to leave right away.
He darted across the room and set the
bowl at Sonny's feet.
Sonny, he cried.
Come back.
Put on an earring.
I have to go.
Sonny opened her eyes, blinking in
confusion.
What?
She looked around, slowly registering the
mountain around her.
I was talking to Glory, she said.
She says Dark Stalker has offered to
become king of whichever night wings want
to follow him.
I guess that'll make glory's life a bit
less complicated.
Did you say put on an earring?
Glory doesn't care?
he asked.
Startled by this odd detail.
Whoa, said Sonny, spotting the bowl in
front of her.
That is a lot of earrings just like
yours.
It's a long story, he said, but I think
Onyx has kidnapped Ostrich so she can use
6 claws to get at Queen Thorn.
So I have to leave now, and you need to
get everyone to wear these right away
especially winter.
All right, goodbye.
He turned to Dash out of the room, but
Sonny grabbed one of his 4 arms in a
steely grip.
Kibley, wait, she said.
I have an idea where ostrich is, but
please explain this first.
She waved her talon to the glowing gold
and orange hill in the bowl.
Kibli blew out a frustrated breath.
This was important too.
He knew that.
Possibly the most important thing right
now, but if anything happened to ostrich
or thorn, he'd never forgive himself.
These earrings are enchanted, he said, to
protect you from evil spells.
He wasn't sure she'd put it on if he told
her the danger was Dark Stalker.
Oh, how nice, Sonny said, a little
dubiously.
Where did they come from?
One of the animus dragons left them for
us, Kibley said, which he thought was a
pretty inspired answer, really.
It was true, but avoided giving away
Turtle's secret.
Oh, Sonny said.
You mean dark stalker?
Or was it anemone?
I hope Anemone didn't waste her soul on
protection for us, although it is very
thoughtful.
Earrings for the whole school?
Wow.
Um, interesting choice to make them all
look like yours.
Please, just put one on, Kibley begged.
All right, Sonny said agreeably.
To his delight, she picked up one of the
earrings and slipped it right on.
He held his breath, watching her face.
I don't see whose evil spells this is
going to...
Sonny started to say.
She stopped mid-sentence, staring at
Kibley.
Sunny?
he said.
Kibley, she cried.
Um, yes, he said.
Kibley, she cried again, leaping to her
feet.
Her wings flared open in a glittering
whirl.
A gigantic, all powerful, possibly evil
dragon, just rose out of the ground, and
flew away with 6 of my students.
Six of my students.
I know, he said.
Uh, don't panic.
Too late. peril said, watching with
bewildered amusement.
Why did I let him do that?
She yelped.
I'm the worst school guardian of all
time.
Three moons.
He took turtle and anemone.
Queen Coral is going to have our heads.
What's all this hollering about?
Tsunami asked, bustling over from her
cave next door.
Why did tsunami let him do that?
Sonny shouted.
We promised we wouldn't let Princess
Anemone out of our sight.
Tsunami, your sister just flew away with
a total stranger.
Who?
Dark stalker?
Tsunami said, tilting her head sideways.
He's not a stranger.
He's your ancestor, remember?
Charming, friendly, harmless.
He said he's going to teach her about
being ananimous.
Shell be back soon.
Here, put this on.
Kibley held out one of the earrings.
Tsunami snorted.
I have my own jewels.
Thank you.
You need it, Sonny said.
Tsunami.
Trust me.
I do trust you, tsunami said hesitantly
as Kibli placed the earring in her palm
about most things, but about fashion?
I mean, it's not like you ever wear the
gifts your mother sends you.
She shot a look at a small locked chest
next to Sonny's blankets.
Just try it on for a minute, Kibley said
impatiently.
Why are some dragons so difficult?
Tsunami flicked her tongue out, Adam, and
stuck the earring on her ear.
There, she said.
Happy?
What is this?
She stopped, blinking.
Why?
Why do I suddenly feel terrible?
Dark Stalker has everyone under a spell
Kibley said in a rush.
He's enchanted everyone around him too
I'm not sure exactly, to trust him or
believe him or like him, something like
that.
How did you know?
Sonny asked.
Because it's what I would do.
Kibley realized, with a twinge of shame.
That's why it had occurred to him so
quickly.
It's one of the 1st spells I thought of.
If I'd gotten dark stalkers scroll, if I
had all that power, 1st I'd protect my
soul.
Next, I'd cast spells to protect everyone
I love, and then, I'd do a spell to make
everyone like me.
Even winter.
Even my family.
Would that be wrong?
I wouldn't abuse it the way Dark Stalker
has.
I wouldn't be tricking anyone into doing
the things I want them to do.
I just want other dragons to like me.
And some of them won't, no matter how
hard I try.
I wouldn't be making their lives worse in
any way.
But I know it's wrong when Dark Stalker
does it.
And yet, I still wish I could do the same
spell myself.
He closed his eyes, trying to shut down
the rushing tornado of thoughts going
around in his head.
Sonny was waiting for an answer.
Because everyone was acting so odd. he
said, especially winter, but not just
him.
Everyone accepted Darkstalker as exactly
what he says he is.
And I thought, well, maybe we should give
him a chance.
But I wanted to be sure our minds were
free to think it through for ourselves.
Wow.
Sonny said.
She touched the dangling amber teardrop
in her earring.
I can't believe I completely missed it.
You want to believe the best in every
dragon anyway.
Kibley said.
He probably didn't need to enchant you
for you to give him a chance.
A chance, maybe.
Sunny said.
But 6 of my students?
I'm horrified at myself.
You got anemone to make these for you?
Tsunami asked.
So she's wearing one too?
She's not under his spell.
Kibley squirmed.
No, he said, wondering how to dance
around the truth here.
I only had one for myself.
But today I figured out how to make
more.
Tsunami and Sunny both looked puzzled.
I'd rather not say any more than that, he
admitted, in case it puts someone else in
danger.
How do I know this earring isn't
enchanted to mess with my head?
Tsunami demanded?
What if it's got a spell on it to make us
more suspicious of dark stalker than we
should be, or something else?
She twitched her ear grumpily.
I don't like wearing animus touched
things.
I don't trust them.
Smart, peril offered unexpectedly.
You shouldn't.
They can have other spells hidden inside
them.
I'm sure, this one doesn't, Kibley said.
I can tell you the exact words of the
spell.
Enchant this earring to make the wearer
immune to any spell Dark Stalker has cast
or will cast, whether past, present, or
future.
That's all there is to it, I promise.
Hmm, tsunami said, twitching her ear
again.
It sounds all right to me, Sonny said.
Then Anemone needs one of those earrings
said Tsunami.
She's in more danger than anyone.
Her and father, said Sonny, then stopped
with a stricken expression.
But I can't give one to Stone Mover.
Dark Stalker saved his life with his
magic.
If I make him immune to all of dark
stalker's spells, It'll erase that one
and then father will die.
I'm not sure Flame will accept one
either.
Even if it shows he's innocent, Kibley
said.
Sonny blinked at him.
I mean, I think Dark Stalker might have
enchanted Flame to kill Stone Mover.
It would make sense to get rid of any
other animus dragons, considering what
Fathom did to him.
Sunny covered her mouth with a small
gasp.
But, He saved him.
She said.
He didn't let Stone Mover die.
Maybe he changed his mind, said Kibley.
Or maybe.
It was a performance to make you trust
him even more.
Or maybe, he needed an excuse to cast a
spell on stone mover, a control spell
hidden inside a healing spell.
Maybe all of those things.
You have a very complicated brain, said
Peril thoughtfully.
Dark Stalker said something like that
too.
Kibley remembered.
He just doesn't seem that sinister to me
Peril added with a shrug.
Because I can't take the spell off you.
He pointed out.
Not yet, anyway.
I'll figure out a way.
We have to get one of these earrings to
glory too.
Sonny said, touching the bowl lightly
with one of her wings.
If only we could convince all the night
wings to wear them.
They won't, not if they know what it is
Kibley said.
It would mean giving up all the powers
he's given them.
None of them will agree to that.
But Moon.
Moon should have one.
I could fly to the rainforest, he said.
Right now.
I can take earrings to glory and moon.
He trailed off, remembering ostrich.
Someone else can go to the rainforest
Sonny said, putting one of her talons
over his.
You have to go after ostrich.
I know, he said.
I found her with a dream visitor, although
she was too shaken to hear me.
But I could see that there were dragons
in black hoods all around her, and she
kept dreaming about their leader, a
really tall sandwing, with a hooked snout
and tattoos of dragon skulls all down his
neck, Tattoos of dragon skulls.
Kibley said slowly, like, lots of them.
Too many to count, Sonny answered.
The whole place gave me this dark, crowded
trapped feeling, and it had a smell, I
remember.
I think she might be in the Scorpion
Den.
Kibli rubbed his neck as though he could
feel the stab of the tattoo needle on
himself.
She is, he said.
And I know who has her.
They all turned to stare at him.
Who?
Tsunami asked.
He took a deep breath, trying to speak
past the claws that were closing around
his throat.
My grandfather.
Chapter 5.
I'm going back to the Scorpion Dan Clay.
Kibley said, the most dangerous city
empire, to save one of your students.
And this is all you have?
Sorry, said Clay.
I told you, it's not exactly a weapons
cave.
No, I would call that a weapons box, said
Kibley.
Pacing in a circle around the box that
sat in the middle of the stone floor, with
hardly anything in it.
This is a school, you know?
Clay pointed out.
Sonny and I thought perhaps an entire
cave full of sharp objects might not be
the best idea.
We thought maybe, hey, something that
locks instead.
So, to defend this entire school, Kibley
said, you've got 3 knives, one sword, and
a big stick, in a locked box.
Hey, that stick is very heavy.
Play protested.
You wouldn't want to get whacked with
that thing.
Also, we have tsunami, and now peril.
That's better than a couple of swords.
Kibley sat down and covered his face with
his wings.
I can't face him with nothing.
He felt as if his heart was trying to
jitter its way down his arms, and out
through his claws, breathing was much
much harder than it was supposed to be.
If I go to him with no weapons, I might
as well cut my own throat and hang my
corpse from the alley wall.
Yeesh, said Clay.
Are we still talking about your
grandfather?
Kibley nodded.
He didn't trust himself to stand up.
While the floor was doing the weird
tilting thing it apparently had to do
right now.
Kimley's 1st memory of his grandfather
was of 100s of eyes.
The eyes of all the tattooed skulls
staring at him with the same cold
calculating look his grandfather wore.
The schools were there to greet him the
day he struggled out of his egg, and they
returned, like malevolent clockwork, every
3 days, as they would have for the rest
of his life, if he hadn't been lifted out
of his family.
A later memory.
The hiss of snakes, their writhing scales
covering the floor, as he beat his wings
to stay above them, while his grandfather
timed how long Kibley and his siblings
could last before collapsing.
He remembered the sharp sting of the
snake bites, as less painful than the
disapproval on his grandfather's face.
Vulture was a large, terrifying presence
that loomed over every corner of Kibley's
early life.
Kibley was convinced that grandfather
would have killed off all 3 of Cobra's
dragonettes if it were up to him.
This was Kibli's biggest clue that his
mother really loved him, because, he
reasoned, Cobra must be protecting them
from grandfather, risking his wrath to
keep them alive, which meant she must
love Kibli in some way, after all, even
if it was a deeply hidden way.
Kibley's plan for a long life boiled down
to one essential element.
Never see grandfather again.
But if grandfather had ostrich, there was
no choice.
You really have to be armed to visit your
grandfather, Clay said.
Definitely.
True when I was a dragonette, more true
now.
He never liked me, said Kibley, giving
breathing another try.
Nope, still impossible.
I haven't gone back to see him since I
joined the Outlaws.
He made it clear he was pretty unhappy
about that, though.
Angry letters, Clay said
sympathetically.
Sort of, said Kibley.
More like 100 dead rats, spread out over
a couple of years, and always in new
unexpected places.
Like, inside my blankets when I went to
sleep at night, buried and decaying in a
vat of grain, I was supposed to be
guarding, lying by the shores of the
oasis pool with their throats slit.
He knew they must be from his grandfather
but he'd never told Thorn.
He didn't want her to worry about him, or
worse, tried to do something about
Kibley's grandfather that might get her
killed.
Do you have any poison?
He asked hopefully.
I could dip one of these knives into it
and have a poisoned dagger.
Oh, I'd feel a lot safer with a poisoned
dagger.
In a very sturdy sheath, I mean.
Of course we don't have poison, Clay
said.
Remember the whole this is a school
thing?
Our plan is to teach these dragonettes
peace, not more violence.
My training sessions are only about self
defense.
That's all I want to do, Kibley said.
Defend myself.
With a poisoned dagger and a couple of
swords, and maybe some throwing stars and
a mace would be nice.
You don't need that stuff, said a gruff
voice from the doorway.
You'll have me.
Winter slouched handsomely against the
cave wall, wearing one of his most heroic
scowls.
Oh, will I?
said Kibley.
I'm coming with you, Winter said.
To rescue your little sandwing friend or
whatever.
Really?
said Kibley, genuinely surprised.
Why?
Because you adore me and can't bear to
see me leave?
What's his real reason?
Is he worried about the ice wings finding
out he's still alive?
So he's decided to get out of here?
Or maybe Dark Stalker has enchanted him
to keep an eye on me.
In addition to whatever other spells he
has on winter.
Because I owe you for helping me find
Hellstorm. said Winter.
And if we're even, maybe, you'll stop
bothering me all the time.
And also because it'll be funny to be the
one annoying your tale for once.
So basically, because you adore me, Kibley
said with a grin.
This is already backfiring, Winter
muttered.
Well, tragically, said Kibley, I'm afraid
you cannot come.
I seem to recall saying something similar
to you once, said Winter.
With equally unsuccessful results, just
so you're prepared.
No, you really can't, said Kibley.
I mean, I'm basically walking into a den
of killer scorpions.
I'm not afraid of the scorpion den.
Winter said, bristling.
I'm not talking about this city, said
Kibley, and I'm talking about my family.
They can't be as bad as mine, Winter
said.
He flicked a wing dismissively.
Actually, they're exactly like yours
Kibley said, rubbing his eyes, except
they don't bother pretending to be
civil.
They don't know which fork is for salad
because in their minds, all forks are for
impaling their enemies, and they'll stab
me from every direction at once, not just
in the back.
So you need me, said Winter.
Perfect.
Ready when you are.
Kibli thought for a moment.
If winter was under some kind of dark
stalker induced spying spell, there
wasn't anything Kibley could do to stop
him, except, If I let you come with me
said Kibley brightly, will you put on my
earring?
Absolutely not said Winter.
His gaze fell on Clay's ear.
Where an earring exactly like Kibley's
now glittered.
Winter's frown went slightly deeper and
more puzzled.
Everyone's wearing them.
Clay said cheerfully.
He touched the amber teardrop so it
wobbled for a moment.
Very fashionable.
Kibli, what are you up to?
Winter demanded.
This is a startling new level of weird
even for you.
Our animist friend enchanted them to
protect us from evil spells, Kibley said
glancing sideways at clay, who mercifully
had not asked a ton of questions about
where the earrings came from.
Come on, winter.
Don't be a burrowing shrew.
Just put one on and you'll understand.
If I'm right, and you're under a spell
right now, it'll release you, and if I'm
wrong, you'll be exactly the same.
But say from any future spells.
And isn't that a good thing?
I'm not under a spell, Winter said, and I
don't want to be.
I remember what hailstorm's spell felt
like, and it was awful.
You keep your enchanted geegaws away from
me.
Geegaws?
Kibley echoed.
How can you call me weird?
and then use ancient old worm words like
that.
I'm coming with you, and I'm not wearing
any stupid earring, Winter said firmly.
I thought this was an emergency.
Why are you still here?
I know, I know, Kibley said, clutching
his head.
I have to go.
I know I need to go right now.
But facing my grandfather.
I'm not ready.
I don't know how to get ready.
Did Sonny tell you about the tattoos?
No, Winter said, in a bored voice.
He has a dragon skull tattoo for every
dragon he's ever killed. said Kibley.
He's covered in them.
Sounds a bit obvious.
Winter yawned.
Why not just had to, I'm totally menacing
on his forehead.
Khibli laughed.
He'd never, ever laughed about his
grandfather before.
The tight claws digging into his lungs
eased back slightly.
It would feel better to have an ally, even
an enchanted, sarcastic one who pretends
to hate me.
And if I keep him close, I'll find a way
to get that earring on him.
All right, you can come, he said, as long
as you listen to me.
Like, if I say, quick, dive into that
barrel of scare beetles, you have to do
it right away, no arguing.
Oh, don't worry.
Winter said.
I intend to be just as helpful and
obedient as you were on my quest.
Kibli picked up one of the daggers.
I guess I'll take this one, he said to
Clay, if that's all right.
Sure.
Play said with a shrug, reaching to close
the box.
I wish I had something else.
One dagger.
And a bowl that doubles anything you put
into it.
That's all I'm taking to face the king of
the Scorpion Den underworld.
If only I had dark stalkers scroll.
It was Winter's fault that peril had
burned the scroll.
Winter was the one who'd refused to let
Kibley have it.
The one who'd turned a perfectly
reasonable discussion into a fight. which
peril felt she had to stop by destroying
Kibley's one chance at having magic.
But he couldn't be furious at winter
right now, not the way he wanted to be.
As long as he was under Dark Stalker's
spell, Winter was basically not himself.
Kibley had to give Winter back his mind.
And then he could be furious at him.
Let's go he said to Winter.
I've been ready forever.
Winter said with another yawn.
Kibli led the way through the school to
the main hall, where Sonny, Starflight
and Peril were waiting for them.
Night had fallen quickly outside, and the
cave was full of fluttering echoes, like
the whispers of tiny dragon wings, as
bats stirred and woke and took flight.
Peril saw Clay enter the cave behind
Kibley, and gave a little sideways jump.
Then made a face like she jumped sideways
all the time.
No big deal, totally normal behavior
followed by an, is everyone looking at
me?
Stop looking at me.
Face.
Kimley suspected he could spend hours
tracking the emotions on Pearl's face and
never get bored.
Kibley?
Maybe I should give you my dream visitor
Sonny said.
Twisting her front talons together.
Oh, why didn't I keep the one we found on
Flame?
I can't believe I let Dark Stalker just
waltz off with it?
Part of the spell?
said Kibley.
You trusted him, so you didn't even think
to worry about it.
Hey, don't forget they were his
originally. peril blurted.
That's true, said Starflight, nodding.
He's the one who made the dream visitors
all those centuries ago.
Kimley tilted his head.
Oh.
I wonder if that means they won't work
for us anymore, he said to Sonny.
She opened her mouth, then closed it
again with a startled look, reaching out
to touch her earring.
Oh dear, she said.
I use it all the time.
How am I supposed to check on you without
it?
Or communicate with glory.
We'll have to think of something else
Kibley said.
But speaking of animus touched objects, I
was wondering.
I was wondering if maybe I could borrow
Anemones weather bracelets.
It would be a small piece of magic, but
magic nonetheless, and he'd take any
magic he could get right now.
Any magic would be better than none.
Sonny hesitated, then glanced at
starflight and clay.
What do you guys think?
She doesn't trust me with them.
Kibley thought, with a crashing wave of
anxiety.
She's like turtle imperil.
She thinks I don't deserve magic, or that
I'll do something terrible with it.
But I wouldn't, his mind flared
indignantly.
I'd be so careful.
I'd think through everything that could
go wrong before I did anything.
And I have so many great ideas.
I would have been the right dragon to
take care of Dark Stalker's scroll.
I know I would have, no matter what
winter thinks.
Sounds all right to me, Clay said with a
shrug.
Unless we might need them to defend the
school.
Starflight worried.
You don't need magic bracelets, Kibley
joked.
I've seen your secret weapon.
Is it me?
Carol asked, throwing her wings open
excitedly, which made Winter jump back
with a hiss.
Am I the secret weapon?
I'd be a great secret weapon.
Actually, I was talking about the very
big stick in the weapons box, Kibley said
but you're almost as scary.
Sonny dug into her bag and pulled out the
bracelets.
They glowed like captured lightning in
the lamplight as she placed them
carefully in Kibley's talons.
Be very careful with them, she said.
I don't know how they work, and please
bring them back for anemone once ostrich
is safe.
Kibley slipped the bracelets around his
wrists.
They looked like bands of fire against
his pale yellow scales.
These were not like turtles quiet, sidling
don't look at me, spell things.
These bracelets shouted, power, power
power, and I do amazing things, and adore
me.
And did you notice the amazing things I
can do?
And stand back while I bring the
lightning?
And P.S.?
Yes, I said lightning.
Cower before me.
Boring normal dragons.
Real magic.
He wished he could wear them forever.
Maybe if I help save anemone, she'll let
me keep them.
They'd look better on me, Winter
commented.
Kibley shot him a frown.
He was not going to do this again.
He was not going to let winter start a
fight that might convince Sonny to take
them away.
We'll see you soon, he said quickly to
Sonny and the others.
We'll get ostrich and bring her right
back.
He glanced at Winter, then lowered his
voice to whisper in Sonny's ear.
And you'll make sure moon gets nearing as
soon as possible.
Tsunami is leaving with earrings for
glory, moon, turtle, and anemone.
As soon as she's got them on the other
sea wings here.
Sonny promised quietly.
I'll handle the rest of the students.
She took Kibley's front talons and hers.
Thank you, Kibley.
Good luck.
You too.
Gah, with the endless goodbyes already.
Winter grouched.
Let's go.
He stomped out of the cave and lifted
into the night sky.
I'll miss you too.
Parel called after him.
Wish we could take you with us, Kibley
said.
But you would literally burn down the
entire scorpion den the minute you
touched anything.
Not the most fireproof place is what I'm
saying.
Dragons should really build more cities
with me in mind, Pearl said.
Also, rainforests and libraries.
More fireproof rainforests and libraries
that would be great.
It was time to go.
Kibli knew it, and he couldn't put it off
any longer.
But it was almost more than he could bear
intentionally seeking out his grandfather
his grandfather, of all dragons.
Couldn't he face scarlet, or dark stalker
or blister, or someone more generally
evil instead?
Did it have to be a dragon who very
specifically hated and haunted him?
Think of ostrich.
Think of the oaths you swore to the
outlaws.
Think of what Thorn would want you to
do.
Think of what Moon would do.
Kibli waved goodbye to the watching
dragons, spread his wings, and launched
himself toward his darkling past, now
become his uncertain future.
Chapter 6.
During the night, as they flew, Kibley
felt a twitch from the slate in his
pouch.
He breathed a small flame to read the
message from Turtle.
Kinkaju is awake and fine.
Please tell Tamarin.
Dark Stalker taking the tribe to the old
knight kingdom in the morning.
And then, a few moments later.
Everyone definitely under his spell
except Kinkaju.
Kinkaju.
Kibli did a delighted flip in the air.
She was all right.
Oh, he wished he was back at Jade
Mountain, so he could tell Sunny and
Tamarin and see their faces.
What are you flopping all over the sky
bout?
Winter asked from his left.
Nothing, Kibley said, tucking the slate
away.
He wanted to let Winter know Kinkachu was
fine, but as long as Winter was under
Dark Stalker's spells, he couldn't be
trusted with any secret information
especially anything related to Turtle.
I'll tell you, once you put on one of my
earrings.
Winter pointed at him.
Peculiar.
That's what you are.
He powered his wings harder to fly on
ahead.
The Kibley's elation began sliding toward
dismay as the rest of the message sank
in.
Dark Stalker is taking the tribe away in
the morning.
What if he leaves before tsunami gets
there?
Is Moon going with him?
What if tsunami misses her chance to give
earrings to moon and anemone?
She'd have to follow them to the old
night kingdom.
If anyone was paying enough attention to
notice where Dark Stalker went?
I don't exactly love the idea of an all
powerful dragon and his army of brain
washed, superpowered followers vanishing
into the mist.
But if someone is paying attention, then
we could go there too, and save Jade
Mountain from the prophecy.
He worried and wondered about this for
the rest of the night, as the mountains
gave way to forest, and then sandy
dunes.
It was just before dawn when they spotted
the scorpion den splayed across the
desert ahead of them.
Winter eyed it from above as they flew
closer, and the straggling alleys, tents
colorful carpet walls, fire pits, and ram
shackle structures became visible.
This place looks.
He struggled for words for a moment
charming.
Kibley supplied, picturesque.
Unsanitary, Winter concluded.
I'm sure you mean charming, Kibley said
thrilling, untamed, unconventional.
Winter snorted, unkempt.
Oh yes, that's true, said Kibley.
We are definitely not Kempt.
So what's the plan?
Winter asked.
Wait until the cover of Darkness?
Sneak over the wall?
Break into your grandfather's house, find
ostrich.
Why are you shaking your head?
There's no sneaking into my grandfather's
place, Kibley said.
It's the most well fortified structure in
Pyria.
I highly doubt anything in this place
could compare to the fortifications
around Queen Glacier's palace, Winter
said haughtily.
And I mean in a deadly way, Kibley went
on.
The whole thing is lined with minds and
traps.
One wrong step, and your foot gets blown
off.
A different wrong step and hello, that's
a lot of axes.
Grandfather isn't interested in catching
intruders and teaching them a lesson.
He's interested in killing them before
they even see his treasure.
Winter's eyebrows were arched high enough
to reach his horns.
Really, he said.
Then what's your ingenious plan?
Kibley grimaced.
Gather information first.
Find out if he's changed in the last few
years, then.
He blew out a long breath.
Then I probably have to talk to him.
Ah, I get it now.
Winter said, nodding.
You're planning to annoy him so much, he
decides to throttle you.
And while he's distracted with that, I
rescue ostrich.
I'm in, especially for the you getting
throttled part.
You think you're joking, said Kibley.
But that sounds pretty much exactly how
this might go.
They swept down to one of the entrances
to the town, which was not even guarded
Kibley noticed indignantly.
Clearly, standards had fallen since Thorn
and her out claws left to run the
kingdom.
A sense of unease prickled along his
scales.
In his lifetime, there had always been 2
worlds in the Scorpion Den.
The visible world, which Thorn ran with
her ferocious strength and wisdom, and
the underworld, which stayed out of her
way, and kept its more unsavory practices
to a minimum, as long as she was in
charge.
But with her gone to the palace, who was
keeping the underworld in check?
Was anything keeping it below the surface
anymore?
Who had risen to take her place?
He had a terrible feeling he could guess
exactly who.
They strolled right in the open gate. onto
a street lined with stalls, many of which
were still closed in the pre-dawn light.
Morning since drifted from those that
were open.
The smell of roasting beetles and coffee
wrestling with the many, many, much less
pleasant smells in the air.
This place is the opposite of Queen
Glacier's palace, Winter murmured
stepping delicately around a dirty sand
wing, who lay asleep, half in the gutter
his tail wrapped in grimy bandages, and
his wings tattered and marked with
sores.
The outlaws wouldn't have left him like
that, Kibley said.
Love too.
Winter asked.
Kibley squinted at him.
He wondered if the ice wing prince even
saw the homeless dragons underfoot, or if
they just looked like inconvenient grime
to him.
You must have wounded soldiers too, Kibley
said.
Are they all perfectly taken care of in
the ice kingdom?
Winter twitched his nose uncomfortably.
I believe so, he said.
They're not in the palace in any case, and
they're certainly not.
Well, in the way like these are, Kibley
mocked him, waving one wing at another
huddled figure.
That's not what I was going to say, Winter
objected.
The Ice Kingdom is very clean, that's
all.
We don't have anywhere like this.
He jumped as a trio of small, scuttling
creatures, darted across the street
almost under his talons.
As far as you know, Queen Glacier's
nephew, Kibley pointed out.
That's true, Winter said unexpectedly.
You're right.
I didn't leave the palace much.
There could be a lot I never saw.
Kibley glanced at him sidelong.
Maybe winter had changed, and not only
from Dark Stalker's spell.
Maybe there was a reasonable open-minded
dragon in there, just waiting to burst
out.
He wanted to say something about palaces
and queen's nephews, and pristine lives
but then, out of the corner of his eye
Kibley caught a glimpse of shadows
slinking after them.
Never mind, he said, speeding up.
He didn't need to draw any more attention
to winter's royal status.
It was too obvious already.
The silvery immaculate prints stood out
like a small iceberg wood, if it bounced
down from the mountains and sailed
through the cobblestone streets.
The farther in they went, the more
shadows seemed to be tailing them, and
the more Kibley's unease grew.
Maybe it was a mistake to bring winter.
Strangers being watched was normal for
the Scorpion Den.
Being followed wasn't unusual either.
The competition to prey on new visitors
was always fierce.
Although I'm not a visitor, and they
should recognize me.
Kibley thought with a frown.
What felt strange was how long they were
followed without any further action.
No urchins accidentally rolled a ball
under their feet to distract them.
No cut purses bumped against them as they
went past.
No one even tried to pick a fight to test
how they'd react.
No one approached them at all.
The shadows did nothing but watch.
And that was weird for the Scorpion Den.
They wound their way through the dusty
streets to a neighborhood that Kibley had
avoided for the last 2 years.
Memories assaulted him as they turned
each corner.
The heavy, sweet smell of incense
burning.
The flies incessantly buzzing the garbage
for discarded bits of prey.
The bright stained cactus plants
bristling in baked clay pots that hung
from the windows.
The carmine red scrawls of paint on the
stone walls, where rivals marked their
territory, and young dragonettes imitated
them boldly.
And then the archway.
The black gate standing open, the
courtyard beyond, where Kibley's brother
and sister had nearly killed him a 100
times.
He hesitated as they reached the
threshold.
I don't have to go in.
Grandfather won't be here.
He'd be in his own compound.
But mother.
After all these years, he'd really
thought he didn't care anymore.
But he found his talons taking him
forward, straight into the sick
uncomfortable, hopeful, terrified
headspace where he'd grown up.
Winter made a scoffing noise deep in his
throat as they crossed the rundown
courtyard, but Kibley couldn't stop to
react to it.
He pushed open the door that led inside
and called, Mother.
Oh, said Winter, you lived?
Here?
He gave the cracked paved stones a look
as though he was even more disappointed
in them.
I can't go inside.
Kibley realized with a shudder.
I can't have those walls around me
again.
The lingering smell of roasted coriander
seeds brought back a rush of painful
memories.
Mother, he called once more.
A heavy, drifting silence answered him.
Like the silence you'd find far under the
dunes in the desert.
She's all right, he told himself.
She's one of the smartest and deadliest
dragons in the scorpion den, who could
possibly get close enough to harm her.
Grandfather, of course, but he wouldn't.
Mother?
He tried one more time.
She's not here, said a mocking voice
behind him.
Winter and Kibley whirled around.
Two dragons were perched on top of the
courtyard walls, one on either side of
them.
Their venomous tails coiled dangerously
over the edge beside them, and their
matching expressions were malevolently
delighted.
Hello, Sarocco, Kibley said.
Stealing his voice to sound calm
rattlesnake, long time no see.
You look, even crueler than you used to.
Older, where is mother?
He noticed that in the years since he'd
seen them, his brother and sister had
acquired Dragon Skull tattoos of their
own, a trio marching down Sarocco's neck
5 trailing from rattlesnake's head, like
a long, morbid earring.
There was a small hope that these were
only decorative, meant to imitate and
flatter grandfather.
But Kibley was fairly sure that they
represented exactly the same thing on his
siblings as they did on his grandfather.
Mother don't want to see you, said
Sarocco in a rough, gravelly voice.
That grandfather does, Rattlesnake
announced, in a menacing sing song.
Better come quick and easy.
Sarocco growled.
He don't like to wait.
Or you could put up a fight.
Rattlesnake suggested.
We don't mind.
She flicked her forked tongue at winter.
I like fighting shiny things.
Ah, grandfather. said Kibley, trying so
hard not to feel like he was 2 years old
all over again, like he was about to be
pounded into the dust, and all his
cleverness couldn't save him.
He glanced down at his wrists.
I have animous friends, and magic
bracelets.
I'm not the same dragon they used to push
around.
How's he doing?
Still a barrel of doom on 4 legs.
Come see for yourself said rattlesnake
flicking her tail pointedly at the gate
to the alley.
Kibli caught the sideways frown Winter
sent his way and shrugged.
At least this would get them into
grandfather's compound, although he
couldn't guarantee they'd ever come out
again.
His brother and sister led the way down
the street, with Kibley and Winter close
behind.
So where is mother?
Kibley asked.
Bit of a long story, said Sarocco.
Let's just say she hasn't exactly been
the same since you abandoned us.
Rattlesnake hissed with a little smile.
What does that mean?
Kibley asked.
His brain went into hyperflight?
Mother regrets letting me go.
I was right.
She did love me after all.
Swung straight into, don't get your hopes
up.
Maybe she was furious, and has been
waiting for me to come back, so she can
finally let grandfather kill me.
Which was bolstered by, where did our
shadows go?
They must have been tailing us for
grandfather.
He knew we were coming.
Shot directly on into how did he know?
Did Onyx guess I'd come after Ostrich?
Was this all a setup?
Followed directly by, how should I play
this?
Pretend like I've come back to rejoin the
family?
Surely they wouldn't believe me for a
moment.
What's the most clever way to save
ostrich and get out of this?
And will mother notice if I'm really
clever?
And then will she realize I'm more
interesting than she ever thought I was?
You'll see, sang rattlesnake.
As they turned down an alley that
suddenly turned left, then right, then
appeared to end in a wall as high as 6
dragons.
Surocco pushed one of the bricks in
grabbed the revealed handle, and slid
open the secret door to grandfather's
compound.
Thorn had never ventured here.
Nor sent her out claws.
As long as vultures stayed out of her
business and let her run the city her way
she stayed away from him.
So Thorn had never seen the vast wealth
hidden behind that secret door.
The sprawling, palatial complex, the only
marble anywhere near the scorpion den, the
gold dripping from every surface.
Kibley had seen it a few times when he
was younger.
When he and his siblings were summoned to
family meals on holidays.
But it looked more ostentatious now, as
if the gold and treasure had been
plastered over, with another 5 layers of
gold and treasure.
Or perhaps, his time with thorn had made
him accustomed to more simple tastes.
Now, when he looked at the emerald
studded doors, or the black diamond eyes
of all the statues, what he saw was a
tremendous waste of wealth, that could
have been used to make 100s of dragons
lives better.
I probably wouldn't get in trouble with
Thorn for stealing from here.
He reflected.
But if he was caught stealing from his
grandfather, the punishment would be
certain death.
As they walked through the garishly
grandiose decor, Kibley could feel
Winter's disapprovals sticking out of him
like giant prickly ice wing spikes.
He hoped winter could contain his
sarcastic arrogance in front of
grandfather.
He hoped he wasn't leading his friend
into a trap.
He hoped Vulture wouldn't dare harm a
prince of the ice wings.
If revealing that information would save
winter.
Vulture did not need to know he was a
disgraced and banished and supposedly
dead prince.
Kibley kept himself alert for any signs
of onyx or ostrich, but there were none.
She has to be here somewhere.
They reached a pavilion where the floor
and columns were inlaid with tiny
turquoise, gold and white tiles, and the
ceiling was covered in mirrors.
Kibley could tell from the dragons
lurking all around it, that his
grandfather would be here.
Even before he spotted Vulture's long
neck, hooked snout and dark eyes
glittering from the dais in the center of
the pavilion.
Let me do all the talking, he whispered
to Winter.
That is how conversations with you
usually work.
Winter observed.
Walter had added to his collection of
Dragon Skull tattoos so that by this
point, he looked rather like a leopard
from a distance, pale yellow, but
stippled all over with black patches.
He wore a black cape, lined with gold, and
draped with gold chains all along his
wings.
His claws were dipped in gold leaf, and
enormous black and gold earrings shaped
like spiders gleamed in his ears.
He didn't look up at Kibley and Winter as
they approached, his eyes, and the eyes
of the 4 dragons beside him were fixed on
a small wooden structure set up on the
floor in front of him.
It looked like a little maze.
It was a little maze.
Kibley realized, drawing closer.
And inside were 2 scavengers, running in
a panic from one dead end to another.
Uh-oh.
Winter, don't react.
Winter drew in a sharp breath, then
started forward.
Kibley blocked him with his wings, but
the noise was enough to make Vulture look
up.
Kibli.
He said, with the smuggest of smiles.
Just the dragon I've been waiting for.
Chapter 7.
Vulture's eyes flicked over Kibli and
Winter, assessing them at the speed of
lightning, and then he returned his
attention to the scavengers in the maze.
Hold your tongues for a moment.
He said.
I want to see who wins.
Then what are you going to do with them?
Winter demanded.
Vulture slowly lifted his head to stare
at winter again.
Eat the loser, he answered.
And save the winner to try again tomorrow
against a different one.
I'm curious to see whether they can learn
anything.
They can, Winter said.
They're very intelligent, too intelligent
to eat.
Eating them would be cruel.
Winter.
Kibley whispered.
What a whimsical friend you've brought
for my entertainment.
Vulture said to Kibley.
He turned back to Winter.
You're quite wrong.
Everyone agrees there are no smarter than
mice.
If you were right.
Dragons would already know that, and no
one would ever eat scavengers, and yet we
eat them all the time.
Ergo, you must be mistaken.
But winter started.
It's perfectly normal to feel like your
pet must think the way you do, Vulture
said, and the condescension was spread so
thick that Kibley felt like rubbing his
scales with sand to get clean.
It's happened to many dragons.
The camel's rights movement, iguanas are
dragons too.
Save the scavengers.
World Walrus Fund.
Oh, very sweet, and very misguided.
Save your energy for dragons who can
appreciate it.
Stop arguing with him.
Kibley hissed out of the side of his
mouth.
He'd seen this a 1000000 times.
The way Vulture could grind down anyone
who disagreed with him, or, if his
opponent argued back for too long.
The way Vulture was perfectly happy to
win the most annoying arguments with
casual violence.
I'll pay you for them, Winter said
quickly.
The 2 scavengers had found each other, and
now one was trying to boost the other up
to look over the walls.
It certainly looked like intelligent
behavior to Kibley, much more intelligent
behavior than what winter was doing right
now.
That was for sure.
I'll buy them off you.
I'm in the market for new pets, in fact.
Oh, really?
Prince Winter, said Vulture, sitting back
in his gilded chair.
And how exactly do you intend to pay me?
When your family thinks you're dead, and
your royal funds have been cut off.
In the silence that fell, Kibley tried to
keep his breathing on track.
He had already identified 4 possible
escape routes, but none of them would
work if he forgot to breathe.
Vulture waved to the scavengers and the
maze.
Take them away, he said, to a pair of
dragons nearby.
My visitors have ruined my experiment for
today anyway.
We'll try again tomorrow.
The dragons bowed, took either side of
the board supporting the maze, and
carried the scavengers out of the room
while they were still trapped inside.
Winter watched them go with a dismayed
expression, but Kibley couldn't pull his
eyes away from vultures.
How did Vulture know not only who Winter
was, but his whole story?
Had the news spread so quickly?
Did he have spies in the ice wing tribe?
So, Grandson, Vulture said commandingly.
I see, that like many 100s of sand wings
across the kingdom.
You've realized that thorn is in no way
qualified to be queen, and you've come to
pledge your loyalty where it truly
belongs.
War broke out inside Kibley's mind.
Play along.
Find out what you can.
Stay alive, shouted one half, while the
other roared, no, no, no, never.
I will not betray her.
Many 100s of sand wings?
he echoed, buying time.
Oh yes, said Vulture.
Her erstwhile popularity, such as it was
is plummeting.
Everyone agrees that she's been quite
useless so far.
Has the kingdom improved in any way.
No one's life is any better, except of
course, for her own outlaws, who are now
rolling in treasure up there in the
palace.
I'm sure you saw that yourself.
She pours wealth into the talons of those
who bow and scrape to her, and she
doesn't care a fig for anyone else.
No, Kibley thought fiercely.
That's what you do.
And these tragic bombings.
Vulture said, reaching for a bowl of
dates beside him.
Dragons are die.
And she hasn't done one thing about it.
She has no idea who's responsible, if she
even cares.
But I do.
I have found the culprits.
I am the only one who can protect our
tribe.
You know, who's been setting off all the
cactus fires, Kibli asked.
Of course I do.
Vulture leaned toward one of his guards.
Summon our informative friend for me, will
you?
The guard nodded, and hurried away into
the garden.
It's really an outrage, Vulture said
sitting back.
His spider earrings caught the light
reflecting it like a sharp knife in
Kibley's eyes.
I mean, absolutely everyone is talking
about how Thorn can't keep us safe.
He chewed a talon full of dates noisily.
But I can.
Really?
Kibley asked, battering back his rage.
How?
I have formed a private militia of my own
Vulture said smugly.
He tapped his gold tipped tail against a
metal sheet hanging beside him, and an
eerie coppery noise, rolled out across
the garden like thunder.
From every shrubbery, from every shadow
from each corner and descending from
their roofs and treetops, came a wave of
dragons.
Black hoods cover their faces, and gold
medallions hung from their necks
emblazoned with the shape of a bird of
prey, of a vulture, Kibley realized.
We're the new law and order in this
town.
And soon, in the whole kingdom, said
Vulture.
I had them looking into these
heartbreaking attacks, and the dreadful
mess Thorn has made of investigating.
We discovered who is responsible, and
will bring them to justice.
As more hooded dragons slithered
forward.
Kibley's 4 possible escape routes became
3, and then 2, and both of those very
questionable.
Who are all these dragons?
Kibli wondered.
How can there be so many who are willing
to follow grandfather and do his evil for
him?
Vulture spread his wings, as though he
were displaying a vast tray of new
jewels?
I call them my talons of power.
He said.
Beside Kibley?
Winter made a choked noise.
Kimble knew exactly what he was
thinking.
The prophecy.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
I thought it was about an animus dragon.
But what if it's about my grandfather's
secret army?
I always thought the talons of peace was
too grand a name for that disorganized
group of whiners, Vulture said.
I knew I could improve on both the
concept and the reality.
Ah, here we are.
The guard had returned, leading a dragon
who was so heavily swathed in jewelry
that it took a moment to see through it
all to figure out which tribe he was
from.
Trails of gold, chains encircled its neck
dangling from an elaborate, ruby
encrusted headpiece that clashed with the
rows of silver, emerald and topaz
earrings in each year.
Silver chain mail studded with sapphires
covered his chest.
Golden silk veils wreathed his wings.
He even had a tailband, which was an item
of jewelry that had gone out of style
centuries ago, because they were hard to
fly with.
His was gold, and shaped to look like
dragon claws, clutching every inch of his
tail, each claw tipped with a sapphire.
Kibley had never seen a dragon look more
ridiculous.
He glanced sideways at winter, whose
expression suggested that his eyes might
never recover.
But underneath all the glitter, the
dragon's scales were simple mud brown, and
his snout was broad and flat.
A mud wing?
Kibley thought, confused.
Vulture surveyed the walking, clanking
pile of treasure for a moment with his
jaw clenched.
Kimberley wondered if his grandfather was
upset because the mud wing was being so
obvious about the lavish bride he must
have gotten.
Or possibly, grandfather just doesn't
like any other dragon, to wear more gold
than he does.
How is your pavilion bog?
Vulture inquired with forced politeness?
Much better than that prison cell?
Bog answered cheerfully, but very much as
though he was reading back a line that
had been written for him.
I was hoping you could share your
confession with our dear guests here
Vulture said, spreading one wing toward
Kibley and Winter.
Bogg's gaze tracked the movement and
landed on them.
He jerked backward, nearly tripping over
his chains and ornaments.
An expression of horror surged across his
face, and then he ducked his head, took a
deep breath, and looked up again, now
placid and smiling.
What was that about?
Kibli wondered.
Of course, sir, he said.
The mud wings are the ones who've been
attacking cities throughout the kingdom
of sand.
Queen Mohen and the Mudwings are
responsible for all of it.
Kibley stared at Bog. who was definitely
avoiding his eyes.
No, I don't believe it.
He's lying.
But why?
You see, said Vulture.
Unlike Thorn, I investigated.
Unlike Thorn, I found out who is trying
to hurt us.
And unlike Thorn.
I can lead us to victory against this
enemy, along with my talons of power.
The mudwing nodded, his gold chains
jangling.
Why is Bog doing this?
Kibli wondered.
For treasure.
How did Vulture find a mud wing, willing
to betray his tribe this way?
A mudwing who's willing to lie, to lead
us into another war.
Willing to see his tribe mates die, just
so he can have another expensive ring on
his claws.
He is lying.
He must be lying.
There's no reason for Queen Moorhen to
attack us.
She wouldn't want more war.
C, Vulture said condescendingly.
Now we know the real truth.
Oh, thanks to me.
And if we're going to defeat this
pervasive mudwing menace.
We're going to need a strong leader, like
me.
Not a corrupt, glory seeking liar like
Thorn.
You may go bog.
The mud wings scurried away as fast as he
could clank, while vultures stood up and
swept toward Kibley in a cloud of heavily
perfumed air.
I'm sure you agree with me.
Since you're here to work for us, right
on time.
Kibli tanted down his rage.
Keep it together.
Gather information.
What exactly do you think I'm going to
do?
he asked.
First.
Tell me everything you know about Thorn.
Her palace, her guards, any weaknesses
everything a good little spy would have
absorbed in your time with her.
Next, teach my talons, any passwords they
need to know, to get close to the
palace.
And finally, return to the palace, and to
our false queen, bearing a gift.
Kibli took a deep breath in and blew it
out again. making sure his voice didn't
shake with anger when he finally spoke.
Where is ostrich?
he asked.
Ostrich.
Vulture said reflectively.
Oh, the general's daughter.
She's fine, perfectly happy.
She loves it here.
Of all the places to be held captive.
This is the best, obviously.
I want to see her.
And I want a new queen of the sand wings
said Vulture, a true queen, who will set
up trade routes that make me richer and
turn this town into the thriving
metropolis it could be.
I'm sure you can imagine. how great that
will be.
All your old friends. your family, happy
and wealthy, and running the world.
We'll kick out everyone who's not a
sandwing and crack down on
troublemakers.
It'll be spectacular.
A new queen of the sandwings?
Winter said skeptically.
Who?
Blaze?
Kibley had met Blaise, the only remaining
daughter of Queen Oasis, and the only
sister left alive after the war of
Sandwing succession.
Thorn had allowed her to keep living in
the palace, as long as she did meddle in
the kingdom's affairs.
Blaise had agreed happily, thrilled to
return to the desert warmth, after years
in the ice wing tundra border zone.
All she cared about was keeping her
scales polished and her gems sparkly.
In Kibley's estimation, Blaze was
silliness personified.
She was the opposite of level headed
empathetic thorn.
No, no. said Vulture, wrinkling his
nose.
Nobody wants Blaze.
Have you really not heard the rumors?
Little dragons.
The whole kingdom has been buzzing for
months, about a secret heir to the sand
wing throne.
One that nobody knew about until
recently.
A granddaughter, who escaped the deadly
claws of Queen Oasis, and has been living
and hiding since she hatched.
A dragon, unlike Thorn, who has true
royal blood in her veins.
Onyx.
Kibley interrupted.
The realization hitting him like snake
fangs sinking into his neck.
Vulture snapped his mouth shut, thrown
off the rhythm of his dramatic
announcement.
Of course she is.
That's what she's been up to this whole
time, Kibley said, his mind racing on
ahead of his words.
Queen Oasis' granddaughter.
But how?
She could be the daughter of blister or
burn, taken away by a trusted servant, to
be raised in secret, except blister, would
never let a possible threat to her leave
her sight.
And Byrne, didn't want anything to do
with partners or eggs.
Blaze has a lot of empty space between
her ears, but she'd remember having a
dragonette, if only because carrying it
would have been a great aggravation to
her.
So she would have gone looking for it
after the war.
And she never did, so it can't be hers.
Which leaves the royal sons, and of those
only one was rumored to have a love
affair, serious enough to warrant an
attempted elopement.
Except his true love was supposedly
captured and killed by Queen Oasis
shortly before the Queen's own death.
But if she wasn't, she could have escaped
and hatched Dragonette, who'd be just
exactly onyx's age.
So onyx could be lying, a false pretender
to the throne.
But it's equally likely to be true
meaning, she's the daughter of Prince
Smolder, the granddaughter of Queen Oasis
and directly in line for the sand wing
throne.
There was a brief silence.
Sometimes, your brain makes my brain
hurt.
Winter observed.
Well done, said Vulture.
I always suspected you were the smartest
of Cobra's offspring.
Rattlesnake let out an injured growl, and
Sarocco stopped picking his claws for a
moment to look at her and say, what?
I didn't do anything.
What?
Now, at last, you can use that
intelligence for a good cause.
Vulture went on.
A righteous cause.
No.
Kibley straightened his neck. and folded
back his wings.
I can't lie about this, he realized.
I'm not a sneak.
I won't betray Thorn, not even by
pretending to.
I'm loyal to Queen Thorn, and always will
be.
Folter made a face.
You think you are, he said.
Because she stole you away and
brainwashed you.
You haven't thought for yourself in
years.
You do exactly what she tells you to. and
think whatever she tells you to think.
You're not your own dragon, grandson.
Everyone knows her group is basically a
cult.
It's true.
Ask anyone.
The whole kingdom has figured out that
her outlaws are blind followers.
You don't want to be a blind follower.
Do you, Kibley?
Don't you want to think for yourself?
I am thinking for myself, Kibli insisted
bristling.
So think, yourself back into your
family.
Vulture suggested, in a deceptively
friendly tone of voice, you loved being
one of us, before Thorn snatched you
away.
She's fed you a lot of lies about us
hasn't she?
Turning you against your own family.
What kind of leader does such a thing?
Don't you remember the puzzles we did
together?
The family dinners?
The way I was grooming you to take over
the business, once you were older.
Those were happy times.
Vulture's eyes reminded Kibley of the Eye
of Onyx, not solid black, but black in
loops all the way down, like looking into
the longest, deepest hole in the world.
The Kibli was not going to let his
grandfather's hypnotic eyes, and
confident attitude play tricks on him.
He had Sirocco and Rattlesnake in his
peripheral vision as a clear and present
reminder of the torment he'd gone through
every day before Thorn saved him.
I did not love being part of this family
Kibley said firmly.
Give me ostrich and let us go, and I will
ask Queen Thorn to spare your life.
Clever, and stubborn, Vulture mused
slithering closer.
I knew you would be.
You see, inferior grandchildren, this is
why I was so unhappy with your mother
when she lost him.
Rattlesnake hissed, and shot Kibley a
vengeful look.
Who?
said Sarako.
Us?
What I do now?
But perhaps, now that he is returned to
us.
If he has truly returned to us, said
Vulture smoothly.
Perhaps now it is finally time to release
your mother from her punishment.
Punishment?
Kibli's heart sank.
What has he done to her?
It doesn't make sense.
Punish her for getting rid of me?
But I thought grandfather never wanted us
alive in the 1st place.
Did he?
Where is she?
Kibley demanded.
Let's go see, said Vulture, flicking out
his wings.
Leave your scavenger loving prince here.
He started off down one of the garden
paths without waiting to see if Kibley
would follow.
Kibli hesitated, looking at winter.
I'll be fine.
Winters said, in a bored voice.
He circled a spot on the cool marble of
the pavilion and lay down, pretending to
look sleepy and impassive.
Just don't forget we're here for
ostrich.
All right, Kibley said.
Try not to get yourself set on fire while
I'm gone.
One time, Winter said icily.
One time I got myself set on fire.
Kibley hurried after his grandfather, who
was already talking when Kibley caught up
to him.
The black cloak swirled out between his
wings and around his tail, casting
glinting gold reflections in the white
marble walkway.
I've always liked that word.
Vulture was saying.
Oobliette.
Ooh, Bliette.
It sounds much friendlier than it is.
Like you should be able to eat it at
parties.
Do you know what an oubliette is?
Kibley nodded, feeling as though his
heart had sunk all the way into his
stomach, and was smashing big holes all
through his insides.
I wish Moon were here.
Everything is less awful when I'm with
Moon.
I wonder, if she could read Vulture's
mind.
Whether she'd still think that dragons
are basically good inside.
She'd be brave enough to stand up to
him.
That's what I have to do.
Dig in my claws and keep standing, like
she would.
Here we are, Vulture said.
Stopping at a courtyard marked out by a
circle of potted palms, all in giant clay
pots painted gold.
Kibli looked around for a moment in
confusion.
The courtyard was deserted, as far as he
could tell.
Then he remembered the word oubliette, and
looked down.
In the floor in the center of the circle
of palms was a trap door, just barely big
enough to squeeze a medium sized dragon
through.
Kibley stepped over to it, his whole body
swamped with dread.
Through the bars in the trap door, he
could see down a long, dark shaft, a hole
that seemed bottomless at first, until
his eyes adjusted, and he could see a
shapeless figure, and the glitter of eyes
looking back up at him. too many eyes.
From far below came a splash, and a low
ongoing hissing.
Mother is down there?
Kibley said, disbelieving.
Oh yes, said Vulture.
Her and a few crocodiles, a number of
snakes, probably a rat, or 7, if they
haven't been eaten yet.
I forget what else.
We just throw down anything nasty we can
find.
Kibli?
A hoarse voice called from the darkness.
Mother!
Kibley called back, gripping the bars
fiercely.
Mother, I'm here.
I'm getting you out.
I promise.
He whirled on Vulture.
You have to let her out of there.
Well, that, my dear grandson, said
Vulture, depends entirely on what you do
next.
Chapter 8.
It wasn't a prison, exactly.
And it wasn't a dungeon.
It certainly wasn't an oubliette.
But Kibli had never felt more trapped
than he did that day, waiting for his
mother in his grandfather's observatory.
It was a beautiful little black marble
building, actually, with a dome set up
higher than all the other structures in
the compound.
Diamonds twinkled like stars everywhere
scattered throughout the walls and
columns.
Moon shapes were carved all around the
outside of the building.
From crescent to full, outlined with
milky pale moonstones.
Inside, the floor was covered with large
silk pillows, in silver and black, and
soft dark blue carpets, where dragons
could lie down to look up at the sky.
On 2 sides of the dome.
Telescopes pointed at one of the moons
and star charts lined the walls.
Under any other circumstances, Kibley
would have adored this place.
But here and now he found it unsettling
because he knew it was a recreation of
the old observatory in the Sandwing
Palace, one that hadn't been used in
years, since before the war, which made
him think of how long his grandfather had
been alive, and how deeply entwined with
a monarchy he had once been.
It made him think of Queen Thorn
struggling to put the kingdom back
together, while a danger like vulture and
onyx's conspiracy crept up on her.
And it made him think of Moon, who would
love this room.
A whole building designed for watching
the moons, just like her name.
He wished he could recreate it at Jade
Mountain, so dragons who would actually
appreciate it could have access to it.
He doubted that anyone used it very often
here, where it was more of a status
symbol than anything else.
Kibli paced around the perimeter of the
dome as the sun crawled slowly across the
sky.
He could see it crawling if he looked up
because the dome was open at the top, but
he refused to look up, because he knew
there were 6 dragons in black hoods
sitting up there, staring down at him and
winter.
There was only one message from Turtle.
In the middle of the morning, and like
all the others, it was breathtakingly
uninformative.
Kinkaju, Moon and I, following Dark
Stalker Tonight Kingdom, hopefully back
at school soon.
Kibley was in agony, wishing more than
ever that he could be in 2 places at
once.
How many night wings had gone with Dark
Stalker?
Which way was the lost city of night?
How was Moon?
Was the spell changing her?
Had tsunami reached them with the
earrings?
And, if so, was Moon wearing one?
Why didn't Turtle mention tsunami at
all?
Was Moon safe?
What was she doing?
What was she thinking?
Had it only been a day and a half since
he last saw her?
Why did it feel like a 1000000 years?
He just wanted to be in the same room as
her for a moment so he could breathe
again?
He just wanted to hear her voice and make
her laugh. and give her his heart.
That was all.
He missed her.
His loyalty to Thorn and the outlaws.
His promise to ostrich's parents, his
ties to this family, and what he owed his
mother.
All of that kept him here.
But he thought of moon every waking
moment.
So does he.
He reminded himself, catching sight of
Winter's face.
I think, I'm sure he does.
Who is she thinking of?
Probably him.
Has anyone ever told you that you are
kind of an exhausting dragon to be
around?
Winter asked, from one of the silk
cushions.
Are you even capable of sitting still?
Why is this taking so long?
Kibley asked.
Grandfather said he'd bring mother and
ostrich to us hours ago?
What if one of them is hurt, and he
doesn't want us to know?
Or what if keeping us trapped here is
what he really wants, to get me out of
the way while he takes down Thorn?
Hmm, yes, said Winter.
Because before this, you were the only
thing stopping him.
Never mind the other 100 loyal outlaws or
the palace guards, or the entire sand
wing army she commands.
I wonder what the kingdom will think.
When they find out Onyx is the
granddaughter of Queen Oasis, Kibley
said.
Trailing one wing along the wall.
Dragons love royal bloodlines.
And if someone is setting off explosions
in the kingdom, winter started.
Someone, Kibley said with a snort, someone
is my grandfather.
Winter blinked and squinted at him.
You think vulture is the one
orchestrating the bombs?
I thought he said he was investigating
them.
Of course, said Kibley, oldest trick in
the book.
Do something terrible in secret, make it
look like your opponent can't protect
their people, then sweep in and protect
them yourself.
The worrying part is that he'll probably
convince a lot of sandwings that we ought
to go to war with the mudwings.
But I'm sure it wasn't them, no matter
what that strange treasure lover said.
He held out his talons and studied
anemones weather bracelets.
Maybe I should use these to get us out of
here.
Just the thought of wielding such magic
made his claws tingle.
What a well thought out plan, said
Winter.
Please do make it rain so he can drown in
here.
Maybe a really big storm would be
distracting, Kibley said.
He flexed his talons optimistically.
No, it would just be wet, Winter said.
I know you're excited about your magic
toys, but try not to be absurd.
Save them for when they can actually be
useful.
The wish of wings made them both look
up.
Two dragons descended into the dome
vulture, and, right behind him, the long
thin shape of Kibley's mother.
Kibley caught his breath.
Cobra was as beautiful and deadly looking
as she'd been the day he left her.
The oubliette hadn't taken away the
dangerous glitter in her eyes.
But maybe it had changed the expression
on her face when she looked at him.
Maybe he was imagining things, but she
looked a tiny bit less out of my way bug
who needs squashing, and a tiny bit more
that's my dragonette.
The 2 dragons touched down on the floor
and Cobra paced toward Kibley, flicking
her tail barb slowly back and forth.
You finally come back to us, she said.
Took you long enough?
I'm sorry.
If I'd known you were being punished like
that, Kibley said.
He hesitated.
Were you?
This whole time?
Because of me?
Because of our own mistake, said
Vulture.
She knew I wanted heirs to my
organization.
I told her not to kill off or get rid of
any of you.
She knew.
There would be consequences to letting
Thorn have you, of all dragons, that
upstart nobody.
Cobra nodded.
Yes, my mistake, she echoed.
Kibley's mind was reeling.
He'd always thought Cobra was keeping
them alive despite his grandfather's
wishes, not because of them.
His understanding of his own childhood
wavered in front of him, like a mirage in
the desert.
I'll go get the other one Vulture said.
Give you 2 a chance to catch up.
He took off into the sky again.
Cobra backed Kibley into the sunshine in
the center of the dome and started
examining him from horns to tail, as if
he were a rented caravan, and she was
checking to see whether Thorn had damaged
him.
Hmm, she said, tapping the scar on his
snout.
Clumsiness or war wound.
You gave that to me, he reminded her.
Oh, she said, skeptically.
She tipped his head up and studied his
eyes.
Well, you seem a bit stronger.
Perhaps you'll be useful to your
grandfather.
Maybe even more useful than you would
have been if I'd kept you.
Depending on how much you've stored in
here.
She tapped his skull once, then started
brushing sand off his shoulders.
There.
That's a bit better.
Cobra's gaze shifted to winter.
Couldn't you have bathed before coming?
You look a bit shabby next to this shiny
creature?
I'm sure I do.
Kibbly thought.
A thought that would not have bothered
him anywhere else in the world, but here
under his mother's eyes, he felt keenly
how unshiny he was, and he couldn't stop
himself from thinking that moon must see
them the same way.
Never mind, said Cobra, spreading one of
her wings around him.
Her breath smelled of coriander, just
like it used to.
I'm glad you've returned.
Kimberley's mother had never put a wing
around him before.
Brushing the sand off him?
That was familiar.
She done it every time grandfather came
to inspect them, but this light
protective touch came from nowhere.
Kibley couldn't stop himself from
thinking.
She did miss me.
She does love me.
And his talons felt as awkward and as
heart as confused, as if he were 3 years
old all over again.
Introduce me to your glittering
companion.
Cobra suggested.
That's winter, Kibley said.
Flicking his tail toward the ice wing.
I keep trying to get rid of him, but he
follows me everywhere, like that monkey
who followed me home one day, remember?
He hesitated, remembering that he'd
wanted to keep the monkey for a pet, but
Cobra had decided to eat it instead.
Stay in the present.
Don't get sucked into the past.
He forced himself to focus on winter, like
a tether in a sandstorm that could lead
him back to his true self.
It's pretty adorable.
He's my biggest fan.
Ha!
Winter barked.
Indeed.
Ha, ha, ha.
Don't believe a word he says.
I can't stand him.
We'll probably end up married one day
Kibley said.
The only reply Winter made to this was a
snort so vigorous he nearly knocked
himself over.
Cobra arched her eyebrows.
Well, that would get your grandfather's
attention. she said, marrying an ice
wing.
She tapped her claws together, looking
thoughtful, then added, He's always been
interested in a business alliance without
tribe.
Kibli blinked up at his mother.
Is she really taking me seriously?
Or is she pretending to for some reason?
Or is she only making conversation, while
she actually thinks about something else
like being trapped in grandfather's
prison for years?
Or does she truly mean it?
That marrying an ice wing could be seen
as advantageous to the family.
That wasn't the family Kibley remembered
with their fierce hostility to other
tribes, but maybe things had changed.
Maybe the peace had turned the other
tribes from enemies into potential pots
of gold.
Are you going to help your grandfather?
Cobra asked abruptly.
Looking Kibley in the eyes.
He looked away first.
I can't.
He wants to know all of Thorn's secrets
and I would never.
I'm not that kind of dragon.
I told him that, Cobra said.
I said you wouldn't.
Even for me.
Even if it meant, well, it's not
important.
I'll find another way to help you, Khibli
insisted.
Thorn will send her army to get you out
of here, if I ask her to.
I'm sure she will.
I have a better idea.
Cobra whispered.
You take me with you.
We escape tonight.
Kibley studied her face, then looked up
at the hulking shapes of the guards above
them.
How?
He whispered back.
I am an assassin, remember?
Between the 2 of us.
I think we can outsmart my father.
Kibli thought for a minute.
A 1000000000 thoughts cascading over one
another.
All right.
He stepped back from her, but we're
taking ostrich too.
Cobra's eyes narrowed to slits, but she
nodded.
Sh, she said.
Here they come.
She was right.
Vulture was descending again.
This time with 2 other dragons, the rangy
black diamond studded form of onyx, and
beside her, tiny ostrich.
Kibli.
Ostrich cried.
She flew across the dome to throw herself
at him and he caught her, beaming.
She was all right.
She was uninjured.
He hadn't failed 6 claws and Kindle
completely.
Hey, he said, hugging her.
You had me kind of worried.
Well, Onyx told me that Queen Thorn had
sent her a message asking for us, and I
thought, whoa, that's kind of awesome.
But guess what?
That turned out to be a lie, Kibley.
She was lying to me.
Why would she do that?
Ostrich shod onyx a resentful look.
And we were halfway to the palace when
suddenly this guy showed up with like 80
creepy dragons in hoods, and they bossed
us all here instead.
Although I was pretty sure Thorn wouldn't
be here, and I was right.
And then they said I couldn't leave.
And finally, I realized, Onyx was
actually working with them.
And then I was like, ah, no.
I'm a stupid hostage again. aren't I?
She seized his front talons.
Kibley, I don't like being a hostage.
Can we stab all these dragons in the face
so no one will ever think I'd make a good
hostage like ever again?
And then maybe I need to eat all the
camels and pyriot to get really huge.
I bet that would help too.
Super huge ostrich, worst hostage ever.
That is the look I would like to go for
please.
We can definitely work on that, Kimberly
promised.
But you're all right?
Outraged, but intact.
Ostrich said proudly, and he could tell
she'd been putting on a brave face, and
that she'd been more scared than she'd
ever admit, but that she was prepared to
be strong, and he could count on her.
Delightful.
Vulture interjected.
Now you have what you want.
Let's discuss what I want.
You mean what I want, Onyx said coldly.
The throne.
Why don't you challenge Queen Thorn?
Kibley asked her if you're so sure the
throne should be yours?
That was my original plan, said Onyx
shooting a glare at Vulture.
But someone told me I'd never make it all
the way into the palace to issue my
challenge.
Someone convinced me my plan would work
better if we delayed long enough to
spread a bunch of rumors first.
Someone thought it would be a great idea
for me to go hide myself away at that
idiotic pacifist school so I could find
out more about the queen's daughter.
Thorn's daughter?
Sonny?
said Ostrich.
Something was happening outside.
Kibley pricked his ears toward the roof
of the dome, some kind of commotion in
the garden.
One of the hooded guards flew off
probably to see what it was.
Vulture had his head tilted toward the
sky as well.
His eyes met Kibley's, and he grinned, as
if to say, see how alike we are.
The only dragons who notice everything.
I thought she'd be another contender for
the throne.
Onyx went on, still talking about Sonny.
She rolled her eyes and let out a small
snort of flame.
But I've never met a less ambitious
dragon.
No interest in killing her mother at all
and so busy with that dreaded school.
I can never get close enough to learn
anything useful.
Finally, I decided I had enough.
The chaos of that giant night wing
arriving, distracted everyone long enough
for me to kidnap this little idiot, who
would have been perfect leverage to get
me through the gates, and passed her
general father, so I could kill Thorn in
her sleep.
But no.
Apparently, I have to wait again for some
other convoluted plan to take shape.
I know, you're getting impatient.
Vulture said soothingly, but successful
plans take a little time.
There was a crash and some muffled
shouting outside.
Now everyone looked up at the sky.
What is it?
Vulture barked at the hooded figures.
Someone trying to see you, sir, answered
one of the talons.
Won't take no for an answer.
Already got a bit of his tail blown off
charging the wall, but still coming
strong, bleeding and everything.
Great snakes, said Vulture calmly.
If he's that intent.
Let's have a look at him.
Yes, sir, the guard said, ducking her
head.
She flew away and returned a few moments
later, escorting a dragon along with 3
other talons.
Two of them had their hoods torn and
tossed back, and the 3rd had a long
scratch on his side, but the newcomer was
in far worse shape, bleeding from several
wounds, and with his tail ending in a
bloody stump instead of a sand wing
barb.
Sir, he cried, as soon as he saw a
vulture, I have an urgent message for
you.
I'm not allowed to stop, or rest, or do
anything else until I give it to you.
He collapsed on the marble floor. as the
guards dropped him in front of Vulture.
Intriguing, said Vulture, go on.
There's a new king of the night wings, the
dragon gasped, letting words spill out
breathlessly.
A giant dragon, the biggest you've ever
seen.
He caught us in the rainforest, and took
the other 4 prisoner.
But he sent me back to tell you.
It's not the right time to kill Queen
Glory.
He said he knows about your plan to
replace Thorn, and he'll help you if you
help him.
He said he'll be in touch soon, and not
to do anything until he sends
instructions.
The last sentence whooshed out of the
dragon in one garbled rush, and then at
last, he took a breath and closed his
eyes and fell, unconscious, at vulture's
feet.
Kibli whirled toward Winter.
This was proof.
Proof that Dark Stalker was working
against their allies, that he couldn't be
trusted.
Surely winter had to see him as he was
now.
But the ice wing prince looked
unaffected.
He was watching Vulture with a politely
curious expression, but he certainly
didn't look as though an enormous
revelation had just been dropped on his
head.
Vulture, on the other talon, absolutely
did.
He stared down at the messenger, his tail
lashing, so his cloak shifted from side
to side, rustling along the floor.
A new King of the Night Wings, he
enunciated slowly.
Must be that big guy I told you about
Onyx said with a shrug.
But, King.
Vulture said again.
The Knight Wings agreed to this.
Queen Glory just handed them over.
To a king.
Why would she want them?
Onyx demanded.
Bunch of lying grumblers.
I'd give them away too.
Focus on my own tribe.
Your tribe.
Vulture mused.
And in a flash of insight, Kibli guessed
what he was thinking.
If one tribe can have a king.
Why not another?
Why be the power behind the throne?
When one could be the power on the
throne?
Why bother installing onyx?
If perhaps the time has come for a sand
winged king at last, This was bad, bad
bad, bad, bad.
Vultures scheming behind the scenes was
terrible enough.
Vulture openly trying to seize the throne
for himself would be a new kind of threat
to Queen Thorn, especially if he was
collaborating with Dark Stalker to make
it happen.
Kibley felt sick.
With dark stalker's magic, they could
kill Thorn anytime, from anywhere, with
barely a thought, I have to get to her.
I have to take her an earring right now.
I can't wait another moment.
I'll take your gift to Queen Thorn.
He blurted.
Like you wanted me to.
Whatever it is.
I'll take it today.
If you let ostrich and cobra come with
me.
Vulture gave him a sideways smile.
A smile that said, I see you, seeing me.
Oh, but that's not all I want, he said.
Remember You're going to tell me all of
Thorn's secrets first.
Passwords, secret stores of treasure
closest allies, how to kill them all.
Ostrich gasped and shoved Kibley's
shoulder.
You're not.
You wouldn't.
Vulture slid a blank scroll out of one of
the racks under the star charts and
unrolled it on the floor in front of
Kibley.
He weighed down the corners with pillows
and a little ink pot.
You may get started now, he said.
Take your time.
Apparently, I'm waiting for
instructions.
He made a little face at that word.
Just a small one, but Kibli noticed it
and he gave him a tiny spark of hope that
dark stalker and vulture wouldn't be the
perfect collaborators they might think
they would be.
We could use that big Nightwing's help
Onyx mused.
I mean, he's got magic.
He can read minds.
See the future.
Useful stuff, if it's on our side.
Indeed, Vulture said, spreading one wing
toward the open dome.
Let's go discuss exactly how useful.
His talents scooped up the unconscious
messenger, and they departed, leaving
Kibley with ostrich, cobra, and winter.
And the 5 guards still watching us, he
remembered.
Don't you even think about it, Kibley?
Ostrich threatened, baring her teeth at
him.
I will stop you.
I will burn that scroll to ashes.
Roar!
A small burst of flames shot out of her
mouth, setting one of the carpets on
fire.
Winter leaned over and exhaled frost
breath all over it to put it out.
I'm going to get some sleep.
Winter said to Kibley.
In the hopes that we'll only be here a
short while longer.
Good idea, Kibley said. nudging one of
the blue cushions toward him.
Winter dragged it into a far corner and
stretched out across it.
Soon, his spikes were rattling softly as
his chest rose and fell.
I'm not going to tell Vulture anything.
Kibli promised ostrich quietly, but if I
don't do this, we need another way out of
here.
Pretend to start riding.
Cobra brushed past him.
I'll look for weapons.
Ostrich's eyes lit up.
I have one, she whispered.
She huddled into Kibley's side, pretending
to read what he was writing, inflict her
tail around, to reveal that she'd been
keeping her tail barb bent down
concealing something in the small fold.
As she slipped it out, Kibli saw a thin
line of blood where it had scratched
her.
I stole this from my guard, she hissed
softly.
She hid it quickly under a pillow and
slid it over to Kibley.
It was a small round disk, with a bladed
edge around the outside, sharp, and
sinister looking.
Kibley had seen these in the market, in
his mother's armory, and among the
outlaws, but he'd rarely practiced with
any himself.
A shakrum.
Cobra whispered.
Leaning over Kibley's shoulder.
Be more specific here, she said loudly
for the guards benefit, pointing to a
spot on the scroll while she palmed the
disc.
Your grandfather will want to know
exactly how many advisors attend the
Queen's morning meeting.
Kibley glanced down at the scroll, where
he had been filling space by writing
There are lots of loyal out claws.
So many loyal outlaws, lots, and lots, and
lots, and lots, of dragons who think
Queen Thorn is awesome because she is.
I can take out one of the guards with
this.
Cobra whispered, but that leaves the
other four.
I can make more chakrams if you distract
the talents, Kibley offered.
He took the pieces of turtle's bowl out
of his bag, concealing them under one of
the pillows, and slotted them together
then nodded at his mother.
As your handwriting gotten worse?
Since you are a dragonette, she spat
sounding scarily like the mother he
remembered.
She snatched the scroll out of his talons
dropping the shockrum in the bowl as she
did, and stormed around, glaring at it
until she was blocking him from view of
the guards.
And your spelling is atrocious.
What self respecting sandwing can't spell
capybarra?
I swear, you've gotten stupider since I
sold you.
Kibley knew she was making a scene and
didn't mean any of it.
But it was still hard to quash the urge
to defend himself.
I wasn't trying to write Capybarra.
My spelling is fine.
Other dragons know what I mean.
He leaned over the shock room in the bowl
and whispered, twice as much, please.
Twice as much, please.
Eight scary looking disks glittered in
the bowl.
Ostrich goggled the multiplying disks in
the bowl, then up at Kibley.
How did you do that?
She breathed, awestruck.
Are you magic?
He shook his head ruefully.
Not me, he said, someone else.
He checked the slate again, while he had
a moment, still blank.
What was Turtle doing?
Had something terrible happened to him?
Or had he forgotten about Kibley, waiting
anxiously for any news?
Ostrich tented one of her wings out a bit
so Kibli could hide the bowl of weapons
underneath.
Try harder.
Cobra spat, flinging the scroll down in
front of Kibli again.
Remember, your grandfather has very high
standards.
He wants every detail, spelled
correctly.
She sat down behind Kibley again.
Every inch the looming, grammar
correcting mother the guards might expect
to see.
Most impressive.
She whispered.
When ostrich tipped her wing to reveal
the shakrums.
Now we just wait for dark.
And then, we escape.
Chapter 9.
Flip thunk.
Flip, thunk, flip, thunk.
Cobra threw three shock rooms at once.
Two with her talons, one with her tail
and they struck three of the talons
perfectly in the throat, cutting off
their vocal cords and killing them at the
same time.
She seized the next 2 discs, and threw
them barely a 2nd later, so the last 2
guards didn't even have time to turn
around in confusion before all 5 were
falling through the dome roof.
Their hoods fluttering like tent canopies
as they fell.
Kibley stared up at the now open sky
misted with the sparkling fog of
galaxies.
None of the moons were full tonight, which
was lucky.
They were lucky too.
That vulture had not returned yet to
examine the scroll, and realized that
Kibley was stalling.
Example.
And then there's the palace, which used
to be Burn's stronghold, which is, whoa
so big, like, really big, like just the
biggest.
Definitely not an easy place to break
into.
I mean, with the walls, and the bigness.
Perhaps the guards that had traded places
with these guards at dusk had reported
that Kibley was working diligently, and
that had been enough for Vulture for
now.
He bent quickly to the fallen talons and
tugged off their hoods, handing one to
cobra, and one to ostrich, and pulling
another over his own head.
Winter was hopeless.
It was too obvious that he was a sparkly
ice wing, and in no way a talent of
power.
They would have to pretend he was a
prisoner if they were stopped.
Stay close to me.
Cobra hissed.
Don't touch anything, or step on anything
if you can avoid it.
Won't the traps and grounds be different
from what you remember?
Kibley asked her.
If you've been imprisoned for so long?
I know my father's tricks, she said
grimly, I'll keep you safe.
Keep me safe.
Protect me, because she loves me.
Kibli shook himself and followed her to
the roof, where they flattened themselves
to slither along the outside, watching
for more guards.
Ostrich was close behind Kibley, with
Winter taking up the end of the line.
The night air smelled of burned coconuts
and grandfather's perfumed oil, and of
the oasis pool not too far away.
Kibli could hear members of the talons of
power, toasting one another in the garden
pavilions.
The hood was heavy around his face
obstructing his peripheral vision.
He wondered how the talons could stand
them.
They slipped down to the ground and
hurried single file along one of the
tiled paths, carefully stepping only
where Cobra stepped, although Kibley
thought the center of the garden should
be safe to walk in, at least.
It was the outskirts, where the walls
were, where they were going. that were
dangerous.
A small fortress loomed out of the dark
ahead of them, bristling with long
spikes.
Hibley stopped, glancing around.
This isn't the way to the outer wall, he
whispered.
I need to stop in here for a minute.
Cobra whispered back, flicking one wing
at the fortress.
In grandfather's treasury?
Kibley hissed.
Are you insane?
He has something that could ruin all our
plans.
Cobra growled.
I must take it from him, or everything we
do is doomed to failure.
But of all the places definitely rigged
to kill you, Kibley said, this will do it
in the most painful way.
She grinned.
Her teeth glittering in the dark.
I know where he hides his key.
You mean where he hid it.
Kibli pointed out, years ago.
This, he won't have changed, she
whispered.
Stay here.
Stop worrying.
No, Kibley said firmly.
Tell me what we're stealing.
If you want us to trust you.
You should be able to tell us that.
Fine.
She said, exasperated.
Ever heard of the obsidian mirror?
I have, said Winter, unexpectedly.
Legend says it gave the night wings the
power to eavesdrop on any conversation
happening anywhere in the world.
Whoa, Kibley said.
Feeling that shimmer of envy he always
felt, anywhere near an animus touched
object.
You'd know everyone's secrets.
You could hear what dragons are saying
about you.
Although, would I want that?
I don't think I would want that.
But imagine the power to anticipate
everyone's next move.
It would be so easy to keep tabs on your
enemies.
Or your long lost grandson.
That's how he knew everything about me in
winter, he said.
That's how he knew we were coming here.
Exactly, said Cobra.
So we have to take it with us, or else
he'll always know where we are and what
we're doing.
Get it now, Lizard.
She snapped at Kibley, then seemed to
catch herself mid-snap.
She closed her snout, took a deep breath
through her nose and said, Sorry.
Sorry.
Kibley was momentarily dazed.
He wouldn't have guessed that his mother
knew how to say that word.
At least, not to one of her offspring.
No, I'm sorry.
He said.
You're right.
We can't leave that in vulture's talons.
She gave him a surprised look, as if she
hadn't thought he knew the word sorry
either.
How did Vulture get the mirror?
Winter asked.
How long has he had it?
He must know so much about Thorn
already.
Kibley realized, with a sense of mounting
horror.
What does he think I can tell him, that
he hasn't already overheard?
Cobra shrugged.
He hasn't had it long, I think, she
said.
He found it, out in the desert, only a
few months ago.
Only a few months ago.
Kibley said thoughtfully.
She glanced at him.
I heard the guards talking about it
walking over my prison.
Her wings folded back, and she pulled the
hood farther over her face.
Now stay here and stop chattering on.
I'll be right back.
Before he could say another word, she
sprinted toward the treasury, darting
from bush to bush in the dark.
Kibley gestured winter and ostrich back
into the shadows of a covert of trees.
It was the best he could do while still
staying on the path, and it felt horribly
exposed.
Talons of power could come by at any
moment.
Vulture could saunter past at any
Grandfather's been spying on the queen
for months.
Kibley thought.
Thorn will have to change all her
passwords, recode the secret message
system, just in case, change everything
she's done, in case he's overheard it, and
can use it against her.
He rubbed his forehead.
His brain starting to explode with all
the implications.
Long minutes ticked by, and each one felt
like a dagger.
Kibli was personally thrusting into his
queen's heart.
The obsidian mirror was a terrible thing
for your enemies to have, but Dark
Stalker's power was even more dangerous.
Thorn needed protection from Dark Stalker
right now, and he was just standing here
in the dark, waiting for his mother.
Maybe we should go, he thought, crossing
to the edge of the shadows, so he could
study the silent treasury.
But she's the one who can navigate us out
of here.
What if we just flew for it, lifted off
and tried to fly away as fast as we
could?
We'd be spotted.
But maybe they wouldn't be able to catch
up to us.
Maybe their arrows would miss.
I can't risk ostrich that way.
What if mother doesn't come back?
What if she's already lying dead on a
pile of gems inside?
Will we still be standing here when
morning comes?
He turned back toward the others and had
a small heart attack.
Where's winter?
He whispered. nudging ostrich with his
wing.
She sat up and looked around with blurry
confusion.
I don't know, she said.
He was here a moment ago.
Kibley twisted in a frantic circle, and
spotted a white shape, flitting through
the pear orchard.
He couldn't shout out to Winter without
alerting the whole compound.
Hiibli growled softly.
Stay here.
He whispered to ostrich.
Stay as hidden as you can.
We'll be right back.
She nodded, folding back into the
shadows.
Kibli hurried after the ice wing prince
and realized that he was aiming for
another small building in the center of
the pear trees.
This one was built low to the ground, with
large windows on all sides, candlelight
flickered in the dim interior.
The outside was decorated with a
turquoise and amber tile mosaic of snakes
and lizards chasing one another
endlessly.
Winter slowed down as he got closer, and
then veered around the building, toward a
shed that appeared to be a storehouse for
food.
Judging from the smells Kibley could now
identify coming from it.
He smelled cinnamon and dates and coconut
smoked ham, and a few live pigs as well.
Some kind of the fancy, smelly cheese
vulture loved, lemons, scavengers, dried
fish, live ducks, scavengers.
R winter, you obsessed ninny.
He caught up as winter was tinkering with
a lock on the shed door. inside.
A few of the animals had heard the
scratching of his claws, and were
starting to stir in an understandably
worried way.
Kibli could hear feathers fluttering, pigs
snorting, and a little stamp of tiny
scavenger feet.
Are you serious?
he said, and winter jumped a mile, which
was almost hilarious enough to make this
side excursion worthwhile.
Winter hissed.
What are you thinking?
Kibley whispered.
I'm thinking, your horrifying grandfather
is going to eat the poor little
scavengers trapped in here.
Winter whispered back, unless I save
them.
Right now, Kibley asked.
In the middle of our own precarious
escape?
Well, I'm not planning on coming back
Winter said.
He tugged on the lock again.
Hey, you're a street thug.
Can you pick this lock for me?
An out claw is not the same thing as a
criminal, Khibli protested.
Oh, fine. move over.
He studied the lock for a moment.
Then inserted his claw into the mechanism
and wiggled it around until he heard a
click.
Now what?
he asked Winter, as he nudged the door
open.
We shove them in a bag and carry them off
into the desert with us.
I'm not sure if you've noticed this, but
scavengers tend to get very noisy when
they think a dragon is about to eat
them.
Or when dragons get anywhere near them
actually.
We'll just let them out, Winter said.
Pacing past him into the dark interior.
They're smart enough to fend for
themselves after that.
Kibley decided not to point out that they
hadn't been smart enough not to get
caught in the 1st place.
Winter crouched beside a large cage in
the corner.
Inside, 3 scavengers were huddled
together by the back wall, squeaking.
Two more poked their heads out of a
little nest of straw and stared at
winter.
Don't be afraid, Winter said softly.
He unlatched the top of the cage, lifted
it off, and set it aside, then took a few
steps back and waited.
One of the scavengers from the straw
immediately popped up and started
clambering up the netting of the cage
wall.
A moment later, 2 of the others followed
squeaking busily at the 2 that hadn't
moved yet.
What's all this noise?
said a voice from outside.
Raiding the storehouse in the middle of
the night?
Is there a feast going on that I wasn't
invited to?
And dragon stuck his head in the door
yawning hugely.
Kibli had him pinned to the floor before
he realized it was vultures lying
mudwing.
He banged his elbow on the tailband and
the chainmailed tangled in his claws as
he subdued the larger dragon.
Winter flashed across the room to help
seizing the headdress to hold the dragon
still.
Don't shout, Kibley said, as the mud wing
opened his mouth.
We just want some answers.
Tell us the truth and we won't hurt you.
Ha!
said the mudwing, with surprising
bitterness in his voice.
Who are you?
Winter demanded.
Nobody, said the mudwing truculently.
Bog, just bog, a regular mudwing me.
Why are you lying about Queen Moorhen
ordering the cactus attacks?
Kibli asked.
Not lying, said Bog.
All true.
Definitely a mudwing plot.
Where are your sibs?
Khibli pressed.
Are they traitors too?
My what?
Bog said.
Kibley and Winter exchange to glance.
Sibs had come up during a class on
Mudwings at Jade Mountain.
Kimberly had heard about the idea before
but that lesson was the 1st time he'd
learned in detail about how Mudwings
lived their lives alongside their
siblings, creating families out of
brothers and sisters rather than ever
getting married or even knowing their
parents.
Um, Bog corrected himself.
Not here, not traitors, just me.
I was captured by the talons of power, and
forced to reveal everything.
I bet, said Winter.
Looks like they used the classic torture
method of burying you in diamonds.
Kibley tried to shake off something that
was snared around one of his claws and
heard a clank from under the chain mail.
He shoved a few of the links aside, while
Bog squirmed, and spotted a pouch tied
firmly under one of Bogg's wings.
Don't touch that.
Bog roared, suddenly slashing at Kibley's
talons, Kibley jerked back out of reach.
Something had ignited a spark of
recognition at last.
The anger in this dragon's eyes, the
pouch he protected with such violence.
I know who this is.
He said.
You do?
said Winter.
When have you ever met a mud wing outside
of school?
He wasn't a mudwing last time we saw him
Kibley said.
He was a night wing, calling himself
shapeshifter.
Chapter 10.
Shapeshifter, said Winter with a hiss, the
one who was working with Scarlet.
You mean the one you robbed?
Bog snarled.
Perhaps you remember beating me bloody in
order to steal my scroll.
Perhaps, you remember putting our friend
Kinkaju in a coma?
Kibley snapped at him.
Sinking his claws into the brown scales.
What are you doing here with my
grandfather?
I didn't like the mud kingdom.
Bog grumbled, to brown.
Thought I'd try my luck in the scorpion
den, looking for treasure.
He managed to flop one of his talons to a
place where he could see it, and see the
giant bejeweled rings on it.
Found it, he said with a smirk.
But what kind of idiot would meddle in
royal politics again after last time?
Kibley demanded.
You could have gone anywhere and started
over?
I was trying to.
Bob snorted.
Vulture approached me in the market.
It offered me a lot of treasure to tell
people this mudwing story.
What was I going to do?
Say no to treasure?
That would have been a good start, said
Kibley.
I'm confused about something, Winter said
to Kibley.
How is he a mudwing now?
Didn't we take away the scroll he was
using to shapeshift?
Taking away the scroll?
Meant he couldn't write any new spells
Kibley said.
But I'm guessing he had a little trove of
spells already written.
Scraps of paper, torn from the scroll
that were enchanted to turn him into
different dragons.
Is that what's in here?
He poked the pouch, and Bog snapped at
his talons again.
Haven't you ruined my life enough, Bog
snarled.
Aren't there any actual bad guys you
could go harassed?
I would love to have nothing to do with
you, said Kibley.
But I can't.
As long as you're in the business of
starting a mud wing sand wing war.
Winter reached for the pouch, but as he
leaned over Bogg's head, the mudwing
abruptly rammed his headdress into
Winter's chin.
At the same moment, he lashed his tail up
and around, and slammed the heavy gold
band into Kibley's side, knocking Kibley
off his back.
Kibley scrabbled to keep his hold on the
chain mail, but Bog ripped it off in a
sudden, smooth motion, leaving Kibley
with a talon full of limp silver links
and sapphires.
Winter lunged for the mud wing again, but
Bog seized something off the floor and
held it out in front of him.
Stop right there, he snarled, or I will
bite this scavenger's head off.
Winter froze.
His gaze fixed on the little creature in
bogs, talons.
It had evidently escaped the cage and
made a run for the door.
The bog had caught it before it reached
the threshold.
It wriggled pitifully in his grip.
The thatch of black fur on its head just
visible over the mud wings heavy rings.
We can't let him go.
Kibley said to Winter.
He keeps showing up.
He's too dangerous.
Put down the scavenger, Winter said to
Bog.
You get out of here and leave me alone
Bob growled.
He whirled and bolted out the door.
Kibley dashed after him, but the mud wing
was halfway across the orchard already
running as fast as he could toward the
sounds of a party at one of the far
pavilions.
Kibley turned back in frustration.
We can't chase him, he said to Winter, or
we'll end up right back in Vulture's
claws.
We have to get out of here, now.
Winter was crouched beside a small shape
in the grass.
The scavenger that Bog had dropped as he
fled.
It scrambled to its feet and backed away
from winter, limping.
One of the other scavengers darted out of
the shed and waved a stick at winter with
some ferocious squeaking noises.
I think you've done enough champion of
the scavengers work for tonight, Kibley
said. poking winter in the side.
Come on.
They abandoned the scavengers and ran
back through the trees to the spot where
Kibley had left ostrich.
Cobra pushed through the bushes, grinning
and streaked with dirt as they came
galloping up.
A large black sack was thrown over her
shoulder.
That's what I call living, she crowed.
We were seen, Kibley panted.
We have to go.
Oh, wonderful.
Cobra snapped.
The triumphant look vanishing from her
face.
She darted off along another path.
Kibli and the others raced after her
keeping their footfalls as silent as
possible.
He kept expecting to hear shouts of alarm
and pounding talons as Bog raised the
entire talons of power militia to find
them.
But nothing broke the stillness of the
night.
Stop.
Ostrich whispered. catching Kibley's
wing.
Two dragons up ahead.
She was right.
Two hulking figures blocked the path in
one of the courtyards, leaning over a
fountain and splashing water onto their
faces.
Cobra skidded to a stop, and plunged into
the shrubbery beside the walkway.
Shh, Kibley said.
He tugged Winter under an imposing statue
of vulture, and spread his wings to hide
him.
Ostrich played along, pretending to
measure him from wing tip to wing tip.
Hmm, she said, as the 2 figures came
toward them.
Yes, I think we can manage an excellent
tattoo of, uh, your face along here.
She sketched out a shape with her claw on
one of his wings, and perhaps a pattern
to match on the other side?
Diamonds are always popular, or snakes.
Schools. shouted one of the approaching
dragons.
The only good tattoo is a skull.
He staggered sideways and the other
dragon shoved him away from her with a
hiss.
Sirocco and Rattlesnake, Kibley muttered
staring fixedly down at his wings.
He prayed that the hood would be enough
of a disguise to hide him.
His mother was very still, and he
wondered if it was strange for her to see
her other 2 children, who had, presumably
been working for Vulture the whole time
she'd been imprisoned.
Did she feel as if they had betrayed
her?
Of course, there are always gem embedding
options.
Ostrich said.
I hear they're painful, but such a
statement.
I want a ruby in the middle of my
forehead.
Sirocco bellowed, lurching toward
ostrich.
Can you do that?
He tripped over his own tail and slammed
down onto his snout, yelping in pain.
You are such an embarrassment.
Riddlesnake fumed.
That's why grandfather thinks we're both
stupid, because all he can see is you and
your big empty head.
Why aren't you on patrol?
She suddenly barked at Kibli and
Ostrich?
Don't you know the compound is on
lockdown tonight?
Yes.
Ostrich stammered.
Just on a break.
Rattlesnake swelled up, so she looked
twice her size.
On a break, sir, she said menacingly.
One day, I will inherit all this.
Both my brothers will be dead, and
everyone will come crawling before me.
The way they crawl before grandfather.
She tossed her head, and suddenly caught
sight of cobra in the shadows.
A slight frown creased her forehead.
Mother.
Aren't you?
Cobra moved so fast that Kibley wouldn't
have been able to stop her, except that
he knew what she would probably do, and
he'd been waiting for it.
She had the disc out and ready to fly.
But he managed to knock her arm aside
before she could throw it.
You can't kill them, he cried.
Mother, they're your children.
You're my only dragonette.
She said coldly, reaching for another
chakrum.
Kibley?
Rattlesnake gasped.
She leaped backward and opened her mouth
to yell for help.
Suddenly, winter was there, knocking her
over, seizing her snout, and smacking her
head into the tile.
Almost at the same moment.
Ostrich leapt at Surocco, who was
blinking in confusion.
She landed on his back and threw her
wings over his face.
No, Kibley said to Cobra, they're awful.
But they're still my brother and sister.
He ran over to ostrich, untying his
hood.
The black fabric worked just as well to
muffle a dragon, as it did to conceal
one.
Sirocco flailed around frantically at
first, but soon he was bound and gagged
behind the statue, tied up with a canopy
stolen from a nearby pavilion.
They dumped Rattlesnake next to him
unconscious and tied up as well.
I thought your years as an outlaw would
have made you less soft.
Cobra said to Kibley disapprovingly
staring down at her other 2 offspring.
There's nothing weak about being
compassionate, Khibli retorted.
Can we fly now?
Before we run into any more of your
loving family?
Winter asked.
Cobra beckoned and darted away, past the
fountain, around another statue of
vulture and to the edge of a stand of
tall, bristling cacti.
Beyond it, Kibli could see the outer wall
of the compound, with a wide open sky of
stars beyond that.
All right, said Cobra, stand back.
This is going to be a little dramatic.
She took a deep breath, then exhaled a
whooshing ball of flame that engulfed the
cacti.
Instantly, several explosions went off
inside the fire, as vultures traps all
burst into action at once.
What the?
cried Winter.
I thought the plan was stealth.
Stealth, and then flying really fast
Cobra Crowed.
See you at the palace.
She launched herself over the flames
beating her wings furiously.
Kibley couldn't hear anything beyond the
crackle and roar of the fire, but he was
sure talons must be converging on them
from all directions.
He grabbed ostrich and hauled her into
the sky with him.
Don't look back, he shouted to her as
they swept over the wall. keep flying.
Winter's moon pale shape soared up
alongside him, and together, the 3 of
them flew after Cobra, north, to the
palace of Queen Thorn.
Chapter 11.
Kibli couldn't remember the last time
he'd slept, but it didn't matter.
The wind lifted him high over the dunes
and his wings felt charged with lightning
as he swept closer and closer to the sand
wing palace and his queen.
Please, let Thorn be safe.
He prayed.
Please let Dark Stalker be too busy with
other things, to have turned his thoughts
to the sand wings yet.
For the 1st hour, there had been dragons
behind them, chasing them, but they
seemed to have given up and gone back to
the Scorpion Den.
Kibli wondered how his grandfather was
reacting right now, and what onyx might
do next, and what kind of terrible
retribution was coming.
He flexed his front talons, and studied
the weather bracelets in the moonlight.
There had to be a way to use these to
stop Vulture.
If he could only figure out how to use
them.
We're almost there.
Ostrich called, doing a flip in the sky
beside him.
Khibli looked up and saw the palace
ahead.
It still gave him a startling surge of
fear and pride each time he saw it.
Like his 1st thought was always
instinctively, oh no, we're too close.
Burn's going to catch us and kill us
all.
And then he had to shift his brain over
to, no, wait.
We defeated her.
She's gone, and that's our palace now
with the best queen of all time ruling
the kingdom.
The outer walls used to be lined with
decapitated heads in Burns day, but those
were all gone now, and the stone had been
scraped and scrubbed and painted to
remove all trays of the blood that used
to drip there.
Thorn was considering knocking down the
gruesome walls altogether, the way she'd
knocked down the weirdling tower, since
they only served to remind everyone of
Bern.
But she had been too busy with other
kingdom business to get that done in the
few months she'd been queen.
Guards lined the top of the wall.
The bristling shadows of their spears
looking like ice wing tail spikes
lamplight glowed in several of the
windows.
Cobra slowed and circled back to fly next
to him.
Al Claws first, she said, with a toothy
grin.
She kept shifting the sack from one
shoulder to the other as though it was
heavy.
Or as though she was nervous.
You'll be safer here than with
grandfather, Kibley told her.
I'll be safe wherever you are, she said.
Her eyes gleamed.
Perhaps we can take out Vulture, and then
you and I can rule the Scorpion Den.
His whole compound and all that treasure
would be ours.
If I were given the scorpion den to rule
the 1st thing I would do is turn that
compound into a home for orphans and
wounded soldiers, Hibli said.
Cobra squinted at him, as if she couldn't
tell whether he was joking or not.
Right, she said, of course, me too.
Two of the guards on the walls flew out
to meet them.
Even by the dim light of the slender
moons, Hibli recognized them both from
their outlaw days.
Tawny, parch, he cried.
I have to see the queen immediately.
The 2 guards swooped around them, waving
to ostrich, and tucking their spears back
into their holsters.
Of course you do, Kibley, Part said
laughing.
Let me guess, it's an emergency.
It is.
Kibley insisted, ruffled.
It's a danger you'd never even begin to
imagine.
I need to see her right now.
She's in a meeting, Tawny reminded Parch
a really important meeting without cool
hybrid dragon from possibility, remember?
Yeah, but it's Ghibli, Part said
agreeably.
She won't mind.
Kibley remembered that parts was one of
the outlaws who'd had the most trouble
adapting to the new rules and strictures
of the palace.
He still behaved like a renegade of the
scorpion den when it came to things like
a dress code, or showing up for guard
duty on time, but not out of malice.
Parts just assumed nobody would ever get
mad at him, considering how many times
he'd nearly died to save the other out
claws.
And that was pretty much true.
Even if it was maddening, to see him joke
with Thorn like she was a regular dragon
and not a queen at all.
But tonight, Parche's disregard for the
rules would work in Kibley's favor.
Yes, Kibley said, seizing one of Parch's
arms.
She'll want to hear about this right
away.
Parch shrugged at Tawny.
Sounds important.
Tawny rolled her eyes, but waved them
toward the palace.
All right, go ahead.
She said.
Wait for me by the Oasis Monument in the
courtyard.
Hibley said to the others.
I want to see Queen Thorn too, cried
Ostrich.
Seriously, said Winter.
Suddenly we're not invited inside.
Yeah, Cobra protested.
Why can't we come with you?
Because I need to explain you before
Queen Thorn sees you?
Kibley said patiently.
He watched them flap down toward the
enormous white stone courtyard, muttering
to themselves, and then he dove toward
one of the gardens.
If Queen Thorn was meeting with an
important dragon, he knew exactly where
she'd have that meeting.
Her favorite room in the palace.
It wasn't even a room, exactly.
It was a tent, made of flapping white
fabric that Thorn had installed next to
the largest palace pool, to remind her of
her old outlaw headquarters.
Khibley was right.
He could hear the murmur of Thorne's
voice as he approached the tent, although
the wind and the trickle of water
obscured her words, pale, yellow, and
pink lilies drifted across the pool
bumping into the petals of fat crimson
flowers from the tree overhead.
Queen Thorn, he called from outside.
It's Kibli.
May I enter?
There was a pause, and then one of the
walls was flung aside as Thorn peered out
at him.
Kibley, she cried, her face lighting up.
Maybe you can.
No, wait.
Hang on.
She set up straight and looked stern.
Why aren't you in school, you ruffian?
She's all right.
Kibley nearly collapsed with relief.
He was still a step ahead of Dark
Stalker's plans, at least for the kingdom
of sand.
It wasn't too late.
He could protect her right now, before
the giant night wing started wiping out
all the queens in Pyria, or whatever he
was going to do.
I need you to put this on.
He said.
Digging one of the earrings out of his
bag.
Please, ride away.
It's urgent, and then I can explain.
Come on in, Thorn said, beckoning.
Inside, the tent was lit by the warm glow
of oil lamps, and smelled like cinnamon
and cardamom tea.
There were 2 other dragons with the queen
and one of them, Kibli realized with
surprise, was Smolder, the brother of
Bern, Blister, and Blaze.
Onyx's father.
He realized with a shiver, Does he have
any idea she exists?
The other dragon in the tent was a
striking cobalt blue color, shining like
sapphires in the lamplight, with a white
underbelly and dark black eyes.
The spikes around his neck marked him as
an ice wing, but he also had stripes
under his wings that glowed
phosphorescently in the semi darkness
like a sea wing.
Tawny said there was a hybrid here, Ghibli
remembered.
A sea wing ice wing hybrid, apparently.
He wondered how this dragon's parents had
met and fallen in love, when their
kingdoms were so far apart, and probably
at war at the time, there must be a story
there.
Kibley, this is Typhoon.
Queen Thorn indicated the stranger, who
nodded politely in Kibley's direction.
He's come with troubling news from
possibility.
That great.
Kibley said in a rush.
I mean, not great.
I'm sure whatever it is is terrible, but
before we get to that, maybe just quick
fling this earring on, and then
everything else can go back to being top
priority, you bet.
Smolder tried to hide his chuckling in
his cup of tea, but not very
successfully.
This sounds rather suspicious, Thorn said
holding out her talent.
Kibli put the earring in her palm with
trembling claws, and she lifted it up to
study the light bending through the warm
amber.
I'm guessing there's a spell on this.
She said astutely.
The question is, is it a good spell or a
bad spell?
And the answer depends on whether you're
under a spell?
Or possibly whether you have wrong
information?
It's a good spell.
Kibley said desperately.
I promise.
It'll protect you from something you
really need protecting from, like right
now.
Trust me.
I do, said Thorn with calm certainty.
Hang on, said Smolder, watching her lift
it to her ear.
Do we all?
Is this the smartest plan?
Should we, um, vote or something?
I've been spoiling him by letting him
express his opinions now and then?
Thorn said to Kibley.
She looked down her nose at Smolder.
I am the queen, you camel chewing snore a
minute son of a toad.
Oh, right, said Smolder, very dignified.
Hard to argue with that kind of elegant
turn of phrase.
Thorn laughed. pulled out the small ruby
that was already in one ear, and stabbed
the enchanted earring through.
Hmm.
I feel the same, she said to smolder.
Have I been turned into a frog and just
can't tell?
An extremely beautiful frog, Smolder
promised.
One we're all still proud to call our
queen.
You are no help, Thorn said, waving her
claws, Adam.
But I suppose I'll let you live for
today.
Kibley sank gratefully onto one of the
large red pillows.
His queen was safe.
His most important mission was complete
and now he could feel his exhaustion
setting in.
You really are worried about something.
Smolder said, studying him closely.
Something darted under his feet, and
Kibley nearly jumped, thinking it was a
wild animal, but it was only Smolders pet
scavenger, flower.
She clambered casually up smolder's leg
until she could sit on his shoulder and
watch all the dragons.
I have to make sure winter meets her
Ghibli thought.
He could learn a lot from smolder about
taking care of scavengers.
I'll tell you everything later, he said
to Thorn, pointedly looking only at her.
Smolder was funny and interesting, but he
wasn't an outlaw, and he looked horribly
like blister, and he had done Burns
bidding all the way through the war.
Even including an attempt to imprison
Thorn and Sonny, so she could have them.
Kibli was not prepared to trust him just
yet.
I'm sorry I interrupted you, he said to
Typhoon.
Quite all right, said Typhoon.
I would never want to get in the way of
urgent accessorizing.
Smolder snorted a laugh, which was
helpful, because Kibley hadn't been
entirely sure if that was a joke.
Typhoon had an excellent straight face.
Tell Kibley what you told us.
Thorn said, to the unusual looking
dragon.
Typhoon leaned forward, and Kibli noticed
a snail shell earring in his left ear.
All the ice wings and possibility are
sick.
He said without preamble.
Three days ago.
They were healthy and normal.
There aren't very many ice wings living
in the town yet, so we tend to stay
close.
And then, all of a sudden, every single
one of them started coughing blood.
A cold feeling ran down Kibley's spine.
Like an ice wing claw trailing along the
ridge of his back.
Could be a normal plague.
Cities get them all the time.
You say you all stay close.
Smolder observed.
So isn't it likely that one dragon got
sick and infected everyone else?
It happened too fast for that, Typhoon
said, shaking his head.
I've been studying medicine and disease
for the last 2 years.
I know how fevers like this usually
spread, and no one is sick except the ice
wings.
This isn't normal.
Why did you come to me?
Instead of Queen Glacier or Queen Coral
Thorn asked.
Because I think you're the smartest and
most capable queen in Pyria right now.
Typhoon answered, looking her in the
eye.
And to be honest, you were also the
closest.
My father is one of the most ill.
If there's any chance of saving him, we
need someone who can act fast.
I have doctors I can send, Thorn
started.
When exactly did the sickness hit?
Kibley interrupted.
Thorn gave him a startled look, but she
was still more outclaw than queen, willing
to give anyone a voice, smolder on the
other talon, made a face as though he
couldn't understand why Kibley was
allowed to keep his head.
The night before last, Typhoon answered
around midnight.
That was Dark Stalker's 1st night of
freedom.
Kibli remembered that Dark Stalker had
been away from Jade Mountain Academy for
most of that night.
What had he been doing?
Did he cast a spell to hurt the ice
wings?
Is he still looking for revenge after
1000s of years?
If so, how bad a spell is it?
Is he trying to wipe out the entire tribe
or just weaken them?
I know that look, said Thorn, watching
him sharply.
You've figured something out.
My faint typhoon is right, said Kibley.
That's always nice to hear, said the blue
dragon with a wry smile.
This isn't a normal disease, Kibley went
on.
Less nice, Typhoon murmured ruefully.
It's not a disease at all, Kibley said.
It's a spell, and I think I know who cast
it.
An animus dragon who hates the ice
wings.
A whole tribe under attack by such
powerful magic, from a distance, and
without even knowing that their enemy had
arisen, they wouldn't even know this was
an attack.
It would just seem like an illness.
Dark stalker would be able to deny that
it had anything to do with him, and even
unbewitched dragons might believe him.
All ice wings?
Thorn said sharply.
You mean this could be happening in the
ice kingdom too, not just in
possibility.
Might assume it is, said Kibley, flicking
his tail.
But the world is different now than it
was in Dark Stalker's time.
In his time, the ice wings would have all
been in the ice kingdom, isolated, where
a plague could wipe them out without
anyone knowing until it was over, in this
world, a world with possibility in it, and
the talons of peace, and hybrid dragons
and soldiers from different tribes who
fought alongside one another in the Great
War.
In this world.
We can see the dying dragons.
We can see them, and we can save them.
We can stop him.
He looked to the animus touched bracelets
on his wrists again, itching to use them
against Dark Stalker.
He wanted to throw a lightning bolt into
the night wing's grinning face.
We have to send someone to check on the
ice kingdom, Thorn said, leaping to her
feet.
You can't.
Smolder pointed out reasonably.
Any of our dragons would freeze to death
or be shot down by the great ice cliff.
That's right.
Thorn started to pace.
Queen Glacier warned me about the ice
cliff.
She whirled toward typhoon.
Can you cross the cliff safely?
Yes, he said.
Apparently, half ice wing is ice wing
enough.
But not enough to be hit by the plague?
Kibli wondered.
And his spinning brain answered itself
because dark stalker is half ice wing
too.
He must have left out hybrids, thinking
there weren't enough of them to save the
others, and so his descendants, like
Sonny, would be safe.
What about winter?
Why was he spared?
He thought of his ice wing friend
standing outside in the palace courtyard
with an ostrich and cobra.
Wait, he said, standing up quickly.
I know a faster way we can find out
what's happening in the ice kingdom.
But first, Queen Thorn.
I need you to arrest my mother.
Chapter 12.
What is the meaning of this?
Cobra Ward.
As 4 sandwing soldiers seized her wings
and tail.
They threw chains around her legs, and
efficiently snapped a metal cage around
the end of her tail, so she couldn't
sting anyone with her venom.
You are under arrest, Thorn announced.
Holding her flaming torch a little higher
to examine Cobra's face, for she gave
Kibley a quizzical look, for lying to me
Kibley said, and conspiring against the
queen.
Lying to you, Cobra shouted.
What are you talking about?
She snapped her teeth at one of the
soldiers, and nearly managed to bite off
his ear.
You have not been imprisoned for the last
2 years.
Kibley said, fighting to keep the tremor
out of his voice.
I doubt you were even in that oubliette
for a day before I arrived.
Vulture knew I was coming, and put you
down there so I'd be willing to risk
everything to save you.
No, Kobra growled, struggling.
Queen Thorn, said Kibley, who's in charge
of all your spies?
A dragon named Capyberra, Thorn
answered.
That's what I thought, said Kibley.
He turned to his mother.
You said the name Capybarra, when you
were pretending to read my scroll of
information for Vulture.
But I hadn't written that name anywhere
in it.
You also mentioned Thorn's morning
meetings with her most trusted advisors.
You'd only know about those details if
you'd been out of prison this whole time
spying on Thorn with the obsidian mirror
right alongside grandfather.
That's, that's ridiculous, Cobra
sputtered, a coincidence.
And when I went to our old house, Ghibli
went on.
I smelled roasted coriander seeds.
The snack you always eat when you're
preparing for an assassination.
You'd been there only a day or so earlier
not gone for 2 years.
That's also why we were able to escape so
easily.
Because this is what Vulture really
wanted, for me to bring you, his top
assassin, into Thorn's palace.
Dung beetles, cobra spat.
This is all wild speculation.
You've always been a half witted idiot
with crazy ideas.
Open that sack.
Kibley said to the soldiers, clicking his
tail at the bag Cobra had brought with
her, carefully.
One of them gingerly undid the top and
peered inside.
She took out an oval of flat black glass
and set it on the sand.
That was followed by the remaining
shakrums, a series of gradually pointier
and scarier knives, a black hood, and a
small glass vial with an emerald green
liquid inside.
Last of all, the guard reached back into
the bag and lifted out a fat, spiky
dragon flame cactus.
That's what blew up the history cave.
Kibley thought, feeling a creeping sense
of horror at the sight of the prickly
weapon.
That's what killed carnelian and big
tail.
He knew, if it caught fire, it would
explode and spray deadly, sharp little
seed pods in all directions.
Smolder took a step closer and squinted
at it.
Your majesty, he said.
I know, said Thorn.
We've seen evidence of these at all the
attack sites.
Were you sent to blow up the palace?
Kibley asked his mother.
He touched the vial lightly with the tip
of his wing.
Or was your mission to poison the queen.
Cobra's eyes narrowed.
There was a bead of silence, and then she
spat, all right, Mr. Clever Claus, you
think you've got it all figured out.
But did it ever occur to you that I might
be betraying him, that he wouldn't have
wanted me to take the obsidian mirror
that I might really want to destroy him
and take over the scorpion den with you
at my side?
With you at my side.
My only true dragonette.
Kibli forced bands of steel around his
heart.
Yes, I did think of that, he said to her
but somehow, the idea that you're even
untrustworthy to your own father, didn't
convince me to trust you more.
I wanted to, mother.
I've always wanted to Vulture knew
exactly how to mess with me.
But he underestimated how much I've
learned from Queen Thorn, and how much
stronger my friends have made me.
He glanced at Winter, who was watching
with an expression that said, he'd had
his doubts about Cobra too.
Take her to the dungeon, Thorn said to
the guards.
Lock her in the cell, next to the mad
prisoner.
They can keep each other company for a
while.
Cobra shrieked with rage. as they dragged
her away.
And Kibli tried not to imagine that
alternate universe, where he played along
with her games, and got to be her
favorite for just a moment longer.
Did you say the Obsidian Mirror?
Thorn said to him.
The one Sonny left in the desert and
couldn't find again after the war?
Hibley flicked his tail at the eerie oval
that looked as if it was made of black
glass.
Vultures had it for the last several
months.
Well, that's horrifying, said Thorn.
I know, but now you can use it to check
on Glacier, Hibli suggested.
Winter's head snapped up.
Glacier, he said, why?
What?
Why do you need to spy on Queen
Galacier?
We're not spying, Khibley said.
He watched the mirror carefully as it was
placed in Thorn's claws.
We think she's in trouble.
What kind of trouble?
Winter hurried over and stared at the
mirror.
One of the moons was reflected in it, thin
and sharp, like a silver claw, with the
torches firelight crackling around the
edges.
Let's see if I can remember how Sonny
described this, said the Queen.
Closing our eyes and thinking for a
moment.
Um, She held the mirror close to her
mouth and whispered, Queen Glacier of the
Ice Wings, then squinted at it.
After a moment of nothing happening, she
nodded, as if remembering something, and
breathed a plume of smoke across the dark
surface.
The smoke curled into 4 separate tendrils
all in shades of pale blue and white.
One, the largest, was in the center, with
the other 3 clustered around it.
She's getting worse, whispered one of the
tendrils, making Kibley jump.
She hasn't woken up since midday
whispered another.
What do we do?
The 3rd one twisted anxiously in little
smoke knots.
Narwhal is too sick to take charge and
she broke off into a coughing spell that
tore at Kibley's heart.
He wished he could reach right into the
mirror and hold her lungs together for
her.
He looked up, and saw a horror struck
expression on Winter's face.
Did he recognize one of the voices?
Or, she'd mentioned someone called
Narwhal, that had to be a member of the
royal family, perhaps even Winter's
father, Kibley guessed.
Everyone's too sick to take charge, said
the 1st in a small, sad voice.
Should we send for help?
said the 2nd. starting to cough as well.
Is anyone well enough to make it to the
kingdom of sand?
Poor glacier, Thorn said softly.
You are right, Kibley.
It's hit all the ice wings in Pyria.
What is wrong with them?
Winter cried.
Why are they all sick?
How did you know?
He whirled toward Kibley, then Queen
Thorn.
His tail spikes rattled frantically.
Is that supposed to be the queen?
He poked his claw at the still, solemn
tendril of smoke in the center.
Queen Glacier is sick?
All the ice wings are, Kibley said.
I'm sorry, Winter, but I'm going to save
them, Winter said fiercely.
I know what to do.
He spread his wings and crouched to take
flight.
Kibley barreled into him, knocking the
ice wing prince to the ground.
Hey, Winter shouted.
Help me.
Kibley yelled at the closest outlaws, pin
him down.
Don't you dare.
Winter roared at them, with such
commanding authority that for a moment
they all hesitated.
Kibli, get off.
I have to tell Dark Stalker, you can save
them.
That's exactly what I can't let you do
Kibley thought.
Hold him down, he shouted at the outlaws
again.
Three sand wings agreeably piled on
sitting on winter's wings and tails so he
couldn't go anywhere.
Winter roared again with frustration.
Kibli, I'm going to kill you for this, he
bellowed.
I have to help my queen.
Dark Stalker's magic can save all of
them.
You idiot!
Kibley shouted in his ear, as Winter
thrashed and kicked.
Dark Stalker did this.
He sent the plague to the ice wings.
The war with your tribe isn't 1000s of
years ago to him.
In his mind, it just happened.
This is his revenge.
One of winter's serrated claws caught
Kibley's side, leaving a long, bloody
scratch.
Kibley jumped back with a yelp of pain
but winter didn't seem to notice what
he'd done.
You're wrong, he growled.
Dark Stalker is a good, noble dragon.
He's going to lead us all into a bright
and wonderful future, and he can save my
tribe.
So get off me and let me go find him.
I don't think you're going to convince
him, Thorn said to Kibley.
I'm not, Kibley said.
I'm going to fix him.
He drew another earring out of his bag
and brandished it like a weapon.
Three moons, said Typhoon.
You sandwings are a little intense about
your jewelry.
No, Winter shouted, as Kibley
approached.
I said no, no spells.
You're already under a spell.
Kibley argued.
This will put your brain back the way
it's supposed to be winter, I promise.
You stay away from my brain, Winter
hissed.
I swear, if you put that on me, I will
hurt you.
I have to, Kibley said.
When you're yourself again, you'll see
that Dark Stalker is behind this, and
then I can help you save your tribe.
You, Winter snorted.
You don't have magic.
You're completely ordinary.
How could you save anyone?
That cut deeper than winter probably
realized.
Stung, Kibley yelled, I would have magic
and we wouldn't have any of these
problems if you hadn't been a complete
slug about dark stalker scroll.
He seized Winter's head and jabbed the
earring at his ear.
Winter twisted out of his grasp, and
fired a blast of frost breath that
slammed right into Kibley's arm.
For a moment, the freezing pain shocked
Kibley into paralysis.
It hurt so much, so instantly, like his
arm had been severed, and then almost
more frightening, his arm went numb, and
he couldn't feel anything anymore.
A 2nd later, Thorn was there, seizing
Winter's snout, holding it shut, and
pinning down his head.
She grabbed the earring from Kibley and
thrust it briskly through one of the
holes in Winter's right ear.
There was a long, tense pause.
Suddenly, winter went limp.
His whole body collapsed to the ground
under the sand wing soldiers, all the
fight drained out of him.
Get the doctors.
Queen Thorn was shouting, somewhere far
away from Kibley.
No, wait.
She was still right in front of him.
But the whole world was fading back
further and further, with hazy blackness
marching in from all sides.
I'm sorry, Kibley, she said, taking his
talons gently to examine the frostbitten
scales on his arm.
I had no idea he'd do that.
I thought he was your friend.
He is, Kibley managed.
Through the haze, he saw Winter lift his
head and look at Kibley wonderingly.
He's a good, A heroish guy.
Friend.
He felt the world pull away as the pain
swept back in.
It was just a spell, he whispered.
We'll fix it, Kibli.
You hear me?
Thorn said.
They're bringing water and hot coals
now.
Don't you pass out, you sand snorter.
Kibli, your queen is giving you an
order.
Earrings, Kibley said, or tried to say, or
said too loud.
He wasn't sure, for all the ice wings.
We have to.
And then everything faded to black.
Chapter 13.
Kibli was on fire.
He was buried in sand in the middle of
the desert, the sun beating down on him
as dry branches snapped into flames all
around him.
His scales were melting, but he couldn't
move a muscle or twitch a talon.
Wake up, wake up.
Dragons are dying.
You have to save them.
He clawed his way out of the dream with
excruciating slowness, and finally opened
his eyes to find winter, sitting beside
him, staring glumly at his talons.
Kibli was pleased to see his earring
glowing in Winter's ear, even if Winter
was right, and it did clash horribly with
the ice wings scales.
They were in a sun baked brick room, with
light pouring in the windows and
skylights.
Kibley glanced down and saw that his arm
was submerged in a cauldron of heated
water.
It still looked damaged here and there
but most of the scales had returned to
their normal color, and he could feel all
his talons again.
All right.
I'm ready.
He said to Winter.
Winter snapped his head up and stared at
him.
You're ready for what?
Your heartfelt apology, said Kibley.
The tragic phase is a good start, but I'm
sure the speech is even better.
Winter scowled at him.
My apology.
You're the one who attacked me.
I was defend.
He stopped and took a deep breath.
Why must you make everything impossible?
He growled.
Needs work, said Kibley, but maybe it
gets sappier as it goes along.
Sorry, I'll shut up and listen
attentively now.
He put on his most sincere, thoughtful
face.
I am sorry, Winter said grumpily.
I can't believe I did that to you.
He glanced at Kibley's arm, winced, and
looked away quickly.
Well, you know, evil spell, Kibley said
waving one of his wings as if he was
clearing away smoke.
The important thing is that you can think
clearly now.
Do you feel better?
No, winter huffed.
Because now I feel like an idiot.
A friend freezing, enchanted moony-eyed
idiot.
Friend.
Khibli cried with delight.
You called me your friend.
You do adore me.
Life goals accomplished.
I'm just saving syllables.
Winter snapped.
Friend is faster to say than annoying
clawmate.
He hesitated.
I wish I could blame the spell.
He said, in a lower voice, but I was so
angry, and so afraid of any magic that
would change me the way hailstorm was
changed.
Don't worry about it.
It's sand in the wind, Kibley said.
I'm going to kill Dark Stalker, Winter
said.
I promise you that.
It'll be bloody and long winded.
He'll be sorry he started another war
with the ice wings.
He'll be sorry he messed with my mind.
I knew he was evil.
I mean, when my mind was my own, I knew
it.
I don't understand what moon sees in
him.
There was an uncomfortable beat while
they both thought about Moon.
I wish I knew she was safe, or what she's
doing.
I wish she could come tell me what to
do.
Khibli looked around for his pack
wondering if Turtle had finally sent an
update.
Maybe she's under a spell too.
Winter suggested.
Maybe, Kibley said, although she trusted
him even before he had his powers back
remember, just from talking to him in her
mind.
Winter growled softly.
First things first, said Kibley.
Did Queen Thorn send protection earrings
to the ice wings?
You said that before you passed out
Winter said, but there were only 2 left
in your bag.
Typhoon agreed to take them and fly as
fast as he could to Queen Glacier's
Palace.
What?
Khibli sat up fast, spilling hot water
over the sides of the cauldron his arm
was in.
That's not enough.
I can give him more.
He already left, Winter said, pushing
Kibley's arm back under the water.
The minute we found the other earrings in
your bag.
I wanted to give him mine as well.
But Queen Thorn said she wasn't sure what
I would do if I went back under Dark
Stalker's spell.
He fiddled guiltily with the tassels of
their rug Kibley was lying on.
I agree with her.
What time is it now?
Hibby asked.
Late afternoon, said winter.
The queen's healers gave you something to
make you sleep longer.
No, no, no, sleeping, err, Kibley said
pulling his arm out of the cauldron and
shaking water droplets off it.
He rolled off the rug and hurried to the
nearest shelf, where someone had left his
pack.
While he slotted the parts of the bowl
together.
He checked the slate, but there were no
new messages from Turtle.
It's been an awfully long time.
Could I have missed one while I slept?
I thought he said messages wouldn't
disappear unless I erased them.
But then, what has he been doing for 2
days?
Has Dark Stalker caught him?
Did tsunami ever find them?
Is Moon all right?
He dropped his own earring into the bowl
and whispered, Twice as much, please
hoarsely.
Winter watched, open mouthed, as an
identical earring popped into existence
beside the first.
Whoa.
Are you secretly an animus dragon 2?
he asked.
No, Kibley said ruefully.
Thanks to you, whispered a bitter, dark
side of his brain, which he hustled back
into darkness as quickly as he could.
It turns out some of Turtle's spells
aren't as useless as they look.
He put his own earring back on.
Get me a large sack, he said to Winter
and 2 dragons, one willing to fly to
possibility, and another that can make it
to Queen Glaciers Palace.
Winter hurried out of the room without
arguing.
By the time he returned, Kibli had made a
pile of 256 earrings and was starting
again with 8. 32 was the maximum the bowl
could hold.
So it was not as fast a process as it
could have been with a larger bowl.
Turtle, Kibley thought disapprovingly, and
then caught himself.
Poor Turtle had never guessed that his
little food bowl would be used or needed
for such a strange, urgent task.
Holy smoking vipers, Thorn said, coming
into the room behind winter, with another
sandwing at her side.
Kibley, what in the world are you doing?
No, I see what you're doing.
So the question is how?
Animus magic, Kibley said, holding out
the bowl.
We have a friend who made this and the
earrings.
It means I can create more for all the
ice wings.
If I'm right, and the plague is sent by
Dark Stalker, it should cure them
instantly.
Thorn watched him intently, as he made
more and more earrings.
Can't this, Anna's friend, just make a
spell to stop Dark Stalker completely?
Perhaps instantly make everyone in Pyria
immune to his magic, or send something to
kill him.
I thought animus magic could do that kind
of thing.
The magic can, but this particular dragon
can't, Khibli answered.
Poor turtle, so afraid of everything
afraid of being discovered.
Afraid of making the wrong decision
afraid of killing.
That's a good thing, though.
Better an animus who's afraid to kill
than an animus who has no problem with
it.
Are we entirely sure this animus is to be
trusted?
Thorn asked.
She picked up one of the earrings from
the growing pile.
There's no hidden spell in these.
How would we know if there was?
Khibli took his earring off.
Look, he said, I can take it on and off
freely.
I am still myself, with or without it.
It just cleared my head of the spell that
made me find Dark Stalker, so charming
and trustworthy.
But the spell on him, Thorn said, pointing
to Winter with her tail, was different
Kibley said.
Targeted to make winter worship him and
agree with everything you said, I
suspect.
Winter growled again, and started pacing
the width of the room.
The queen cupped the earrings she held in
her talons, and squinted at the warm
amber glow.
Kibli wondered if she was thinking about
how small it was.
To protect against such a dangerous
dragon.
Does Sonny have one?
she asked.
Ghibli nodded.
Everyone at Jade Mountain should be
wearing one now.
Then I want them for the sand wings
next.
After the ice wings, she said.
I want one for every dragon in my
kingdom.
She thought for a moment, and all the
queens.
You must have sent one to glory, right?
Yes, but I don't know if she got it
Kibley answered.
I'll check the obsidian mirror, but if we
can't tell for sure.
Let's send another.
I'll have a dragon go through the
tunnel.
Three dragons, so the other 2 can go to
Coral and Morehen.
We're going to inflict Kibli's terrible
fashion sense on this whole continent?
Winter asked, joking awkwardly.
I'm afraid we have no choice, said Queen
Thorn.
I think you mean, wow, what a lot of
lucky, soon to be stylish dragons, Kibley
said.
He glanced at the slowly growing pile of
earrings.
Um, how many dragons would that be?
I don't know. she said.
Keep making them.
This is my fastest messenger.
She will take as many as she can carry to
possibility for the ice wings there.
And I'll take the rest to the ice kingdom
said Winter.
Will they let you in?
Hibley asked, in between, twice as much
please.
Whispers.
Will they trust you?
Don't they think you're dead?
Yes, but if I'm there to save lives
surely.
Winter trailed off, as if he wasn't
actually sure how his tribe would receive
him.
Magic plague cure or not.
One of the ice wings and possibility can
take the rest of the earrings to the ice
kingdom as soon as they're healed.
Thorn ordered.
It's essentially on the way.
We won't lose much time.
You stay here and figure out how we're
going to fight this demon dragon.
She turned and swept out of the room.
Muttering calculations under her breath.
Before long, the sack was full.
The messenger seized it in her claws and
soared out the window.
They could see her pale scales flashing
in the sky as she shot away toward
possibility.
I hope this works.
Kibley prayed.
I hope I'm not sending false hopes to all
these dragons.
The day faded into evening.
The golden light into deep purple dusk
outside.
Kibli kept making earrings.
Winter brought him food and water, and
took over whispering to the bowl, while
Kibli wolfed down the meal and checked
the slate again.
Turtle, where are you?
I just had a horrible thought, Winter
said, as Kibley took the bowl back.
No, thank you, Kibley answered.
I've got quite enough of my own.
Winter barreled on.
Dark Stalker can see the future
remember?
So if this works, mustn't he know by now
that his plan to wipe out the ice wings
will fail?
Kibley felt that cold talon slide down
his spine again.
Maybe the future doesn't completely
change until the earrings get there.
Maybe we have a little time before he
notices, but you're right.
Surely he will soon.
I wonder if that will make him suspicious
about who's working against him, he
said.
Poor turtle, exactly as he feared.
But turtle, I have to save these
dragons.
You do the same thing in my place
wouldn't you?
There was a muffled boom somewhere not
far enough away.
Winter and Kibli stared at each other, and
for a panicked moment, Kibli thought, It's
dark stalker.
We brought him here just by talking about
him.
He's come to kill everyone, and I don't
have enough protection spells.
And then there was another boom.
And another, very close, that shook the
brakes under their feet.
Earrings, slid and bounced off the pile
scattering between Kibley's claws.
He jumped to his feet, flinching slightly
as he put weight on his wounded arm.
He wanted to fly out there in a wild rush
but he couldn't lose the only items they
had to fight dark stalker.
Quickly.
He took apart the bowl and slipped it
back in his bag, around his chest, along
with several earrings, while Winter
shoveled the rest of the earrings into
more sacks, and hid them among the jars
and medical paraphernalia on the
shelves.
They hurried out into the corridor, and
found themselves in a sea of running
dragons.
Kibley struggled against the tide for a
moment, thinking the dragons were running
away from whatever this attack was, but
then he realized, then most of them were
out claws, and he knew these were the
dragons, who would run straight into the
danger if it threatened Queen Thorn.
He turned and ran with them.
Winter's icy scales, cast a chill over
his tail and back as the ice wing ran
close behind him.
They emerged onto one of the balconies
that overlooked most of the palace.
Kibli skidded to a stop with a gasp.
Smoke was pouring from a gash in one of
the outer walls.
More smoke rose from a hold in the roof
of the treasury.
It sounded as though dragons were
fighting, but it was hard to see exactly
what was going on.
Khibli glanced up, wishing for brighter
moons, and realized that much of the
moonlight was blotted out by the wings of
dragons filling the sky.
Night Wings?
He thought in confusion for a moment, but
the firelight from the palace below
reflected off pale scales, like his own.
It's not dark stalker, he said to Winter
it's the talons of power.
It's my grandfather.
And as he said that, he recognized the
nightmarish shape of vulture, rising
triumphantly from the hole in the
treasury roof, wreathed in smoke, and
holding aloft the eye of onyx.
Chapter 14.
Friends, vulture ward.
Sand wings, talons of power.
Listen to me.
He landed on the top of a dome that rose
above many of the other palace
buildings.
Hibele wondered if Vulture knew what it
was, and whether he'd deliberately chosen
to give his speech with his claws on the
mausoleum where the ashes of sand winged
queens were kept.
Three of his minions circled him
breathing trails of flame, that lit
Vulture's face with a terrifying orange
glow.
The battling dragons pulled away from one
another, looking up at him, and silence
fell across the palace grounds.
Have we really come to this?
Vulture said, in his hypnotic voice.
Sand wings, fighting sand wings.
So soon after the war that tore our tribe
apart, He swept his wings out to
encompass all of them.
Look how divided we are.
Do you know why we fight each other?
Because you attacked the palace?
Khibli thought, frowning.
Because we are ruled by a false queen.
Vulture boomed.
One who does not deserve this palace.
She doesn't care about anyone but
herself.
She stole this throne to make herself
rich.
She's been letting sand wings die all
over her kingdom without lifting a talent
to save them.
A real monarch would keep you safe.
A good ruler would find the dragons
responsible and protect you all.
We need someone who will see the danger
clearly.
Our tribe is under attack.
Fellow Sandwings.
Yes, Kibley yelled, by you.
Volter turned his dark, haunting eyes
toward the balcony, and Kibley had to
tense every muscle in his body to keep
from trembling.
You see that?
My grandson.
Once a loyal follower of Thorn agrees
with me, he said smoothly.
He knows I am the one who sees the danger
and I am the one who can protect you
all.
That's not what I said.
Khibli shouted furiously.
Because I have found the threat, Vulture
announced.
Speaking right over Kibley.
I know who is attacking us, my fellow
sandwings.
It is the mud wings, and I have proof.
Khibli felt the force of the gasp that
went up around the crowd like a punch in
his stomach.
We caught one of the mud wing
infiltrators, and forced him to confess
said Vulture.
Then we took the last of his weapons and
came here.
Knowing my talons of power, were the only
ones who could protect the kingdom.
He brandished the eye of onyx, like a
bolt of lightning, he was ready to hurl
into the ground.
My friends, it is time for a new ruler of
the sand wings.
Where is onyx?
Kibli wondered.
Why is she letting Vulture do all this
speechifying?
He hasn't even mentioned her yet.
Has he cut her out?
Left her behind?
Is he planning to take the throne for
himself?
He glanced around, searching the crowds
of dragons, or is she here?
And if so, what is she up to?
Vulture?
Queen Thorn's voice was calm but clear
carrying across the palace and into the
desert beyond.
Enough.
Everyone turned to look for her.
The queen stood in the balcony of the
whispering tower.
A tall, thin tower that had been used by
queens for 100s of years to make speeches
to her tribe.
It was designed for perfect acoustics, so
even dragons outside the palace would be
able to hear her.
Bern had never used it.
She did not see the point of giving
speeches, and she did not have a tribe
unified enough to listen to her anyway.
If you have illegally taken a mud wing
into custody, I suggest you bring him
here for questioning before spreading
dangerous rumors.
And if you have a serious challenger for
the sand wing throne, let's take this to
the dueling grounds.
We don't need duel, said Vulture.
We have the eye of onyx, the symbol of
royal power.
It's much more than a symbol, Thorn said
quietly, firmly.
It's animus touched, and that is not the
Eye of Onyx.
She lifted off her necklace and held up a
black sphere encircled by golden wings.
What you hold is a replica.
I keep in my treasury to fool thieves, and
save their lives.
This is the real eye of onyx.
Vulture narrowed his eyes at her, and
even from a distance, Kibli recognized
the look his grandfather got when he was
tricked, and ready for vengeance.
Please be careful, Thorn, he begged in
his head.
Why should we believe that's the real
one?
Vulture demanded.
His talons caressed the sphere he held as
if it was an egg.
But an egg that could hatch out
unimaginable power instead of a
dragonette.
Because, she said, the eye of Onyx, will
kill anyone unworthy who tries to steal
it and the throne.
A small smile crossed her face, and it
hasn't killed me yet.
Vulture eyed the jewel in his claws
suspiciously.
Everyone could hear the implication in
Thorn's words.
If that was the real eye of Onyx, you
would be dead.
Oh, Winter said quietly beside Kibley.
I bet that's where her name comes from.
Onyx, for the eye of Onyx, a clue to her
royal heritage.
Kibli was still frantically searching the
sand wings in the sky, and the ones that
had spilled through the palace walls.
She had to be here somewhere, and if you
couldn't see her, she could be doing
anything.
There.
It was only a flicker of movement, but it
was enough to catch his attention.
A twitch of a tail tip against the stone
of the whispering tower, a hint of a
dragon, slowly slithering up beneath the
queen.
Thorn, Kibley shrieked, launching himself
off the balcony toward her.
Look out.
She's right below you.
He dove toward the hidden dragon, just as
she reared up into the moonlight.
Her venomous tail plunged toward the
queen's heart, and Kibley felt his own
heart shudder and freeze.
Not thorn, not thorn, not thorn.
But his warning had worked.
Thorn was already spinning toward onyx as
she attacked.
She smacked onyx's tail out of the way
with her own, and shoved onyx backward
off the tower.
Onyx's wings shot out to stop her fall
but before she could write herself, 7 out
claws were on her, including Kibley
seizing her limbs and tail and holding
her in the air.
Don't hurt her.
Thorn ordered from above them, yet.
Kibley looked up at her in disbelief.
She just tried to kill you.
He protested.
Onyx snarled at him.
I'm only taking what's mine, she hissed.
My throne, my crown.
If you really think it should be yours.
Then fight me for it like a true queen
would, Thorn scoffed.
This crown will never fall to a sneaking
skulking shadow killer.
Fine, onyx spat, twisting free from one
of the guards.
I am the granddaughter of Queen Oasis, and
the true heir to this throne.
I challenge you.
Shocked murmurs ran through the crowd of
watching dragons.
But Thorn just grinned at Onyx.
Anytime, said Thorn.
Let's take this to the Palace Stadium.
That's where duels for the throne have
always been fought.
But maybe you already know that.
She swept her wing toward the arena that
took up a back corner of the palace
grounds.
Since Thorn had become queen, Kibli had
only seen it used for games and moon
festivals.
He hadn't realized it had such a dark
history.
How many queens have spilled their blood
on those sands.
Is my queen going to be one of them?
Release her, Thorn ordered, flicking her
tail.
She leaped aloft as the outlaws
reluctantly let go of onyx.
I'm taking my throne right now.
Onyx growled, jabbing her tail at the
dragons who had held her.
And then you will be the 1st ones I
punish.
She whirled in the air and dove toward
the stadium, sending dragons scattering
out of her flight path.
Kibley looked back at Vulture, who was
rubbing his chin and studying the false
eye of onyx.
He thought it would be enough to come and
take it.
He hoped that holding it would be enough
to make him king.
I bet he was going to cut out onyx, if he
could, after she killed Thorn for him.
But now, knowing the real stone might
kill him.
He's not going to take that risk, not
right now.
Not if he can throw onyx into the fire
1st to see what happens.
If she wins, he thinks he can control
her.
He's cleverly surrounded her with dragons
who are loyal to him 1st and foremost.
She doesn't have an army of her own.
But she can't win.
I can't let her win.
Kimley felt a cold breeze sweep out
behind him, and turned in the air to see
winter.
What if the eye chooses onyx, he blurted
before the ice wing could speak.
It'll know that she's Smolder's daughter
won't it?
Winter's expression said volumes more
than any words he could have spoken.
He's sure that onyx will win.
Kibley realized.
Of course he believes in the monarchy.
In the line of succession and royal
blood.
That's how his family is defined, how his
whole tribe is organized.
He might even think Onyx should win.
Kibli realized, with a surge of fury.
He turned away, unable to look at
Winter's face a moment longer.
They swept down toward the stadium in a
whirling cloud of wings.
Every dragon wanted to see what would
happen.
There were few left alive who could
remember the last time the Eye of Onyx
had been used in a proper challenge for
the throne, although everyone remembered
very clearly how it had killed Blister
only a few months earlier in the palace
courtyard.
The stadium was designed like an oval
amphitheater, built of sandstone, with no
roof.
The benches rose like steps from the
ground upward, and at the top, sturdy
poles could be folded out to add more
places for additional audience members to
perch.
The wall at the bottom still had barely
faded paintings on it, from the last moon
festival, dark blue backgrounds covered
with white and gold stars in circles.
Kibley managed to elbow his way to a seat
in the front row, using his smaller size
to slip under the wings of larger
dragons.
As he settled, drawing his tail safely
under him, he saw a flurry of sandwings
moving aside for smolder and blaze to
land in the front row as well, not far
away from him.
They both looked confused and anxious.
Unlike Queen Scarlet's gladiator arena
this one had no royal box.
No special platform for the Royal
Family.
Queen Thorn usually sat wing to wing with
her subjects, singing and sharing shish
kebabs and throwing coins at the best
dancers, just like everyone else.
But now she landed on the sand, briefly
alone in that vast oval, and Kibley felt
a terrible shudder of fear inside him.
What would happen to the world without
thorn in it?
What would happen to the sand wings?
They needed her.
She was the only queen who could heal the
scars left by the war.
And she's my leader, and my friend.
She changed my life.
If she hadn't saved me, who would I be?
Onyx landed heavily in front of Thorn, and
his spasm of fear twisted tighter.
Kibli had been thinking of onyx as a
fellow dragonette, because she was a
student at Jade Mountain Academy.
But of course, she was much older than
the other students, almost 20 years old
which made her around the same age as
Thorn, but definitely bigger.
In the center of the far wall that ringed
the oval, there was an indentation, which
Kibley had noticed before, because it
looked deliberate, and yet he'd never
been able to figure out what it was for.
Now its purpose became clear.
As Thorn set the eye of onyx into the
hollow, where it fit perfectly.
Torches were being lit all around the
stadium.
So Kibley wasn't sure if it was a trick
of the light, but he could have sworn, a
crackle of blue energy zipped around the
stone for a moment as Thorn lifted her
talons away.
Onyx stepped closer to it, staring at the
eye hungrily.
Are you sure you want to do this?
Thorn asked her.
What the eye does.
It's not a pleasant way to die.
Onyx scowled.
It won't kill me, she snapped.
I'm the true heir to the sandwing
throne.
You said you're a granddaughter of Queen
Oasis, Thorn prompted.
Onyx lifted her chin proudly.
My mother's name was Palm, she said.
My father is Prince Smolder.
Kibli leaned forward to see Smolder's
reaction.
I should have warned him.
I was so distracted with everything
else.
Smolder looked as though someone had
driven cactus spikes under his claws.
He blinked several times, then vaulted
over the wall, and ran across the sand
toward the daughter he never knew he
had.
She jumped back, scowling at him.
And he stumbled to a stop in front of
her.
Palm's daughter, he said, bracing himself
to look down at her.
I didn't know she.
She never told me.
But if we had a daughter, we were going
to name her.
Onyx, she answered.
That's me.
He took a step back, his wings sagging.
But Palm died.
She died years ago.
My mother killed her.
It was rather a specialty of mothers
killing dragons she didn't like.
Not this one, said Onyx.
Palm escaped and had me.
She thought you were dead.
Good job looking for us, though.
Appreciate that.
I would have if I'd known, he said
fiercely.
Behind him, Thorn reached out and brushed
his wing lightly with hers.
Smolder kept his gaze on onyx, but his
body seemed to react subconsciously
leaning toward Thorn so their wings
stayed connected.
When did they start falling for each
other?
Kibley wondered.
How had he missed it?
He hadn't been away at school that long
but then, he hadn't seen as much of Thorn
in the last few months as usual, with her
royal duties keeping her busy.
Thorn and smolder?
Really?
My guest, Sonny, did tell her to go have
some more eggs, so there would be heirs
to the sandwing throne who actually want
to be queen.
But she'll have to survive this 1st, and
she might have to kill his daughter in
front of him.
Onyx.
I have a suggestion, said Smolder.
His usual half mocking tone just failing
to conceal a note of deeper sincerity.
How about instead of immediately risking
death against our shiny new queen.
You take a few days to get to know us
first.
Stay here at the palace.
Tell me all about your life.
See how incredibly boring the job of
queen really is.
Eat as much as you want.
Hang out with me.
I mean, wouldn't you rather get to know
your father than expire in a ball of
ancient crackling magic?
So give me the throne.
Onyx said challengingly to Thorn.
We don't have to fight for it.
I'd be happy to take it off your talons.
I can't, Thorn said.
I couldn't give it to you, even if I
wanted to, which I don't, to be clear.
But the eye of onyx must choose.
We've been reading the legends about it.
Smolder said.
An animus dragon named Jerboa, created it
for the queen of the sand wings 1000s of
years ago.
It's been an essential and deadly, part
of the transition of power ever since.
Yes, yes.
Mother told me all about it.
Anx said impatiently.
She said it was the one thing that could
prove I was royal, so she wanted me to
stay far away from it.
She rolled her eyes.
Let's get on with it.
We fight until the eye chooses the
greater dragon.
Isn't that right?
Onyx.
Smolder tried one last time.
Please.
Sit down, you old lizard.
Onyx snapped.
I'm not here for you.
I'm here for my crown.
Hiberly's heart started thumping
painfully.
A smolder bowed his head and turned back
to his seat.
Thorn and onyx squared off, tails raised
like scorpions, with the eye glowering
darkly in the wall beyond them.
I can't watch the eye choose onyx and
kill Thorn.
I can't just sit here and let that
happen.
Maybe it will choose Thorn, argued
another part of his brain.
Maybe it knows she's the better queen.
How would it know that?
Surely it'll sense royal blood versus
common blood, and that's all it needs to
know.
Onyx let out a roar, and leaped at Thorn
all claws and teeth and venom.
Thorn ducked and rolled aside, delivering
a blow to the back of Onyx's head as she
whirled by.
Onyx spat furiously, and slashed at
Thorn's wing.
She just missed, but left bleeding claw
marks along Thorn's side.
A new terrifying thought struck Kibley.
Dark Stalker was offering to conspire
with Vulture.
What if he did something to the eye?
What if he used his magic from afar to
make it choose onyx?
That's what I would do, he realized
digging his claws into the bench below
him.
If I had Dark Stalker's magic, I'd
enchant the eye to choose Thorn forever.
I'd enchant it to protect her and destroy
anyone who tried to steal her throne.
But I don't have Dark Stalker's magic.
He slid a few inches away from winter
hunching into his wings.
I have nothing to protect her wit.
He paused, staring down at his wrists, and
the glowing armbands there.
If he could call a storm, maybe a
lightning bolt to strike down onyx.
Quick before the eye attacked.
He could end this fight with Thorn safe
and sound.
The only way to fight magic is with more
magic, right?
I have to do what I can.
Kibley sat back and raised his forearms.
Give me thunder, he whispered to the
bracelets, give me rain.
He felt winter twitch toward him, but he
tended his wings around himself to shut
winter out.
Bring me a storm, he said, in a low voice
closing his talons into fists.
A rush of wind swept across the arena
strong enough to buffet, thorn, and onyx
nearly into the wall.
With a howl, it swooped away again, and
everyone looked up to see dark clouds
billowing up to cover the stars.
The 3 moons were quickly swallowed.
More, Kibley whispered, turning his
wrists up toward the sky.
I want lightning.
His scales prickled under the bands, like
sharp little teeth digging in.
The wind rushed through again, fiercer
this time, and the air crackled ominously
around the arena.
Kibli, you fool, Winter said, shaking his
shoulder.
You don't know how to control those.
I have to save Thorn, Kibley answered
through gritted teeth.
The bracelets were starting to hurt, as
if they were constricting tighter and
tighter.
There was still no rain, but the wind was
growing stronger than he'd ever felt it
before, beating the clouds across the sky
and shrieking around the walls and towers
of the palace.
Down in the arena.
Thorn and onyx had stopped fighting.
They were having trouble even staying
upright, as the wind tried to seize their
wings and carry them away.
Onyx took 2 clawing steps toward Thorn
and stopped, coughing and choking on the
sand that flew up into her face.
Sandstorm, roared a dragon from one of
the upper poles.
She was looking out over the walls of the
palace at the desert beyond.
Sandstorm heading this way.
Oh, no, Kibley thought.
That's not what I was trying to summon.
He'd seen bad sandstorms before.
He knew they were not to be trifled
with.
Another dragon tried to take to the air
to see the storm, but the wind
immediately caught him and whirled him
away into the clouds, screaming.
Kibley stared after him, stricken with
horror.
Everyone inside, Thorn shouted, stay low
and run.
Get into the great hall.
Close all the doors and windows.
Sand wings stampeded over the top of the
stadium, clinging to the benches and
walls with their talons, and keeping
their wings tucked in close.
Blaze screamed louder than anyone and
bolted, climbing over other dragons until
she was one of the 1st ones racing
through the gardens to the doors of the
great hall.
No, Onyx cried.
I want to fight.
I've been waiting for this my whole
life.
She called forward another step, and then
the wind picked her up and slammed her
back into the far wall.
Onyxed.
Come on, Smolder shouted, climbing into
the arena.
He ran over to his daughter, but the wind
was building to another shrieking roar, so
Kibley couldn't hear what they were
yelling at each other.
Can you stop it?
Winter asked, grabbing one of Kibley's
wrists.
I'm trying, Kibley said.
He sliced his arms downward, as he'd seen
anemone do.
Stop this, he commanded them.
Enough.
Stop the storm.
Take it away.
Bring back the sunshine.
Stupid things.
Listen to me.
So we're running then, Winter said.
Kibli glanced around and saw Thorn
herding a group of palace dragonettes to
safety.
Loyal outlaw guards were gathered thick
around her, keeping her safe in case
vulture or onyx tried to assassinate her
in the chaos.
Kibley spotted the Eye of Onyx around her
neck again.
At least she's still alive.
Whatever happens next, I kept her alive
that much longer.
A sandstorm can't be worse than my queen
lying dead in a ball of blue fire.
Yup, he said to Winter, running.
They fled with everyone else, chased by
the wind and sand, wings jostled them, and
talons stepped on their claws, as all the
dragons in the palace ran for safety.
At the threshold of the great hall.
Kibli risked a look back and saw the
storm he had raised.
A thundering cloud of sand rose from the
dunes up to the sky, spreading across the
entire horizon and bearing down on the
palace.
It was a tidal wave of fury, 3 times as
high as the tallest palace tower.
And then Winter pushed him inside, and
Doris began slamming shut all around
them.
As the sand wings locked themselves in
and waited to be buried alive.
Chapter 15.
The storm raged for hours, which was a
long time to be packed into a room, with
over 100 other dragons, even a room as
big as the Great Hall.
Blaise used one of the large curtains to
make herself a hammock, hung from the
tall ceiling and proceeded to sleep
through most of the storm.
After a while, Thorn organized an
expedition to the kitchens that brought
back dried fruit, water, and bread for
everyone, though all of it tasted a
little gritty with sand.
Kibley spent most of the time worrying
about the fact that vulture, smolder, and
onyx weren't in the hall with everyone
else.
Where had they gone instead?
Were they still alive?
He kept himself busy making more earrings
in a sheltered corner, where not too many
dragons could see him and ask awkward
questions.
Ostrich and her father, 6 Claws, found
him there halfway through the storm and
volunteered to distribute earrings to all
the dragons in the hall.
Kibley felt a little resentful about the
fact that some of those dragons were
talons of power, driven into hiding with
the palace sand wings after attacking
them.
But even they needed magical protection.
Brainwashed talons of power would not be
any improvement over the current
version.
He also checked turtle slate every few
minutes, and then again, and then again
more and more frequently.
Where was Turtle?
Why had he disappeared for so long?
Had something terrible happened to him?
He didn't know how long it had been when
he looked up to find Thorn standing over
him, frowning slightly.
Oh, hey, he said.
Winter jabbed him with a pointy elbow and
Kibley jumped.
I mean, hello, Your Majesty.
I have the strangest feeling. said Thorn
that you know something about this.
She waved one of her wings at the rafters
that were shaking in the wind.
Um, Kibli set his jaw and squared his
shoulders.
Yes, that was me.
I called the storm to save your life.
I didn't quite have a handle on how big
it would turn out to be.
More animus magic, Thorn said, still
frowning.
He held out his wrists to display the
bracelets.
They're supposed to control the weather.
She tapped one claw against the copper.
I'm not sure control is the right word
here.
I'm sorry, said Kibley, about the palace
I mean, and I hope everyone's all right.
But I'm not sorry that you're safe.
I was trying to protect you from the
eye.
Thorn's wings flicked up and down, and
she stared at him with raised eyebrows.
Protect me from the eye?
Didn't you trust it to choose me?
Like it did before.
But onyx is royalty.
Kibley said.
And Dark Stalker is on her side.
And I was afraid he'd done something to
it.
And plus, she's royalty.
I thought that's what the I would want.
She shook her head and lifted the eye of
onyx necklace over her head to hold it in
her talons.
Kibli took an instinctive step back.
It so clearly radiated power.
And danger.
Even if he hadn't seen it kill blister
he'd be terrified of it.
But since he had, it was hard not to
remember the sinister dragon's silent
agonized thrashing, or the charred smell
that was left after she exploded into
black dust.
I know it's scary. said Queen Thorn.
But I've been wearing it around my neck
for months now, and I've come to trust
it.
She traced the wings gently with one
claw.
It feels right to me.
Like it was crafted by an animus with
wisdom and goodness in her heart.
And all of my research into it has
confirmed that.
The eye doesn't choose the most royal or
most dangerous dragon to be queen.
It chooses the best queen available for
the job.
She smiled down at it.
In fact, Smolder and I discovered a
secret.
The eye has chosen commoners over royalty
before.
The current royal bloodline goes back to
a dragon who grew up in a town a lot like
the Scorpion den.
A dragon who got the throne basically by
accident, because the eye chose her to
save the kingdom from a cruel and vicious
princess.
Thorn met Kibley's eyes.
The truth is, Oasis and her descendants
including Onyx, aren't any more royal
than you or me?
Except insofar as having power for 100s
of years makes you royal.
But that's not what the eye cares about.
Really?
Kibli's mind was spinning.
This was exactly what he thought animus
magic should be used for, not personal
power, but improving the world in ways
that made entire tribes safer.
Imagine if every tribe had an eye of onyx
something that ensured only wise and good
queens were chosen.
Wouldn't that mean Pyrea would always be
at peace?
So all dragons would be happier and well
cared for?
My theory?
is that Jerboa was playing a trick on her
queen, said Thorn.
If she was ordered to make the eye
perhaps the queen wanted something to
keep herself in power.
But instead, Jerboa made this clever
spell to pick good queens.
I'm sorry, Kibley said.
I didn't realize.
Of course it'll choose you, if that's the
real spell.
I think I am a good queen, Thorn said
thoughtfully.
And I guess if I'm ever not, it should be
comforting that there's a way for me to
find out.
She laughed.
It would be nice if I could bargain with
it though.
Like, hey, I have Onyx.
Instead of blowing me up, could you just
send me a note that's like, time to stop
being queen, Crazy Claus, and then I
could happily retire?
If I had an animus of my own, I'd
probably get them working on that.
Maybe I can get Turtle to do that for
her.
Kibley thought, after we deal with Dark
Stalker.
When we've averted the prophecy, and
everything is calm again.
Thorn looked up toward the ceiling.
I think it's finally stopped, she said
and Kibli realized she was right.
The wind had fallen silent at last.
Let's go see what a mess you've made
Thorn said to Kibley.
I don't suppose you brought an animous
object that cleans up after you.
Sorry, Kibley said ruefully.
The main doors of the hall were
impossible to push open.
They had to fly to one of the upper
windows and open the shutters, to
discover that the palace was buried in a
layer of sand 3 dragons deep, entirely
blocking the doors and covering all the
gardens.
The sun sparkled cheerfully in the bright
blue sky overhead.
Kibley, Thorn grumbled.
She scanned the palace, the towers and
rooftops poking out of the ridiculous new
dunes, Kibli realized that she must be
worried about smolder, although she was
hiding it under her exasperation with
him.
I'll start looking for anyone who needs
to be dug out, he offered, and darted
back inside to assemble a team.
They found dragons safely squirreled away
all over the palace.
It had been built to have a lot of places
to safely hole up during a sandstorm, with
reinforced shutters and strong doors.
Some of them required digging to get to
but by the early hours of the morning, all
the dragons in the palace seem to be
accounted for, except for smolder and
onyx.
And there was no sign anywhere of
vulture.
Kibli took winter, ostrich, 6 claws, and
tawny, back to the giant sandpile that
used to be the arena, the last place he'd
seen smolder.
Please let him be all right.
Ghibli prayed as they dug.
Smolder might not be good enough for
Queen Thorn, in his opinion, but if she
liked him, that was all that mattered.
Please, let him be all right.
Please let us find him soon.
His shoulders ached.
He wished moon were there, digging beside
him, with her never giving up face on.
Any luck, Thorn asked, landing on one of
the perches that stuck out of the sand.
Not yet, your majesty.
Six claws answered.
Thorn wriggled her wings as though they
itched.
Kibli had noticed that she often did this
when her closest friends called her, Your
Majesty.
You should try the Obsidian Mirror.
He suggested.
I know I should, she said. rubbing her
snout.
It's buried in a very safe chest in a
very safe, hidden compartment in my
bedroom, under a couple of tons of sand.
She glanced back at a contingent of wings
flurrying around the central palace
building.
We're working on it.
Kibley sat up and studied the arena
shaking sand off his wings.
What would he have done if the storm had
hit before he could get to the great
hall?
If he'd been standing right here, like
smolder and onyx.
Smolder knows this palace better than
anyone.
He's lived here his whole life.
All throughout the war while his sisters
were away fighting one another.
He survived oasis and burn.
He must know every possible hiding hole
every safe place.
His eyes scanned the walls as his brain
spun rapidly through possibilities.
I'd want to get underground, if I could.
Somewhere fortified and secure.
Kibli looked down at his talons, then up
at his queen.
Thorn, he called.
Aren't the dungeons right below us?
Part of them, Thorn answered, wrinkling
her nose.
This palace has a lot of dungeons.
She tipped her head.
What are you thinking?
Maybe the dungeon is connected to the
arena somehow, Kibley said, pacing in a
large circle.
So prisoners could be brought here to
fight for the queen.
Like in Scarlet's palace.
It's possible, isn't it?
That this arena was used that way a long
time ago?
Horribly possible, Thorn agreed.
Good idea.
You four, look for a way in from here.
Kibli, come with me.
He followed her back to the upper windows
of the great hall, then swooped down to
the lower levels and out through the
covered passageways that led to the
kitchens, the throne room, and other
parts of the palace.
Drifts of sand lay across the floor in
places where the windows hadn't been
completely shuttered.
Where's your guard?
Kibli asked.
Watching Thorn's tail whisk through one
of these drifts, leaving a spray of
sunlit sand modes in the air behind her.
Digging out the palace like everyone else
said Thorn.
I put all of Vulture's dragons who are
still here to work as well.
In exchange for amnesty and resettlement
packages.
Outlaws are watching them, but I think
they'll turn out to be fine after we chat
with them a little bit and get their
heads on straight.
She glanced back at Kibley.
It's hard to readjust, after someone you
trust has been lying to for years.
But hey, you turned out mostly normal, so
I think there's hope for them.
Mostly normal?
Kibli protested.
Three moons.
I'm not sure which is worse, mostly or
normal.
Thorn laughed.
Maybe normal is the wrong word. generally
acceptable, reasonably fit for society
solidly on the side of the not so
murderous.
Stop, stop.
This much flattery can't be good for me
Kibley said wryly.
She turned down a poorly lit, narrow
passage that twisted and angled
downward.
Kibley stayed close, hopping down the
occasional steps, and keeping his wings
away from the rough scraped walls.
Lanterns flickered from niches all the
way down, casting jumpy little shadows
around his claws.
The air had an odd smell, like a trove of
decayed lizards buried under a floorboard
and forgotten about for years.
Thorn unlocked a series of gates on the
way down, relocking them behind her.
It passed a few guards, posted in pairs
who saluted to the queen and stayed in
position, holding their weapons.
Finally, a flight of stone stairs
deposited them in an antechamber, with 4
tunnels branching out from it.
Thorn took a lantern from a low shelf by
the stairs, and breathed a small burst of
flame to light it.
I don't like coming down here.
She admitted to Kibley.
Horse Molder refuses to come with me.
It's the one thing I can't get him to
do.
I suspect his mother used to punish him
by locking him down here overnight
whenever he displeased her.
She lifted her lantern to look down one
of the tunnels.
If he had to take refuge down here
because of the storm.
I can't imagine how sick he must be
feeling.
We'll find him, Kibley promised.
He pictured the palace in his head
mapping it over the turns they had taken
on the way down.
This one leads under the arena, I think.
Right?
He pointed to the darkest tunnel, just as
a strange gibbering wail erupted from
it.
The sound sliced under Kibley scales, like
freezing needles, terrifying him down to
his bones.
He leaped back from the passage, and
resisted the urge to run screaming up the
steps back to the sunlight.
What?
he said, picturing ghosts and furious
spirits.
What?
That's the mad prisoner, Thorn said
grimly.
She's been down here since the time of
Queen Oasis.
She brushed past him and set off down the
passage.
Kibley scrambled to keep up, so he could
stay close to the light, and to Thorn's
reassuring, no nonsense voice.
Mad?
He echoed.
I wanted to release her, or at least talk
to her, said Thorn, but she attacks
anyone who enters her cell or goes near
her chains.
She managed to stab 2 of my guards with
her tail before we gave up.
I think there were times during the war
when she was forgotten for days, and
nearly starved.
Burne was not the most careful dragon
with her prisoners.
I'm sure she didn't even care what this
one did to end up in here.
There's no record of a crime anyway.
She waived one wing at the deserted cells
they were passing.
The whole dungeon is almost empty now.
I freed most of the dragons burn had
imprisoned, since their crimes all
involved disloyalty to her.
There's a jail in the courtyard barracks
that's a lot more humane. for prisoners
who we can try quickly.
Thorn sighed.
I was keeping those 2 night wings here
for Queen Glory, but somehow they escaped
which is another argument for shutting
this whole dungeon down and never using
it again, if you ask me.
They turned a corner, and Kibley saw the
glow of firelight up ahead.
In unspoken agreement, they both began to
run, until they were close enough to see
2 dragons huddled by the wall at the end
of the tunnel outside the cells.
Smolder, Thorn called joyfully.
He lifted his head, and grinned weakly at
the side of her.
About time, your royal sluggishness, he
said.
You didn't have to sit here and wait for
me.
You broiled snail, she pointed out.
Sliding her lantern into a niche across
from the one that was lit.
You do have feet.
You could have just come on upstairs
instead of making us all worry about
you.
I mean, not that I was worried.
Well, I was, Smolder said.
He opened his wings and Thorn hugged him
pulling back quickly, as though she
didn't want to get too emotional in front
of witnesses.
On top of Smolder's head, something like
a little tuft of fur sat up and shook
itself.
It leaned into the light, and Kibli
realized it was flower, yawning and
stretching.
But we couldn't leave, Smolder
continued.
Onyx is hurt.
He moved aside to reveal his daughter
curled into a sullen ball and breathing
shallowly.
One of her back feet looked as though it
had been crushed by something heavy.
It was an awful bloody mess, and she
clearly couldn't walk.
In fact, Kibli wasn't sure she'd ever
walk on it again.
Thorn inhaled sharply.
We need to get you to a doctor, she said
to Onyx.
I know, on expat.
I told him to go get one.
But I didn't want to leave her alone
Smolder interjected.
Right.
Onyx snorted.
More like he's a coward who's afraid of
ghosts.
She tried to shift her weight to sit up
and froze, shuddering in pain.
Smolder lifted his wings.
Well, I haven't stayed alive this long by
running toward the shrieking things in
the dark.
He made an I am who I am, face.
The thing in the dark screamed again from
somewhere very nearby, sending Kibley's
heart pounding.
That's just the mad prisoner, Thorn said
to smolder.
I told you about her.
You couldn't remember what she was
arrested for either.
For lies!
The dragon shrieked.
For my face, not my face.
I'm going to kill her.
Thorne sighed and took the lantern
again.
Stepping back to one of the cells they'd
run past, inside, a tortured looking
sandwing paste, clawing at the scales
around her neck, rusty chains stretched
from her ankles to loops, bolted into the
floor.
As the light illuminated her prison, she
whirled around, and threw herself at the
bars, screaming, let me out so I can kill
her.
See?
That just doesn't sound like a good idea
Thorn said.
Smolder.
Look, she's only a dragon.
She probably wasn't mad when she got here
but more than 20 years in the dark will
eat away at anyone's sanity.
For lies.
The dragon shrieked again.
I'm not her.
The queen never came.
No one ever came.
No one sees me.
She stole my face.
She threw my face into the fire.
I'm not her.
Wait.
Onyx rasped.
She dragged herself forward using her
front talons, shoving smolder off when he
tried to help her.
Her dark eyes squinted at the frantic
prisoner.
You can't possibly know her, Thorn said
curiously.
She's been in here longer than you've
been alive.
She looks like my mother, Anyx said, who
wasn't too emotionally stable herself by
the way.
Lots of nightmares, super paranoid, would
have kept me buried under a rock forever
if she could have.
Smolder edged forward to take a closer
look at the prisoner too.
She had her claws wrapped around the bars
and her snout pressed between 2 of them
her eyes closed, as though she were
trying to will herself free with a force
of pure hatred.
Does she look like palm?
Thorn asked him.
No, howled the prisoner.
Smolder sat back, lifting his talons to
cover his snout with an expression of
horror and dismay.
No, he said.
I mean, Yes, but no, because this.
I think this is prickle.
Who?
said Thorn.
Aunt Prickle?
Onyx said, grimacing as another wave of
pain seemed to grip her.
Holmes sister, said Smolder.
Prickle.
Is that you?
What are you doing here?
You!
She snarled at him, clawing at her
chains.
A thin layer of clarity seemed to settle
over her as she recognized him.
This is your fault.
Your earrings, your fine words, your
stupid dragonette.
That's me, said Onyx, the stupid
dragonette.
Mother let the soldiers take prickle
thinking she was palm, so mother could
escape with me.
She told me the whole story after her
like 9000th nightmare about it.
But she said they would have released
Prickle within a day or 2 once the queen
realized the mistake.
Except the queen died.
Said Smolder.
She must have died before seeing her.
And then no one ever...
He trailed off.
Wow, Kibley said faintly.
I want to release you.
Thorn said to prickle through the bars
but I'm a little worried about what you
might do.
She glanced sideways at smolder.
Prickle hissed and turned her back
hunching her wings around herself.
We'll come back and try again, Thorn
said.
Now that we know who you are and what
happened, we'll bring someone you can
talk to, we'll get you back to the
sunlight, I promise.
The only answer was a low growl.
Hello?
called a bored voice.
If prisoners are being released, can I be
next?
No, Cobra, Thorn called back.
And by the way, your father attacked
without your help, failed to overthrow me
and left again.
Cobra chuckled somewhere in the dark.
You really think he would give up that
easily.
She said.
You think he'll go back to his gilded
compound and lie around eating scavengers
peacefully for the rest of his life.
Ha, ha, ha.
Volter will burn the kingdom to the
ground before he gives up.
Thorn looked at Kibley, and he nodded.
He wished Cobra was wrong, but he knew it
was true.
A grinding, scraping sound came from the
wall at the end of the tunnel.
The sound of the old door to the arena
being dragged open from the outside.
Sunlight tumbled in, chasing away the
ominous gloom of the dungeon.
Smolder turned toward it, relief scrawled
all over his face.
Ostrich popped her head around the door.
I found it.
She chirped.
It was me.
You're very clever.
Six claws rumbled affectionately behind
her.
Well done.
Go get a doctor, Thorn ordered ostrich
striding over and shoving the door open
another few inches.
Six claws, help me get onyx out onto the
sand.
Onyx hissed furiously, as 6 claws bent to
lift her, but she kept her tail coiled
safely away from him and Thorn as they
carried her outside.
She won't be challenging Thorn again
anytime soon, Kibley thought.
Maybe ever, if they can talk her out of
it while she's recuperating.
He glanced at Smolder, who was hurrying
after them.
That's suspiciously lucky.
In the chaos of the storm, anything could
have happened.
Would smolder deliberately injure his own
daughter to stop her from fighting Thorn
to save Thorn's life, and her own?
He wasn't sure he wanted to know.
Intentional harm or a lucky accident
whichever it was, Thorn was safe, and
Onyx didn't have to die.
The eye could go back around Thorn's neck
and she could continue to rule the
kingdom in peace.
Unless Dark Stalker comes for it.
Until the next step of his plan, whatever
it is.
Bye, Kibley.
Cobra's voice whispered from the dark.
I'm sure your grandfather will be seeing
you soon.
Kibley shuddered and climbed out onto the
arena sands.
Winter reached down and caught his talons
hauling him up the last incline.
The chill of his talons against Kibley's
felt like a reminder of the cold, worried
feeling inside of him.
Dark stalker and vulture. working
together.
That could mean the end of Pyria.
He reached for the slate in his pouch
again, although he'd almost lost hope
that Turtle would ever send another
message.
Maybe he'd forgotten he had the slate, or
that Kibley was out here waiting for
news.
But this time, there was a new message.
The message Kibley had been dreading ever
since he watched Moon and Turtle fly away
with Dark Stalker.
It read, Dark Stalker knows about me
Trapped in the Nightwing Palace.
Help Part two.
King of Shadows.
Chapter 16.
Winter turned the slate over a few times
and then held it out to the sun, as if
searching for a hidden message under the
one that was there.
That's it.
Kibley said, spreading his talons.
That's all he wrote.
He paced back across the tiles, coiled
his tail around one of the outstretched
wings of the pavilion roof, and stared
out at the desert.
The wind breezed cheerfully around him, as
if it had nothing to do with a mess of
sand covering the palace below.
From up here, atop one of the tallest
palace towers.
Pyria looked as if it stretched forever
in all directions.
This is bad. said Winter.
Do you think so?
Khibli shouted.
There's no need to raise your voice at me
winter said, ruffling up the spines
around his neck.
I'm the one who's going to help you
rescue him.
I know, I know.
Kibley said.
He clenched his talons and tried to calm
down.
Turtle is the one I really feel like
yelling at.
Turtle said Winter.
Isn't he the dragon in distress here?
Yes, but, said Kibley.
If you're going to send out a cry for
help, shouldn't it be a useful cry for
help?
With any information in it?
Such as may be, for instance, where the
moon's blasted camel licking night
kingdom is?
Oh, Winter said, looking at the message
again.
You're right.
He doesn't mention that.
How are we supposed to rescue him?
Kibley cried, flinging his front claws in
the air.
When we can't even find him.
Why hasn't he sent me a message in 3
days?
Just, hey, off to the night kingdom
Toodles.
And then, oh, no, act.
I'm trapped in the night kingdom, and
nothing in between.
He buried his face in his talons.
And nothing about Moon.
Is she all right?
What does she think about dark stalker
trapping turtle?
Does this mean she's in trouble too?
He took a deep breath and looked up at
winter again.
As frustrated as he was, he had to admit
to himself that he really didn't know
what turtle had been going through, or
how awful the last few days might have
been for him.
Most likely, there hadn't been any time
to write a message.
And now, Turtle was living his worst
nightmare.
Poor turtle.
He said.
He must be terrified.
What do you think Dark Stalker will do to
him?
Winter asked.
I mean, he did promise Moon that he
wouldn't hurt any of her friends.
Sure, but I have a feeling.
Dark Stalker knows a lot of ways to
wriggle around his promises.
Kibley said, like, it's not herding
turtle to gently throw him in a night
wing dungeon.
It's not herding you to put a
brainwashing spell on you.
It wouldn't be hurting Kinkaju if he cast
a spell like the one on Hailstorm, turning
her into an entirely different dragon.
See what I mean?
He knows how to play tricks with words.
Winter said, nodding, kind of like you.
What?
No, but evil, Khibli protested, so
nothing like me.
Right.
Winter said unconvincingly.
Oh, look, she's found it.
He pointed at the shape of Queen Thorn
flying toward them.
Kibli beat back the suspicion that winter
was trying to change the subject.
He stood up and waved, and Thorn swooped
down to drop the obsidian mirror in his
talons.
Thank you, he said as she landed beside
him.
I hope you find your friend, she said.
Do you need an army?
Because guess what?
I have an army now.
Like a big one?
They're pretty awesome.
But the night wing army has superpowers.
Winter pointed out darkly.
And Dark Stalker will see us coming if we
arrive with an army, Kibley said.
That's the kind of thing that would show
up bright and clear in his visions of the
future.
I don't want to get any sandwings
killed.
He balanced the mirror on his front
talons.
I'm hoping Winter and I won't look like
much of a threat to him.
I mean, we're no threat at all right now
since we can't even find him.
I'm not sure this will help, Thorn said
nodding at the mirror.
You can't see the dragons you're spying
on.
There aren't any details about where they
are.
They'd have to say something helpful.
I know, Kibley said.
Cross your claws for me.
He breathed smoke across the smooth black
surface and whispered, Moon Watcher.
Winter gave him a sharp, sideways look.
Moon, he said.
Not turtle or dark stalker.
I'll try them next, Kibley said.
He chosen her instinctively.
He really needed to know Moon was all
right.
The smoke coiled immediately into one
small black spiral, and a slightly
smaller twist of blue, pink, yellow red
which was flurrying wildly around the 1st
one.
Bet I know who that is, Kibley said.
Just as Moon's voice said, Kinkaju, please
calm down.
Kinkaju's all right?
Winter said, his eyes lighting up.
Kibli nodded and shushed him.
Me calm down.
Kinkachu cried.
You need to uncalm down.
You need to ramp all the way up to
freaking out right now.
About what?
Moon protested.
How can I freak out when you won't tell
me why?
I can't tell you.
Kinkaju yelped.
Arrr!
Because you don't have Skyfire.
So if I tell you, Dark Stalker might read
it in your mind, and then he'll know, I
told you, and all kinds of terrible
things might happen.
Oh my goodness, Kinkaju, Moon said
whatever it is.
I'm sure it's not the end of the world.
Except that it totally is.
It is probably the actual literal end of
the world.
I have to go back to Jade Mountain.
Kankaju said abruptly.
Will you come with me?
Right now?
Moon hesitated.
Dark Stalker asked me to stay until
tomorrow at least.
He said he wants to introduce me to
someone.
Can we leave after that?
Kinkaju's curl of smoke turned several
different colors, finally settling on an
interesting mix of pea green and smoky
red.
Fine, she said.
I'll do some detective work until then.
Stealth mode.
That's me.
All the colors vanished, leaving barely a
whisper of pale smoke behind.
Just be careful, Moon said.
Remember, Dark Stalker is paranoid for
reason, considering what happened to
him.
Which he brought upon himself, Kingaju
observed, by being completely evil.
Kinkaju.
Don't you argue with me, Kinkachu said.
Just tell me when you're ready to get out
of here.
Her barely visible smoke whirled away
leaving moons wisp alone on the mirror.
I can't believe Kinkaju is making more
sense than Moon right now, Winter said
rubbing his forehead.
I hope she's all right.
Kibley said.
Dark Stalker could figure out Kinkaju
isn't under his spell any moment.
He frowned.
But I don't understand how Moon is still
enchanted.
Didn't tsunami ever catch up with him?
She should have given Moon an earring
days ago.
Maybe we should look for her too, Thorn
suggested.
Let's check on Turtle first, said
Kibley.
For a moment, he gazed at the tiny trail
of smoke that was as close as he could
get to Moon right now, and then he
breathed the mirror clear again and
called up Turtle.
Turtles' smoke was dark green, and
somehow radiated sadness, as much as a
wisp of smoke could do that.
It was coiled miserably in the middle of
the mirror.
Kibli couldn't tell if he was asleep or
just sad.
The only sound the smoke made was an
occasional deep sigh.
At least he's alive, Thorn said
hopefully.
Probably in a cell, Winter guest.
No one to talk to.
I hope this isn't our fault somehow.
Ghibli worried.
Like if something I did changed the
future, which led Dark Stalker to figure
out that another animus must be working
against him.
Oh, turtle.
I'm sorry.
That wasn't giving them any information.
So Kibley finally tried Dark Stalker
although even saying Dark Stalker's name
gave Kibley the creepy feeling that the
ancient dragon would somehow hear him and
know he was being spied on.
Dark Stalker's spire of smoke was taller
than anyone else's, and it moved slowly
but purposefully across the obsidian.
Hello?
His voice rumbled, and Kibley saw Winter
take an involuntary step back, as if he
too, feared the night wing might be
looking back at them.
Hello, Dark Stalker said again.
Oh, very nice work clearing the weeds.
Smart thinking.
We should get these gardens going again
so we can feed ourselves.
You haven't received a gift yet, have
you?
I could give you the power to sprout
every seed you plant.
Some kind of master gardener skill.
Wouldn't that be useful?
Um, said a small dark purple wisp that
had unfurled beside his.
I mean, yes, very useful, sir, thank
you.
But I was thinking, something more like
seeing the future.
I guess I've always thought seeing the
future would be cool.
Hmm, said Dark Stalker.
I suppose it is, but you don't really
need you. since I can see the future.
And one seer in the tribe is really quite
enough, whereas we could use lots of
gardeners.
Well, you think it over and we'll talk
again soon.
Wait, said the other dragon.
Sorry, sir, you're right.
I'd love the power you described.
I'm ready for it now.
If you're sure.
Dark Stalker paused heavily.
I'm sure, I'm sure.
Yikes, said Thorn, leaning forward as
Dark Stalker muttered something.
It's that easy.
You want a superpower?
Here, done?
It's that easy.
Kibley said. curling in his claws.
That could have been him, handing out
powers to make dragon lives better if he
had Dark Stalker's scroll.
They listened for a while longer.
The dark stalker seemed to be strolling
through the streets of his kingdom
visiting his subjects.
And no one he spoke with said anything
like, boy, this island, half a day's
flight due west of the scorpion den is
pretty neat.
Or, who would have ever guessed there was
a whole kingdom buried under the
mountains and accessible by a tunnel at
the foot of Scarlet's palace?
Both of which were among Kibli's numerous
theories for where the ancient kingdom
might be.
No one dropped any clues at all.
The only thing Kibli picked up on that
might have been useful was the background
noise of the wind, as if it was whistling
through deep ravines.
So, not underground then.
I think there's only one thing we can do
he said at last.
What's that?
Winter asked.
Go back to Jade Mountain.
Kibli blew away Dark Stalker's smoke, with
a little more vigor than was really
necessary.
We know Kinkaju and Moon will hopefully
be there in a day or 2, or maybe Sonny
and Clay can help us.
He shook his head.
I hate leaving them all wherever they are
though.
I want to get to turtle right now.
And to Moon and Kinkachu, who are in
danger every second.
Last one, Winter said, pointing to the
mirror.
Try tsunami.
She's probably back at the academy.
Khibley said with a sigh.
Most likely she'd arrived at the
rainforest after everyone had left, and
they were too far ahead for her to figure
out where they'd gone.
But he whispered her name to the mirror
and breathed out smoke.
It seemed to take a moment, coiling back
and forth and around, before settling
into a blue spiral in the center, which
immediately started yelling.
I said, who are you?
shouted tsunami's voice, you coward.
Show yourself.
What do you want with me?
She took a deep breath, as if listening
for a response, then roared again, let me
out of here.
My friends are heroes, you know.
You'll be sorry for this.
Thorn's eyes met Kibley's, both of them
shocked into silence.
Tsunami wasn't safely back at Jane
Mountain after all.
The great warrior of the 5 Dragonettes
one of the best and most ferocious
dragons Kibli knew, was somebody's
prisoner.
Chapter 17.
Tsunamis a prisoner?
Queen Thorn said disbelievingly.
But whose?
said Kibley.
And how?
Tsunami?
Of all dragons.
How?
And why?
And who?
Dark stalker, right?
said Winter.
Who else could it be?
He must have had a vision of her coming
with the earrings, snuck off, captured
her, and stuck her somewhere.
But tsunami doesn't seem to know who her
captor is.
Kibley pointed out.
Even if she was blindfolded or drugged
she'd have some clue just from his size
wouldn't she?
He closed his eyes, trying to think, who
else could have tsunami?
Who would dare grab the famous warrior of
the 5 prophecy dragonettes?
What did they want with her?
Dark Stalker did make the most sense?
But it didn't feel like the right answer
to him.
Now we really have to go back to Jade
Mountain, Winter said, standing up.
They must be worried sick about her, and
we'll need their help to find her and
rescue Turtle anyway.
I'll check on glory and the other queens
said Thorn.
She took the obsidian mirror back from
Kibley, clearing its surface, and I'll
start distributing all those earrings you
made.
Thank you, Kibley.
I don't know if it's enough, he said.
Maybe I should leave you the bowl.
There are earrings all over my palace
right now.
She said.
Between them and your sand.
I'm surprised I can see any of my royal
things.
Trust me, it'll be enough for the time
being.
I'll keep the obsidian mirror, but you
might need the bowl.
We should give it an imposing name too.
He said.
The inscrutable bowl of infinite stew or
something.
Thorn wrapped her wings around Kibli and
hugged him tightly.
Go keep saving the world.
She whispered in his ear.
I always knew you would.
Me?
he said, as she let go.
Really?
Yes, she said.
Well, unless you screw up and bury it all
in sand first.
She tapped one of his bracelets.
No more storms, Kibley.
Right, he said. absolutely.
He nodded, unless it's an emergency.
No, she said, use your brain, not someone
else's unreliable magic, or I will hunt
you down and bury you in a sand dune.
Yes, boss, he said. grinning at her.
But he thought about it as they flew
south toward Jade Mountain.
He thought about magic and power, and who
had which and what you were supposed to
do to fight bad guys when you had
neither.
Surely it was better to create an
accidental sandstorm here and there, if
it was all in the name of stopping
villainy.
He needed that magic, any magic at all. to
even the balance.
Not that balance was even possible when
it came to dark stalker.
What else could he do?
How else could Kibli fight or rescue
Turtle?
Ordinary rang in his head.
Small, insignificant, useless.
One scruffy street dragon against the
most powerful dragon in history, and all
the minions he'd given superpowers to.
Winter's flashing silver scales crossed
his peripheral vision, and he glanced
over at his friend.
One scruffy street dragon, and one exiled
prince, plus a fierce little rainbow.
If we can get to her before Dark Stalker
does.
Kibli's wings were tiring by the time
they flew past the scorpion den.
But he didn't want to stop until they
reached Jade Mountain.
The sight of the sprawling den gave him
more of a shiver than ever as he wondered
where Vulture had gone.
Two dark stalker, or back to his
compound.
What's that?
Winter said suddenly.
He pointed to a shape crouched by one of
the small desert pools, barely big enough
to count as an oasis.
They flew closer and saw that it was a
dragon drinking the water.
But not a sand wing.
The coloring was more of a gray blue pink
odd but familiar.
It's anemone, Kibley gasped.
I thought she was with Dark Stalker.
What's she doing all the way out here?
We should stay away from her, Winter said
banking sharply up to a higher air
current.
She practically threw herself into dark
stalker's web.
She's more loyal to him than anyone.
Or deeply enchanted, Kibley pointed out.
She needs to be freed from him as badly
as you did.
Have you forgotten that she's an animus
Winter argued.
And your hideous earrings, only protect
us from dark stalker's spells, right?
She could tangle us right back up, or do
something worse.
It would be idiocy in the extreme to go
anywhere near her.
I think she needs our help, Kibley said
stubbornly.
She's alone in the desert.
Maybe she ran away from him.
Or maybe, Dark Stalker sent her this way
for one of his sinister plans, said
Winter.
Kibli, stop.
What are you doing?
Get back here, you absurdly irrational
dragon.
Kibley ignored him, swooping down toward
the sea wing princess.
He understood Winter's points, but he was
sure Anemone needed help, and that it was
important to free her from dark stalker
if they could.
In addition, she was a promising link to
dark stalker in the knight kingdom.
He just had to hope he could charm
anemone into putting on an earring.
He wheeled around to approach her from
the front, so he wouldn't startle her.
She looked up at the sound of his wing
beats, and to his surprise, her whole
face lit up.
Does she actually know who I am?
Is winter right?
Did Dark Stalker send her looking for
me?
Wow.
Kibley said, landing with a splash in the
shallow water beside her.
It's not every day a sing wing princess
looked so happy to see me.
He couldn't help grinning back at her.
Dragons who smiled at him, dragons who
seemed to actually like him, he could
never resist them.
But anemone didn't say anything.
Instead, she sat up, waved her front
talons in the air, and frantically
pointed at her snout.
Something's wrong, Kibley realized out
loud.
Is it?
Wait.
He stepped closer.
Staring at something she held in a death
grip with her claws.
Is that turtle stick?
He'd only seen it once.
Briefly, when Turtle had been rearranging
things in his pouch, before he left for
the rainforest with Moon and Dark
Stalker.
But he knew the importance of the stick
Turtle had enchanted to hide him from
Dark Stalker.
And this one anemone was holding, had the
same aura to it.
Uh, don't notice me, but I'm everything.
Aura.
Anemones wings drooped, and she nodded
miserably.
So that's what happened, Kibley said.
That's how Dark Stalker knows about
turtle, because you have his hiding
stick.
Did you take it from him?
Her head snapped up and she scowled at
Kibley?
Why can't you talk?
Kibli walked slowly around her.
Her silver neck band, the one that was
supposed to protect her soul, was missing
and she was covered in scratches, as
though she'd been in a fight very
recently.
Had she fought Turtle to take his stick?
Had Turtle cast his spell to stop her
from speaking?
It was sort of hard to imagine turtle
fighting anyone, or coming up with a
useful spell on his own.
Sorry, turtle, Kibley thought with a
wince.
He wished he could stop himself from
having thoughts like that about Turtle
who was a good dragon at heart.
It wasn't Turtle's fault that the
universe had given him magic instead of
Kibley, or that he was sort of terrible
at using it.
Anemone let out a frustrated growl
splashing her tail in the water.
She pointed to her mouth again, then used
the stick to ride in the sand in big
wobbly letters, Dark Stalker spell.
Oh, Kibley said, we can fix that.
Anemone, look.
He had taken a few earrings from Thorn's
stockpile.
Now he dug in his bag and pulled one
out.
Just put this on.
It'll cancel any spells that Dark Stalker
is put on you and protect you from any in
the future.
Anemone reached for it hesitantly, but
paused, studying him.
It's safe, I promise, he said.
If she had turtles stick.
She must know by now that her brother was
an animus.
He hoped anyway.
He didn't want to be the one breaking
that news to her.
Turtle enchanted it.
He made one for me.
See?
Kibble pointed to his own ear.
I asked him to protect me from Dark
Stalker's magic.
That's all it does, I swear.
The look of hope on her face was
heartbreaking.
Which was a strange feeling to have for
the sea wing princess, who had always
been kind of a brat to everyone.
She took the earring delicately between 2
claws and stared into the amber for a
moment.
Kibley felt his heart jumping nervously
as she lifted it and affixed it to her
ear.
Her blue eyes were as big as full moons.
Did it work?
She said, and then gasped, clapping her
talons to her snout.
Looks like it, Kibley said, beaming.
I can talk.
She shouted.
I'm free.
Let's go kill that evil son of a slug.
Whoa, hang on.
Hang on.
Kibley said, catching one of her wings
before she could take off.
Tell us what happened.
All we know is that Turtle's been
captured by Dark Stalker.
Us?
Anemone echoed.
She looked up at the sky and spotted
winter.
Kibley waved to him to come down, and
winter reluctantly descended, looking
wary and disgruntled.
As he did, Anemone leaned over and
grabbed one of Kibley's forearms.
Hey, she said, these are my bracelets.
Oh right, he said.
Sorry.
Um, we needed them and you just left them
behind, so we thought you wouldn't mind.
Well, you can give them right back, she
said, flicking her claws demandingly at
him.
He felt a twinge of outraged
possessiveness.
Why should I give them to her?
She left them at school.
She didn't even care about them until she
saw I had them.
She has plenty of magic, but this is all
I have.
I want to keep them, he said.
I mean, for now.
Until we deal with dark stalker.
Please?
He gave her a charming grin in exchange
for my very fashionable earring.
That earring looks even worse on her than
it does on me, Winter announced, splashing
toward them.
Doubtful, said Anemone.
I can pull anything off.
She tossed her head.
Besides, I'd wear a necklace of dragon
bite vipers, if it meant I was free of
dark stalker spells.
Her large blue eyes narrowed at Kibley
for a moment, as if she was looking at
him through a jeweler's glass, examining
all his flaws.
Fine, she said finally.
You can keep the weather bracelets.
For now.
Thank you, Kibley said.
So what happened?
Winter asked.
What are you doing all the way out here?
And why did Dark Stalker enchant you to
stop talking?
Kibley asked.
He did worse than that, Anemone
admitted.
He enchanted me to obey his every
command.
Like the spell on his father.
Winter said shuddering.
You're lucky you're still alive.
Oh.
Turtle gave you his stick, didn't he?
Kibley realized, to protect you from that
spell.
Once you were erased from dark stalker's
mind.
He couldn't control you anymore.
Or at least he could, but only if he
somehow remembered you were there.
Wow, said Winter.
Yeah.
Anemone drew the stick in toward her
heart.
I know, I know.
It was super brave of him, but can we
save the mushy stuff for after we killed
Dark Stalker?
You could kill him right now, can't you?
said Winter.
We can end this right here.
One spell from you and zap.
He's dead.
Anemone shook her head with a little
snarl.
I would, believe me.
But he told me none of my spells will
ever work on him.
He's protected himself against my magic.
The same way these protect against his, I
guess.
She touched the earring in her ear.
And you couldn't cast any other magic
like freeing yourself, because he can
sense animus spells being cast, Kibley
said.
You're in the same current as Turtle
was.
You don't want to do anything that will
make him notice you.
Yes, I do, Anemone said ferociously.
I want to make him notice me by stabbing
him in the eyeball.
I am suddenly seeing the family
resemblance between you and tsunami
Winter remarked, who is also in danger
Kibley said to Anemone.
Someone has her prisoner, but we don't
know who.
Um, of course we do, Anemone cried.
It must be Dark Stalker.
He hates all sea wings because of Fathom
especially my family, because we're
descended from him.
She jumped into the air, nearly whacking
them both in the face with her tail.
Now we have to rescue my brother and my
sister.
You can tell me as we go, let's talk and
fly, talk and fly, slow pokes.
Where are we going?
Winter asked.
Stepping back as Kibley jumped aloft with
a princess.
To the lost city of night, Anemone said.
To fulfill the prophecy, Kibley said
gleefully, to save the world.
To kill dark stalker, anemone cried
hooray.
Chapter 18.
Winter argued with them all the way to
the night kingdom, across the miles and
miles of desert they flew over, heading
southwest.
Listen, this is all very enthusiastic, he
said.
The dark stalker is literally impossible
to kill.
Invulnerability spells immortality, and
he can see the future.
He must know we're on our way right now.
Not me, Anemone said, holding out the
stick.
He can't see me in his future, so I'm the
one who gets to kill him.
She's got a point, Kibley said.
You and me?
We're just going to see Moon and
Kinkaju.
Got that winter?
Keep it in your head.
That is our goal.
We're not going to alter the future in
any way that would threaten Dark
Stalker.
We're just going to find our friends.
And give them protective earrings.
He thought, hopefully, I'm coming, Moon.
I'll be with you soon.
But you can't kill Dark Stalker, Winter
said again.
No ordinary method of killing will work
on him, and your magic is useless against
him.
So let's start by rescuing Turtle, Kibley
said, and hopefully tsunami, if she's
there too.
Maybe Turtle's magic will still work on
Dark Stalker.
Not a chance, said winter.
Your positive attitude is my favorite
thing about you.
Kibley said to him.
And your long-term planning is my
favorite thing about you, Winter snapped
back.
Why can't we have a plan?
Just once.
If you have too much of a plan, it'll
show up in Dark Stalker's view of the
future, Anemone observed.
C, so it's actually better to wing it
said Kibley.
Ha ha.
Dragon pun, wing it.
I'm hilarious.
He did a little flip in the air.
His heart was soaring as high as his
wings.
They had an animus on their side now.
One who is hidden and safe from Dark
Stalker's magic.
They had a guide to the kingdom of night
and they'd be there soon.
And he was flying toward Moon at last.
Everything felt possible, even defeating
Dark Stalker.
I really think we should go to Jade
Mountain first.
Winter protested.
We should tell the other prophecy
dragonettes, in case something happens to
us.
No, Anemone said bossily.
The more time we give dark stalker to see
us coming, the more prepared he'll be to
stop us.
When did you start to see him clearly?
Kibley asked.
Turtle cast a spell to take all of Dark
Stalker's spells off me, she said.
We were in the middle of a fight, so I
didn't really realize what I was feeling
at first, but when I was able to stop and
think, I could see that he wasn't the
wonderful, all knowing mentor I'd been
looking for.
I saw that I'd done some kind of awful
things to try to make him like me.
She looked down at the dunes flashing by
below them, and then she told them
everything that had happened.
How Dark Stalker had won over most of the
night wing tribe in the rainforest, how
they had agreed to follow him to the old
kingdom.
How she'd cast a spell to wake up
Kinkajou.
That was you?
Kibley interrupted.
You healed her?
Anemone hesitated.
Yes, she said awkwardly.
It was turtle's idea.
I guess he couldn't do it without dark
stalker noticing, but, but what?
Kibley asked.
Nothing, Anemone said.
She's doing great.
Safest Dragon Empirea.
Dark Stalker won't hurt a scale on her
head because she's Moon's best friend.
She lifted her chin haughtily.
Khibli let a few moments of silence
pass.
He had a feeling there was something
anemone didn't want to tell them.
All right, she said finally.
Here's the thing.
I kind of, Had a fight with Moon, and
Dark Stalker kicked me out.
A fight with Moon, Winter said sharply.
What did you do to her?
Is she all right?
Khibli asked.
She's fine.
Anemone growled.
Everyone is so obsessed with her for no
reason.
It was only a little bitty spell.
The Dark Stalker totally freaked out and
sent me home to kill my mother.
What?
Kibli cried.
Stop interrupting and listen, said the
princess.
She told them about the fight, how Dark
Stalker was always worrying about Moon
and listening to her and caring about her
instead of anemone.
So Anemone tried to do a little spell
that would make him care about anemone
more.
But it backfired, and so she had gone to
the kingdom of the sea to get a weapon
that would kill Queen Coral.
But I didn't, she said quickly, seeing
the looks on their faces.
I don't even know if it was me who really
wanted to kill her, or if Dark Stalker
enchanted me to want to somehow, she
said.
I mean, I grew up thinking I would have
to, you know?
And I was so angry by then.
It just felt like the right thing to do
but turtles stopped me.
She described a flat out animus fight on
a beach, spells exploding all around
them.
That's what tipped Dark Stalker off.
Ghibli thought.
Not anything I did, or not just what I
did.
Maybe both together.
The spells, and then the future changing
when we saved the ice wings.
And then she told them how Dark Stalker
had summoned them back into his throne
room, cast his obedience spell on anemone
threatened Kinkaju and uncovered turtle.
But how Turtle had thrown her his stick
at the last moment, casting its hiding
spell around her instead of him.
He told me to look for you, she said to
Kibley.
So I ran away, as fast as I could.
I don't know what happened to turtle
after that.
She scrunched up her snout, as though she
was having a lot of feelings she didn't
particularly want to deal with.
He's still alive, Kibley told her.
We know he's in a cell or something like
that.
I'm sure he's all right.
I don't think Dark Stalker would kill him
if he could find a way to use him
instead.
Winter had been flying in an odd pattern
for a few minutes, sweeping away and
above them, as if he was surveying the
land below.
Now he pulled up on anemones left
frowning in his brooding, aristocratic
way.
Princess, he said, where exactly are you
taking us?
The old knight kingdom is south of those
mountains, she said, pointing to a range
of tall peaks in the near distance.
On the Talon Peninsula?
Khibli asked, picturing the map of Pyria
in his head.
But it's so small.
There's no way a whole tribe could have
lived there.
That was one of the theories he'd had and
dismissed, studying the map with Moon
while they were in possibility together.
It used to be bigger, Anemone said with a
shrug.
Earthquakes, avalanches, tidal waves
something, something, blah, blah, blah.
Dark stalker was a little melodramatic
about it, to be honest, like, roar, where
did my kingdom go?
But like, what did he expect?
I mean, he's been gone for 1000s of
years.
Of course it's different.
Anyway, the drive is small enough to live
there just fine for now.
And he was already muttering about
pulling rocks out of the sea and
rebuilding the whole place with his
magic.
She made a grumpy, huffing sound with her
nose.
I was supposed to help him, but I'm
certainly not going to now.
Kibli suddenly realized that winter had
fallen behind them.
He paused in the air and turned, hovering
to face his friend.
Winter.
Everything all right?
I can't go there, Winter said.
Why not?
Hibley asked, startled.
It's cursed.
Winter waved a talon at the sharp edged
shapes of the mountains.
No ice wing has ever returned from those
mountains alive.
They're a legend as old as dark stalker
in our tribe.
With a poetically ominous sounding name, I
bet, said Kibley.
Peaks of Doom, mountain range of certain
death.
Winter frowned at him.
We call them Dark Stalker's teeth.
He said, with immense dignity.
Seriously?
Kibley cried.
A mountain range called Dark Stalker's
Teeth, and you never thought maybe the
old night kingdom was on the other side?
It's not like I think about it very often
Winter objected.
And no, honestly.
We all assumed he went around cursing
random parts of Pyria as traps for ice
wings to fall into.
What are we waiting for?
Anemone demanded, flying back to them.
Winter thinks the mountains are going to
eat him.
Kibley answered.
I do not, Winter protested.
But I do think they're going to kill me
yes.
Um, a whole horde of dragons just flew
over them a few days ago.
Anemone flicked her tail at the evening
sky, dimming to purple, and there, all
fine.
Because they're not ice wings.
Winter pointed out.
The mountains only eat ice wings.
Kibley explained, with a straight face.
Stop that, Winter hissed at him.
It's a real curse.
If it's real, then it's not a curse.
It a spell, Kibley said practically.
And if it's a spell, then dark stalker
cast it, in which case the earring will
protect you.
Winter touched his ear doubtfully.
One piece of jewelry, against centuries
of nightmare stories.
Kibley could practically see Winter's
courage trying to stamp out his childhood
fears.
You'll make it through, he said.
Remember, moon is on the other side.
He knew that would work, because it was
working for him.
Winter gave him a puzzled look, as though
he would never understand Kibley.
Yes, he said.
All right, let's fly.
Finally.
Anemone grouched, wheeling about in the
sky.
As they flew through the shadowy peaks
with darkness stretching long, thin claws
around them, Kibli did sort of wish
winter had kept his ghost stories to
himself.
But nothing reached out to grab them.
No ancient spells dragged them screaming
into the perilous ravines below.
And at last, they flew up behind a
towering palace, and saw the ruins of the
night kingdom, now dotted with flickers
of firelight, as though dark stalker had
spread his wings out to welcome his new
tribe, and each flame was one of the
starlike scales against the black.
She's here.
She's close.
Hible's heart thumped painfully.
So, king of winging it, Winter asked, are
we sneaking in, or do we knock on the
front door?
We can go in through the room he offered
me?
Anemone suggested.
No one will be in there, since it's dusty
and dreadful and unfit for dragon
occupation, let alone a princess.
She swept huffily up the walls of the
palace to a dark balcony.
Kibli and Winter followed as she hopped
off the balcony rail, and crunched
through debris into the deserted room
beyond.
As Kibley had expected, it was 9 times
the size of any room he'd ever lived in
even at Thorn's palace.
He breathed out a small flame so he could
look around.
True, it was a little run down now, but
he can imagine how beautiful it must have
been all those centuries ago.
It looked as though it even once had a
running fountain over in the corner.
His fire reflected off something on the
floor next to the tiled fountain pool.
He picked his way carefully over to it in
the dark, and then breathed out again to
find it.
He had expected some kind of treasure, but
it turned out to be a strange looking
little contraption, like a telescope, with
an hourglass attached, but an odd
hourglass, with black sand on one side
and white sand on the other.
He picked it up and studied it in the
moonlight.
Was this some kind of advanced machine
the Nightwings had built, and then lost
all knowledge of over the last 2,000
years?
What did it do?
Hey, fire breather, Winter said gruffly
do something useful and light this for
us.
He shoved a torch under Kibley's nose.
Khibley was too absorbed in the little
machine to make a crack about royal ice
wing manners.
He absent-mindedly lit the torch and then
peered through the miniature telescope in
winter.
It seemed to work like a regular
telescope.
But then, what was the hourglass for?
Oddly, when he tipped the whole thing
upside down?
Nothing happened to the sand inside the
hourglass.
One side held white sand, the other black
and although they shifted around inside
their bulbs, the grains of sand never
drifted to the other side or mingled
together.
Maybe it was broken.
Strange.
Kibley said.
You mean boring, anemone said with a
yawn.
The princess seemed to be listing
slightly to the side, and he remembered
that she was younger than him and his
friends.
When was the last time you slept?
Kibley asked her, tucking the telescope
hourglass object into his bag so he could
study it later.
I...
Can't remember?
she said.
Do that first, he said, handing Winter
the torch, and nudging her toward a
blanket that had been left inside the
door.
No, she whispered loudly.
I want to go kill Dark Stalker.
And rescue turtle?
He prompted her.
Right, she said.
I'm very busy.
I don't have time to.
She stumbled over the blanket and flopped
onto it.
Maybe just a little nap.
She sighed as her eyes closed, and she
curled into a ball.
Don't go anywhere without us.
Kibley whispered in her ear.
She mumbled something that sounded like
go sit on a reef.
Right said Winter.
She'll definitely be gone when we get
back.
Have a little faith in your fellow royal
Hibley said with a grin.
Ready to explore?
Winter nodded, and they crept out into
the hallway.
The palace was massive and imposing, but
they could hear music coming from
somewhere.
So they followed that until it grew
louder, and they saw lights glowing up
ahead.
The corridor they were in turned out to
lead to a long colonnade, encircling and
overlooking a courtyard, which, at
present, was full of dragons mingling and
chatting, beasting and dancing.
All around the courtyard, like sentinel
ghosts from the distant past, were
statues of dragons in black marble, in
various heroic poses, all of them with
diamonds for eyes.
Four night wings were in one corner
playing instruments Kibli had never seen
before.
It was silvery, cheerful music, but
without the driving excitement of any
drums.
The smell of food wafted up, from long
tables around the courtyard, fried
bananas, and roasted sweet potatoes and
wild boar, all taken from the rainforest
Kibley guessed.
Winter and Kibli crept forward, staying
low, until they spotted Dark Stalker
sprawled across an unmistakable throne
wearing a spiky crown on his head.
Kibley hadn't seen dark stalker in days
and in his mind, the ancient night wing
had grown bigger and scarier and more
menacing every minute.
It startled him to see how normal dark
stalker looked in reality, bigger than
everyone else, yes, but not cackling with
power, or dripping with blood, or glaring
dangerously down at his cowering
subjects.
He looked friendly, at peace, even a
little bored.
His tail flicked occasionally in time to
the music, and he kept glancing around
the courtyard, like a host who'd invited
all the wrong dragons to his party.
Khibli searched the crowd intently, but
he couldn't see Moon or Kinkaju
anywhere.
Is it time, yet, your majesty, called a
tall, bony nightwing from the center of
the crowd.
All faces immediately turned toward Dark
Stalker, as though he were the sun.
Kibley hoped he didn't look like that at
Thorn.
There was loyalty, and then there was
this, this other thing, something more
desperate and grasping.
The night wings had nothing for so long
he thought.
Remembering the brief glimpse he'd had of
the volcanic island where they'd lived
for the last 2000 years.
They lost their homes. their status, their
powers.
They want dark stalker to give them back
everything they think they should have.
They want power to be dropped on them
magically, because they think they
deserve it.
He inhaled sharply.
But isn't that what I want to?
All right, Dark Stalker said, waving at
the musicians, who all dropped their
instruments and leaned forward in the
eager silence that followed.
You're all very lucky.
Once again, I have found a way to hand
out 10 gifts tonight.
Nightwings clasped one another's talons
and whispered excitedly.
Although, Dark Stalker went on in a
cautionary tone.
Again, in order to make that work, I had
to prepare the gifts ahead of time, so
these can't be individually chosen, I'm
afraid.
These are for dragons, who can be happy
with whatever they're given.
He stood up and beckoned and a bristling
female dragon came striding out of the
shadows, carrying a basket of silver
bracelets.
She plunked it down next to Dark Stalker
and gave him a rebellious face.
Thank you, be his teeth, he said
politely.
Let's see.
Is our guest here?
Oh, yes, there you are.
Come watch.
I think you'll be impressed by this.
Hible somehow new in his bones who it
would be, and yet, he still felt a pit
opening in his stomach, as he saw his
grandfather slither forward to stand
beside Dark Stalker.
Who's that?
Fierce teeth asked.
What's a sandwing doing in our secret
kingdom?
It doesn't have to be a secret anymore.
Dark Stalker pointed out.
We can have normal allies and trade
routes now.
And this, Sandwing, may be our hope for a
truly loyal and helpful ally to the North
which we'll need when the ice wings
decide to unfairly attack us, as my
visions say they might.
Welcome, vulture.
Vulture's eyes were avidly scanning the
courtyard.
Cataloguing Dark Stalker's wealth in his
head, Kibli guest.
He ducked lower, unable to avoid the
feeling that vulture's obsidian gaze
would snatch him up, no matter how well
hidden he was.
These bracelets, Dark Stalker announced.
Like the ones last night, bestow the
powers of super strength and
invulnerability on anyone who wears
them.
Pretty exciting, don't you think?
Now, who wants one?
Me, shouted several dragons in the
crowd.
Me, me!
At least 20 of them started pushing
forward. clawing their way to the front.
The other night wings fell back to leave
a space for the combatants, watching with
laughter, or cheers, or hisses.
Dark stalker watched too.
A small smile curving the arch of his
mouth, as his subjects began brutally
fighting at his feet.
Eventually, the ground was littered with
defeated, groaning challengers, and only
10 dragons were left standing.
They were still bleeding and gasping for
breath as they staggered forward to the
basket.
But once the bracelets snapped around
their wrists, each one stood taller.
His or her wounds healed.
A new surge of power seemed to ripple
through their muscles.
Together, they threw their wings back and
bowed to dark stalker.
Kibley's eyes met Winters, and he saw his
worst fears reflected in the ice wings
pale blue eyes.
Dark Stalker was preparing for war with
the ice wings, and creating an army of
super soldiers to kill them with.
Chapter 19.
Kibli couldn't watch this anymore.
He couldn't stand seeing Vulture this
close to dark stalker, the 2 of them
chuckling together, like best friends
plotting to tear apart the world.
Let's check the gardens for moon, he
whispered to winter.
On a night as clear as this, he had a
feeling she would be outside under the
stars.
I want to watch him a bit longer.
Winter said, flicking his tail at dark
stalker.
In case he says anything else about
fighting the ice wings.
Hibley hesitated.
He didn't want to leave Winter alone, but
he felt something tugging him toward Moon
like he was a broken vase, and she was
the piece that would fit him all back
together.
All right, he whispered.
He slipped away from the balcony edge.
Meet you back in Anemone's room.
Winter nodded absently.
His breath had left small traces of frost
on the stonework of the railing.
Kibli followed the breeze he could feel
wafting through the corridors until he
reached a grand staircase that swept down
into the terraces of gardens.
At least, he could tell that there used
to be orderly terraces around the levels
of the palace, but the plans had rioted
in the last several centuries.
Vines and ivy had wrapped their way
around the stonework a 100 times over.
And it was hard to tell where the gardens
were supposed to begin and end anymore.
He stopped for a moment, looking up at
the moons.
And then suddenly he got a strong
horrible creeping feeling along his spine
like someone was staring at him from one
of the shadows.
Like he was being watched.
He was definitely being watched.
He vaulted quickly over the railing, and
into a large leafy bush.
Acidly fragrant flowers assaulted his
nose as he tried to calm his breathing.
He couldn't see anyone.
No night wing guards appeared, no super
soldiers with enhanced sight, or whatever
other magical abilities dark stalker
might have thrown around.
The staircase was silent.
The shadows were still.
And yet he was sure. something had been
watching him.
Something that could still be out there
waiting.
Some one.
He corrected himself.
There's no such thing as ghosts.
There are no vengeful spirits haunting
this palace.
I am not hiding from a phantom.
In these ruins, though.
It was all too easy to imagine something
unearthly, whispering through the
crumbling halls.
Khibli crept through the greenery, as
soundlessly as he could, keeping close to
the wall where the vegetation would hide
him.
The prickling feeling in his scales
slowly subsided, and he breathed a sigh
of relief when he finally reached a spot
out of sight of the staircase.
He rounded the corner and collided head
on with a very sturdy bit of empty space
empty space that yelped with joy and
tackled him as he staggered back
dizzily.
Kibli!
cried the empty space.
You're here.
You're really here.
Shh.
A pair of invisible talons closed around
his snout, and he felt the flutter of
wings around his face for a long moment.
All right, he's still there, she
whispered.
But keep it down, would you?
The talons retreated, as Kibley muffled a
laugh.
Kinkaju?
He whispered.
I hope.
Oh yes, it's me.
She said softly.
An outline of her wings and face
shimmered into view briefly, before her
scales shifted back to camouflage.
I'm investigating a suspicious
character.
Suddenly, her talons wrapped around his
mouth again.
He just turned around.
Hmm, mmm, mmm?
Khibley inquired.
She tipped his head toward a half tumbled
tower that rose out of a swarm of ivy by
the edge of the terrace.
He spotted a dragon snooping around the
base of the tower, picking up anything
that glinted.
I was on a mission, Kingachu whispered.
Exploring the palace, just like that
intrepid detective in the scrolls moon
was helping me copy back at school.
And then I saw the weirdest thing.
A mud wing.
Here, in the old night kingdom, just
sauntering around the palace, like it was
his own personal swamp.
Kibley stared alertly at the distant
dragon.
A mud wing.
It has to be bog.
He must have come with Vulture.
So I followed him, she said, very
stealthily.
It was awesome.
You'd be so impressed, and Nanny went
into a room and closed the door.
And I stood there thinking about ways to
keep spying on him.
But then the door opened and out came a
night wing.
Well, that's not so weird, right?
So I waited until the night wing was
halfway down the hall.
And then I zipped into the room because
he left the door open, and guess what?
The mud wing was gone.
I guess out the window?
But I couldn't see him anywhere.
So I figured I'd follow his friend over
there.
He's kind of a big honking night wing, I
have to say, and a little boring.
All he's done is steal little crumbs of
treasure wherever he can find them.
Yep, bog, or rather, in this form
shapeshifter.
He tapped her claws and she let go of his
snout.
Kinkaju.
He whispered, don't freak out.
But I'm pretty sure.
That's the dragon who attacked you in the
sky kingdom.
Little splashes of startled orange
appeared in the air as Kinkajoo's scales
reacted.
No way, she whispered.
The one who can change shapes?
Pearl's dad?
Oh, right.
Kibble had actually managed to forget
that part of it.
Turtle told you about him?
He sure did, she said fiercely.
I owe that guy a few broken bones and a
coma.
We were hoping he'd disappear forever
after we took Dark Stalker's scroll away
from him.
Kibley whispered.
But now he's working for my sinister
grandfather, and pretending to be a
mudwing.
We need to take away his shape shifting
spells.
On it, said Kinkachu.
Kibli pounced at the empty air and
managed to catch her tail before she
darted away.
Not by yourself, he said.
He's enchanted this shape to have extra
strength and super hot fire, something.
Maybe in vulnerable scales too.
We do not want to get in a fight with
this version of him, if we can help it.
Aw.
Kinkaju said.
Can't I just spit a little venom in his
face?
I think your stealth mode is what we need
here.
Kibley said.
Sorry.
Face full of venom can be plan B. All
right, fine.
So I sneak up and grab, what am I
grabbing?
He carries his transformation spells
inside pieces of jewelry in a brown
leather pouch.
Last time I saw him, it was tied under
one of his wings, so it won't be easy to
get.
And then he'll also be wearing something
containing his night wing spell.
He squinted at the moonlit dragon.
The good news is, he's wearing a lot less
jewelry now than he was before.
But it could be anything.
I see an earring, 3 bracelets, a ring, and
a couple of necklaces on him.
It's the earring, Kinkachu said
confidently.
He was wearing all that other stuff when
he was a mudwing.
The earring is what's new.
Khibli tried to give the empty air a
skeptical expression.
I was being a detective, she said.
I was being super observant.
I mean, okay.
I missed the part about how he was
actually the exact same dragon, but I did
notice the matching treasure.
I just thought the mud wing had handed
over all his jewelry for some reason.
It's not like that makes less sense than
he shapeshifted into a whole other tribe
of dragon.
The earring, Kibley murmured.
All right.
All I can think of is I distract him and
you try to lift the pouch.
We might not be able to get the earring
but at least he'll be stuck with only one
form instead of seven.
You distracting him doesn't sound very
safe.
Kingachu pointed out.
I'll be fine.
We have a solid plan B, right?
He grinned. and had the unique experience
of sensing that the air was grinning back
at him.
Shapeshifter had found something in the
ruins of the tower, and was exhaling
little bits of flame so he could peer at
it.
Ghibli let the branches crackle under his
feet as he approached, and the night wing
whirled around.
His face contorted angrily.
You again, he snarled.
I come in peace, Kibley said quickly
spreading his wings.
I just want to talk.
That would be wise, said Shapeshifter.
This form could snap your neck as easily
as breathing if you come any closer.
Oh, Kinkachu.
Please be so careful.
Sure.
All right, Kibley said.
I'll stay right here.
I just wanted to ask whether you're ever
planning to see peril again.
Why should I?
Shapeshifter snorted.
She betrayed me.
She turned me into Queen Ruby, and then
she helped you all steal my scroll.
To be fair, Kibley said.
You really kind of betrayed her 1st.
But she betrayed me more, he complained.
Besides, she doesn't want to see me again
either.
I don't know about that.
Kibley said.
I told her I ran into in the kingdom of
sand, and she asked me to give you
something, if I saw you again.
Yeah, right.
Shapeshifter took a step toward him
squinting.
What is it?
Just an earring, Kibley said.
He held out one of the amber and gold
earrings.
Shiny and warm on his palm.
It's not as fancy as your other treasure
I know.
But Pearl felt bad about what happened.
She wanted you to have something that
would make you think of her.
He forced himself to keep breathing
normally.
Shapeshifters stomped another few steps
closer, and studied the earring with an
avaricious gleam in his eye.
Kind of small, he muttered, not very
sparkly.
He frowned at Kibley.
Looks like yours.
I bought them both at the same shop and
possibility.
He said.
She couldn't touch it herself, obviously
or it would melt, but she said to get one
just like mine.
Seems like a pathetic peace offering.
After what she did.
Shapeshifter grumbled softly to himself
for a long, anxiety inducing moment, but
the lure of treasure, any treasure, was
too strong for peril's father to resist.
He snatched the earring out of Kibley's
talons and immediately put it on.
Tell her I don't forgive her, though, he
snapped.
Tell her this isn't over, and I still
I...
Hey.
What's happening?
He flared his wings, which had rippled
suddenly from black to lime green.
And Kibley saw a blur of movement in the
air, as his pouch was quickly sliced away
and vanished behind Kinkachu's back.
No!
Chameleon roared.
Now, fully transformed back into his real
self, who was much scrawnier and less
intimidating than any of his false
shapes.
This was a trick, you lying sandwing.
He reached up to the earring, but Kibley
lunged forward and seized his talons.
I'm sorry, he shouted.
Over the thunder of chameleon beating his
wings around Kibley's head.
Pearl let you keep your shapes because a
part of her still loves you, even after
what you did to her, but we can't trust
you with them.
Chameleon let out a yell, and Kimley
looked up to see that the silver earring
was gone from his other ear.
Nice work, Kinkachu.
You can't do this to me.
Chameleon hissed, snapping his jaws at
Kibley's face.
I'm nothing without my shapes.
You can't leave me as a useless rain
wing.
Where am I supposed to go?
Go back to the rainforest, Hibley
suggested.
Queen Glory is very fair.
She'll take care of you.
I would never, Chameleon started.
And then a chunk of stone from the tower
above them came toppling down and cracked
him on the head.
Chameleon's eyes rolled up, and he
slumped to the ground unconscious.
Kibley blinked down at him, then up at
the tower.
Whoa, he said, that was Awesome.
Kinkachu finished, popping into view on
the tower.
I thought so.
She bounded down from the ruins and
landed beside him, beaming.
You were perfect, he said.
I still think he deserves a face full of
venom, she said.
But yeah, that wasn't bad.
You were perfect too.
I mean, I'm not quite sure what you did
but it was very impressive.
He hugged her.
It's so great to see you awake.
He said.
I was so, so worried about you.
Pshaw!
Me?
I'm too tough to be taken out by a super
strong shape shifting traitor face.
Kinkaju said brightly.
Her scales had turned the most startling
shade of lemon yellow splashed with
pink.
Plus, I can't die because I'm like Queen
Glory's best friend and she needs me.
And Moon needs me to keep her head on
straight, and we have to stop Dark
Stalker and rescue Turtle.
I know, he said, we will.
Do you want to hang on to those?
He pointed to the pouch of shapeshifting
jewelry.
Or we could destroy them now.
When Chameleon wakes up, he might come
looking for them.
Then I'm definitely keeping them, she
said, twisting around to tie it under her
wing the same way he'd had it.
I am absolutely up for having a heated
discussion with this dragon anytime he'd
like to try me.
He smiled at her.
So, what heroic feat should we perform
next?
I am still working on finding out where
Turtle is being held, she said.
You should go find Moon and convince her
to leave with us as soon as possible.
Do you think you can do that?
Kibble's heart thumped as if it was
flipping over.
Where is she?
He asked.
Down there.
Kinkachu pointed to the square far below
the palace.
Kibli saw a torch flickering, and a
figure carrying that torch, who slipped
into the vast building across from the
palace.
It's Moon.
She's right there, right there, right
there.
Go on, sort her out, Kinkachu said, and
her eyes were mischievous, like she'd
read exactly what she expected to on his
face.
I'll see you soon.
She let her scales shimmer back into the
colors of the background.
That tugging was taking over Kibley's
heart again, and a moment later, he was
soaring down toward the square, his wings
skimming the tops of the wild palace
trees.
Chapter 20.
There were 4 large structures forming the
sides of the plaza, including the
palace.
This particular one had tall columns
across the front that were carved to look
like scrolls holding up the roof.
In the moonlight, Kibli could see that
letters were etched into each column, but
the moons weren't bright enough for him
to read any of their writing.
One of the columns had cracks all around
the base, and another column had broken
in half and toppled over.
But for such an old building, it seemed
more intact than a lot of the others.
The doorway yawned emptily.
Whatever Dora had once been here had
either rotted away or been taken for some
other purpose, more riding was carved
into the lintel.
Something about knowledge and flames and
darkness, as far as Kibli could tell.
He stepped cautiously inside, hoping
there weren't other, less friendly night
wings lurking in the shadows.
The glow of firelight was coming from one
of the rooms off the central hall.
As Kibley tiptoed up to begin.
He realized suddenly what this building
was, and then he felt like rather an
idiot for not guessing sooner.
It was a library.
The biggest library in the world, most
likely, if every room was like the one
that was lit up.
The walls in here were lined with slots
for scrolls from floor to ceiling, and
the ceiling was pretty far overhead.
A vast wooden table filled the center of
the room, so large it couldn't have fit
through the doors.
Most of the slots were empty, but up by
the ceiling, a dragon was flying from one
to another, pulling out the few scrolls
that were left.
She was humming quietly to herself, and
the light gleamed off the silver teardrop
scales by her eyes.
It is her.
Kibli felt as if he could breathe again.
For the 1st time in days.
He listened to the song she was humming
for a moment, and then he stepped over to
the table and began lightly drumming on
it with his claws, in rhythm with her
music.
It took her a moment to notice, but
finally she whirled around, looked down
and saw him.
The expression of joy that flared across
her face, nearly made his heart burst.
He wanted to make her smile like that
every day.
He wanted to feel like this forever, like
a dragon who was welcomed and missed.
And maybe something else he didn't dare
put into words.
No way, she cried, always away.
He answered, smiling back at her.
Kibley.
She stuck the torch into a holder near
her and soared down, landing in a run
that threw her into his wings.
He caught her laughing, and not crying
not crying.
You're real, he blurted.
I was starting to feel like I'd imagined
you.
Inside the dome of his wings, her talons
took his, and she leaned against him, a
mystery of cool scales and strong muscles
and beating heart.
He bent his head toward her, letting hope
wash over him.
How are you here?
She asked.
Well, he said.
I figured, check every library in Pyria
and you'll run into moon eventually.
She laughed and looked up at him, her
eyes shining.
Isn't this place amazing?
Wouldn't you live here forever if you
could?
No, Hibli thought, in these cold halls
away from the sun and the sky.
Only if you asked me to.
And then he thought, would winter say
yes?
Doesn't that make him the better dragon?
Come see, Moon said, tugging him toward
the shelves.
She led him around in a whirl of
excitement, describing the old
classification system, the archives, the
collections each room used to hold, and
the giant index scrolls that used to
contain the entire catalog of books in
the night wing library.
The tribe took as much as they could, but
they left so much behind, she said, and
we have to be so careful.
I mean, scrolls are not supposed to last
2000 years.
Some of these are just fragments or dust
but some are beautifully preserved.
We've started copying the most important
ones, quick, before they fall apart.
There's so much history here.
She said dreamily.
I haven't seen you this excited since the
librarian possibility, he joked.
That one was great too, she said
especially because it had scrolls from
all the tribes.
Do you remember we even found that really
old rain wing scroll?
Of course, Kibli remembered.
He remembered that Moon had shrieked loud
enough to bring a stern Skywing librarian
bustling over, to grump about how hopping
up and down was not allowed in the
library.
This much excitement about scrolls is
strictly forbidden, he said, in an
imitation of the sky wings pinched voice
and he remembered this too, the way moon
collapsed against him and giggles after
the librarian left, exactly as she was
doing now.
Why would you be a librarian if you don't
get excited about scrolls?
she cried.
I will never understand some dragons.
I wish I could find them this exciting, he
admitted, a little nervously.
She tilted her chin up to look at him
then reached up to touch his face.
Not everyone has to be a scroll worm.
For you.
Other dragons are like scrolls.
You love meeting new ones and trying to
read them.
You're always thinking about how other
dragons think, and what they're like on
the inside.
That's what, I mean, that's one of the
interesting things about you.
She pulled back suddenly and looked
down.
Sorry.
I know you don't like hearing about what
I overheard in your thoughts.
I don't mind anymore, he said, catching
her talent.
I mean, if you don't mind what a mess it
is in there.
Or the mean thoughts I have sometimes.
If she has looked all the way into me and
still wants to be my friend, maybe I'm
maybe I'm actually worth something.
Least messy brain I've ever met, she said
smiling and squeezing his claws.
She doesn't seem enchanted at all.
She seems exactly like herself.
But we haven't talked about Dark Stalker
yet.
Moon whacked his side with her wing.
You're distracting me with library talk
she said.
How did you really get here?
I shouldn't tell her about anemone?
He realized, just in case.
He didn't want to lie to her, but he had
to, at least for now, for anemones
safety.
You're not going to believe it, he said.
Winter remembered that the ice wings call
those mountains out there dark stalker's
teeth.
So we thought, huh, maybe the lost city
of night is on the other side.
And here you all are.
That's why I'm here.
She said.
I mean, in the library.
I'm still trying to figure out the
prophecy.
We found the lost city of night.
So now what?
Is Jade Mountain saved?
Or is there something here we're supposed
to get, or read, or figure out?
Maybe something that fathom or clear
sight left behind?
But I can't find anything about what
happened to his friends afterward.
Kibley tilted his head at her.
It was a relief to discover she was still
worried about the prophecy.
And kind of cool that she'd had the same
thought he did, that maybe Fathom or
Clearsight had left something for them.
He'd expected that dark stalker's
bewitching would make her think
everything was absolutely fine, like
everyone else did.
I can help you look, he said, but I, um, I
have kind of a weird request first.
Everything about my life has been weird
since school started, she said, give it
your best shot.
The amber teardrop of the earring glowed
like a captured ball of fire, reflecting
the light of the torch up above them.
Kibli cupped it in his talons for a
moment, wishing he could add more armor
to the spell for her, and then he held it
out for her to see.
Moon blinked at the earring, then at
him.
Matching earrings?
She said curiously.
Is this a sandwing thing?
Are we?
Um, does this mean they're enchanted?
he said quickly, before she misunderstood
any further.
There's a protection spell on both of
them.
All of them.
There are others.
Oh, she said.
Did she seem disappointed or relieved?
Maybe in brighter light, he would have
been able to tell.
What kind of spell?
I asked Turtle to make me immune to any
spelled dark stalker casts, Khibli
confessed.
It protects me from his magic, and this
one can protect you.
Now she definitely looked sad.
I hope I don't need that, she said, but
she lifted the earring out of his claws.
He promised not to cast any spells on
me.
I want to trust him.
Even if you trust him.
Isn't it better to be safe?
Just in case, Kibley asked.
It's like the Skyfire.
We trust you.
But you gave it to us anyway, so our
thoughts would be private.
He might cast a spell accidentally, or
think he's trying to help, but it's
something you don't actually want, you
know?
I do.
She touched the amber gently with one
claw, then reached up and put the earring
on.
Just like that.
He'd expected more arguments.
He'd worried that dark stalker's spells
on her would be so strong, they'd repel
any effort to fight them.
But there she was now, safe, with a tiny
sun on her ear.
Kibley smiled.
It's a weird feeling, right?
He said.
Doesn't everything feel different?
Like the air around you was full of smoke
and now it's all blowing away and
everything is clear.
She gave him a funny look.
No, she said slowly.
I don't feel any different.
She glanced around the library and shook
her head.
I really don't think I had any dark
stalker spells on me, Kibley.
I've been confused since he came out, and
I'm still the same amount of confused
now.
He's a complicated dragon.
I know that.
But I don't think he's evil.
I really don't.
He's my friend.
Khibli stared at her in astonishment.
It sank in slowly.
She's not bewitched.
She genuinely likes him.
His understanding of dark stalkers
shifted around, like a puzzle box
clicking into a new configuration.
Because he genuinely likes her.
I bet he wanted to have one dragon in the
world who likes him for real, not because
of a spell.
She's important to him.
They're really friends.
But she doesn't know everything he's
done.
Can I tell her?
Is it safe?
Dark Stalker can still read her mind.
Anything I tell her, he'll find it
there.
The spell on winter, the threatening
kinkaju, imprisoning turtle.
The plague killing the ice wings, his
alliance with a vulture.
Will it put her in danger if he realizes
she knows about all of that?
I need to find Skyfire for her.
Then I can tell her everything.
He shivered suddenly with a realization.
As soon as he sees her, he'll know about
the earrings too.
Don't worry, Kibley, Moon said.
We're together now.
We can figure out the prophecy and save
Jade Mountain.
I'm sure of it.
She clasped his talons.
Her face lighting up.
Oh, and the best thing ever happened.
Kinkaju's awake.
She's all right, Kibli.
I know, he said.
That's awesome.
And winter's here too.
He watched her face intently for a
reaction, but she just looked happy.
Happier than she'd been to see him, or
the same, did she feel anything more for
either of them?
He couldn't tell.
Our wing lit, she said with a smile.
Now we just need turtle.
The smile faded from her face.
I haven't seen him for days.
There was a, a problem with anemone.
I know about that too, he said.
You do?
she said.
How?
A soft thumb from outside interrupted
her.
They both turned toward the door, and
Kibley heard talon steps, slowly
approaching through the central hall.
He reached out to twine his tail around
moons, carefully, carefully.
The way sand wings always had to because
of their venom barbs.
He remembered the crawling feeling of
being watched by something in the
palace.
But it was no ghost who poked his head
into the room.
It was Dark Stalker.
There you are.
He said cheerfully to Moon.
That party was so boring without you.
Don't worry, I get it.
You don't like parties like that.
Clearsight, didn't love them either.
He transferred his smile to Kibley
looking thoroughly unsurprised to see
him.
Welcome to the Night Kingdom, Kibli.
I was wondering when you'd show up.
I didn't think you'd be able to wait very
long before coming to find Moon.
Dark Stalker winked, and Kibley wondered
if he looked as flustered as Moon did.
This is a really cool library.
Kibley said quickly, spreading his wings
to indicate the vast space around them.
So, am I supposed to call you your
majesty now?
Dark stalker shrugged.
You're not one of my subjects, so it's up
to you.
He wriggled his shoulders slightly.
King dog stalker.
It's weird how it kind of feels exactly
right and kind of doesn't fit.
And then he froze suddenly, with his ears
pricked, as if he was listening to
something.
A small frown crossed his face.
He stepped forward and ducked his head
way down to peer at Moon.
New earring, he said flatly.
He shot a sideways glance at the one in
Kibley's ear.
He knows, Kibley thought, with a twist of
fear in his heart.
Don't be sad, Moon said, meeting Dark
Stalker's eyes.
You know, it's just a precaution.
You do the same thing, if our situations
were reversed. wouldn't you?
Hmm, said Dark Stalker.
It just Reminds me of a bracelet I made
for someone once, because she didn't
trust me.
Which, turns out, should have been the
other way around.
You promised not to put any spells on me
or my friends, Moon reminded him.
So these shouldn't make any difference.
She tapped the earring with her claw.
I promised, your friends would always be
safe.
Dark Stalker corrected her.
What if you get attacked, and I need to
heal you, like I healed stone mover.
What if Kibli gets kidnapped, and I can't
get him back for you?
And all the beautiful magic I've made.
No more dream visiting.
I was going to fly you to one of the
moons.
Dragons standing on an actual moon, can
you imagine?
Let's see what happens, Moon said.
Kindly but firmly.
Dark Stalker swiveled his head to focus
on Kibley.
His gaze was intense, and yet Kibley got
the impression that Dark Stalker was
looking through him as well.
Like he could see all the Kibleys that
had ever existed, and all the ones that
might ever be.
He's checking my future.
Ghibli didn't know if it would do any
good, but he banned all his willpower
toward imagining the future he wanted
most.
And a future that would alarm Darkstalker
the least.
A future where Kibley was a loyal advisor
to Queen Thorn, living in the Sandwing
Palace, with Moon.
She appeared in his vision without him
realizing it at first.
He was imagining walking the palace
grounds, and there she was beside him
brushing his wing, and they were flying
over the desert, laughing, and they had a
suite of their own that she filled with
scrolls.
He couldn't delude himself that Dark
Stalker would really find this idyllic
dream in Kibley's actual future.
But hopefully, he'd see only Kibley
trying to help Thorn, and nothing about
Kibley trying to stop Dark Stalker's
plans.
He wished he knew more about how future
seeing worked.
Unexpectedly, Dark Stalker chuckled.
He dipped his head to Kibley, as if he'd
just eaten a particularly delicious goat
that Kibley had caught for him.
Well, do what you feel you have to do.
Dark Stalker said to Moon, sounding much
more cheerful.
Can you come outside for a moment?
I want you to meet someone.
He turned and padded away, swinging his
tail back and forth to some music in his
head.
That was the most ominous thing I've seen
him do yet.
Kibli thought.
What did he see in my future?
Why did it make him stop worrying?
Moon gave Kibli an amused shrug.
Like, well, that went better than I'd
hoped.
She flew up to get her torch, and they
went out through the central room, through
the arched doorway, and into the moonlit
square.
Dark Stalker had paused by one of the
scroll like columns, as if he'd been
arrested by the side of something ahead
of him.
The expression on his face.
The closest Kibley could get to
describing it, was the way winter looked
at moon sometimes.
A beautiful black dragon was walking
through the toppled statues and overgrown
weeds of the square.
Her wings reached out to brush across the
stones, as if she needed to touch them to
believe they were real.
She looked up and saw them, and saw Dark
Stalker, and Kibley thought, okay, that
is what seeing someone you love looks
like.
Moon, Kibli, Dark Stalker rumbled.
I'd like you to meet Clear sight.
Chapter 21.
Moon reacted first.
While Kibli was still trying to fit Dark
Stalker's words into something that had
meaning and reality.
He could hear music playing from the
distant palace, eerie and remote, like it
was actually coming from the stars.
Clearsight?
Moon said, in a startled voice.
Clear sight.
Like, The clear sight from 2000 years
ago?
My clear sight, yes. said Dark Stalker.
He reached out one of his talons, and the
night wing came forward to take it
smiling at him.
A gust of wind swept down from the
mountain peaks, blew through the square
paused for a moment, and then diverged
around the 2 dragons, as if it didn't
dare disturb them.
That's not possible.
How is that possible?
Moon took a step closer, blinking at the
new dragon?
How could it be possible?
Kibley's mind began hypothesizing.
Maybe he enchanted her to be immortal too
all those centuries ago, which seems like
something he would do.
But then, where has she been all this
time, lurking around the ruins, waiting
for him to return?
Is she the presence I felt watching me
earlier?
Or perhaps it wasn't Dark Stalker.
Maybe Fathom did something to keep her
alive, or to bring her back to life if
Dark Stalker ever returned.
That would be an interesting plan.
Maybe she's what we were supposed to find
in the lost city of night.
The only dragon who has ever been able to
stop Dark Stalker.
He studied her, hopefully.
Was this the meaning of the prophecy
revealed at last?
Hmm.
She doesn't exactly look like she's
planning to stop him from doing anything
right now.
She looks more like she'd happily set the
world on fire if he asked her to.
It's nice to meet you, Moon, Clearsight
said sweetly.
Dark Stalker has been telling me all
about you and how you helped set him
free.
That's not exactly, Moon hesitated.
How are you alive right now?
she asked.
Why wouldn't I be?
Clearside blinked large, dark eyes at
Moon.
How she's alive isn't important, said
Dark Stalker, who looked as though he'd
found literally all the treasure in
Pyria.
What's important is that she's here now.
She can rule the tribe with me.
We're getting married tomorrow.
That's right, said Clearside, with a
dreamy expression.
Dark Stalker doesn't look surprised
Kibley realized abruptly.
Even if he had a vision of this.
Shouldn't he still be surprised to find
his long lost love here?
This should be a miracle.
Not to mention, she's the one who
betrayed him and trapped him under that
mountain.
He should be surprised and mad at her.
Instead, he looks...
Triumphant?
Married?
echoed Moon.
After everything that happened with, The
bracelet and the murder?
All forgiven, said Dark Stalker, looking
at Clearsight fondly.
There was a pause, while Clearsight gazed
affectionately back at him.
And you, Kibley prompted her.
You forgive him too?
For what?
She asked.
Dark stalker, Moon said incredulously.
What?
I mean, yes, of course, said Clearsight.
I forgive him too.
Moon and Clearsight regarded each other
with mutual confusion for a moment.
Your visions of the future are
legendary.
Moon said slowly.
I'd love to learn how you do it.
How you can send your site down each
possible path and study all the futures
at once.
Oh, Clearsight said, flicking one of her
wings at a moth flying by.
You know, I'm not really interested in
studying the future anymore.
I'd rather live in the present.
Moon wrinkled her snout at clear sight.
Seriously?
You?
She's a little different after 2000 years
that's all.
Dark Stalker said hurriedly.
This is better though.
She always worried about the future too
much.
Now she won't worry, and we can just be
happy.
And everything will be fine.
He nods to one of her wings with his, and
she nodded, smiling.
But, I still, how?
Moon started.
Enough questions.
Clearsight is tired.
Dark Stalker announced.
I'm going to show her around our palace
and find her a royal suite of her own.
Please, join us for breakfast in the
morning.
We're all going to be great friends.
You can come too, Kibley.
He ducked his head at Moon and Kibley
then put one wing around Clearsight to
steer her back across the square.
She waved brightly to them, and a moment
later, the 2 black dragons were soaring
up to the palace together.
Nope, Moon said to Kibley, as soon as
they were gone.
Nope.
No, no, no.
This is not happening.
What is happening?
Very weird things, he agreed.
More than weird.
Clearsight is suddenly back from the dead
with a personality of a sun-dried
tomato?
Maybe she was always like that?
He said.
We don't know.
I know, Moon protested.
I've been reading everything I can find
about her.
I found papers she wrote in school and
stories written about her by a friend
named listener.
Clearsight was brilliant.
Maybe the most brilliant night wing who
ever lived.
No one's ever been able to navigate
multiple futures in their visions the way
she did.
She flapped her wings at the looming
palace.
That's why Dark Stalker loved her.
He wouldn't love someone like that.
Maybe she's just waking up, Kibley
tried.
Or maybe she's manipulating him to change
the future.
I was thinking, she might be the heart of
the prophecy.
The one we're supposed to find in the
lost city of night.
Moon twisted her front talons together
thinking, That might make sense, she said
finally, if she can warn us about
something so we can stop it, but she
didn't even want to talk about the future
or her prophecy gift.
She shivered, and Kibley sidled closer to
give her the warmth of his scales.
I'm just worried, she admitted.
Something about this worries me.
I mean everything.
Everything about this is super weird.
Why wouldn't he tell us where she came
from?
Khibli could imagine a few reasons, but
all of them would only worry Moon more.
I should get back to winter.
He realized out loud.
You'll be wondering why I've been gone so
long.
Yes, Moon said, flaring her wings.
Don't be selfish, Kibli.
You wanted to make her smile.
If taking her to winter would make her
happy.
Isn't that what you want?
I'll get Kinkaju, and we can all
brainstorm about the prophecy, and maybe
you can talk her off whatever moon she's
on.
She won't tell me what's wrong.
A dozen new anxieties stampeded across
Kibley's mind.
He did want to talk to Kinkaju about what
had happened to Turtle, but he couldn't
do that in front of Moon.
He also couldn't take Moon to Anemones
room, because Anemone was there.
Dark Stalker wouldn't be able to hear any
thoughts Moon had about the Sea Wing
princess, but to explain why she was
there, they'd have to tell Moon about
Turtles' imprisonment, and that would
show up in her thoughts.
R, mind readers.
I'll get winter and come to you, he
suggested.
How will we find you?
I'll mark our balcony, she said.
You'll know it's ours.
All right, he said, spreading his wings.
See you soon.
Kibley, she said, and he stopped short of
launching, turning to her with his
momentum instead.
Her smile was all the moons and the sun
together, warm as gold coins on desert
sand.
I'm really glad you're here, she said.
And I think our matching earrings are
pretty cool.
Me too. he said, with an answering grin.
It was strange, he reflected, as he flew
back to the castle, how it could feel
like the world was falling apart, and yet
he could still be happier than he'd ever
been before.
Except there was winter.
Winter, who also loved Moon, who became
his best self around her.
Winter, Kibli's friend.
Save the world first.
Sort out complicated feelings later.
When he reached the balcony, which took a
few moments, finding the correct one
Anemone was still asleep, curled in the
blanket and breathing peacefully.
Winter was pacing the length of the room
twitching his spiky tail back and forth.
You've been gone a long time.
He said to Kibley.
I found her, Kibley said softly. glancing
at anemone.
Come with me.
They flew out from the palace and banked
around, so Kibley could scan the
balconies.
Listen, he said to Winter, as they
wheeled about in the sky.
Be careful what you say to Moon, all
right?
She doesn't have Skyfire for her own.
Dog stalker can read her mind as easily
as a scroll.
So I haven't told her about turtle, or
the ice wings, or anything else.
She thinks we're just here to figure out
the prophecy, and it has to stay that way
until we can find a way to shield her
thoughts.
Do you understand?
I hardly think I need a lecture on
discretion from you, Winter said.
Kibley spotted movement on one of the
balconies.
Wings unfurling, and then incandescent
patterns spilling across them, like the
glow in the dark stripes on a sea wing
but spiraling across her scales.
Kinkaju, he said, nudging Winter.
They dove for the balcony.
As they got closer, Kinkachu saw them and
waved excitedly.
Kibli adjusted his trajectory and speed
so he could swoop right into her, catching
her in his front talons, and tumbling her
backward into the room in a giant hug.
She erupted and giggles as they slid and
crashed into a pile of cushions.
Ah, sorry, he said, helping her up.
Are you kidding?
I wish everyone said hi to me that way
she said, shaking out her wings.
Kibli turned toward winter and moon, and
immediately wished he hadn't.
They were just looking at each other.
But winter had a way of looking that any
tragic hero would die for.
His face was full of such tortured
longing that even Kibley wanted to go
wrap his heart in furs to protect it.
That's what I should have done.
He thought sadly.
I should have tried to put how I feel in
my eyes like that, instead of joking
around her like a goofy friend.
Why would she ever choose me when she
could have that?
And how can I even fight for her?
Knowing what it would do to winter if I
won.
I can't believe you 2 are here.
Kinkajud chirped, breaking the spell.
She bounded over and gave winter a hug as
well.
Oh, brr.
I forgot how cold you are, she said
jumping away from him and whacking
herself with her wings.
I'm very relieved to see your fully
recovered, Winter said to her.
I know, it's awesome.
She said.
Anemone totally healed me, except it's
also not awesome because she also, and
you, Winter said to Moon, smiling.
He reached out to touch the earring in
her ear.
Although we can all agree these are
hideous.
At least you're free now.
I don't think they're hideous.
Kinkaju interjected.
Hey, wait a 2nd.
Why does everyone have a matching earring
except me?
Is this some kind of secret club thing?
Can I be in it?
Why aren't I in it already?
Moon's smile had faded.
And she was giving Winter a concerned
look.
What do you mean?
I'm free.
Of Dark Stalker's evil spells.
Winter said.
You see what he's really like now.
He paused.
Don't you?
I wasn't under any evil spells.
She said, taking a step back from him.
He's just my friend.
Your friend, Winter exploded.
What is wrong with you?
He backed away from her, lashing his tail
until it knocked over an antique looking
vase on a side table.
Kinkachu jumped to catch it but missed.
The porcelain shattered at her feet
scattering white petals and pointed
shards in a spreading puddle of water
around her claws.
Kinkachu looked down at it with a
helpless expression.
Winter didn't seem to notice.
How can you even consider being friends
with someone who's completely evil, he
shouted at Moon.
He's not evil, Moon flared, before Kibley
could step between them.
I think he's really trying to do the
right thing.
He just does it differently than we would
sometimes.
Why are you so mad?
I thought you said you would give him a
chance.
Her front talons suddenly flew up to her
snout, as if she'd been struck by
lightning.
She turned to Kibley with an anguished
expression.
Oh, no.
He wasn't.
Brainwashed?
Winter said fiercely.
Bewitched?
Did I have my mind taken over by your
friend?
Is that what you're wondering?
The answer is yes.
This dragon you like so much used his
magic on me, Moon.
You knew right away.
She said to Kibley.
But Dark Stalker promised.
He only promised we'd all be safe
remember?
Kibley said.
Hey, he probably thought everyone would
be safer if winter was enchanted to like
him, instead of trying to start fights
all over the place.
I mean, if I had a spell that would make
winter like me.
This was the wrong thing to say, he
realized immediately, Winter whirled
toward him hissing.
Don't you trivialize this.
Winter growled.
Don't act like what he did is normal or
acceptable.
He was trying to make me adore him
against my will, changing my thoughts and
my feelings, like I'm just a character in
the story he's writing about himself, like
nobody else is real except him.
If that's something you would seriously
do, Sandwing, then we can never, never be
friends.
Khibli opened and closed his mouth.
Even when he'd been at his most worried
about winter, there had still been a
small part of him that thought the basic
idea of Dark Stalker's spell was all
right.
A spell that can make everyone like him?
Would that be so terrible?
He hadn't thought of it as something
completely selfish.
You're right, he said quietly.
I'm sorry.
Winter turned to Moon as if he was ready
for her apology too.
She met his gaze for a moment, then
folded her wings and crouched beside
Kinkaju, helping her pick up the broken
pieces of the vase.
Don't move, she said to the rain wing.
You'll cut your feet.
I pretty much think he's evil too, said
Kinkaju.
I'm sorry, Moon.
She rested one of her wings lightly on
her friend's back.
Moon looked up at her, then over her
shoulder at Kibley.
But I've seen good in him, she said, and
I've heard it in his thoughts.
He has this vision of a peaceful future
where everyone in Pyria is safe and
happy.
He wants to make sure it happens.
I believe that's what he really wants.
Tell me something.
Winter said harshly.
Are there any ice wings in this blissful
future?
She blinked at him, uncomprehending.
Of course there are.
Winter, Kibley said, in a warning voice.
No, there aren't.
Winter snapped.
Because he just sent a magic plague to
kill every single one of them.
Winter, Ghibli cried.
What did we just talk about?
Did you really not understand me?
You can't tell her stuff like that.
What?
Moon started to stand up and let out a
yelp, as one of the vase shards stabbed
her palm, a line of blood welled up
bright red against the black scales.
She has to know, Winter insisted, as
Kibley grabbed one of the dark green
blankets from the closet bed and ripped
off his wath.
She has to understand how dangerous he
is.
Kibli crossed to Moon, took her talon
gently in his and wrapped the bit of
cloth around the wound.
This was the side of winter he didn't
like, the angry, self righteous side.
It was the only thing that made him
wonder if winter was good enough for
Moon.
How could he yell at her the way he did
if he really loved her?
I do want to know, Moon said, touching
her snout to the top of Kibley's head.
I want to know everything.
But it puts everyone in danger, Kibley
said anxiously.
He tied the bit of blanket together so it
would stay, and met Moon's eyes.
You don't have Skyfire.
I don't know where to find more.
Dark Stalker already knows about the
earrings from your thoughts.
Now he'll know we know about the ice wing
plague too.
I don't know what that'll make him do.
Her talent was trembling between his.
So it's true?
He really did that.
An ice wing plague.
Yes, said Winter, a spell that would kill
every ice wing in Pyria.
Except winter or any hybrids.
And I guess we don't have confirmation
that it was him.
Kibley said, trying to be honest.
Winter shot him a glare.
But we're pretty sure.
I feel sick, Moon said, sitting down and
pressing her talons to her eyes.
We have to do something, Kinkachu said.
Can't we save them?
We have to make him stop the spell, or
find another animus who can.
It's all right, Kibley said.
We think we've stopped it.
If it was a spell from Dark Stalker.
They should be cured now.
He tugged away one of Moon's talons from
her face so she could see him smile.
We sent them 100s of my hideous
earrings.
So the entire ice wing tribe is in the
secret club?
Kinkaju said, huh, I don't get it, but
I'm still offended.
They're protection spells, Kibley
explained.
They make us immune to dark stalker's
spells.
You can have one, but I think turtle
already made you immune, didn't he?
That's true.
She said.
I don't know what to do now, Kibli said.
Moon, I think we have to get you away
from here before Dark Stalker sees you
again.
That won't be necessary, said a voice
from the window.
I have Skyfire.
Chapter 22.
Princess Anemone stepped regally through
the doorway from the balcony, delicately
avoiding the puddle of water from the
broken vase.
She had a new makeshift pout tied
securely to her chest, which Kibley guest
must have the enchanted stick inside.
Anemone.
Kikachu snarled.
In the most un rainwing like voice, Kibli
had ever heard her use.
She arched her back, turning an ominous
dark red.
Calm down, fruit eater.
Anemone said snottily.
I'm not here to hurt moon.
I'm here to help.
She turned over her wrist and poked
around under the silver and sapphire
bracelet she was wearing.
A moment later, a small glittering black
rock popped out and rolled into her
talon.
Turtle gave me this right before Dark
Stalker summoned us back here, Anemone
said, holding it up.
But as long as I have turtles stick, Dark
Stalker can't read my mind anyway.
So I guess Moon can have it.
She tossed it to Moon, who caught it
awkwardly between her good talent and her
injured talon.
There.
Now we're even.
I'm still really mad at you.
Kinkaju said to Anemone.
You know why.
Anemone arched her eyebrows at the angry
rain wing.
I do?
Wait, turtles stick?
Moon echoed.
Why do you have it?
What do you mean Dark Stalker summoned
you back here?
It's...
Kind of a long story.
Kibley said, but now you can hear it.
As long as you hold on to that skyfire
and don't let Dark Stalker know what you
know.
Make it snappy though, said Anemone.
I'm ready to go rescue my brother.
Khibli hurried through it as fast as he
could.
The slate with the messages from Turtle
his trip to the kingdom of sand, and what
he'd discovered about vulture, typhoon
and the news about the ice wings.
Anemone told her part, about the fight
with Turtle, and the scene in Dark
Stalker's throne room.
And finally, Kinkaju told them the end
about how Dark Stalker had decided to put
turtle in his dungeon, and then enchanted
Kinkaju to forget everything she'd seen
in the throne room.
Except, of course, it didn't work, she
concluded, because Brave, noble, handsome
turtle protected me.
And if I sound a little strange about it
that's because this sea viper over here
put a love spell on me.
She bared her teeth at anemone.
Oh.
You know about that?
Anemone said.
I can't believe he told you.
Turtle is such a doofus.
He's a hero with a really kind heart, and
I can't even tell if I really think that
because of you.
I am so mad at you, I could drown you in
venom.
Anemone edged away from her.
If you do that, I won't be able to rescue
him, she said, and I'm his only hope.
No, I'm his only hope, Kinkachu flared.
Dark Stalker can't see me in his future
either.
He thinks I'm completely insignificant, so
I'm going to save Turtle.
Are you all right?
Khibli asked Moon, who hadn't spoken in a
long time.
Just thinking about what to do, she
said.
Wrapping another strip of blanket around
her talon.
Anemone.
Can you take the spell off, Kinkaju?
I guess probably, anemone said, in an
annoyed voice.
But I can't right now, because if I cast
any new animus spells, Dark Stalker will
know it, and we've already had one
horrible hidden animus unveiling.
Or, I mean, she could drop her rock from
turtle and maybe the spell would go away
but that's the same rock with all the
other spells on it, so she probably needs
to hang on to that.
Kinkaju growled at her.
Well, at least you know how I feel, Winter
said to Kinkaju, unlike these two, he
waved one of his wings at Kibli and
Moon.
I feel lied to, Moon said sharply.
I feel like there's a whole side of Dark
Stalker, he's been hiding from me.
I'm just not sure what we're going to do
about it.
Well, I'm going to get turtle, Anemone
said, sailing toward the door.
No, I'm going to get turtle.
Kinkaju cried.
She ran after the princess and threw
herself in front of the door.
Why should any of us trust you?
You've been using your magic so much, you
probably don't have any soul left.
Anemone stiffened, her wings snapping
back.
I think you should both go, Moon said.
It sounds like you're the only ones who
can, at least safely, without dark
stalker realizing what's happening, and
you might need each other's help.
I would eat my tail before I accepted any
help from her, Kinkachu said, scowling at
anemone.
I don't mind if she tags along, Anemone
said, with a little flick of her wings
but I think we should go now, before dark
soccer changes his mind and decides to
get rid of Turtle.
Kinkaju let out a little squeak of fury.
You just try to keep up with me.
Her scales abruptly switched to
camouflage, and she vanished against the
backdrop of the wall.
The air around the door blurred as her
camouflaged talons opened it, and she
whisked out into the hall.
Anemone rolled her eyes, so mature, like
you know where the dungeon is.
She stomped out after Kinkachu.
Look for tsunami while you're down there
Kibli called, as the door swung closed.
Yeah, that's definitely going to go
well.
He realized awkwardly that he and Moon
and Winter were alone.
Do they wish I would leave?
So they can finish fighting and forgive
each other with a big romantic scene.
Winter didn't look as though he was
feeling very romantic.
He paced the length of the room, winding
between the 2 beds, the chests on the
floor, and the little side tables piled
with scrolls.
Please don't break anything else?
Moon said to him.
Kibley, come with me.
Me?
he said.
Where are we going?
To talk to Dark Stalker.
You stay here she said to Winter.
What?
No, Winter said.
That's a terrible idea.
See, that's why you're staying here, she
said, going to the door.
Kibley?
Kibley gave Winter an apologetic shrug
and hurried after her.
He could kill you, Winter protested, or
he could take your earring, and cast a
spell to make you kill us.
You have no idea what he's capable of
Moon.
I do now, she said, but he won't kill
me.
There are some true things about him, and
that's one of them.
You still think you can trust him.
After all the evidence, Winter said
wearily, at least let me come with you to
protect you.
I'm afraid you'll protect me by attacking
him as soon as you see him, she said.
Trust me, stay here, and think about the
prophecy.
We'll be back soon.
She held the door open for Kibley.
Winter flung himself down on one of the
beds, his face an icy mask that hid his
feelings.
He didn't meet Kibley's eyes, or respond
to his wave goodbye.
Khibli waited until they were at the
other end of the corridor before he said
quietly to Moon.
I have to admit, I don't not think this
is a terrible idea.
Talking to Dark Stalker, Moon said.
It's the right thing to do.
I want to see what he says when he's
confronted with his lies, and I want to
hear how he's justified the ice wing
plague to himself.
I think I'm one of the few dragons left
he'll at least try to be honest with.
I mean, about himself, and his reasons
for what he does.
Unless I'm completely delusional about
our friendship.
But I think he wants me to agree with him
so he can feel like he's doing the right
thing.
I think that's true, said Kibley.
But if you don't agree with him?
I'm not sure how long you'll stay his
favorite dragon.
The other thing is, Moon said, I'm hoping
this will distract him long enough for
Kinkachu to get turtle out of the
dungeons.
If he's arguing with me, he won't be
studying the future and seeing it
change.
She froze suddenly, midstep, and crumpled
forward, clutching her head, her wings
pressed close around her like a scarab
shell.
Moon, what's wrong?
Kibley crouched beside her, stretching
one wing over her back.
What's happening?
She didn't answer for a long moment, and
then she grimaced and sat up, rubbing the
spot on her forehead between her horns.
Speaking of visions of the future.
She said.
What did you see?
he asked.
The same thing as always.
She sighed.
Lightning flashing, an avalanche crushing
dragons, jade mountain cracking and
falling, everybody dying.
I've been having it a lot in the last few
days, awake or asleep, with the words of
the prophecy repeating over and over
again.
Does that mean it's going to happen
soon?
Khibli asked.
All I know is it means we definitely
haven't stopped it yet, she said, even
though we found the lost city.
That's something else I want to talk to
dark stalker about.
I worry he might be the thing that
destroys Jade Mountain, but I don't
understand how or why.
They were walking again now, down yet
another black marble corridor.
Khibli wondered if Moon had already
memorized the layout of this confusing
place.
His room is just up here, she said
picking up the pace.
But when they knocked on the door, nobody
answered.
I hope he's not in the dungeon.
Kibley whispered.
Let's check the throne room, she said.
He's got natural night wing tendencies.
He prefers to stay up all night and sleep
during the day.
If he sleeps at all.
Maybe he's working on something.
The throne room was also empty, as was
the courtyard where the feast had been
held earlier that night.
They kept walking through the quiet
palace, and Kibli, oddly, felt his hope
returning.
There was something about being alongside
moon.
It reminded him of the days they had
spent, just the 2 of them, in possibility
looking for clues about the old night
kingdom, and waiting for Kinkachu to get
better, or winter to return.
They'd walked the streets together then
too.
They'd tossed ideas back and forth, and
studied maps, and taken turns reading to
their unconscious friend.
Being with Moon felt to him like a
concentrated version of being an outlaw.
Like being on a team with someone who
really cared about you, who worked with
you, and made your own brain work
better.
Finally, they heard a voice coming from
one of the smaller council rooms on the
top floor of the palace.
They crept toward it, listening.
It was dark stalker.
No, no, no, he said.
That's not right.
Back up.
They hurt his claws.
Scraping the marble, and the slither of
tails on the cold stone.
Start over.
All memories intact.
Up to the day before she took off the
earrings.
Hey, you, said Clearsight's voice.
Have you seen Fathom Anywhere?
Stop, said Dark Stalker.
That's worse.
They were close enough to peek into the
room now.
It was empty except for dark stalker and
clear sight, with a wall of open windows
overlooking the city below.
A scroll was laid out on the floor.
Dark Stalker stepped over to it and made
a note in green ink.
Clearsight stood watching him with a
patient expression.
The memories are the tricky pot.
Dark stalker said, half to himself, but
no memories at all is useless.
Okay.
He went over to Clearsight, and placed
one talent on the top of her head.
B Clearsight, with all her memories, up
until the day after she met me, but with
no powers, completely in love with me.
No worries about the future at all.
She closed her eyes for a moment, then
opens them again and smiled at him
adoringly.
Whoa.
Are we in the palace?
How did we get here?
By all the moons?
What happened to you?
she asked, blinking at his size.
She went on without waiting for a
response.
You know what's weird?
My visions don't seem to be working.
Isn't that funny?
It's very relaxing.
Maybe we should go to the beach today.
She glanced out one of the windows.
Hmm.
There seems to be something wrong with
this city.
Did you notice?
Oh, well, I'm sure it's nothing.
Clear sight, said Dark Stalker.
Will you marry me?
I'm going to rule the night wings, and I
want you to be my queen.
She laughed.
You can't rule the night wings.
We have a queen, remember?
Her name is Vigilance.
But sure, I'll marry you.
If it makes any difference to the future
I can't tell.
Such a weird feeling.
Dog stalker growled.
Freeze.
Clearsight stopped moving.
Frozen in the middle of a laugh.
Maybe it's not the memories, Dark Stalker
said, leaving a smudge of green ink on
his face as he tapped his snout
thoughtfully.
Maybe.
Maybe your power was one of the things I
loved about you.
Even if it was spectacularly annoying
sometimes.
He sighed. fine.
Be clear sight, with all her memories, and
an understanding of what's happening now
but only able to see the good futures
where everything turns out perfectly.
Unfreeze.
Clearsight didn't move for a moment.
She stared out the window, reaching
toward the ruins visible below.
Dark stalker, she whispered.
What happened?
It doesn't matter, he said.
It's all in the past.
We're together now.
We can be happy.
Ruling the night wings?
She said, disbelievingly.
After everything you did, they...
Stop, said Dark Stalker, and she froze
again.
This is awful.
Moon whispered to Kibley.
I don't even understand, Kibley whispered
back.
It's like she's not real.
He's, he's rewriting her over and over
again.
She isn't real, Moon agreed, or at least
she's not really clear sight.
He must have made her somehow.
Be clear sight, dog stalker said, now
visibly frustrated, exactly as I knew her
but without any nagging, or worrying, or
pessimism, or telling me what to do, and
what's wrong with me all the time, by all
the shining moons.
He seized the scroll and ripped it into
shreds.
Go on.
Be her.
Oh.
Poor dog stalker.
Clear aside said soothingly.
Don't you fret so much, darling.
You're just perfect.
You'll be a wonderful king.
Why isn't this working, Dark Stalker said
to her.
Why does being with you feel so wrong and
weird?
He slumped to the floor and buried his
face in his talons.
I really miss you, Clearsight.
I'm right here, she said gently.
Not you.
Freeze.
She stopped with one wing around him.
The real you, he said miserably to the
floor.
What am I doing all this for?
If I never get to be with you again.
That's the dragon I see, Moon whispered
to Kibley.
Underneath the other dragon.
You're right, Kibley said to her.
Underneath the brainwashing genocidal
murderer is a very lonely, brainwashing
genocidal murderer.
All right, I know, I get it, she said.
But this is the right time to talk to
him.
Stay close.
I'll be right here, he said, brushing her
wing with his.
I'll always be close if you need me.
She took a deep breath and stepped into
the room.
Chapter 23.
Dark Stalker looked up and started
violently at the side of moon.
What are you doing here?
He said.
Why didn't I hear you coming?
He touched his head for a moment, then
gave her a searching look.
Are you all right?
I can't reach you.
I'm using Skyfire.
Moon said.
Skyfire.
Protection spells.
He said, looking genuinely wounded.
Moon.
Aren't we friends?
I thought so. she said, but then I found
out you've been lying to me, and doing
some really terrible things.
He raised his front claws to his forehead
again.
Oh, the futures are wavering, Moon.
The futures where we're not friends.
Those aren't good futures for anyone.
His eyes drifted to the side, as if he
was watching a path unfold.
Something is happening.
Something very bad.
Turtle escaping?
Khibli thought worriedly.
Is he seeing the ripples from that?
This dragon isn't real, Moon said, pulling
his attention back to her.
She pointed at clear side.
I don't know how you made her, but I know
she's not the real clear sight.
At 1st I was worried you'd really brought
her back from the dead somehow.
No, Dark Stalker sighed.
Regarding the silent, enchanted dragon.
Rumor has it.
That's the one thing an animus dragon
can't do.
I'd probably need her bones to try
anyway.
I mean, not that I would, he added.
Catching Moon's expression, because
creepy, right?
Creepy.
But that's why she feels wrong to you
dark stalker, Moon said, because this is
wrong.
This experimenting with other dragons
trying to create a perfect dragon for
yourself, trying to change someone to be
exactly what you think you want.
That's not love.
I do love Clearsight.
Dark Stalker insisted.
Right.
And this isn't her.
Moon said.
You loved the real her, even when she
fought with you, because she was always
completely herself.
She spread one of her wings toward the
false clear sight.
Not the version of her you tried to
create.
Let her go, dark stalker.
Whatever this is, whatever you enchanted
to turn into clear sight, turn it back.
It's not whatever, Kibli guessed, with a
bolt of inspiration and horror.
It's whoever.
There's someone else under there.
Dog stalker looked at Moon for a while
thinking.
He doesn't want her to know it's another
dragon.
He knows how she'd react.
All right.
I will, he said finally.
If you promise to stay my friend, always.
Moon picked up a torn piece of the scroll
and started folding it carefully between
her claws.
I don't know if I can promise that, she
said.
She looked him in the eyes.
Not if it's true about what you've done
to the ice wings.
What I've done, he said.
What do you?
That's it.
His voice abruptly dropped into a low
hiss.
That's the change.
I see it.
It's the ice wings.
There.
My spells aren't working on them
anymore.
He whirled furiously toward the window.
Who did this?
What idiot?
Moon.
Can't you feel it?
A vision, she said.
Yes, he said, your vision.
It's drawing closer.
Can't you tell how soon it is?
I have it all the time, she said, every
day now.
I thought I'd stopped it for you.
But somebody ruined my plans.
Dark Stalker pounced on the other half of
the ripped scroll and picked up the
bottle of green ink.
Tell me what the ice wings are doing
right at this moment. he said, upending
the bottle over the paper.
Green ink poured out, but instead of
splashing into a blobby puddle, it spread
and shifted into letters that scrawled
across the scroll.
Queen Glacier is dead.
Dogstalker read aloud.
Kibley stifled a gasp.
Oh no.
They hadn't been fast enough with the
earrings.
Winter was going to be devastated.
The new queen of the ice wings is her
daughter, Snowfall.
Dark Stalker read on.
She has declared war on the night wings
after learning that the dark stalker has
returned, and that he was responsible for
the plague decimating their tribe.
The entire ice wing army is on the move
planning to wipe out the night wings for
good.
He snarled angrily.
So you did try to kill them all, Moon
said.
Because I knew otherwise, they'd come
kill us, he cried.
There are a lot more ice wings than
Nightwings right now, in case you hadn't
heard, and they hate us.
They're going to wipe out our whole
tribe.
And it's all because of your interfering
friends.
No, it's because of you, Moon said
spiritedly.
The ice wings and night wings were at
peace.
Queen Glory and Queen Glacier had worked
out a truce.
Finally, after all those centuries of
hatred.
We were starting over.
But of course, they're going to fight
back after what you did.
They would have come for us anyway.
Dark Stalker insisted.
As soon as they heard I was alive.
That's what your vision was always
about.
The coming war between the night wings
and ice wings.
That's what I was trying to save us
from.
By murdering an entire tribe.
She said.
Dark Stalker.
You really don't see how fundamentally
horrible that is.
They started it, he growled.
He turned back to the scroll, lashing his
tail.
Tell me where the ice wing army is now.
Moon tipped her head to read the new
letters that rearranged themselves on the
page.
On their way to Jade Mountain, she read
to demand answers about where Dark
Stalker and the Night Wings are.
Oh no.
She pressed her front talons together.
Jade Mountain will fall.
The prophecy.
It's too late to stop it now, Dark
Stalker said.
We have to go fight them, or else they'll
come here and destroy the new home we're
building.
Maybe they won't, Moon said desperately.
Kibli told me they're afraid of the
mountains on the northern border.
Maybe they won't want to come through
them.
Dark Stalker stopped, looking at her with
glittering eyes.
That's right, he said.
My spell to protect the border.
That was a stroke of genius.
It did an excellent job of protecting our
kingdom, from invading ice dragons.
Well, guess what?
It's completely useless now.
He stabbed a claw violently into the
scroll.
Thanks to whatever clever claws made the
ice wings safe from all my spells.
Now, the whole tribe can come pouring
through to wipe us out.
He shook his head.
No.
We won't just wait for them to come
destroy us.
We're night wings.
The greatest tribe in Pyria.
We're taking this fight to them.
He whirled toward Clearsight.
Go back to the dragon you were, with no
memory of the spells I put on you, he
barked.
She smiled and nodded pleasantly, and
then a moment later, sleek, beautiful
clear sight was gone, and in her place
stood the thin and scowling shape of
fierce teeth.
She glanced around the room, scowling
more deeply in confusion.
Yikes, Kibli thought.
You, Moon pointed at fierce teeth
aghast.
She, you?
Gather all the night wings who can
fight.
Dark Stalker said to fierce teeth.
The very young and the sick can stay here
safely.
The rest should meet me in the great
diamond as soon as possible.
The Great Diamond?
Fierce teeth said snippily.
The plaza below the palace, said Dark
Stalker, waving one talon out the
window.
Go on.
Flies as fast as you can, and don't annoy
me again.
But what for?
What do I tell them?
Fierce teeth demanded.
Dark Stalker's face looked carved from
stone.
Tell them, we're going to war.
Chapter 24.
Kible and Moon ran to the palace, flying
down the levels, leaping over staircases
on their way back to Moon's room.
Hibley had a stitch in his side, and
Moon's wound was bleeding again, leaving
little smears of blood behind them, but
neither of them stopped.
I'm guessing.
That wasn't exactly how you hoped it
would go, Kibley said.
Well, Moon answered.
At least now he's definitely going to be
too busy to worry about turtle escaping.
Can we get a message to Jade Mountain?
Kibley asked, panting for breath, to
Sonny?
He shook his head, answering himself.
I can't think of a way.
We have to get there ourselves as fast as
we can.
And we have to break the news to winter.
Moon said, with an agonized wince.
I can do that.
Hibby volunteered.
I can tell him.
You don't have to.
No, I'll do it.
You go look for Kinkachu and Turtle. she
said, skidding to a stop outside her
door.
Where are the dungeons?
he asked.
She lifted her wings in a hopeless
shrug.
I'm guessing down?
I could end up running around this huge
palace for the rest of the night, he
pointed out.
Is there anyone we can safely ask?
Yes, Moon said.
I mean, no, but there's a scroll with the
architectural plans of the palace.
I was looking at it in the palace library
earlier today.
It'll still be out on the table, up those
stairs, 2nd door on your right.
She pointed at the closest flight of
stairs.
Khibli hesitated.
I don't want to leave you here.
I...
I don't want winter to yell at you
again.
I've heard it all in his thoughts. she
said, and worse in other dragons.
I can handle it.
Does it make you hate everyone?
He blurted.
Knowing what we're really thinking.
She tilted her head to the side.
No, Kibley.
Just the opposite, she said, catching one
of his talons.
It helps me see what's really going on
inside everyone.
It's why I believe every dragon has good
in them.
She squeezed his claws.
Some have so much kindness inside.
It gives me hope for the world.
Does she mean me?
He thought wonderingly.
Is that what she found in me?
Find Kinkajou, she said.
Get back here as quick as you can.
He raced up the stairs and found the
palace library immediately.
It was only one room, but a very big one
and more than one of the tables had a
scroll unrolled on it.
It didn't take him long to find the one
with the blueprints though.
He fumbled to roll through it, leaving a
little tear in the paper with his claws
by accident.
There were 3 floors of dungeons at the
very bottom of the palace, it turned out
which seemed a bit excessive to Kibley
until he tried imagining what else Dark
Stalker might do with prisoners if he ran
out of room to jail them.
He studied the little sketches of stairs
carefully and figured out that there must
be an entrance to the dungeons right next
to the royal throne room.
The back of his neck started to prickle
as if his scales were shifting uneasily.
That haunted feeling rolled over him
slowly, like curling wet fog.
He whirled around.
And his surprise, someone was actually
there.
Hello, said the strange Nightwing.
She stared at him for a moment.
I can't figure out who you are.
She took a step closer.
Studying him with eyes that were neither
friendly nor entirely unfriendly.
Her face was hard to read.
Just a friend, said Kibley, of moon
watchers.
Moon watcher she said, as if she were
tasting the name on her forked tongue.
I see.
Are you a friend to dog stalker?
The pause was tense, laden with danger.
Picibli wasn't sure in which direction.
Moon is his friend.
He said at length.
I would say I have some concerns.
She flicked her tail.
Such as, be honest, please.
I kind of have to be somewhere.
He said, taking a step backward toward
the door.
Then be honest and brief, she suggested
in a tone that wasn't open to argument.
All right?
he said, such as the fact that he killed
his father, the fact that his see your
girlfriend thought he was so dangerous, he
had to be hidden under a mountain for
eternity.
He can enchant dragons to do anything he
tells them to, or turn them into other
dragons entirely if he wants.
The fact that he just tried to kill the
entire ice wing tribe with magic, and the
fact that he's so charming and sincere
that smart dragons tend to like him, even
when they're not enchanted to.
Also, I'm not sure there's anyone who can
stop him.
He kept edging toward the door as he
spoke, putting more space between him and
the stranger.
I'm not sure there's anyone he cares
about enough that he'd listen to them.
Or anyone who's willing to try.
I see, she said.
Compelling.
One last question.
Why was there an angry sea wing chasing
after him?
This arrested Kibli midstep.
Tsunami?
he said.
Are you the one who stopped her?
Where is she?
I understand Dark Stalker has had some
trouble with angry sea wings before, she
said.
This one was.
Very shouty.
Not terrific at answering polite
questions.
Confining her seemed like a sensible
precaution.
Where?
Kibley asked, is she here?
At the palace?
No, said the night wing.
I left her in a convenient cave in the
rainforest, while I assessed her threat
level.
Upon reflection, I would like to let her
go, she added thoughtfully.
But she's made some very specific
threats.
One might call them alarmingly detailed.
If you tell me where to find her, I'll
let her out, and make sure she
understands, it was your idea.
I can talk her out of any revenge, I
promise.
That would be very helpful. said.
She held out a scrap of folded paper.
When Kibli unfolded it, he found a
sketchy map of the rainforest, with a
little X marked about halfway between the
mountains and the rain wing village.
Is that why you approached me?
He asked.
Studying the map for a moment before
looking up, because you guessed I'd...
Oh.
The Nightwing had vanished.
Which was weird, since Kibli was standing
in front of the door.
He peeked under the closest table, glanced
around the vast room, and realized there
must be another exit at the far end.
Still wondering what had just happened.
He hurried to the throne room, and
searched the corridors around it, until
he found an appropriately sinister
looking iron door coated with rust.
It wasn't guarded, which surprised him.
Maybe the guards are in the great diamond
listening to Dark Stalker call for war.
Or maybe, he chose not to post any here
because he didn't want Moon to notice
them and ask who was in the dungeon.
Three heavy iron bolts studded the edge
of the door, sealing it in place.
He threw them back one by one, then
seized the handle and pulled as hard as
he could.
With an outraged, degrading shriek, the
door swung open.
On the other side was darkness.
He could see a few stairs going down, but
the rest vanished beyond the edge of the
light.
He blinked, letting his eyes adjust for a
moment, and then something slammed into
his chest.
He stumbled backward, feeling wings smack
him in the face, but unable to see
anything of his attacker.
Ow, he yelled.
Please be an excited rain wing, and not
something scarier?
Oh, sorry, said Kinkachu's voice.
She popped into view, disguised as a
night wing in black and silver scales.
It was very weird to see Kingaju's face
on a night wing.
Khibli wasn't sure any nightwing in
history had ever smiled so much.
We've been stuck in there for ages
Kinkaju said, all because someone refused
to stay outside the door and make sure it
didn't get locked again.
Yes, said Anemone's irate voice.
The princess poked her head around the
door and peeked up and down the hall, and
that someone is you.
No, it isn't.
Kinkaju yelled.
It's you.
I was talking about you.
I got that, Kibli reassured her.
All right, it's safe to come out, Anemone
said over her shoulder.
I can see more of the hallway than she
can, and I say it's safe to come out.
Kinkaju said quickly.
Anemone rolled her eyes elaborately and
ascended into the corridor, tucking
herself behind the open door, behind her
slow and blinking, came Turtle.
He looked older and more tired than he
had the last time Kibli had seen him.
There were tiny little dried trickles of
blood all over him.
His face, his neck, his sides, his wings
his tail.
For a moment, Kibley was afraid Dark
Stalker had tortured him, but then he
remembered the fight with anemone, and he
noticed how anemone was having trouble
looking at Turtle.
You got my message, he said to Kibley, in
a wavering voice, his eyes brightening.
Of course I did.
Kibley said, feeling immensely guilty for
how much he'd complained about turtles
communication skills.
We came right away.
He stepped forward and wrapped his wings
around Turtle.
Anemone says you made her safe from dark
stalker spells.
Hurtle said, thank you.
No, you did that, Kibley said, pulling
back and grabbing Turtle's shoulders.
You're a hero, turtle.
You saved her, and Queen Thorn, and
everyone in Jade Mountain, and the whole
ice wing tribe.
Turtles squinted at him.
Um, I'm pretty sure I'd remember that.
It's true.
Kibli pointed to his ear and then
anemones look familiar.
The spell you used to protect me.
It's the same one protecting her, and
Sonny and Clay, and Starflight, and
Winter, and Moon, and all the ice wings.
Your spell.
Dark Stalker sent a plague to kill the
entire ice wing tribe, and your spell
saved them.
What?
said Turtle, looking dizzy.
It did?
Told you you were a hero.
Kinkachu said proudly.
She scrunched her snout and rubbed her
face with her talons.
Arrr!
I think I'm making a stupid love spell
face.
Anemone.
Pretty sure your face always looks that
stupid.
Kinkaju.
The princess snarked back.
All right, stop it.
Kibley said, grabbing Kinkaju before she
could tackle anemone.
I have bad news.
Those ice wings, turtles saved.
They're pretty mad about what Dark
Stalker tried to do.
They're on their way to Jade Mountain
looking for a fight, and Dark Stalker is
about to lead the night wings there to
give them one.
Over Jade Mountain?
Kinkaju cried.
Like, yes, just like in Moon's Vision
Hibley said.
But we found the lost city of night
Kinkachu said frantically.
That should have stopped the prophecy.
Well, it hasn't yet, said Kibley.
But maybe if we can get to Jane Mountain
first.
We can do something.
With your magic or your magic if we have
to.
He said to Anemone and Turtle.
Turtle's wings drooped.
I don't have any magic anymore.
He said.
Dark Stalker took it away from me.
Oh, turtle, Kinkaju said
sympathetically.
She reached over and twined her tail
around his, then shot a glare at anemone
as if to say, I'd be doing this even
without your spell.
Khibli was horrified.
To have animus magic and then lose it
must be the worst thing that could happen
to someone.
Maybe even worse than never having animus
magic at all.
Like, holding a scroll with infinite
power in your talent, and then watching
it burn to ashes a moment later.
The earring should fix that, he said
quickly.
It'll remove any spells Dark Stalker ever
put on you.
You'll be inanimous again.
He dug in his pouch, realizing he was
almost out of earrings and needed to make
more.
I'm not sure I deserve to be, Turtle said
sadly.
Well, that's irrelevant, Anemone barked.
We're fixing you, whether you like it or
mope about it.
She's right.
Khibli said.
Sorry, but we need all the animus magic
we can get on our side if we're going to
defeat Dark Stalker.
He held out the earring, and Turtle took
it, his eyes wide and a little blurry
like it was holding back tears.
Except none of our magic will work on him
Anemone pointed out, so don't get too
excited.
Are we going to stand around feeling
sorry for each other all day?
Or can we go to Jade Mountain now?
Oh, very compassionate, Kinkaju said to
her.
It's so comforting to think you might be
running a kingdom one day.
Come on, this way, Kibley said.
They saw no night wings as they ran to
the palace.
It was eerily deserted, as if the tribe
had vanished again, but when Kibli
glanced out one of the windows, he saw
the great diamond below swarming with
black wings and flickering torches.
The tribe wasn't going to run away this
time.
They were going to fight, and dragons
were going to die.
He had the map of the palace clear in his
head.
So it didn't take long to lead the others
back through the winding halls and stairs
to Moon's room, where Winter looked about
ready to explode.
Hello, nice to see you.
Glad you're safe.
Let's go, let's go.
Winter said, herding them toward the
window with his wings.
He was the 1st one to leap into the sky
and then the others followed, one by
one.
They soared toward the mountains, catching
the strange, twisting currents of the
wind, and beating their wings as fast as
they could.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
The prophecy ran through Kibli's mind
like a drum beat, pounding darkly
alongside his heart.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Moon's vision was about to come true.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice.
And he had no idea how to stop it.
Part three.
The light of dragons.
Chapter 25.
Invisible paint brushes streaked pink and
orange clouds across the horizon ahead of
them, and soon the sun rose.
A ball of fire that shone brightly in
Kibley's eyes.
He was glad to be a sandwing, built for a
long flight across the desert without
stopping, and able to go days on very
little food.
When did I last eat?
He could see Kinkachoo, anemone, and
turtles struggling, although none of them
complained, not even anemone, which was
surprising.
Rain wings were not long distance flyers
or accustomed to deprivation.
They usually swung and hopped from branch
to branch, in a rainforest always full of
food, and sea wings preferred to
alternate swimming and flying when they
had to travel a long distance.
Not only that, but Anemone and Turtle had
both traveled all the way across the
continent only a few days ago, with
almost no time to recover since.
As an ice wing, winter could handle the
length of the flight, but the heat of the
desert clearly wore on him.
Still, he cleansed his jaw and flew with
grim determination, no doubt driven by
the danger his tribe was in.
Only moon flew as swiftly and surely as
Kibley.
But he watched her carefully, and saw the
agony that twisted across her face from
time to time.
The visions, hitting like a tree smashing
over her head.
Once the pain looked so bad that her
wings faltered, and he dove underneath
her to catch her if she fell.
But she righted herself and flew onward
shooting him a rueful.
Thank you.
Look.
The long flight gave Kibley a lot of time
to think.
And think and think.
We have magic, if we can figure out how
to use it.
Dark Stalker's going to discover turtle
is free soon enough.
Turtles should start using his magic
before Dark Stalker thinks of another way
to stop him.
But how?
What's the best spell?
Could we enchant the 2 tribes to agree to
a peace treaty?
But would it be right to magically compel
them?
Is that any better than bewitching
dragons to like you?
Or anemone's love spell, or Dark
Stalker's manipulation?
And there will be nothing to stop
Darkstalker from breaking the treaty
whenever he wants.
I wonder if turtle and anemone could
craft a spell to protect Jade Mountain
like some kind of shield around it.
I wonder if that would stop it from
falling It wouldn't save the ice wings or
the night wings, though.
How many dragons are going to die today?
Around and around went his mind, chasing
the same questions.
We should evacuate Jade Mountain as soon
as we get there, to be safe.
The other dragonettes in the school, they
should be moved to safety.
The rainforest is closest, or Queen
Morehen's Palace.
But they were only halfway to Jade
Mountain when a wing of black dragons
suddenly flashed past them.
At least 15 dragons, flying it twice the
pace of the fastest sky wing. 3 of them
were carrying something white, perhaps
pieces of a scroll or cloth.
Kibli didn't get a good look.
A few threw the dragonette's smirks of
triumph as they whisked by.
No, shouted Winter, pounding his wings to
try and catch them, but it was no use.
They vanished into the distance with
frightening speed.
The super speed that Dark Stalker gave
them.
Khibli lashed his tail with frustration.
They didn't talk about it, saving their
energy for flight.
The Kibli felt new fear creeping through
the group after that.
What other powers had Dark Stalker handed
out in preparation for war?
How many invulnerable, super strong
dragons were on their way to kill ice
wings right now.
What if he had given someone else animus
magic?
The earrings wouldn't protect anyone from
a new animus.
The Kibli couldn't imagine Dark Stalker
doing that.
He didn't trust other animus dragons.
He wouldn't want there to be more of them
in the world.
Each one was a threat to his absolute
power.
Soon after they reached the edge of the
claws of the clouds mountain range and
were flying over the foothills, 2 of the
swift night wings came tearing back from
the mountains and swept past them again
this time, without even a glance at the
breathless dragonettes.
Gone to update dark stalker on the
situation.
How many ice wings, whether they have
weapons, where they are?
That must be useful.
Scouts as fast as that.
Although I'm sure Dark Stalker has
magical ways to get all the same
answers.
This way, though, his subjects feel
useful.
He's been careful to feed their vanity so
they'll love him all the more.
Kibli finally sighted Jade Mountain ahead
of them in the late afternoon.
At 1st glance it looked peaceful.
The 2 pigs crowned with golden sunlight
and long streaks of puffy clouds above it
like dragon smoke.
But as they got closer, they saw flashes
in the sky, like light bouncing off
bright snow, the white and pale blue
wings of ice wings, swooping around the
mountain.
Khibli focused his sharp eyes on a nearby
peak that was dusted with snow, and
realized it wasn't snow.
Those were more ice wings, 100s of them
gathering into formations, ready to surge
into battle.
He saw no sign of the Nightwing Scouts
which was worrying.
Down on the wide ledge that formed the
main entrance of the school.
He spotted 3 large ice wings, bristling
with spikes and righteous anger.
Facing off against them, blocking the way
into the school, were sunny, clay
Starflight, and peril.
All of them, even clay and pearl, looked
small next to the tallest towering ice
dragon.
A moment later, Winter saw them too. and
let out a hiss.
Friends of yours, Kibli asked.
No, worse, relatives.
My father, Narwhal, Winter said, pointing
to the biggest of the dragons.
My cousin, Snowfall, the new queen, and
you remember my brother, Hailstorm.
He sighed a long breath in and out
through his nose.
They think Sunny and Starflight know
where the new Knight Kingdom is, said
Moon.
Can you hear their thoughts?
Ghibli asked.
She shook her head.
The Skyfire blocks my mind reading when
I'm holding it, but I can tell from the
way they're shouting at them.
That would have been Kibley's gas as
well.
Narwhal and snowfall radiated fury
snapping their wings out, and rattling
their tail spikes as they roared.
Hillstorms stood a step behind narwhal
frowning stiffly, like a dragon in a play
trying to be the most serious and
menacing character.
As they got closer, they could hear the
dragon's voices echoing off the cliffs
around them.
How could you let a monster like that
loose on the world, and then stop paying
attention.
Narwhal bellowed.
Our entire tribe nearly died, and it
would have been your fault, Snowfall
snarled.
We didn't let him loose, Sonny cried.
He enchanted us, same as you.
And we've been trying to figure out what
to do ever since the spell was broken
Starflight added nervously.
Edging a little closer to Sonny's
warmth.
Hibli guessed that even without his sight
Starflight must have been able to feel
the cold glares that the 3 ice wings were
sending his way.
That's quite simple.
All you have to do is tell us where he
is.
Snowfall bared her teeth.
We really don't know, Clay said
helplessly.
I don't know how many times we can say
it.
But we wouldn't tell you anyway, Peril
spoke up fiercely.
We can see that giant army behind you, you
know.
This is a centuries old war, narwhal
hissed.
You would do well to stay out of it.
Fine by us, snapped Pearl, so go away
then.
No, please don't go attack the night
wings, Sonny said passionately.
They're all under his spell, don't you
see?
It's not the tribe who tried to hurt
you.
It's just dark stalker.
We'll find a way to stop him, but ice
wings and night wings killing each other
isn't the answer. 20 ice wings died of
that plague, including our queen, said
Snowfall.
They started this.
They're going to pay for it.
I don't know why you're here yelling at
us.
Carol jumped in again.
It was a Jade Mountain student who sent
those earrings to save you all.
Without Jade Mountain, you'd all be
dead.
So, you're welcome very much.
Without Jade Mountain.
The dog stalker would still be buried
deep under the earth where he should be
Narwhal growled.
That's, Peril hesitated, and they were
close enough now for Kibli to see the
heartbreaking look that swept across her
face.
She glanced down at her talons and
covered them with her wings.
Clay reached out and rested one of his
wings over hers, wincing a little as her
fire scales touched him.
Please, give us time to find another way
Sonny pleaded.
Let us try to deal with dark stalker
without killing any more dragons.
It's too late, said Winter, as they all
landed on the ledge between the ice wings
and the Jade Mountain Dragons.
He bowed solemnly to his family.
Father, cousin, hailstorm.
They stared back at him, thunderstruck.
What?
But, Narwhal turned around to look at
Hailstorm, as though expecting that his
other son might have vanished.
Hailstorm's expression was petrified, and
trapped, and anguished, and a tiny bit
relieved as well if Kibley was reading
him right.
You are... dead!
Snowfall exclaimed.
Her tail twitched back and forth in
bewilderment.
You totally died.
Winter spread his wings.
Not totally, I'm afraid.
This is awkward, said Kibley, but we
don't have time for epic family sagas
right now.
The Nightwing Army is on its way here.
He might as well have lit a dragon flame
cactus in the middle of the gathering.
What?
Narwhal and Snowfall roared
simultaneously.
Oh no, Sonny cried, turning toward the
school as if she wanted to wrap her wings
around it.
Great, said Pearl.
Now you can go be idiots at each other
and leave the rest of us alone.
Starflight skittered back a few steps
toward the entrance, paused, and crouched
gripping the stone with his claws, as
though he was preparing to hold his
ground in a strong wind.
How much time do we have?
asked Clay.
Enough time to get the ice wing army away
from here?
We are not going anywhere, Snowfall
declared.
We are ready to fight them.
Enough time to evacuate the school?
Sonny asked. taking a step closer and
looking Kibley in the eyes.
I hope, he started, but before he could
finish, 3 night wings burst from the
trees, shot through the air with our
claws outstretched, and attacked the new
queen of the ice wings.
Chapter 26.
Snowfall shrieked, and everyone on the
ledge leaped forward, but the closest
dragon to her was narwhal.
He struck one of the night wings full
force, killing her with a single blow.
But the other 2 were only a moment behind
and now he was between them and their
prey.
As he twisted to confront them, they
caught his throat in their slashing
talons.
Father, hailstorm and winter screamed.
Hailstorm reached him first, throwing off
one of the night wings, and smashing his
spiked tail into the other.
Winter grabbed for the one he'd flung
aside.
But the black dragon flashed out of his
reach, with his unnatural speed, and
sliced his claws along Hillstorm's side.
Hillstorm roared with pain, and now Clay
was there too, dragging one of the night
wings back by his tail, and Kibley darted
forward to leap on the other one's back
but suddenly, 3 more night wings
plummeted from the rocks above the cave
opening, all aiming for the young ice
wing queen.
Stop it!
Moon shouted at them, trying to throw
herself in their way.
Smoke see her.
Eclipse, don't do this.
We don't want a war.
They swerved around her as if she were a
rock in a stream.
Only one stopped for a moment to yell
they want this war.
We're defending ourselves, and you should
be fighting alongside us, traitor.
Snowfall shrieked again.
This time shooting a blast of frost
breath that hit one of the attacking
night wings in the face so hard, it
knocked him backward.
He crashed to the ground and scrabbled at
his snout frantically as ice spread
across his nose and eyes.
Frost breath was everywhere now, as
snowfall, winter and hailstorm all fought
back.
A slick of ice spread across the back of
the dragon below Kibley's talons, the
chill hitting his claws, just as he lost
his grip and fell off.
He hit the ground with a hard thump, and
leaped to his feet again, ramming his
shoulder into another night wing.
Through the mess of frost breath and fire
and scales, he saw Moon, frantically
trying to pull her tribe mates back, but
they shook her off as though she was a
clinging spider web.
He heard Kinkachu overhead shouting
something about using her venom on
everyone.
He caught a glimpse of anemone backing
into the school, calling to Turtle.
A black tail smashed Kibley back into a
silvery blue wing, freezing, serrated
claws stamped down on one of his feet.
He heard a roar of pain that sounded like
clay.
He tried to find his way toward moon or
winter, but they were both lost in the
melee of surging scales on the blood
slick stone.
And then, one of the night wing screamed
at a higher register than everyone else
and a wall of heat swamped over Kibley.
He staggered back, covering his eyes.
As the screaming black dragon turned into
a massive flames from wings to tail.
Whose next?
Peril shouted, storming through the fire
with her wings spread wide, and her tail
lashing.
Who else hurt clay?
The remaining night wings fell back
hissing to one side of the ledge.
Ice wings were diving down from every
direction now, some of them holding long
icicle spears, but they wheeled about in
the air at the side of the burning
dragon.
I'm all right, Pearl, Clay said, trying
to stand before he collapsed forward over
a deep bite wound in one of his fore
legs.
Harold darted to his side and glared
around at the watching dragons.
You all stop fighting and talk this out
like Sonny says, or I will set every
single one of you on fire starting with
your eyeballs.
She threw Clay's wing over her back and
lifted him.
Sonny ran forward to support his other
side, as the 3 of them hobbled toward the
school.
Starflight leaned toward them as they
passed, and Sonny said something to him
that made him nod and sit down again.
Kibley looked up at the warring tribes
all of them briefly unified in their fear
of peril.
Would it work?
Could she terrify them into bargaining
for peace?
But then, rolling in from the west, he
saw a cloud that was not a cloud.
It was a roaring tide of black scales and
flashing claws.
It was the night wing army, with dark
stalker at their head, and they were not
here for peace.
The ice wing saw them too. and rose up
from the mountain peaks like a snowstorm
whirling backward, up into the sky.
On the ledge, snowfall growled something
at winter, and shouted, Fly, fly, at
Hellstorm, as she leaped into the air.
She soared up into the midst of her army
as the night wings and the ice wings
crashed into each other in a chorus of
roars and screams and furious wing
beats.
Hailstorm paused for a moment over the
body of his father.
Narwhale lay in a pool of blue ice wing
blood, which spread and dripped into
crevices and across the rocks, mingling
with dark red night wing blood in ghastly
violet puddles.
Winter joined his brother, and in silence
they rested their front talons on their
father's head, and closed his staring
blue eyes.
Would you fight alongside us?
Hailstorm said to Winter.
Even after what we did to you?
You're my tribe, Winter said to him.
You're my family.
But winter, moon tried, reaching for
him.
I'm sorry, he said to her, and then the 2
ice wings were aloft, racing toward the
battle.
Kibley looked around, feeling as though
he'd been run over by a herd of dragon
sized camels.
One night wing corps lay next to
narwhals.
The other dead night wing was a charred
heap of ashes.
Overhead, the ice wings outnumbered the
night wings 5 to one.
But he could see some night wings
fighting with the strength of 10 ice
wings, smashing dragons into cliff sides
with their tails, and ripping others
apart with brute force.
He saw ice wings forming lines to create
a wall of deadly frost breath, and he saw
some night wings fly right through it
their scales invulnerable to harm
laughing as they sank their claws into
the ice dragons.
What do we do?
Kingachu asked.
Landing just outside the puddles of
blood?
Her scales had turned dark green.
On the rain wing spectrum for fear, Khibli
thought from his observations, but shot
through with deep purple, determination?
He hadn't seen enough of that color on
them, to be sure.
How do we stop them?
Turtle limped up beside her, his wings
dragging tiredly behind him.
I don't know, Moon said helplessly.
She stared up at the fighting, dying
dragons.
They wouldn't listen to me when it was
only a few of them.
I'll never get through to the whole
army.
What about just dark stalker?
Hibley suggested.
You're the only dragon he will ever
listen to.
Could you talk to him?
Her eyes shifted to the epicenter of the
battle, where the enormous figure of dark
stalker was lashing out ferociously.
Spears bounced off his side.
Frost breath slid away with no effect
claws and teeth, and the sharpest of
spiked tails left no mark.
He couldn't use his magic against them
with every ice wing in the tribe wearing
Kibley's earrings, but he could still
kill them face to face easily.
He was untouchable, invincible, and every
ice wing he caught in his talons dropped
away from him dead.
I can try, said Moon.
She braced herself to fly.
No, don't, please don't, Kibley said
catching her and wrapping a wing around
her.
If you go up there, you'll be just
another night wing, and I'm afraid you
won't make it to Dark Stalker before an
ice wing kills you.
Maybe even winter.
If he's fighting too hard to see what
he's doing, and that would kill him, and
me, along with you.
Don't I have to try?
Moon asked, my head.
The vision.
She squeezed her eyes shut and folded
into herself.
We have to get the students out, and
Sonny and Clay and everyone else. before
Jade Mountain Falls.
Hibli glanced over his shoulder and saw
Starflight, still sitting determinedly at
the cave entrance, trembling, but there
beside him was fate speaker, looking
equally determined, as though they would
both fight anyone before they let them
near their students, even dragons from
their own tribe.
It's not going to fall.
I'll come up with another plan, he said.
His eyes searched the mountain for
ideas.
The peaks were glimmering oddly in the
sunset, and he realized they were covered
with frost and ice, collateral damage
from the ice wings swooping around them.
As he stared at them, a night wing was
flung into the cliff wall of one of the
peaks with such force that a crack
shivered out in the rock from where she
struck.
If I had magic, what would I do?
If I had dark stalkers scroll or anemones
power, I could stop this.
I know I could.
What would be the right spell?
A few possibilities flashed through his
head, and he whirled toward turtle.
Uh-oh, said Turtle, seeing Kibley's
face.
I mean, um, yes, whatever it is, ready to
do it.
That's me.
Where's anemone, Hibli asked.
Here, she said, emerging from the cave
with her tail dragging.
I'm sorry I ran away.
That was a lot of fighting at once.
She hunched her wings with
embarrassment.
It's all right, Turtle said kindly.
Mother would want you to be safe, and
jumping into an ice wing night wing war
is the opposite of safe.
No one will be safe until Dark Stalker is
dead, she answered, tipping her head up
with a dangerous gleam in her eye.
Your spells won't work on him.
Hibley said to both of them, but maybe we
can do something else with your magic.
Turtle twitched nervously.
Like what?
He asked.
I mean, I'm in.
But what do we do?
Something to stop the fighting?
Moon said.
But won't Dark Stalker notice if Turtle
does magic?
Kinkachu asked, reaching out to brush
wings with him.
And what about Turtle's soul?
A spell big enough to stop a war?
That can't be good for him.
That's up to you, turtle.
Kibley said.
The earring will keep you safe from dark
stalker's spells, but he's dangerous in
other ways too.
And we all care about keeping your soul
safe.
So if you're worried about it at all.
You don't have to do any of this.
I want to do something, Turtle said
firmly, setting his jaw.
Just tell me what.
Well, what if we put an invisible wall
between the ice wings and the night
wings?
Hibele suggested, something that won't
let any attacks through.
There's nowhere to put one at this point
Moon said, pointing to the melee in the
sky.
They're all over the place.
Anemone flicked her tail.
Anything we do, Dark Stalker will find a
way around it.
How about a message?
Khibli climbed onto one of the rocks
trying to scrape the blood off his talons
a telepathic message to all the night
wings that seems to come from dark
stalker, telling them to retreat.
They'd believe he could do that, wouldn't
they?
Let's try it, said Turtle.
I'll do it.
No, I'll do the message, Anemone said.
I can sound way more like dark stalker
than you can.
You just stand next to me so he thinks
it's coming from you when he feels the
magic happening.
Right.
You're right, he said. nodding.
He fidgeted in an awkward circle
searching the ground, and finally picked
up a scrap of moss that had been clawed
off one of the closest rocks during the
fight.
Here, you can use this he suggested.
Anemone wrinkled her nose at it.
A pell of dirt?
She said.
Doesn't anyone have any jewelry or
something I could enchant instead?
It only needs to last long enough to work
once, Kibley said.
Nothing fancy.
Fine.
Anemone clasped it between her talons
shuddering theatrically at how damp it
was, and closed her eyes.
Turtles sat down beside her with an
anxious expression.
Moon climbed up beside Kibley, and twined
her tail around his.
He could feel her heart beat through her
scales, as they leaned into each other
watching the battle overhead.
Please let this work.
Moon prayed softly.
Please stop fighting.
Kibley saw fearless.
One of the dragonettes from school
darting through the battle, slamming
dragons aside with her tail.
He remembered she was the 1st dragon to
be gifted with super strength by Dark
Stalker, and he saw with dismay that she
was using it to cut a swath through the
ice wings.
She threw a pale blue dragon into Jade
Mountain with a crack that echoed off the
peaks and sent a small avalanche tumbling
down into a crevice.
Then, fearless, turned, and lunged at a
silver dragon, who looked as young as she
was, a skillful fighter, with blue scales
freckling her snout, but Winter shot
across her path before Fearless reached
her, spraying frost breath on Fearless's
wing.
The night wing led out an agonized roar
and crash landed on the nearest stretch
of mountain, where she dragged herself
into the shelter of a small cave.
Elsewhere in the sky.
Hillstorm was struggling with 2 night
wings, who were dive bombing him, flames
blazing from their mouths.
Kibley glanced uneasily back at anemone.
She looked as though she was
concentrating as hard as she could.
Moon grabbed one of his talons, inhaling
sharply, and he looked up again.
Winter had flown up beside Hillstorm, and
they were trying to drive off the night
wings together, fighting back to back.
Suddenly the night wings darted away
shaking their heads slightly with
confused expressions.
They looked at one another, then over a
dark stalker, whose head snapped up.
Dark stalker threw 4 ice wings aside, and
slammed his tail into the cliff side of
another mountain, a rain of boulders fell
around him, and he deftly caught the
largest one.
Without even a pause, he whirled in the
same motion, and flung the enormous rock
with all his strength, straight at turtle
and anemone.
No, Kibli shouted, leaping to his feet.
He was too slow.
He felt the wind of its passage as it
shot past him, like a plummeting comet
and he heard the impact as it smashed
into the sea wings.
Moon screamed.
One of the night wings was whispering in
Dark Stalker's ear now.
Dark Stalker lifted his snout and yelled
it's a trick, Nightwings.
Hold the line.
Don't be fooled.
The Nightwing surged forward again with a
vicious new energy.
But Kibley barely noticed.
He crouched beside the boulder with moon
trying frantically to dig under it or
push it aside or anything useful.
Did I just get them both killed?
he thought, in a rising panic.
Finally, he and Moon got their talons
underneath the rock, and heaved up
together.
It clunked aside with an ear rattling
scrape, and Kibley saw a turtle lying
underneath.
His wings spread to cover anemone.
Turtle, he cried.
Are you dead?
No, Turtles said, in a raspy full of rock
dust voice.
I'm all right.
Anemone?
I'm fine.
She called from under him.
Except that I have a great galumping
brother on top of me.
Get off already, kelp breath.
But how?
Moon asked.
That rock was heavy enough to kill you.
I really thought, she took a breath
fighting back tears.
I kind of accidentally made my scales
invulnerable a couple of days ago, Turtles
said, stretching out his wings and
standing up.
When somebody else tried to drop a rock
on me.
He winced.
Apparently something could still hurt.
Well, you're welcome.
Anemone said to him.
Anyway, so much for that plan.
She said to Kibley.
If we do any other spells, they better
work, because he'll notice us and kill us
super quick and probably more effectively
this time.
Kibli's head was pounding.
What else could they do?
Was there anything that wouldn't put
anemone and turtle in danger?
They needed new magic, magic that could
compete with dark stalkers.
The setting sun flashed into his eyes
reflecting off the copper around his
wrists, the weather bracelets.
The only magic he had.
It had been a disaster last time, and the
Sandwing Palace, but what other choice
was there?
If he could call a big enough storm
surely that would stop the battle.
A well placed lightning bolt might even
knock out dark stalker if they were
lucky.
He took a deep breath and raised his
talons toward the sky.
Chapter 27.
A savage gust of wind whipped down from
the north, scattering dragons right and
left.
What are you doing?
Moon whispered, calling a storm, Kibley
answered, a big one.
The air felt as if it was crackling
around his claws.
He felt stronger this time, more sure.
He could sense heavy clouds in the
distance to the north.
He just had to reach for them and pull
them over Jade Mountain.
They would come looming down.
A 3rd army crashing the war.
Then the rain would fall, and the
lightning would flash, and thunder would
roll over the battle, and the dragons
would all, the dragons would...
His gaze fixed on the sky.
He felt more than saw a moon crumpling
beside him, her talons clutching her head
as she cried out with pain.
A flash of white and orange in his
peripheral vision was Kinkajou, darting
forward to catch her friend, shouting
Moon, Moon, are you all right?
Thunder.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath Thunder
and Ice.
No.
Oh, no.
It's me.
He jerked his talons back in toward his
chest, Dread surging through him.
I'm the one who brings the thunder.
If I do this, I make Jade Mountain Fall.
The sky was already darkening.
Early evening stars blotted out by the
incoming clouds, Kibley stumbled backward
off the rock.
Go back, he thought desperately the
storm.
Go away.
I don't want you.
I didn't mean it.
He clawed at the bracelets, stabbing the
tiny clasp over and over again until one
snapped open and clanked to the ground
and then the other.
Tell the storm to go away, he cried
shoving the bracelets at anemone.
Make it leave, quick.
Why?
she asked.
I think a storm is a good idea.
She caught the bracelets. blinking at the
panic on his face.
No, he shouted over the rising wind.
The storm is the thunder in the
prophecy.
That's what brings down the mountain.
He pointed to the trembling peaks
overhead, the ice, the cracks.
The avalanches ready to fall on the turn
of a dagger.
Can you stop it?
The sea wing princess nodded.
Finally understanding.
She slid the bracelets onto her own
wrists and curled her claws in, murmuring
to herself.
Kibley ran over to Starflight and Fate
Speaker.
We have to get the students out, he
called.
I'm worried about the mountain.
Isn't it safer inside than trying to fly
through a war?
Fate speaker shouted.
Her claws dug into the ground as the wind
tried to batter her off the ledge.
Not right now, Kibley said, shielding
them with his wings so they could hear
each other.
Is there another way out?
On the other side of the mountain.
Through stone mover's cave, Starflight
suggested.
Flame is still in there.
Fate speaker reminded him, trapped, angry
and possibly doomed, unless we get him
out, Kibley said.
He tipped an earring out of his pouch and
pressed it into Starflight's talons.
All for him this.
Tell him it'll free him from Dark
Stalker's spells, including the stone
cuffs.
That means his face will go back to the
way it was.
But if Dark Stalker cast any secret
spells on his mind, he'll be freed from
those as well.
That's a trade I would gladly take.
He hesitated.
I don't know how to freeze stone mover
from the wall, though, he said.
I think he has to choose that for himself
if he wants to escape.
Starflight spread one wing instinctively
toward fate speaker, and she lifted hers
to rest underneath it so she could lead
him into the school.
You'll get to safety too.
Starflight said to Kibley.
You and the others.
Especially the sea wing princess, fate
speaker said, with a slide eye roll, who
will be in all sorts of trouble if a
single one of her scales is harmed.
Don't worry about us, Kibley said.
Starflight let out a small laugh.
You make that quite impossible, he said.
Oh, and take this, just in case.
Kibley said, giving Starflight the map
from the strange night wing in the palace
library.
This is where tsunami is.
She's a prisoner in the rainforest.
She's safe, but she needs rescuing, and
tell her no revenge.
Her captor sent us to let her out.
Rescuing tsunami.
That'll be fun.
Fate speaker said.
Kibli watched the 2 of them run into the
mountain.
Fear shivered along his spine, and out to
the tips of his wings.
He hoped everyone would get to safety.
He hoped the school would survive.
After everything that had already
happened here, If it all ended in an
avalanche and devastation, what hope
would there ever be for a school like
this again?
Would any of the tribes be willing to
send their dragonettes to a 2nd grand
experiment?
Wouldn't they blame Sonny and Clay and
the others, no matter who survived?
Or didn't?
He dashed back to Moon and Kinkaju, who
were huddled together with turtle against
the fat raindrops that were starting to
fall.
Anemones stood beside them, waving her
talons at the clouds.
Moon looked up at him.
The wind whipping her wings and tail
back.
She had a really odd expression on her
face, as if the agony of the prophecy
vision had suddenly popped, and meerkats
had come cartwheeling out of the cracked
mountain instead of death.
What is it?
Hiibli asked her, what happened?
I don't know, she said.
I caught a glimpse of a new vision, I
think, but a strange one.
She shook her head.
It was a dragon, someone I've never seen
before.
What was he doing?
Joining the battle?
Was he a sandwing?
Kibley narrowed his eyes at the sky
wondering if Vulture was up there
somewhere.
Or if not, where he was, and what evil he
was plotting.
No, he was.
He was picking strawberries.
Moon said.
Kibley stared at her for a moment.
Evil strawberries?
He asked finally.
I don't think so, she said, with a hint
of a smile.
I know.
It was strange, probably not worth
mentioning.
But he knew it must have felt important
to her.
He'd spend more time puzzling over it
later.
If they had a later.
I think we should move away from Jade
Mountain, he said.
Just in case.
No need, anemone said, tossing her head
triumphantly.
I'm winning.
Off you go, Storm Clouds.
She flicked her wings at the sky.
She was right.
The raindrops were slowing, and the wind
was dying down.
Glimmers of starlight were visible
through the thinning clouds.
The sun was almost down now, rendering
many of the night wings impossible to
see.
But Kibli could still make out the vast
shape of Dark Stalker, lifting his head
to scent the air.
Does he sense the storm retreating?
Does he know I stopped myself from using
the bracelets?
Did he know that was part of the
prophecy?
Is that what he saw in my future in the
library?
Me bringing down Jade Mountain?
Is that what he wanted me to do?
He didn't think I'd be able to stop
myself.
He also didn't know anemone would be
here.
We still have to stop the fighting, Moon
said.
She reached into the pouch around her
neck, and drew out the skyfire.
The rock looked more than ever like a
piece of a fallen star, winking
enigmatically in her talons.
If I put this down, I can reach Dark
Stalker's mind.
I'll try to talk him into ending the
battle.
She sighed.
It seems kind of fitting that this
started with us talking in our minds, and
maybe that's how it'll end too.
But there are so many dragons here, Kibley
said, catching her talent and closing her
claws around the rock.
Angry dragons, violent dragons, injured
and dying dragons.
Won't it be overwhelming?
Won't it hurt you to have all their minds
flooding into yours right now?
Maybe, she said, but it's what I have to
do.
She tugged herself out of his grip, and
carefully placed the skyfire on top of
the jagged tooth of a boulder beside
her.
Kimble could see the tension whiplashing
through her muscles, as the thoughts of
100s of warring dragons clashed and
clawed at one another inside her head.
Moon slowly sank to the ground, her wings
spreading around her like a carpet of
fallen leaves, her palms pressed against
her eyes.
I hope she comes out of this, still
thinking there's good in other dragons.
I wonder if she's right.
Or if she sees us that way because that's
how she is.
I wonder if those dragons up there would
fight like this, if they could read each
other's minds.
If everyone could feel what she's feeling
if they understood all the other dragons
around them.
Would they still be able to kill each
other?
A tremor shivered through his wings.
What if that's the way to peace?
What if the way to change other dragons
isn't a spell that forces them to like
you, or makes them do what you want.
What if it's opening them up to other
minds and letting them decide for
themselves?
I have an idea.
He said to Turtle, who jumped slightly.
Oh, good, said Turtle, because I don't
have any.
Apart from stand here and try not to
die.
It's another spell.
Kibley said.
One that dark stalker won't be able to
counteract.
I hope, at least not right away.
We want the ice wings to win, don't we?
Anemone interjected.
What if we give all of them super
strength?
That would make it fair at least?
No, no, Kibley said.
We don't want to make the war worse.
We want to end it for good, forever, with
no more dragons dying.
He put one talent on Turtle's shoulder.
Can you do one more spell?
Yes, Turtle said solidly, or more
whatever you need.
No, Anamony jumped in.
I should do it.
Dark Stalker can't see me in his future.
He won't see it coming if I'm the one to
cast it.
She shot a look at Turtle, and then down
at her feet.
Besides, there's still hope for turtles
soul.
We shouldn't waste it.
Kibli cleared the leaves from a patch of
dirt with his tail.
He used his claw to ride out the spell
erasing and rewriting it until it was the
way he wanted it.
While he was working on it, Turtle bumped
his shoulder against anemones, and ducked
his head to meet her eyes.
It's not too late for your soul, he said
to her.
You're here now, with us.
You're on the right side, doing the right
thing.
You're not evil.
Maybe, a tiny bit, evil, Kinkaju
muttered.
I'm here because I want to destroy Dark
Stalker, Anemone said.
That doesn't exactly make me the most
heroic dragon in the world.
Come on, C snail, aren't you done yet?
She said to Kibley.
He nodded down at the spell.
That's it, he said.
I think, I hope it'll work.
Can we trust her?
Kinkaju asked.
What if she randomly decides to make all
the ice wings fall in love with winter or
something?
You are so ungrateful, Anemone said
huffily.
I was just trying to do something nice
for my brother because of his enormous
crush on you.
I was trying to make your love lives a
little happier, and all I get for it is
wine, wine, wine.
You don't get to decide who I'm in love
with.
Kinkaju cried, her scales rippling
scarlet and lavender.
Could we have this fight later?
Kibli asked.
Yes, pipe down, Anemone said to Kinkaju
who bared her teeth furiously.
I'm saving the world right now, although
this spell is super weird, Sandwing.
Just do it, please, anemone, or let me
said Turtle.
I need a thing to enchant, she said.
Kibley felt in his pouch, and took out
his library card from school.
Here, might as well use this, he said.
Anemone held it up gingerly in one talon
and leaned over to read what Kibley had
written in the dirt.
I enchant this object to connect the
minds of all the dragons in the battle
overhead for the space of 100 dragon
heartbeats, she said aloud, so that they
feel what every other dragon is feeling
as completely as they feel their own
emotions, and know exactly whose feelings
they're experiencing.
When that time is up, they will return to
normal.
And at that moment, I enchant this object
to instantly transport all the ice wings
to the main palace of the ice kingdom, and
all the night wings to the great diamond
in the night kingdom, safe and unharmed.
Anemone's eyes flicked up to her brother
for a moment.
And while we're at it, she added, I also
enchant this object to take the love
spell off Kingaju, so she can feel
whatever incredibly special feelings she
wants to feel about absolutely anyone and
stops annoying me about it.
Turtle gave her a wordless, grateful
smile.
Kinkaju just looked startled.
Kimli tipped his head back to watch the
fighting dragons.
Something was rippling through them.
It took a few moments to sink in, but he
could see the attacks faltering, the
claws pulling back, the confusion on
every face.
He felt moon rise to her feet beside
him.
Her expression suddenly clear and
peaceful.
She took a breath, and words spilled out
of her, just like the time she'd spoken
the Jade Mountain prophecy, but spinning
and tumbling faster and free like cactus
blossoms in the wind.
I see her dragonettes, waiting in fear
back in the night kingdom.
I feel her terror that she'll never see
them again.
She's fighting to protect them.
She thinks I want to kill them, and she
has to kill me first.
I see his mother.
Dying of the plague that dark stalkers
sent.
He loved her as much as I loved my
mother.
He wants to stop us before we kill any
more of his family.
I see years of hunger and fear.
I see a volcano seething with danger.
I see the endless struggle for survival
and the constant worry that his beloved
tribe would die out forever.
I see hope arrive in the form of a dragon
who promises everything, who promises all
the glory and power the tribe used to
have in a place of safety and beauty.
I see him fighting to protect it, because
he needs that hope.
I see her in an ice wing nursery.
Listening to the ancient tales of Dark
Stalker and the Night Wings, with wide
frightened eyes.
I see her nightmares.
I hear the stories that run through the
tribe, about how many ice wings
Darkstalker killed, even after his
supposed death, I see her study the
scrolls about night wings, wondering when
they will take the animus gift they stole
break through the great ice cliff, and
wipe out the entire ice wing tribe
because they hate them, and have always
hated them.
But you hated us first.
You hated us first.
You want to kill us all.
I'm afraid of you.
I'm afraid, and that is why I fight.
Silence fell.
The 100 heartbeats were up.
The night wings and ice wings faced one
another for a long moment.
And then they all vanished from the sky.
Chapter 28.
They're gone, Hinkaju said wonderingly.
Oops, said Turtle, scanning the sky.
I think we might have zapped winter back
to the ice kingdom, along with everyone
else.
Are they gone for good?
Kinkaju asked.
Or will they come flying right back?
Did we end the war or just postpone it?
If I understood their thoughts correctly
said Moon.
I think those dragons will have a hard
time killing one another from now on.
We did it, Khibli breathed.
You did it, said Moon.
She turned toward him with shining eyes.
He certainly did, said Dark Stalker
swooping down out of the sky.
He seized Kibley in his talons with
startling speed, and shot away on his
enormous wings.
Kibley!
Moon shouted.
It happened too fast for Kibli to react.
Massive claws dug into his chest, holding
him just tightly enough to let him know
that with the slightest bit more pressure
he'd be dead.
His wings were pinned to his back in an
uncomfortable twisted position.
He could tell if he struggled too much.
He might sprain one of them.
His tail swung free, but he knew that
stabbing Dark Stalker's invulnerable
scales with his venom barb would be
useless.
He could see the ground rushing by far
below him, or if he craned his neck
around, he could see the line of icy
white scales under dark stalkers beating
black wings.
Where is he taking me?
Why not just kill me?
Dark Stalker was huge.
But carrying an entire dragonette in his
talons still had to be exhausting for
him.
He wouldn't be able to go far, Kibley
hoped.
Sure enough, it wasn't long before Dark
Stalker banked suddenly and dove.
Hiibli's eyes stung in the rush of wind.
The earth seemed to be hurtling up toward
him, and he wondered if this was how he
was going to die, smashed into the dirt
by a vengeful monster from the past.
Then he saw a gaping maw ahead.
A mouth studded with rocks, and drooling
splintered trees.
The crevice gouged out a piece of
mountain, and went too deep to see the
bottom, at least from Kibley's dizzy
spinning point of view.
Apparently, he would see the bottom
though.
Dark Stalker plummeted straight into the
fissure and down, spiraling as the walls
narrowed in around them.
Kibley's suppressed claustrophobia rushed
over him, dying in a dark cave, where the
sun and wind would never touch his scales
again, was a recurring nightmare of his.
Is he taking me somewhere to kill me out
of sight?
So moon doesn't have to see it?
The light had faded to a small line
overhead.
When Dark Stalker slowed, and dropped
Kibley the last short distance to the
ground at the bottom of the gorge.
The stone was smooth and cold under
Kibley's talons, as he stood up shakily.
Dog Stalker sat on an outcropping just
above him, blocking the route to the
sky.
He plucked a stone from the cliff wall
and conjured it into a compact ball of
flames, setting it spinning beside him
like a haunted imitation of the sun.
The glow illuminated a cramped crawl
space behind Kibley, barely large enough
for a dragon the size of Dark Stalker to
turn around.
If he squashed his wings in, and stood on
his own tail as he did it.
All around, Kibli were claw marks in the
stone.
Hundreds upon 100s of scratches, some of
them firm and bold, others tiny, and
slanted to fit in around the others.
A discarded scrap of rusty metal wires
lay near the opening, frayed and looped
around a trio of misty white gemstones.
His tail brushed something the size of a
tooth.
When Kibley bent to pick it up.
It turned out to be a mouse skull, rubbed
almost smooth as velvet.
One thing I like about you.
Dark Stalker said conversationally, is
that I don't have to waste a lot of time
on tedious explanations.
I drop you somewhere, and your brain goes
clickety click, and a moment later, you
know where we are, and we can get on with
the interesting bits.
This is the cave Clearsight left you in
Kibley said.
Where you were buried for 1000s of
years.
That's the broken bracelet.
He nudged the fragment of wires.
Such a small, fragile thing to hold back
such a powerful danger.
Ghibli lifted a claw to touch one of the
scratches.
And these are the number of days you are
awake down here before perils set you
free.
Dark stalker flicked his tail at the
skull in Kibley's talons.
And that, left over from my only dinner
was also my only friend in the world
until I heard Moon's thoughts overhead
and realized another mind reader was
finally nearby.
Did you bring me down here to make me
feel sorry for you?
Kibley asked incredulously.
Dark Stalker's mouth quirked into a small
half smile.
Well, that empathy spell of yours was so
effective on my subjects, he said.
I figured it couldn't hurt, for you and I
to understand each other, a little
better.
It wasn't my spell, Ghibli said, tracing
the tiny eye holes of the mouse's skull.
Let's be serious.
Dark Stalker nudged the floating sun a
little closer to him.
That was your spell.
You like the magic, but you have the
ideas.
Kibley didn't answer.
You have the brains to be a great animus
dragon.
The turtle has the power instead, Dark
Stalker observed.
I know that's frustrating for you.
There was a pause.
I've noticed something, Dark Stalker said
a little more quietly.
You're just like me, Kibli.
Maybe even as smart as me.
Certainly smarter than everyone else.
You have big ideas, and lots of them, not
just one or 2 in a lifetime, like some
dragons.
You want to change things.
All the things that are wrong with the
world.
You know you could do it, if you had the
chance.
I'm not like you, Khibley interrupted.
I'm not a murderer.
Oh, but you would be.
Under the right conditions, Dark Stalker
said, waving this off, to protect your
queen, to save your tribe, or if it would
make moon love you.
That's not true, said Kibley.
She wouldn't love a murderer.
Sure, she would.
Dark Stalker looked amused.
You don't think she would love a dragon
who had to kill someone in order to save
Kinkaju, just for one example.
Or what if you figure out how to kill
me?
The amusement faded from his face.
Wouldn't she still love you then?
Do I figure out how to kill you?
In the future?
Kibley asked.
Avoiding Dark Stalker's question, and the
other questions that spiraled out of it
inside him.
Is that why you brought me here?
To stop that from happening?
Dark Stalker chuckled.
No, no.
There's no future in which I die.
That's impossible.
But there are futures where I go about my
business peacefully, and there are
futures where certain clever gnats
continue to annoy me for an interminable
length of time.
Something to aspire to, said Kibley.
Annoying, clever Natness.
Dark Stalker pointed a talent atom.
There's one crucial difference between
us.
He went on.
You want to be loved so desperately.
I think it lies underneath everything you
do.
Will this make that dragon like me
better?
What should I do now to turn all these
dragons into friends?
If I can convince this cold, standoffish
ice wing to like me.
Surely that'll prove that I'm a dragon
worth liking.
Excuse me, Kibley said.
I'm not the one who literally enchanted
the entire world to like me.
That was you, if you've forgotten.
But I got the idea from you, Dark Stalker
said.
Now immensely amused.
Your 1st day at Jade Mountain.
Oh, if only I could magically make
everyone like me.
Don't you remember?
That comes from the holes in your heart
that your family never bothered to fill.
My 1st thought was, how tremendously
sad.
What a tragic well of need that dragon
is.
And then I thought, But my.
That would be a useful spell.
How easy life would be if everyone liked
and trusted me.
No one scheming against me, sending
assassins to kill me.
Or getting irrationally upset over
perfectly harmless enchantments.
He frowned, as though a part of him was
locked in an endless argument with
someone long gone.
Clearsight and fathom like you, Kibley
said.
As I understand it, they loved you.
But they still risked everything to stop
you, because they saw how dangerous you
are.
Dark stalker snorted.
They couldn't think big, he said.
Not like you and me, Kibley.
They couldn't imagine all the wonderful
things we could do with our magic.
They would have been content with small
meaningless lives.
Clearly that's what they chose.
Look how they vanished from history after
I was gone.
They didn't want to take the hard steps
to get to the best futures.
He leaned toward Kibley.
But you can imagine it.
You know what you would do with unlimited
power.
You've thought about it enough.
Your big secret dream to be an animus.
He scratched a talon full of pebbles into
his claws, and they started to bounce and
bubble like boiling water.
One by one.
They turned into gemstones, tiny opals
and emeralds and amethysts, and tiger
eyes leaping and dancing together.
Khibli couldn't pull his eyes away from
them.
So what if you could be?
Dog stalker asked, in a low rumble.
What if I made you an animus too?
Hibli's talents felt as if they were
drifting away from him, suddenly as
unreal as the rest of this situation.
You would never do that, he said.
Even Turtle, my actual friend, refused to
do that for me.
I would, actually.
Dark Stalker plucked a ruby from the
spinning galaxy of gemstones and
scrutinized it.
Because I can see that if I do, it leads
to the best future, for you, for me, for
moon, for all of Pyria.
For you, Khibli wondered.
Wouldn't I use my magic against you?
In these hypothetical futures?
No, this is a trick.
He said out loud.
You're trying to trick me into taking off
my protective spell, and then you'll
enchant me.
That would be a reasonable worry, said
Dark Stalker, except that I am about 10
times as strong as you, and right now, I
could literally rip that earring off your
ear anytime I wanted to.
That was quite true.
Khibli realized uncomfortably.
He felt smaller than the dead mouth.
So, I don't need to orchestrate an
elaborate trick.
Dark Stalker twitched his wings.
Set the ruby in its own constellation, and
nudged an agate over to orbit it.
But you're right, there is a condition to
this offer.
I'll give you unlimited animus magic.
In exchange for a tiny spell that says
you can never do me any harm.
That seems quite fair to me, though.
My hope, of course, is that you won't
want to do me any harm, once we are
allies.
Never do him any harm, Kibli thought.
There would be ways around that.
This might be a trick, but I can turn it
back on him once I have that magic.
I could outsmart him if I was an animus.
If I say yes.
I could stop Dark Stalker and get all the
magic I've ever wanted.
Let me tell you about the best future.
Dark Stalker said dreamily.
You'll adore it.
Everyone loves us.
We share the continent and rule all the
tribes with benevolent wisdom.
You and moon, me and clear sight, once I
get a right.
Our dragonettes play together in the
palaces of Pyria.
There's no more war.
There's no more sickness, thanks to us.
No more sadness or worry, no more hunger
no more starving dragonettes, scrabbling
for food in back alleys.
No more terrible parents, because we can
fix them.
You could make your mother a dragon who
loves you.
I could have healed the scars on my
father's soul.
I know that's what I should have done.
To make him a father that Whiteout and I
could love.
He bowed his head for a moment.
Kimley didn't want to give him ideas, but
he had to ask.
But you could do all that by yourself.
So why would you share your power with me
when you could simply kill me right now.
Because I don't just want power, Kibli.
Dark Stalker said, a little impatiently.
That's what so many dragons get wrong
about me.
Even Clearside thought that way, toward
the end.
He selected a pair of perfect diamonds
from his treasure cloud and set them
spinning on their own axis with the
ruby.
I also want to make the world a better
place.
I want to have real friends I care
about.
I want my happily ever after.
You think I could be your real friend.
Kibley asked.
You're funny and not boring. said Dark
Stalker.
You can keep up with my conversation.
Unlike pretty much all of my subjects
except Moon, You have ideas that I
haven't already had myself, which is
fascinating and rare.
I like to be surprised, I mean, unless
the surprise involves betrayal and
involuntary comas, of course.
Yes.
I think we'd get along really well.
Ghibli wondered about that.
Was Dark Stalker right?
Were there really futures where they were
friends, even co-rulers?
And you'd be a good influence on me, Dark
Stalker said charmingly.
I can see that too.
You steer me through some pretty rough
times, and save a lot of dragons from my
mistakes.
We all end up on much better paths if
we're friends.
I mean, consider my alternatives.
If you're not my friend, moon won't be
either, and then who do I have?
This lizard?
He snapped his claws, and with a
startling popping sound, vultures
suddenly materialized in the air beside
him.
Kibley's grandfather let out a yell of
surprise, where am I?
He shouted.
What did you do?
He craned his neck to look up at the
speck of sky far above them, his talons
pressed against the sheer rock walls, and
Kibli knew the sandwing claustrophobia
was snaring him too.
And yet, even though he could see
vulture's fear, Kibli's heart still tried
to make a run for it.
He felt it galloping wildly around his
chest, like a terrified chinchilla, he
couldn't stop himself from crouching
trying to make himself smaller until
perhaps he'd be invisible, and then
Vulture wouldn't be able to hurt him.
He wouldn't be able to worm inside
Kibley's ears and make him doubt
everything that was real.
Enchant this dragon to obey my every
command.
Dark Stalker said offhandedly.
He tapped Vulture on the forehead.
Stop talking and stay where you are.
Vulture's eyes bulged as he tried to snap
something furious and failed.
His talons touched down on a small bump
of stone, and he teetered there, unable
to fly away.
I can't believe you're so terrified of
this salamander.
Dog stalker said to Kibley with a
chuckle.
He's so easy to manipulate, even without
magic.
Thin scales, loves treasure, lies about
everything, until he doesn't even know
what's true, not that he cares.
He's a dragon made of paper, who has
never been happy one day in his life.
Kibli took in a lung full of air, trying
to see his grandfather that way.
It was hard, with those black eyes
attempting to spear him in the gut.
If you accept my gift, Dark Stalker said
you never have to worry about him, or
anyone else like him ever again, watch.
He tapped Vulture's head again.
Enchant this dragon to have the mind of a
new hatched dragonette.
You may speak.
Vulture's head slowly lolled sideways, and
a goofy grin spread across his face.
He chirped at Kibley.
It was one of the most horrifying things
Kibley had ever seen.
Perhaps reading Kibley's expression.
Dark Stalker hastily reached over and
tapped Vulture again.
Go back to the way you were before the
last spell, he said.
Now, I enchant this dragon to feel guilt
for all the terrible things he's done.
Vulture's face collapsed into grief.
I'm a monster, he whispered.
Oh, those deaths.
The cruelty to my family.
How can I ever make up for it all?
See how easy it is?
Dark Stalker said to Kibley.
Let's see.
Now be a grandfather, who loves Kibli
more than anything else in the world.
He ordered Vulture.
Kibli.
Vulture cried. reaching his talons toward
his grandson.
Dearest of dragons.
Have I ever told you how proud I am of
you?
An outlaw.
Advisor to Queen Thorn.
I missed our games so much when you went
away with her.
But you've grown into such a fine young
dragon.
Stop it.
Stop it, Kibley said, covering his ears.
It's not real.
Of course it is.
Vulture cried exuberantly.
Shush, Dark Stalker said to him, and
Vulture instantly fell silent.
But of course it's real, he said to
Kibley.
We just made it real.
He really feels that way with all his
heart right now.
Because you put a spell on him, Kibley
said, that's not what real means.
Dark Stalker looked skeptical.
If magic can improve a dragon. he said.
I don't see what the problem is.
We could turn your grandfather into the
kindest dragon in the scorpion den.
Wouldn't it be fun?
To watch him give away his entire
treasure. to orphans and homeless
dragons.
Yes, whispered a small but unavoidable
part of Kibley's soul.
Wouldn't that be the best way to deal
with this dragon who has haunted your
nightmares your entire life?
Dark Stalker asked.
Wouldn't it be better than killing him, or
whatever the real alternatives are?
Yes.
Kibley's heart whispered again.
So, Why didn't you do that?
Kibley asked Dark Stalker.
What do you mean?
Dark Stalker asked.
To the ice wings.
Kibley said.
When you 1st came out of the mountain, and
you saw visions of them threatening your
tribe.
Why didn't you enchant them all to want
peace with you instead?
Or cast a spell to make all ice wings and
night wings forget their ancient hatred
and forgive everything that's happened?
Why didn't you use your magic to avoid
war instead of trying to kill them all?
Dark Stalker's eyes narrowed.
His jaw worked silently for a long moment
as though he was grinding his teeth.
See?
He finally managed to force out.
Smart, like I said, always thinking.
He turned his head away and thought for
another moment.
Because I haven't forgiven them, he
admitted finally.
For what happened to my mother.
He took a deep breath.
All right.
I see your point.
I thought I was protecting the tribe.
But it was about revenge too.
I can see that.
He spoke, as if each word was a tooth
being yanked out of his mouth.
Maybe you need to put a kindness spell on
yourself, Kibley suggested.
This is what I mean, Dog Stalker said
slowly.
How you can keep me on the better paths.
You'll suggest peace spells instead of
plagues.
You'll help me see these things I don't
recognize about myself.
He paused, and Kipley could tell that
Dark Stalker wasn't entirely convinced
that that was what he wanted.
Is that what I want?
To be Dark Stalker's conscience?
To spend my life telling him the things
he doesn't want to hear?
But, I'd have animus magic.
And moon would love me.
In this future, he sees me with moon.
She must forgive me for this choice.
Maybe it's what she would want.
Me with magic and a chance to influence a
better, kinder, dark stalker.
Are the ice wings safe in his future?
Where's winter?
Are we still friends?
Is turtles safe?
What happens to anemone?
Does she have to hide for the rest of her
life?
No, I could fix all of that.
I could keep them all safe.
I'd have animus magic.
I could do everything I've ever wanted to
do.
So what do you think?
Dark Stalker asked.
Are you ready to become an animus
dragon?
He drew a circle in the air around the
floating gemstones, and they all whirled
into one another until they became a
crown, glowing with gems from all over
the world.
Dark Stalker nudged the crown to set it
floating gently toward Kibley.
Who would say no to their secret dream
come true?
Why would I ever say no?
Say yes to the magic.
Say yes to the bright future.
Say yes.
Kibley looked up into Dark Stalker's eyes
and said, No.
Chapter 29.
Oh, that's not the right answer.
Dog stalker said, fanning out his wings.
The gemstone crown vanished abruptly.
That answer leads to bad, bad, bad
futures, Kibley.
No, for a lot of reasons, Kibley said
starting with this one.
I like you, but I can't trust you.
I don't know what you'd put in the spell
on me, but if there's a chance it could
turn me evil.
I don't want to risk it.
I don't want to turn into a dragon who
plays with other dragons like toys.
He nodded at the mute figure of his
grandfather, perched awkwardly beside
Dark Stalker.
Bad futures.
Dark Stalker continued.
His brows lowering.
Because if you don't accept my offer.
I have to kill you.
Surely you understand that.
Kibley felt full of holes, all the way
through his bones.
Was he really going to die without seeing
moon again?
Without knowing for sure that all his
friends were safe.
Dark Stalker shook his head.
You're too much trouble if you're not my
friend.
When I take the Nightwing Army out
again.
I can't have you coming up with more
clever tricks to stop me.
I don't like those futures.
I also don't like the futures, where I do
kill you, because Moon never forgives
me.
And then I have no friends, Kibley.
Enchanted friends, who aren't the same.
No one to keep me good.
Where do you think that leads?
The fact that you can't be good on your
own, said Kibli.
That's part of the problem.
You shouldn't need a dragon on your
shoulder telling you, that killing all
the ice wings is wrong, or that taking
over your father's mind was an awful
thing to do.
He deserved it.
Dark Stalker hissed.
You don't really want that dragon on your
shoulder either.
Khibli shook his head.
You wouldn't even have listened to
Clearsight if she tried to be that
dragon.
I can do it myself, Dark Stalker said.
Abruptly shifting course.
See, here I go.
Hey, overlords of dragon morality.
I hereby acknowledge that killing Kibley
would be something only an evil dragon
would do.
And since I'm not evil.
I am not going to do that.
I am going to take the high road.
Rip off his earring, and enchant him to
be my best friend instead.
No wait, Kibley said, taking a step back
into the crawl space.
His bag bumped hard against his chest
ricochetting off his pounding heart.
Let's talk about, um, moral gray areas.
Dark stalk or froze and cocked his head.
What is that?
The last vestiges of your soul, trying to
cough up a reason to let me go?
Khibley suggested.
No, that...
Whirring sound.
Dog stalker shook his head, like there
were mosquitoes in his ears.
Kibli went quiet, listening, and for the
1st time, felt the vibrations coming from
his bag.
Puzzled, he tugged it open and pulled out
the old telescope hourglass contraption
he'd found in the Night Palace.
To his surprise, the hourglass was
spinning frantically on its axis, and it
sped up as he turned the end of the
telescope toward Dark Stalker and
Vulture.
Where did you get that?
Dark Stalker asked, in a hushed voice.
I found it in a room in your palace
Kibley said.
What is it?
Why is it spinning like that?
Dark Stalker edged forward on his
outcropping and stretched his neck down
toward it.
Kibley held the telescope up to his eye
and centered it on Dark Stalker's
bewildered face.
I made that.
Dark Stalker said.
For Fathom.
Such a long time ago.
I mean, it doesn't feel that long to me
but I know it was.
He squinted at the hourglass, which was
still spinning.
It's a soul reader.
A soul reader, Kibley echoed.
I made it to reassure Fathom that we were
fine, that we could use our magic safely
without going evil.
His expression was curiously affectionate
as if he'd just remembered a version of
Fathom he genuinely liked.
It shows how much of your soul is still
good.
The hourglass slowed, tipped one way, then
the other, and finally stopped.
The telescope was pointed at dark stalker
inside the hourglass.
The bottom half was almost entirely full
of white sand.
In the bell of the top half, only a few
grains of black sand were left.
Dark stalker stared at it.
Disbelief slowly crawling across his
face.
Well, that makes no sense, he said.
Did you do something to it?
The turtle put a new spell on it.
No, Kibley said, touching the hourglass.
It swayed slightly under his claws, the
sand shifting, but staying where it was.
I didn't even know it was animus
touched.
What does this mean?
Dog Stalker snatched the object out of
Kibley's talons, and flipped it over a
few times, as if looking for signs of
tampering, before turning it back toward
himself, and squinting at the hourglass
again.
It must be broken, he muttered, starting
over.
He shook it vigorously for a moment, and
then held it out in his talons.
When this soul readers pointed at a
dragon.
I enchanted to measure the good and evil
in that dragon's soul, and reveal it in
the drifts of sand.
Black sand to mark the amount of good
white sand to show the amount of evil, or
damage to that dragon's soul.
Oh, Kibley thought.
Interesting.
The black sand indicates goodness.
Makes sense for a night wing.
He wasn't surprised, now that he
understood it, by the balance of sand in
Dark Stalker's hourglass.
Dark Stalker pointed the telescope at
Vulture, and peered through it.
The hourglass obligingly began to spin
sending whirlwinds of sand dancing inside
it.
At last it stopped and settled into
equilibrium.
In the top half, a tiny sprinkling of
black sand, about the same as dark
stalkers, in the bottom half, a
correspondingly large pile of glittering
white sand.
Now that's logical.
Dark Stalker muttered.
He's obviously terrible.
So it's working now.
He frowned down at the soul reader
inhaled deeply, and pointed the end of
the telescope at himself.
Shrum, shrum, shrum, the hourglass
tumbled busily.
It slowed to a stop.
As before, the mountain of white sand in
the bottom was large, almost large enough
to overflow the bulb, and in the top half
shown those last few tiny grains of black
sand.
But that's impossible.
Dog stalker exploded.
He threw the soul reader away from him
violently, and Kibli lunged to catch it
before it shattered on the stone floor.
I protected my soul.
Dark Stalker cried.
Veins were starting to throb in his neck
writhing like livid snakes under his
scales. 1st with my scroll, and now with
my wristband.
I shouldn't have lost any of it.
And yet, it looks like you've lost almost
all of it, Kibley pointed out.
He was shocked to see how much this upset
Dark Stalker.
The ancient night wing seemed to swell to
twice his normal enormous size.
His wings were flared and twitching
wrathfully.
No!
Dark Stalker slammed his tail into the
crevasse wall, unleashing a scamper of
loud pebbles.
I'm not like other animus dragons.
I'm smarter than they are.
My soul is safe from my magic.
That can't be what it looks like.
Safe from your magic, maybe.
Kibley said, but not safe from your
actions.
What?
Dark Stalker roared.
Hibli squared his shoulders and held his
ground, although the expression on Dark
Stalker's face kind of made him want to
retreat all the way back into the crawl
space.
You didn't lose your soul because magic
ate it away slowly, Kibley said.
You lost it, because you chose to do
terrible things, over and over again.
Each terrible thing, each betrayal, each
murder, added to this mountain.
He tapped the white sand side.
That's not the magic's fault.
That's you.
That's who you chose to be.
But, I had good reasons for everything I
did, Dark Stalker said.
Visions of a good future.
Doesn't that count for something?
Yes, sometimes, Khibli agreed.
But not when your choices are so dark and
damaging.
Not when there were better alternatives
you didn't even explore.
Blah, blah, blah.
Dark stalker muttered, but he was staring
into space now.
Who?
That's not possible.
Is it?
Where does that go?
How does it end?
He twisted his neck around to look above
and behind him.
Can you see what I'm seeing?
Come on out.
I've obviously known you were there since
you crawled down here.
There was a pause, and then a ripple in
the rocks overhead.
Whirls of yellow and blue, suddenly
appearing on the gray, and spreading into
the shape of a dragon, who is covering
the shape of another dragon, clinging to
the small claw holds in the wall.
Huh, said Dark Stalker.
Actually, I didn't know she was there.
He jerked his chin at Kinkachu as she
peeled herself off Moon.
The rain wing shot a glare at him, and
fluttered down to sit beside Kibley.
A moment later, Moon landed on his other
side, and even though this meant the 3 of
them were crowded together in the small
space, Kibley was finally able to
breathe.
Hello, dark stalker, Moon said.
Can you see this vision?
he asked, reaching down toward her.
Ghibli shivered as Moon rested her talon
in the giant night wing's palm.
She closed her eyes for a long moment.
Isn't that strange?
Dog stalker said.
It's so blurred, and it ends in
darkness.
Is someone going to betray me again?
But no one's magic can hurt me anymore.
And who?
Did you see her?
She looks like.
But she can't be.
If it was her, said Moon, opening her
eyes again.
Would you take that path?
Even knowing it ends in possible
darkness?
Would you do it to see her again?
A light was kindling in Dark Stalker's
eyes.
But do you?
He stopped, his claws gripping the
stone.
Yes, of course I would.
Then let's see where this path leads, Moon
said, tipping her snout up to the sky.
Dark Stalker spread his wings and
paused.
He leaned over to Vulture, tapped his
head, and whispered something.
Kibley's grandfather vanished again as
suddenly as he'd appeared.
Then Dark Stalker took off, aiming for
the crack of sky overhead.
Hibli exhaled with relief.
This was not his final resting place
after all.
He would live to see another sunrise
although he wasn't sure he could count on
more than one.
Come on, we have to keep up.
Kinkaju said, leaping aloft.
Her wings looked like flower petals on a
river as she flashed away across the gray
stone.
But Moon stopped one of Kibley's wings
with her own before he could follow
suit.
I heard all that, she said. looking at
him searchingly.
Why did you say no to his offer?
Did you want me to say yes?
He asked.
So I could be more special, like you.
I know.
It's what I've wished for a 100 times.
I just...
If I'd been born in animus.
That would be one thing.
But I couldn't accept it as a gift from
him.
It wouldn't be safe.
And I wouldn't know if I was myself
anymore.
He glanced down at the soul reader.
That much power.
It would change me.
And I'm not sure it would change me in
ways I would like.
Or, um, ways you would like.
Kibli, she said, so fiercely that he
flinched, was she going to tell him to
change his mind, to chase after Dark
Stalker and beg for the magic after all?
Moon seized his talons in hers.
How are you so brilliant and such an
idiot at the same time?
You are special.
You don't need his poisoned magic, or any
magic.
You're smart, and you're brave, and you
care, and you don't give up, and you take
all of that, and use it to help other
dragons instead of yourself.
That's better than magic.
You did the right thing.
I did?
He said.
Hey, swooning friends, Kinkaju shouted
from far overhead.
Am I defeating dark soccer by myself
today?
Don't you at least want to come watch?
Moon laughed and let go of Kibley.
Time to fly, she said.
And they did.
Chapter 30.
A dragon was waiting for them.
On one of the peaks of Jade Mountain.
The 3 moons illuminated her silhouette
and Kibli heard Dark Stalker inhale
sharply.
He abruptly looped back in the sky to
hover in front of Moon.
I'm not going to fall for this.
Turtle made her, didn't he?
He said.
The way I made Clearsight.
This is a plan to mess with my head.
But his expression wasn't angry, or
suspicious.
Kibley thought it was more desperately
hopeful.
No, Moon said.
She's real dark stalker.
She's been in the ice kingdom all these
years, trapped in a kind of suspended
animation spell.
She has only lived for tiny fragments of
time here and there.
So she is not much older than when you
last saw her.
I thought they killed her, he said, his
voice breaking.
Moon hesitated.
It's, It's actually worse, what Queen
Diamond did to her, but she's all right
now.
She wants to see you.
Dark Stalker wheeled around without
further argument and soared down to the
dragon on the mountaintop.
She turned to face him, her wings
whispering across the frozen violets that
dotted the grass around her talons.
It was the dragon from the palace library
Kibley realized.
Moon beckoned to Kibley and Kingachu, and
they landed softly nearby, close enough
to hear without intruding.
Neither a dragon said anything for a long
moment, as Dark Stalker stepped closer
and closer to her, his face still anxious
with disbelief, his long neck and vast
wings towering over her.
Finally, he stopped right in front of her
and crouched, making himself as small as
he could.
Mother, he said.
She opened her wings to him.
Dog stalker, she said.
My beloved disaster.
The 2 dragons folded into each other.
Kibli could hear Dark Stalker's quiet
sobs carried on the wind.
Huh, he thought.
So Dark Stalker has a mother who loves
him.
Oh, very good idea, Kibley.
This is an excellent time for some self
pity.
Where did she come from?
He asked Moon softly.
She's the night wing winter rescued from
the ice kingdom.
Moon whispered.
Foe Slayer.
She's been hiding in the shadows, watching
him and the other night wings, trying to
figure out what was happening and what
she should do.
She didn't want to see him immediately?
Khibli said. surprised.
Well, she'd heard what he did to his
father, Moon said, making her voice even
quieter, and she really loved Arctic, you
know?
I think she was afraid Dark Stalker had
lost his mind.
And she didn't know if her reappearance
would make it worse.
She said she was thinking of fleeing the
continent instead.
And then she met you.
Oh, he said, remembering their
conversation in the library, and all the
things he probably wouldn't have said
about Dark Stalker if he'd known she was
his mother.
I guess you made her realize she had to
try reaching him. said Moon.
She came to us after the battle when she
saw Dark Stalker take you.
We were chasing after him and she joined
us.
She said she wanted to help.
I hope she can, he said, but I don't know
how.
You'd be surprised what that kind of love
can do, Moon said, with a wistful look.
He wondered if she was thinking about her
own mother, and her strange upbringing
hidden away in the rainforest, but loved
very, very much.
Mother, Dark Stalker said, in a sudden
rush, sitting up to look at her.
Do you remember?
The sole reader I made.
Yes, she said wryly.
I remember you prowling around the house
trying to catch your father with it to
read his soul.
He hesitated, perhaps reading on her face
that she knew everything about what had
happened with Arctic.
It.
It says I'm evil, he said to her, sounding
centuries younger than he looked, like
all the way almost entirely completely
evil.
Worse than father ever was.
I'm not though, am I?
I'm not.
Evil.
Well, said Fowslayer.
I can't say I entirely approve of your
choices lately, or 2000 years ago, for
that matter.
Dark Stalker hunched his shoulders, his
wings hanging askew.
It was his fault.
You got caught by the ice wings.
He said petulantly.
No.
It was my fault, but letting a stupid
fight make me so mad I took off my
protection.
What did they do to you?
In the ice kingdom, Dark Stalker asked.
I'll make them pay.
You can watch while I make them all
sorry.
His claws jerked open and closed again.
None of the ice wings alive today did
anything to me.
Those layers said firmly, except for one
who freed me from my prison.
But you were imprisoned, he said, pouncing
on that word, all this time.
Wasn't it awful?
Don't you want revenge?
I was never a vengeful dragon, she said
with a sigh.
You get that from your father.
Calm down.
It's true.
But it doesn't make sense to punish the
ice wing tribe.
For what happened to us all those
centuries ago, dark stalker.
Queen Diamond is long gone.
The war should have ended then.
Time has moved on without us, and we
should let it.
Not drag it back into the blood and fire
of our old fight.
But they started it?
She interrupted.
They don't see it that way.
I remember what Arctic did during our
escape from the ice kingdom.
I understand why they were so angry, and
why he never really recovered.
I'm sorry, you had to live a life shaped
by that anger.
She reached out to trace the lines of his
face.
I wish.
I could start over and give you a happy
life instead.
Maybe you can, Moon said, moving forward
into the moonlight.
That's true, Dark Stalker said.
You can help me rule Pyria, mother.
I wouldn't need anyone else then.
He touched his forehead.
Why can't I see that future?
Because I would never say yes to that.
Those Slayer said, sadly, Wait, Dark
Stalker.
Moon cut in.
I've had a new vision, since the moment
Jade Mountain didn't fall.
I wasn't sure it was a vision at first
but it keeps looping back over and over.
Which one?
Dog Stalker asked, his gaze shifting to
the far away look.
Kibli, as an animus.
I liked that one, although it wasn't
strongly probable.
The others, none of them are perfect.
I can see I never get clear sight right.
The Ice Kingdom is a frozen wasteland
that's a misery to conquer.
The sea wings never stop popping out of
the ocean to fight us, no matter how many
times I think I've stamped them out.
The rain wings are impossible.
It's like trying to fight butterflies.
An army of invisible butterflies who can
melt your face off the moment you fall
asleep.
He rubbed his eyes.
Thanks to those wretched earrings
becoming king of the whole continent, it's
a lot harder than it should be.
It's exhausting.
I'm tired, and I haven't even begun yet.
He sat down heavily.
Resting his chin on the ground in front
of Foe Slayer.
And what's the point?
he said sadly.
Clear so it's gone.
I never have dragonette.
I never fall in love again.
You're still my only friend, and you and
mother spend the rest of your lives
yelling at me.
He snapped one of the ice covered flowers
off its stem, and crushed it into tiny
purple fragments between his claws.
Is that what you see, move?
Moon?
Not exactly, she said.
The vision I see.
I don't think you'd be able to see it.
He raised his head and looked offended.
Oh, really?
You can see a future, I can't.
I think so, she said.
If I'm right about it.
It's a vision of a dragonette.
He's growing up in the rainforest.
He loves to weave and fish and sing.
His favorite fruit is strawberries, which
he and his friends fly to the mountains
to find.
He teaches himself to make jam and pies
and he writes a song called strawberries
as big as a scavenger's head, which
becomes the anthem for a yearly
strawberry festival.
He lives a peaceful, ordinary life.
He marries the tribe's blacksmith, and
they have 2 funny little dragonettes, who
steal his strawberries and make him laugh
every day.
They're with him when he dies quietly in
his sleep.
She paused, watching him expectantly.
Well, I don't know who that is, he said.
She kept looking at him and he frowned.
I mean, who loves strawberries that
much?
I've never tried one.
They look like they're full of seeds.
Really?
Moon said with a little laugh.
They're not at all.
You'd like them?
I saw some over here.
Those layers said, searching a patch of
leaves near her talons.
She plucked one of the dark, jewel red
fruits and passed it to her son.
He held the green stem between his claws
and eyed it suspiciously.
Wait, he said.
You think the dragon in your vision is
me.
You, without your powers, said Moon, you
without your memories, a new you, with a
chance to start over.
Dark Stalker snorted.
Little puffs of flame shooting out of his
nose.
Why would I ever give up my powers?
he said.
I'm the most powerful dragon Pyria has
ever seen.
Everyone wants to be me.
I don't, said Kibley.
Me neither, said Kinkachu.
Evil and smug and fat headed and evil.
No, thank you.
I'm not, Dark Stalker started, and then
surprisingly, fell silent.
Beauslayer settled her tail over his, and
patted one of his free talons, as though
it was a lonely sloth.
You could be happy, she said to him.
You could be loved.
But you have to choose it, Moon said.
You're the only one who can make it
real.
Imagine it, dark stalker.
If you turn yourself into a different
dragon.
You could actually do good things for the
world.
He shook his head vigorously.
That's ridiculous.
Without my powers.
What do I do?
Make pie.
You must be joking.
Couldn't I do more good things with my
powers intact?
He asked.
Like, take Pyrea into the glorious future
I've seen.
I'd rather have pie, Hinkachu said.
Moon shook her head.
The future of Pyria is not your own
personal scroll, waiting for you to write
it, Dark Stalker.
The only future you control is yours, and
you have not brought happiness to the
dragon tribes.
We don't want that future you see if we
have to travel your dark path to get
there.
Dark Stalker spun the strawberry in his
claws for a moment, thinking.
Do it, Thoslayer said quietly.
Become a dragonette again.
I'll take care of you.
I want to.
We'll be happy this time.
All I see this way is darkness. he said
touching his forehead.
Darkness is all the rest of us see.
If you do become king, Moon said, but
this way.
No, he said.
I can't.
I can't do it.
I won't.
Moon blinked, looking bewildered.
But my vision.
I'm sure this is the path you choose.
Dark Stalker's tail lashed back and forth
throwing off his mother's.
I don't want to lose all my memories.
I'd forget clear sight.
She'd be even more gone than she is now.
He rose to his feet.
No, I'm going to be king.
King of the whole continent, king of all
the tribes.
That's my future.
I've seen it a 1000 times.
Dark Stalker, please.
Moon pleaded.
I know there's good in you still.
If you listen to it, you'll choose this
for yourself, I'm sure you will.
You are a bunch of small minded little
lizards, he said, rising to his full
height and spreading his wings.
What did you think?
I'd taste a strawberry and decide, mmm
wow, that's worth giving up my magic
for.
He looked down at the tiny fruit in his
claws and ripped off all the green
leaves.
Or did you have turtle enchant this?
Or perhaps another secret animus I don't
know about?
It doesn't matter.
You boring, ordinary creatures.
I can't be enchanted by anyone.
I'm smarter now.
I've made myself completely safe.
Nobody's animus magic will work on me
which means nobody will ever be able to
stop me.
He threw the strawberry in its mouth and
swallowed it.
Casting a dark look at his mother.
Actually, said Kinkaju.
There is one dragon's magic that will
still work on you.
He glowered down at her.
You're wrong.
I'm right, she snapped back.
Oh, really?
Whose?
She glared right back, and her scales
were the color of burning strawberries.
Your own.
Chapter 31.
Kinkaju upended her pouch and poured a
tiny pile of scraps of paper onto the
ground in front of her.
Kibley's mouth dropped open.
The last pieces of Dark Stalker's scroll
the ones chameleon used to transform
himself into different dragons.
He could see the dark, jagged scrawl of
Parel's father's handwriting on them.
And then, as Kinkachu carefully flipped
them over, he recognized her own awkward
lettering on the other side, and he
remembered the hours and hours she'd
spent practicing so she could be the 1st
rain wing in a century to learn to
write.
She used his own magic against him.
What?
Dog stalker said, choking.
But how?
I didn't see.
I know.
Kinkachu said proudly, never saw me
coming, taken down by a ball of fluff.
Who's insignificant now, frog face?
Dark soccer collapsed forward.
No, he was shrinking, Kibley realized.
You knew?
He gasped to his mother.
You helped her.
Of course I did, she said.
What else could I do?
Send you to your room?
Extra chores for week?
Somehow, neither of those seemed
particularly apt for this situation.
She patted his shoulder.
He was now about the same size as her.
It was this, or leave forever, and never
see you again.
I decided we'd both be happier this way.
But my powers, he cried.
His voice was higher, less cavernous and
booming now, as his lungs shrank.
All my magic.
Can't I keep any of it?
The mind reading?
Wait.
Dark soccer held up his front talons
watching the claws get smaller.
Sorry, Dark Stalker, Hibley said.
You had more than one chance to use them
wisely and well, and you chose not to.
I really thought he was going to choose
this for himself, Moon said, tipping her
head at the shrinking dragon.
Oh, I knew he wouldn't, Kinkachu said, but
I couldn't tell you my awesome plan
obviously.
You told her, though.
Why didn't he see it in your mind?
Moon asked Foeslayer.
You don't raise a mind reading sun
without learning a few tricks about how
to hide your thoughts, those slayers said
calmly, Didn't I help you?
Dark Stalker said. in a lost, small voice
looking up at Moon.
Didn't I save dragons too?
I'm not evil.
I'm not.
Not anymore, Kinkaju said.
As a shimmer spread across his scales.
Dark stalker was a dragonette now, younger
than anemone, and then younger still
until he appeared to be about one year
old.
He lifted his wings awkwardly, and Kibley
noticed that the line of white ice wing
scales was gone from under his wings.
But he wasn't entirely black either.
Underneath his wings, in place of the
usual night wing silver star scales, he
had a constellation of rainbow colored
scales, one emerald green here, one
parrot blue there, sunrise gold, and
oranges scattered throughout the black
scales, like shining beetles dropped on a
dark velvet cloth.
What in the world?
Moon asked.
Oh, yeah, I made him half rain wing
Kinkaju said, fighting back a giggle.
I thought that would be good for him, and
it turned out so pretty.
I'll work it into my backstory.
Those slayers said to Moon.
If the other night wings ever wonder
where I came from.
You're going to join the tribe, Kibley
asked her, and live with them.
The ones in the rainforest.
She said.
It's beautiful there, and I hear good
things about our new queen.
She smiled at Moon.
I don't know what the others are going to
do when Doc Stalker never comes back, but
I couldn't live in the old night kingdom
anyway.
Too many memories.
The dragonette at her feet had been
examining his talons closely for the last
few minutes.
Now his head popped up, and he bonked her
leg with it.
Hungry.
He chirped.
What are your new names going to be?
Hibli asked.
Oh.
I'm not sure, she said.
You should be awesomeness.
Kingaju suggested.
Salvation, said Moon.
Beauslayer laughed.
That's a little grandiose from me.
She picked up the tiny dragonette that
used to be Dark Stalker.
He didn't look like a young dark
stalker.
His face was too round, and his eyes set
too wide, but more than all that, there
was a serenity in his expression, that
Kibley had never glimpsed on Dark
Stalker's face.
Being bombarded by dragon thoughts, all
day long, from the moment you hatch
probably isn't the most peaceful
existence, he gasped.
The dragonette wrapped his arms and legs
around his mother's neck and nudged her
ear with a snout.
Hungry, he said in a loud whisper.
Here, she said, delving into the patch of
leaves next to her again.
Have some strawberries.
He seized them with enormous delight and
stuffed 2 in his mouth at once, dripping
berried juice down his neck.
I think I'll call him Peacemaker, she
said.
I wonder, if history would have been
different if I'd chosen a name like that
from the beginning.
Peacemaker.
Kibli couldn't help but find the name a
bit ironic, but then this wasn't Dark
Stalker anymore.
He was an entirely new dragon, and the
spell wasn't in a piece of jewelry that
could be removed.
It was inside him once he'd eaten that
1st enchanted strawberry, changing him
permanently and forever.
He'd never remember being Dark Stalker.
He was peacemaker now, and for always.
I have a name for you, Kibley said to Foe
Slayer, if you're interested.
Let's hear it, she said.
He smiled at the little dragon stuffing
his face with strawberries.
I was thinking maybe hope.
Hope, she said thoughtfully.
I like that.
Epilogue.
Moon soared down to the dripping trees
scattering raindrops off the branches, and
setting yellow and green parakeets of
flutter.
Below her, she could see the night wing
village spread out along the river bank.
Nearly all the night wings who had left
with Dark Stalker had returned to the
rainforest after he disappeared.
The ruins of the old kingdom on the Talon
Peninsula would be fascinating to study.
Queen Glory was setting up a team to do
that now.
But it turned out they weren't actually a
great place to live, especially for
dragons who were just starting to get
used to the plentiful food of the
rainforest.
Glory would have let them stay there, and
choose a new queen for themselves, if
that's what they'd wanted, but despite
fierce teeth's best efforts, most
Nightwings ended up deciding that a rain
wing queen wasn't such a catastrophe
after all. especially in comparison to a
king, who instantly brainwashed them and
took them to war.
They were all still pretty shell shocked
by that.
And by the experience of seeing into the
hearts of the ice wings they were trying
to kill.
You'll hear again.
Moon's mother teased, as Moon swept down
to land in the village clearing.
Don't you ever have schoolwork to do.
I finished it already, Moon said, jumping
out to hug her mother with her wings.
Secret keeper held her clothes, and her
mind said everything about how much she
missed Moon, even though she wouldn't let
herself say it out loud.
The hum of background thoughts in the
rainforest was so different these days.
The night wings were too busy to be
resentful, too well fed to keep
complaining, and too abashed by their
instant hero worship of dark stalker, to
think about leaving again.
They'd discovered that when they stopped
grumbling all the time, they actually
quite liked it in the rainforest.
Queen Glory couldn't hand out superpowers
but she had forged another piece with a
new ice wing queen, and most of the night
wings had really lost their taste for
war.
You know, you don't have to stay at
school if you miss me so much.
Secret Keeper said, nudging Moon's
snout.
No, I still love it, Moon said.
Kingaju and I got a new clawmate, a
mudwing.
I like her.
I miss the ones who aren't in our winglet
anymore, though.
Cornelian, umber, winter, Kibley.
There was still hope that one of them
would come back.
She hoped for it every day.
I should go see him.
I should tell him how I feel.
I've certainly thought about it enough
trying to figure out how I feel about
each of them.
I didn't want to choose.
But if I want either of them in my life, I
know I have to.
Moon sighed and looked around the
clearing.
She let her mother think these visits
were to see her, but really, she was
checking on Dark Stalker, not Dark
Stalker, Peacemaker, and there he was
close to the river, making mud pies.
Moon, he sang happily as he saw her
approaching, moon, moon, moon, pies.
He scrambled over with a smudge of mud on
his snout, and hugged her leg.
How are you today, peacemaker?
Moon asked.
Feeling even the slightest bit evil
contemplating the conquest of the world?
She knew Kinkaju had worded the
transformation spell very carefully, but
there was a part of her that couldn't
help worrying all the time.
Sleepy.
He said promptly.
Mommy made me get up so early.
Which is not how most dragons would
describe noon, Hope pointed out, hopping
down from one of the baobab trees
overhead.
We're all trying to adjust to some kind
of normal night wing sleep schedule.
She said to Moon.
Lowering her voice, she added, these
modern dragons have it all wrong.
I'm sure they'll figure it out eventually
Moon said, smiling.
When is your house going to be ready?
Mighty Claus is working on it now?
Hope answered.
She nodded at the dragonette.
Crowds over a flat rock in the pavilion
drawing intently on a square piece of
paper.
Queen Glory sat beside him.
Her scales all gold and dark purple
watching quietly over his shoulder.
Behind her, Deathbringer was eyeing the
forest fiercely.
Most Night Wings had accepted earrings to
free themselves from all of Dark
Stalker's spells, even the ones that gave
them extra powers.
But a few had chosen to keep their powers
including mighty Claus.
Half the houses in the village had sprung
from his magic in the last month.
It turned out, this had been mighty
Claus's secret dream, when he asked Dark
Stalker for the power to bring his
drawings to life.
Almighty Claus wanted to do was help
build a new, truly wonderful place for
his tribe to live.
That was why he hadn't returned to
school.
He was too happy and busy here.
Hope.
I wanted to ask you something, Moon
said.
Do you know anything about any legends of
a lost continent?
A little, Hope said.
It was sort of a joke in my time.
Like, I'm so fed up with all of this.
I'm moving to the lost continent.
Where did these weird plums come from?
The lost continent?
That sort of thing?
But is it real?
Moon asked.
Are there really other tribes out there
somewhere?
Made you a pie?
Peacemaker chirped.
Smashing a pile of mud over Hope's
talons.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, he sang, as he buried
her claws, his wings fluttering in the
breeze from the river.
Oh, delightful, Hope said.
She shot Moon a curious look.
I have no idea.
I guess I always thought yes, probably.
I mean, she broke off, freed one of her
talons from the mud, and picked up a
cantaloupe from a nearby pile of fruit.
Imagine this is our world, right?
According to Nightwing calculations.
Our continent only covers about this much
of it.
She spread her talons on one side of the
melon, covering about a 3rd of the space
on the knobbly globe.
So it's well within the realm of
possibility that there's more land around
this side.
She turned the melon around, and if
there's another continent, why wouldn't
there be more dragons?
But it's too far for any dragon to fly, we
believe, so there's no way to know for
sure.
Hmm, Moon said.
Her temples were starting to pulse
again.
You had a vision, didn't you?
Hope lowered her voice even more.
I know that look.
Maybe, Moon said, but it's mysterious.
As visions should be, Hope said wryly.
Well, before you go looking for trouble
see if you can find anything on the
legend of the hive.
What's that?
Moon asked, An old story.
I don't remember it well.
So read about it if you can.
It might give you some ideas about these
missing tribes.
Aha!
Peacemakers suddenly declared, have an
idea.
Super good one.
Going to take a nap, like a rain wing.
Yay.
He scampered off toward one of the
hammocks.
You've only been up for an hour.
Hope protested.
Peacemaker?
What about this mess?
Excuse me.
She said to Moon and chased after him.
It was always such a strange feeling
coming to see Peacemaker.
Moon kept expecting to find hints of dark
stalker in him.
It was both a little sad, and an enormous
relief that she never did.
It was exactly the ordinary dragonette
that Kinkajou had promised he would be.
Very few dragons knew his secret.
He himself certainly never would.
Everyone else thought Dark Stalker was
back under the mountain again, asleep for
good this time.
Most of them assumed anemone had taken
care of him with the same spell that
ended the battle.
Others were sure that Moon and Kibley
were involved somehow, or thought perhaps
the original dragonettes of destiny had
saved the world again.
Pretty much nobody guessed that the real
mastermind who took him down was
Kinkaju.
She didn't mind.
She said, the epic legend of Kinkaju was
a work in progress, and one day when she
and Peacemaker were both long gone, the
truth would be revealed, and then
everyone could sing rousing songs about
her for the rest of time.
But Kinkaju said that for now, really, it
was a lot easier to be a student without
an epic legend following her around.
Moon's mother thought the whole mess with
dark stalker was proof that powers were a
curse and disaster for any dragon who had
them.
But despite everything that had happened
Moon didn't think so.
I like my powers.
I like caring about what other dragons
think, and feeling their emotions.
I'm even glad I have my visions, no
matter how much they hurt sometimes.
I think there's a way to use my powers
for good, like Kibli always says, and
that starts with taking this new vision
and doing something about it.
The forest was full of scuttling noises
from fallen leaves tossed by the wind, to
squirrels darting up tree trunks, but
some of the noises were bigger than
others, and winter was getting better at
figuring out which ones were scavengers.
They had a way of walking, even when they
were trying to be quiet, and his sharp
ice wing ears could pick out their
footsteps from quite a distance.
He crept slowly through the trees.
Now he could hear whispered squeaking as
well.
So there were at least 2 of them.
He wondered if his little net would be
able to hold both, or if he should focus
on catching just one.
There they were.
One was clambering around the branches of
an apple tree, while the others stood
below, holding something that looked
almost like a miniature dragon basket.
They can make baskets?
Actually, that wasn't too hard to imagine
with those clever little paws.
He felt a little shiver of excitement
through his wings.
If he could make his scavenger sanctuary
happen, he'd get to study them all day
long.
He'd be able to see them making baskets
and maybe even drawings.
If Sonny was right that they could do
that.
He'd seen some of the ones Flower Drew
but he personally suspected that she was
unusual, because of spending so many
years around dragons.
It would be astonishing to discover that
capacity in other scavengers as well, a
scientific breakthrough, really.
Winter!
A voice yelled in the distance.
Winter, where are you?
Oh, no.
The scavengers both shot into alert
stanzas, staring around them like little
meerkats.
The black fur on their heads fluffed and
tufted in the wind.
Winter.
Whoever it was crashed closer, making an
almighty dragon sized racket.
The scavenger in the tree made a flying
leap to the ground, knocking over the
other one as it landed.
They both scrambled up and bolted away.
With a frustrated growl, Winters shot
after them, but it was too late.
The scavengers around here must have some
kind of system of bolt holes or well
concealed tunnels.
They managed to vanish within a pair of
heartbeats.
There you are.
The dragonette, bounding into the
clearing, was absolutely bright lemon
yellow and beaming all over her face.
Ribtide said you were skulking around the
forest somewhere.
I was being stealthy, kinkaju.
Winter grumbled.
I know that's a foreign concept to you.
Oh, hello to you too, grouchy and
ridiculous all at the same time, she
said.
I am the queen of stealth.
I stealthed my way all around that night
wing palace.
I can out stealth you any day of the
week.
Her scales became pine trees and shadows
and he had to concentrate to keep his
glare on the spot where she had been
standing.
Although, actually, his frown faded.
Hey, that's true, he said excitedly.
You could catch me a scavenger.
They'd never see you coming.
Kinkachu reappeared.
Lilac and light blue now, looking
somewhat mollified.
I might be willing to help you with that
she said.
Depending on what you plan to do with it
once you have it.
Riptide is letting me build a den for
them in sanctuary, he explained.
Winter had been living with the talons of
peace since the Battle of Jade Mountain
helping them build another town like
possibility, where dragons from every
tribe would be welcome.
It was nestled in the foothills of the
Claws of the Clouds Mountains, beside a
small, very cold lake that winter was
particularly fond of.
Actually, he added.
That's how riptide got the name for the
town.
I mentioned wanting to build a scavenger
sanctuary, and he liked the word so much
he decided to fly with it.
I'm hoping to get about 6 or 7 scavengers
to live in there so I can watch what they
do.
Your scavenger obsession is so weird
Kingaju said, although they are pretty
cute.
Almost as cute as sloths.
But smarter than sloths, Winter pointed
out.
Kinkaju looked skeptical.
I guess we'll find out, she said.
Anyway, I'm sure what you meant to say
was, hi, Kinkachu?
Oh my goodness.
Thanks for coming to visit.
I've missed you so much.
Indeed, said Winter.
Sorry, of course.
In those exact words.
He hesitated.
Did you come by yourself?
Oh, that's nice.
Kinkaju wrinkled her nose, Adam.
Way to make a dragon feel wanted.
I thought I phrased that very politely, he
protested.
Yes, but I know what you mean, she said.
And no, Moon didn't come with me.
He tried valiantly to keep his wings from
drooping.
You could visit her, Kinkaju reminded
him.
You could even have stayed at school.
Sunny and Tsunami would have stuck up for
you.
I know.
He said.
But I didn't want to cause any more
trouble with snowfall.
I'm not a real eye swing to her anymore.
So me taking the place of another ice
wing who really wanted it.
Well, it wouldn't have made relations
between her and the school any easier.
Winter was still surprised that all the
queens had agreed to give Jade Mountain
Academy another chance.
He knew that Queen Snowfall would have
preferred to wall off her tribe and never
leave the ice kingdom again.
But after the spell that ended the war
her palace had been flooded with requests
from Ice Wings who wanted to attend Jade
Mountain Academy.
Even if she had wanted to shut down
communications, her subjects wouldn't
have let her, and so 2 new students had
arrived to replace winter and icicle, and
there was a wait list ready for when the
school expanded.
They really won't let you go home?
Kinkachu asked.
Even after you fought alongside them, even
though you're totally awesome?
No, they're still pretty mad at me, Winter
said.
Snowfall said I could come back for
visits, like for icicles trial, and to
visit Hellstorm, as long as I leave again
within a few days.
But my mother doesn't want to see me.
And there's no one else I really want to
see there.
No one in the circles, I mean.
He heaped a small pile of needles in
front of him, and nestled a pine cone
into the middle of it.
It's not so bad.
I thought a lot about some of the stuff
Kibli is always saying to me.
There are all these ice wings outside the
circles, outside the palaces.
I'd never thought about them before.
But I visited as many villages as I could
to make sure they all were cured of the
plague.
And you know what?
Apart from being less obsessed with
status and circles, they're not that
different from the ice wings inside the
palaces.
That is astonishing news.
Kinkaju said gravely.
He made a face at her.
I know.
I shouldn't have been surprised.
Anyway, I met several who were interested
in moving to sanctuary.
So I'm not the only ice swing here.
Which is great.
But why is snowfall so mad at you?
Kinkachu asked.
Oh, the whole 1st circle is furious, but
I've ruined their diamond trial by
letting Foe Slayer escape.
Luckily none of them know what she looks
like, except hailstorm, and I'm sure he
won't say anything.
Even if he happens to run into her in the
rainforest.
He paused.
Moon's last letter said, Foeslayer has
changed her name, and is settling in with
the rest of the tribe.
I...
I know she had something to do with dark
stalker disappearing, but nobody will
tell me exactly what happened.
That's because you might not be cool
about it.
Kinkaju pointed out.
I'm always cool, he protested.
Oh, that wasn't a pun.
Stop laughing at me.
I'm serious.
You guys are acting like you can't trust
me.
We know we can trust you to be a loyal
friend and awesome dragon, and stand with
us when we need you, yes, said Kinkaju.
But to let us handle Dark Stalker our own
way.
We're not so sure.
Winter swept his tail through the pine
needles.
He's really not coming back though.
Is he asleep under the mountain again?
Are we sure he's definitely gone?
He won't be back in another 2000 years or
something?
Winter.
He's gone.
Kinkaju put one of her talons on his
looking him straight in the eyes.
He's never coming back.
Your tribe is safe.
All right, Winters said with a sigh.
I hope Moon is willing to tell me the
whole story someday.
Like I said, you could visit her, and you
could start by apologizing for all those
times you yelled at her and didn't
believe in her and were totally mean.
He winced.
Was I awful?
I was so angry about her being friends
with Dark Stalker.
I guess I can be a little awful when I'm
angry.
You can keep working on that.
Kinkachu assured him.
It, um, it might be too late though.
I know, he said.
I knew back in the Nightwing Palace.
When she took Kibli with her to face Dark
Stalker, instead of me, It's my own
fault.
He traced his claw through the carpeted
pine needles, wondering how long it would
take his heart to heal.
But we're all still friends, right?
Kinkaju said, hopefully.
Turtle and moon and I miss you.
I miss you too, he said.
He didn't want to admit it out loud, but
he missed Kibley as well.
The letters he got from his former claw
mate, were not those of a triumphant
rival, but a best friend, who was worried
about him.
Best friends with a sandwing.
What is the world coming to?
And not just a sandwing, but the one who
won Moon's heart.
If only I didn't like him so much.
In his last letter, Kibley had promised
to come to sanctuary soon, and to bring
flour and smolder in case they had any
ideas for his scavenger project.
He won't let me stop being friends with
him.
None of them will.
As weird as it is, they're my new family
now.
My new tribe.
And I think I'm going to be okay.
So what do you say?
Kinkaju asked.
Her scales rippled and faded into the
background, but he could hear her smile
in her voice.
Want to go catch some scavengers
together?
He smiled back.
Absolutely.
Harold still couldn't quite believe that
Jade Mountain was really her home now.
She was part of a winglet in everything.
Turtles wing lit no less.
She went to classes and studied and had
homework and did projects with other
dragons.
It was so weird.
She still had her own cave because of the
whole accidentally setting your clawmates
on fire while sleepwalking would be bad
thing, and she still needed her friends
to read all the scrolls to her.
She'd asked Starflight to get to work on
inflammable scrolls, once he and Tamarin
were done with our project of making
scrolls that blind dragons could read.
Peril figured if anyone could figure out
scrolls that wouldn't burn, it was
Starflight.
He was certainly motivated to.
He got hilariously twitchy whenever he
smelled pereled anywhere near his
papers.
She padded down the corridor toward the
prey center.
Not because it was highly likely that
Clay would be there at any given time, of
course.
She actually had a perfectly good, all
peril, no clay reason to go to the pray
center.
But she didn't mind the little bounce her
heart gave when she peeked into the
center and saw him there.
Act normal.
Or at least vaguely as though you have
any idea what normal is.
He was curled by the river, chatting with
his brother Marsh.
Marcia's clawmate coconut was there too
poking around on the far side of the
cave.
The rain wings scales were a honey
colored mix of amber and brown, like a
gold dappled version of marshes.
Is he busy?
Maybe he's busy.
Maybe I should?
Clay turned and smiled at her before she
could duck out of sight again.
She smiled back sheepishly, and he padded
across the cave to join her.
Hey, peril, he said.
She knew he sounded kind, no matter who
he was talking to, but she hoped she
wasn't imagining, the extra little bit of
sweetness in his smile for her.
I came down to see if anyone wants their
food set on fire, Pearl said quickly.
The rain wings like it when I roast their
bananas and sweet potatoes, so we're
experimenting with other stuff.
Siamong and I came up with this cooked
mashed up apple thing that is awesome.
Apple sauce?
Clay asked.
Oh, Carol said, is that what it's
called?
We didn't invent it?
Okay, fine.
Applesauce then.
I bet ours is better than anyone else's
though.
Probably, he said.
You'd better make it for me sometime.
He put one wing around her, and she
somehow managed not to burst into
delighted flames.
What are you doing here?
she asked.
I mean, not that you shouldn't be here.
You can be anywhere you want, of course
and it's just a wild coincidence that you
happen to be here in the place where I
also happen to be going, wild
coincidence.
Checking on Marsh, Clay said.
I was so worried about him after Umber
and Zora left.
But he seems really happy lately.
Doesn't he?
I think so, Pearl said.
I mean, I'm not super great at, like
emotions on other dragons, but I'm pretty
sure when a dragon smiles that much, it
means he's happy.
I think it's coconut.
Clay said.
He's the perfect claw made for marsh.
I wish we'd paired everyone else into
best friends that well.
I like the sky wing that Queen Ruby sent
to replace Flame, Pearl said.
He's not completely terrified of me.
It is pretty weird to have conversations
with a Skywing who isn't terrified of
me.
I hope Flame will be all right, Clay
said.
The angry Skywing Dragonette had accepted
an earring reluctantly, choosing freedom
from Dark Stalker's spells, even though
it meant having his scars back.
But he couldn't stay at the school after
what he did to Stone Mover, and he didn't
want to anyway, and Peril thought that
was for the best, because he was an awful
grouch to be around.
Queen Ruby had taken him back to the sky
kingdom to work with the healers.
The queen will sort him out, she said.
She glanced around the almost empty prey
center.
It seems so quiet today.
Everyone's working on independent study
projects, he said.
I just saw ostrich, thrush, and barracuda
talking about the science of rain wing
camouflage in the library, and Tamarin
Pike and Fearless, are doing a
presentation about Dark Stalker's history
later.
If you're interested.
She shuddered a little, flicking her tail
closer to his, I don't know.
Whenever his name comes up, everyone
looks at me like they're remembering it
was my fault he got out.
I mean, I'm clearly the talons of fire in
the prophecy, which makes me want to be
like, yeah, I know, and I'm sorry, okay?
And I'd like to see you try to save your
friends from an ancient scroll with
nebulous powers.
You said friends.
Play echoed, bumping her side with a
grin.
She scrunched up her snout so she
wouldn't smile too much.
I think sometimes maybe they actually
like me a little bit.
Or a lot, Clay said.
My guess is a lot.
Even Winter has sent me a couple of
letters, she said wonderingly, like he
cares what's going on with me.
I got one from Kibley today.
Sonny read it to me.
I can help you write a letter back later
if you want, he said.
Although I can't promise any of the words
will be spelled right.
She laughed.
Aren't you a teacher now?
I'm pretty sure teachers should be able
to spell.
Yeah, I carefully avoid writing anything
where my students can see it, he said.
Peril.
Don't feel bad about Dark Stalker
anymore.
He would have gotten out of his prison
sooner or later.
He was too smart to be stuck under there
for long.
And I think that scroll could have been
just as dangerous as he was, if it was
left floating around the continent.
Right.
Peril said dubiously.
Sometimes she agreed and was all like
good for me, yay, peril, especially
whenever Kibley talked about what a
scroll might have done to him, if it had
stayed in his talons, but a lot of the
time, she remembered Dark Stalker
bursting out of the mountain, and
thanking her for releasing him.
And then it was hard not to feel like the
dragon who nearly set the whole entire
world on fire.
She thought for a moment.
You know, she said, nudging Clay's neck
with her snout.
Sometimes I think it's a good thing it
was my dad who found it.
He was a jerk, but he could have done
much worse things with it.
Another dragon might have done way worse
things, right?
Right, Clay reassured her.
Peril looked out at the rain.
I wonder if I'll ever see him again.
I think he's going to stay pretty mad at
me forever.
You don't need him, Clay said.
You have friends now.
He ducked his head to meet her eyes.
You have me.
Now there was no chance of holding back
her smile.
Want to go flying with me?
she said impulsively.
I mean, I know it's raining, but it's
kind of cool to fly in the rain, unless
you're busy, you're probably busy.
You're like running a school, so that's
okay if you can't, we... peril, he said
catching one of her front talons in his.
I'd love to.
Turtles spread the scroll out on a sunlit
rock and read it again, humming to
himself.
Dear turtle, Auckland and I send our
love.
You must come home for a visit soon, so
you can see the new palace we're
building.
We chose the perfect island for it, and
we're starting with an auditorium that
will have wonderful acoustics for my
scroll readings, with enough room to host
dragons from all the tribes.
We're not going to hide this one, like
the Summer Palace.
I'm hoping it'll be a center for
diplomacy and trade and art that will
help us build relations across Pyria, but
especially with Queen Morhen and Queen
Glory, who have such interesting ideas.
Thank you for the spell you sent to get
rid of the albatross ghost, dark stalker
conjured.
What a strange and malevolent piece of
magic.
Everyone is quite relieved it's gone.
I hope your sister is doing well.
Your brothers seem to think you played an
enormously clever practical joke on them
the last time you were at the palace.
I didn't get all the details, but they're
very impressed with you.
You'd better carefully check your bed for
lobsters the next time you're here.
Sending you all my love and my newest
story, mother.
He dabbled his tail in the water of the
lake below him, smiling.
Every letter from Queen Coral felt like a
new magic spell, making him stronger and
braver, and more the hero he hoped to
be.
Up in the sky, Anemone was doing flips in
the air, flinging out her wings happily.
A bracelet of pale pink pearls shone
around her wrist, matching her scales.
It was the only jewelry she wore anymore
most of the time.
She'd sat with Kibley for hours one day
working out the words for a spell that
would protect her soul, not just from
animus magic, but from the feelings of
invincibility and superiority that went
along with it.
Ever since putting it on, she'd been
acting lighter and younger, giggling and
teasing Pike, and taking her winglet
swimming in the mountain lakes every
day.
Turtle wasn't sure if it was the magic of
the bracelet, or the relief that came
from not worrying about her soul
anymore.
The sole reader had revealed a much
higher level of good in the princess's
soul than they all had feared, and
Hurtle's own soul was almost entirely
good too, to his delight.
Now Anemone kept the soul reader in her
room.
And turtles suspected she checked it
fairly often.
He hadn't seen her cast any spells in the
last month.
She'd been focused on doing good things
like donating half her treasure to help
build sanctuary.
And otherwise, she seemed content to be a
normal student for now.
He heard splashing in the lake, and
turned to find Kinkachu wading out of the
water toward him.
I thought we were going swimming, she
said.
I just wanted to read this letter one
more time.
Turtles said, rolling it up again.
Ah.
Kinkajoo flicked a spray of water at his
tail.
You're so cute about your mom.
It almost makes me wish I knew who my
parents are.
He tipped his head at her.
I could probably find out for you.
That's all right, she said.
I know you're trying to use your magic as
little as possible.
I can figure it out some other way if I
ever really want to.
Turtle tapped his Skyfire armband, but I
can use it if you ever need to.
Kibli's soul spell is really well
written.
Speaking of well written, Kingaju said, as
he dove into the water.
She waited until he surfaced again to
finish her thought.
I loved the story you wrote for a class
the other day.
You should write more of it.
Really?
He said shyly.
You're not just saying that?
I'm not enchanted to say nice things
about you anymore, she said with a
laugh.
He laughed too, but a little awkwardly.
They'd pretty much avoided the subject of
the love spell for the last month.
He paddled his webbed talons underneath
him for a moment, then blurted.
I still really like you, Kinkaju.
Her scales shimmered rose, with flecks of
citrus orange and yellow.
Oh, she said.
I mean, I really like you too.
Just, I'm still...
It's weird, turtle.
It's weird to wake up suddenly, having
all these feelings, and then find out
they're not real.
And then suddenly they're gone, but not
really, because you remember feeling them
which is awfully close to actually still
feeling them, and then there are lots of
reasons to feel them because you are
adorable, but I'm not totally sure how
much I feel them, and so it's very
confusing.
Sure.
Yeah, okay, he said.
Never mind.
No, not never mind, she said. splashing
water over his head.
More like, let's keep hanging out and see
what happens.
And I'll try to figure out which feelings
are real after a little more time has
passed.
That's what I think we should do.
That's all right with me. he said.
I mean, it's great.
Totally great with me.
He felt a fish swim right between his
claws, but it wiggled away when he tried
to grab it.
You really think I'm adorable?
Yes. said Kinkaju, but I think lots of
things are adorable, so don't get too
excited.
I mean, you're somewhere between baby
sloths and anemones crush on tamarind on
the adorableness scale.
He dunked his head underwater. hiding his
smile.
A moment later, he popped out again.
Wait, what?
Anemone has a crush on someone?
Oh my gosh, yes.
Kinkaju said with a giggle.
You haven't noticed?
She's been casually showing up everywhere
Tamarin is, offering to read her scrolls
leaving her little gifts of flowers or
unusual fruit.
It's almost cute enough to make me
forgive her.
But I told Tamron she better be careful.
I am watching very closely to make sure
Anemone doesn't use any magic on my
friend.
She won't, Turtle said confidently.
Our soul spells stipulate that we can
only do magic that doesn't affect another
dragon's free will.
And that we can do any magic that's
selfishly motivated.
Both of those should keep anemone from
doing any more love spells.
Humph, said Kinkaju.
Well, I'm keeping an eye on her anyway.
She's going to have to be pretty super
awesome to ever be worthy of tamarind.
I'm going to work hard to be super
awesome too.
Turtle promised himself.
I've read enough romance scrolls.
I should have some idea of what to do.
It'll be crazy if I actually end up in
one of those stories myself.
Save the world, check.
Stop being afraid of my magic?
Check.
Figure out a way to protect my soul.
Become the kind of dragon I'd want to
read about.
Working on it.
Probably working on it for the rest of my
life.
But I think I'm getting there.
A gust of wind lifted a spray of sand and
danced it across the dunes.
Kibley said the stone he was carrying
into its place in the wall and checked
the sky.
Dark blue and cloudless, as usual, as
afternoon faded into evening.
A few stars were already shining over the
horizon, and the moons were rising in the
distance, everything was calm, nothing to
worry about.
Time for a break.
Six claws called from the roof of the
treasury.
The sand wings around Kibley stretched
and wandered off in search of water.
The reconstruction work was almost done.
Everything vulture, the talons of power
and Kibley's sandstorm had done to the
palace was nearly fixed.
Kibley spotted Queen Thorn standing next
to Six Claws, as though she'd been there
watching for a while.
She said something to her general and
then flew down to land beside Kibley.
Six Claws says you've been working hard
she said. handing him a flask of water.
Thank you, your majesty, he said.
Okay, enough of that, she said.
Your talents are completely wasted on
building walls.
When are you going back to school?
Don't you need me here?
He said.
There will still be plenty to do after
you are done with school, she said
firmly.
Are you hiding from someone?
That was a little too perceptive for
Kibli to handle.
No, he said quickly.
Oh, good. she said, because the someone
you've not been hiding from is here to
see you.
She is?
he said, flaring his wings.
Queen Thorn gave him an amused glance, and
he realized he'd given himself away.
I mean, who?
What?
I have no idea what you're talking
about.
I told her to wait for you in the
observatory, Thorn said.
Nodding at the domed tower that was open
to the sky.
If she can talk you into going back to
school, I'll give her some kind of
sandwing medal of honor.
Kibley's wings were trembling so much, he
wasn't sure he'd make it all the way up
to the tower.
He took a few deep breaths, poured the
water over his head to clean off the sand
and shook himself dry.
Moon was peering into the telescope as he
came through the hole in the roof.
This is amazing, she said, turning to him
with the brightest of smiles.
I can see craters on that moon.
Are there any sandwing astronomy
scrolls?
Does this palace have a library?
It must, right?
It does, Kibley said.
I can take you there if, um, if that's
why you're here.
No.
No, it's not, she said.
She crossed the room and was suddenly
right in front of him, like he'd been
imagining for weeks.
What were all the clever things he was
going to say?
Why had they all flown out of his brain?
Please come back to school, Kibley?
She said.
She took his front talons in hers.
We miss you.
I miss you.
Moon, he said, looking down at the
floor.
You should be saying this to Winter.
She paused.
Winter, she said cautiously.
Why?
This part he'd prepared for.
That didn't make this any easier to say
but he was determined to try.
Because he needs you.
He'd go back to school if you asked him.
You make him a better dragon and I...
I don't know if he can live without you.
She studied his phase.
I don't know if that's true, Kibley.
I think he'll be all right no matter what
happens.
He's strong and smart, and he's going to
do great things with his life.
But I do know.
I need you.
That wasn't in any of the possible
scripts Kibley had practiced.
He was startled into meeting her eyes.
When she smiled.
Her teardrop scales became little
rivulets of silver.
I want to be with someone who's kind, and
makes me laugh, and listens to me.
That's you.
When I think about the future and
everything I want to do with my life, I
think about you.
That's what I know.
Khibli wasn't sure his lungs were working
properly, or maybe that was his heart
trying to escape from his chest to fly
around the room.
But he started.
No, no, she said.
She touched her claws to his temples.
I know, your brain is shooting like a
comet right now.
Stop thinking about all the problems and
scenarios and ways out.
Just take a breath and look at me.
He did.
Her eyes looked into him, and even with
the Skyfire hiding his thoughts, he knew
she saw his whole self, and that was what
she wanted, somehow, miraculously.
Can we try being together?
she asked. without a prophecy, or a
scroll, or a catastrophe, or a war, or
anything else crazy going on?
Don't overthink.
Say yes.
Yes, he said.
A smile spread across her face like a
sunrise.
Awesome, she said.
Awesome.
He agreed, smiling back.
They stood there, smiling and feeling
very silly for a long, quiet moment.
So, she said, I know I literally just
said without a prophecy or catastrophe or
anything crazy, but I've kind of been
having a vision lately.
Oh no, he said with a laugh, another
mysterious prophecy.
Not exactly, she said.
But there's something I need to check
out.
I was hoping you'd come with me.
Anywhere, he said.
Always.
They said goodbye to Queen Thorn, flew
west through the night, and reached the
coast before morning.
Kibli had never been as far west.
He'd never seen this edge of the kingdom
of sand.
He hadn't quite thought about the surging
ocean right at their doorstep.
Although he knew there were a few sand
wing settlements along the water.
The moon didn't take them in that
direction.
She turned north instead, toward the
border with the ice kingdom.
In a little cove north of the farthest
northern oasis, they found what she was
looking for, a small hut on the beach
roofed with palm fronds.
Kibley glanced at moon and confusion as
they landed on the damp sand in front of
it.
Who lives here?
Someone I saw in my vision, I think, she
said, if I'm right, Turtle saw her too
just for a moment, in Dark Stalker's
throne room, he told me about it, but he
said he wasn't sure she was real.
I think she is.
I think we'll find her here.
As she said that, the door opened, and a
sand wing emerged.
She was tall and long necked and graceful
with wide black eyes, and a dappled brown
triangle pattern on her wings.
She watched them gravely as they climbed
the beach toward her.
Hello, Moon said, dipping her head to the
stranger.
My name is Moon, and this is Kibley.
Did you know we were coming?
I knew someone would come?
She said in a quiet voice.
I guessed it would be soon.
What's your name?
Moon asked.
I saw you in a vision, but I don't really
know why.
I'm Jerboa, said the Sandwing.
Khibli's eyes widened. and she noticed
and shook her head.
Not the original Jerboa, she said, her
daughter.
From way back in Dark Stalker's time?
Kibley asked.
Yes.
My mother cast a spell to make sure
nothing could ever harm me.
Treboa shrugged.
I've been waiting a long time to fulfill
my purpose.
Your purpose?
Moon asked.
Yes, Draboa said again.
She spread one wing to invite them into
the hut.
I believe the 1st step is introducing
you.
To who?
Kibley asked, stepping inside.
He edged sideways to make room for Moon
to enter too, and his eyes took a moment
to adjust to the dark interior.
There was an injured dragon in there
lying on a bed of palm fronds.
She sat up as they entered and eyed them
warily.
And then Kibley saw the shape of her
wings, and her face, and the color of her
scales, and he realized this dragon was
no hybrid.
She was not from any tribe he'd ever seen
before.
She was something completely different.
What?
Moon whispered.
How?
I believe this, said Jerboa, is our 1st
visitor from the lost continent.
A guide to the Dragons of Pyria, updated
and edited by Starflight of the Night
Wings.
Welcome to the Jade Mountain Academy.
At this school, you will be learning side
by side with dragons from all the other
tribes.
So we wanted to give you some basic
information that may be useful as you get
to know one another.
You have been assigned to a winglet with
6 other dragons.
The winglet groups are listed on the
following page.
Thank you for being a part of this
school.
You are the hope of Pyria's future.
You are the dragons who can bring lasting
peace to this world.
We wish you all the power of wings of
fire.
Jade Winglet.
Ice Wing, Winter, Mud Wing, Umber, Night
Wing, Moon Watcher, Rain Wing, Kinkajoo
Sand Wing, Kibli, Sea Wing, Turtle, Sky
Wing, Carnelian.
Gold Winglet, Ice Wing, Icicle, Mud Wing
Sora, Night Wing, Big Tail, Rain Wing
Tamarind, Sand Wing, Onyx, Sea Wing, Pike
Sky Wing, Flame, Silver Winglet, Ice Wing
Cheng Bai, Mud Wing, Sepia, Night Wing
Fearless, Rain Wing, Photo, Sand Wing
Ostrich, Sea Wing, Anemone, Sky Wing
Thrush, Copper Winglet, Ice Wing, Alba
Mud Wing, Marsh, Night Wing, Mind Reader
Rain Wing, Coconut, Sand Wing, Prong Horn
Sea Wing, Snail, Sky Wing, Peregrine.
Quartz Winglet, Ice Wing, Ermine, Mud
Wing, Newt, Night Wing, Mighty Claws, Rain
Wing, Siamang, Sand Wing, Arid, Sea Wing
Barracuda, Sky Wing, Garnet.
Sand wings, description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, poisonous barbed tail, forked
black tongues, abilities, can survive a
long time without water, poison enemies
with the tips of their tails like
scorpions.
Bury themselves for camouflage in the
desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the end of the war of Sandwing
Succession, Queen Thorn.
Students at Jade Mountain, Arid, Onyx
Ostrich, Pronghorn, Kibley.
Mudwings.
Description thick armored brown scales.
Sometimes with amber and gold underscales
large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities can breathe fire, if warm
enough, hold their breath for up to an
hour, blend into large mud puddles
usually very strong.
Queen, Queen Morin.
Students at Jade Mountain, Marsh, Newt
Sepia, Sora, Umber.
Skywings.
Description.
Red, gold, or orange scales, enormous
wings, abilities, powerful fighters, and
flyers, can breathe fire, Queen, Ruby
although some dragons still support Queen
Scarlet, who may be alive and in hiding.
Students at Jade Mountain, Carnelian
Flame, Garnet, Peregrine, Thrush.
Sea wings, description.
Blue or green or aquamarine scales, webs
between their claws, gills on their necks
glow in the dark stripes on their tails
snouts, underbellies, abilities, can
breathe underwater.
See in the dark, create huge waves with
one splash of their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, Queen Coral, students at Jade
Mountain, anemone, barracuda, pike, snail
turtle.
Ice wings.
Description.
Silvery scales like the moon, or pale
blue like ice, ridged claws to grip the
ice.
Forked blue tongues, tails narrow to a
whip thin end.
Abilities can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light.
Exhale a deadly frost breath.
Queen, Queen Glacier.
Students at Jade Mountain, Alba, Cheng
Bai, Ermine, icicle, winter.
Rain wings.
Description.
Scales constantly shift colors, usually
bright like birds of paradise, prehensile
tails, abilities, can camouflage their
scales to blend into their surroundings
shoot a deadly venom from their fangs.
Queen, Queen glory.
Students at Jade Mountain, Bodo, Coconut
Kinkaju, CMA, Tamarin, Night Wings
Description.
Purlish black scales and scattered silver
scales on the underside of their wings
like a night sky full of stars, forked
black tongues.
Abilities, can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows.
Once known for reading minds and
foretelling the future, but no longer.
Queen, Queen Glory.
See recent scrolls on the Nightwing
Exodus and the Rainwing Royal Challenge.
Students of Jade Mountain, Big Tail
Fearless, Mighty Claus, Mind Reader, Moon
Watcher.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you've enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 10
Darkness of Dragons, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Zetton.
Executive producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2017 by 2ET Sutherland.
Production Copyright, 2017 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.